technology advances a Paramount concern
takes Center Stage which is cyber
security adaptive breached defenses
stealing valuable knowledge in an
ever-evolving conflict as a result the
demand for cyber Security Experts is
substantial cyber security career
encompasses diverse roles from security
analysts earning from sixty thousand
dollars to ninety thousand dollars to
cisos earning hundred and fifty thousand
dollars to two hundred fifty thousand
dollars salaries fluctuate based on
experience and location but the fields
growth promises strong career paths if
you are looking to dive deep into the
world of cyber security then become an
expert with postgraduate program in
cyber security some key features of this
program include master classes from MIT
faculty featuring modules from MIT SSC
and EC Council eight times higher
interaction in life online in classes
conducted by industry experts simply
lands job assists help you to get
noticed by top hiring companies and much
more you will gain skills like Advanced
hacking Concepts Network packet analysis
ethical hacking ideas firewalls and
honeybots security and risk management
network security and software
development security so hurry up and
endola get the complete course details
in the description box if you are
looking to have a smart entry in this
field then simply learn offers a six
months program Caltech cyber security
boot camp with this program you will
learn all the cyber security
fundamentals with Hands-On projects find
the complete course details from the
link in the description box and pin
command so without any further delay
over to our tutors
now there are several reasons as to why
you should learn cyber security here we
have the top 10 reasons for the same
at number 10
the reason we have is basic requirements
there is a wrong notion that building a
career in cyber security is daunting
well it is not
a fancy college degree is not at all
that it takes to become a successful
cyber security professional
you can Venture into the domain of cyber
security with some basic knowledge of
I.T and with an authorized cyber
security certification the overall
eligibility Criterion for the cyber
security domain is relaxing across the
world
it professionals with cyber security
certifications are known to receive
higher salary packages
certifications are always given extra
weightage in the infosec field and it
opens dose to bigger opportunities
these cyber security certifications can
be opted by anyone as the eligibility
for these are very basic
cyber security certifications trained
professionals and thus helps in Bridging
the Gap between the supply and demand of
skilled cyber Security Professionals
so don't take a step back from learning
cyber security thinking it is a tedious
process if you are a fresher or a
professional you can go ahead with just
these basic requirements
before moving on to our next reason here
is a question for you all
how many of you like mathematics please
let us know in the comment section below
I'm sure not everyone loves mathematics
and that is completely okay when it
comes to learning cyber security
and our ninth reason is mathematics is
not a concern for learning cyber
security
many of us find mathematics challenging
some have the aptitude for dealing with
numbers and some don't
and for those who don't they find it
difficult to proceed with a career that
has maths involved
however you can take your decision
without any worries when it comes to
cyber security as the domain of cyber
security does not involve mathematics
so if maths is not your strong point
then choosing to learn cyber security is
a great choice
this can definitely be a relief to many
instead you can get acquainted with
networking network security control and
coding to build a career in cyber
security
our eighth reason is that cyber security
is a profession that helps achieve the
greater good
cyber security consists of a set of
measures and approaches that help
companies and individuals data from
being compromised and stolen
cyber Security Professionals have
defended organizations from several
deadly cyber attacks that aimed at
jeopardizing an organization's
confidentiality integrity and
availability
cyber crimes are currently on their eyes
but different types of cyber attacks the
threat to organizations and individuals
alike is only growing by the day
government agencies police forces and
cyber crime cells are tackling this
threat however there is more requirement
for skilled cyber security professionals
who can protect data and work for the
greater good
therefore if you want to bring about a
positive impact and a meaningful
difference to the society we live in
then learning cyber security is a great
choice our seventh reason is that you
get to travel the world
who doesn't love to travel the globe
learning cyber security is a great
reason especially for those of you who
aspire to travel the world
with the lack of cyber Security
Professionals in the world there are
plenty of opportunities for skilled
experts to travel overseas to Showcase
their cyber security skills which are in
high demand
The increased demand for cyber Security
Professionals is not just restricted to
one area but to the entire world
there are several employment
opportunities for cyber Security
Professionals across the globe so
learning cyber security can open new
doors for you overseas as well our sixth
reason is very interesting and that is
the fact that you get to work with
secret agencies and high profile ones
like other professionals
cyber Security Professionals also have
the opportunity to work with several
prestigious multinational companies and
big giants like Google Dell Accenture
and others however a cyber security
professional's career opportunities can
go beyond mncs and they might get the
opportunity to work with top government
secret agencies like Mossad NSA Nia FBI
and so on
so what are you waiting for become a
cyber security expert and showcase your
skills to grab the chance to work with
these top agencies our fifth reason is
it is never too late to begin with there
are very few professions that give you
the Liberty to begin late
and one such profession is cyber
security it is never too late to realize
that you want to become a cyber security
expert
many people work as cyber Security
Professionals even after the retirement
if they have a good knowledge about ID
you could also join cyber security
courses that train you irrespective of
your age
as long as you have good cyber security
skills there is no need to worry about
job security however late it is
our fourth reason is cyber security is
an evergreen industry
cyber security has gradually become an
evergreen industry
in the current times with the onset of
the covid-19 pandemic businesses are
moving online and shifting to cloud
storage the demand for cyber security is
at its peak
there is a high demand for cyber
Security Experts who can Safeguard
Digital Data hence we can be rest
assured that cyber security is here to
stay and this domain is only going to
grow in the coming years
according to cyber security Ventures the
number of Internet users will hit a
whopping 6 billion by 2022.
these numbers speak volumes and this
reveals the growing demand for cyber
Security Professionals across the globe
digitalization is taking place across
several Industries
a cyber security expert finds
opportunities in every field as every
organization wants to be secure on the
digital front so now is the right time
if you are looking to learn and start a
career in cyber security before moving
to our top three reasons to learn cyber
security here are some crucial
information for you all
as you know with relevant certifications
you can grow your cyber security career
and here we are to help you with that
you can check out Simply learns cyber
security export Masters program to equip
you with the necessary skills to become
an expert in this rapidly growing domain
training for highly sought after
certifications like CompTIA Security
Plus CH cism and cissp is at the
Forefront of this course preparing you
for the industry's best jobs
so what are you waiting for get
certified with simply learn and grow
your career in cyber security today
so our third reason to learn cyber
security is because of the plenty of job
opportunities it offers
according to the U.S Bureau of Labor
Statistics the employment of information
security analyst is projected to grow 33
percent from 2020 to 2030. much faster
than the average for all occupations
with the world turning digital that is a
dire need for companies to hire cyber
Security Experts who can protect and
Safeguard sensitive data
as firms work to improve their cyber
security structure they are also hiring
several cyber security exports to design
Implement and maintain the Cyber
Security Solutions
cyber security jobs are not limited to
the it domain many security positions
are found at companies outside of it
including Industries like Media Sports
or Finance to name a few
this emphasizes on the fact that cyber
security export is exposed to several
job opportunities from different types
of companies across the globe
our second reason for you to learn cyber
security is the good salary package it
offers
salaries play a crucial part in any job
that you undertake isn't it
every individual likes to get duly
rewarded for their work and cyber
security is one such domain that
provides fat paychecks
cyber Security Experts are the
individuals who have come to the rescue
with the unprecedented rise in cyber
crimes across the world organizations
are willing to pay Sky High salaries for
these cyber security exports
there is a lack of skilled cyber
Security Professionals and this is
another reason cyber Security Experts
are paid well
the salaries of cyber Security
Professionals are still expected to grow
in the coming times owing to the high
demand
salaries and cyber security have a high
growth potential and if you are a
skilled cyber security professional you
can always negotiate your salary
finally a top reason to learn cyber
security is that you will have a job
that never gets boring and a domain that
offers unlimited potential for personal
growth
several times individuals find
themselves lost in their career due to
lack of challenges due to their mundane
work and also due to stagnation at work
these reasons play a major role when it
comes to a professional quitting their
job however a job rule in cyber security
tackles these reasons to an extent and
that is why we have this reason at
number one
cyber security is a domain that is
constantly evolving and so are the
nature of cyber attacks hackers are
always trying to develop new methods to
get to your data
they develop new exploits regularly and
hence as a cyber security professional
you will face interesting challenges to
find Optimal Solutions for new exploits
you will have new puzzles to solve
a cyber security career is not going to
be stale
along with failures you will also be
exposed to new and interesting
discoveries
to keep yourself updated in this field
and to tackle cyber attacks you should
be in a position to outsmart the hackers
being in the field of cyber security
allows you to constantly upskill and
enhance your knowledge and experience it
also ensures that your Learning Journey
will never stop
was your Sony PlayStation hacked in 2011
to the 77 million PlayStation accounts
were indeed hacked according to Sony if
a huge cooperation like Sony could not
protect itself from cyber threats you
can assume that the chances of any
organization being 100 safe are pretty
slim cyber security is a booming
industry and will be for the foreseeable
future considering most of the it
business has moved on to the cloud
according to recent Trend studies the
cyber security domain is set to
Skyrocket to nearly 200 billion dollars
by 2027. so what are you waiting for
stay tuned to this video on becoming a
cyber security expert in 2023 and jump
start your career in today's video we
will cover the basic responsibilities of
a cyber security expert and the
different types of cyber security
domains we go through the required
skills for being a cyber security expert
and a roadmap on how to become one
finally we cover the best cyber security
certifications to help you secure your
first job in this lucrative domain
followed by the different rules you can
aim for in this industry before we move
forward ensure your subscribed to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon to stay
updated with the latest trends and
informative videos and for all the
budding cyber Security Professionals
here is a small question to test your
knowledge if a user finds a Facebook
Loan website that hackers set up to
steal passwords what attack can this be
classified as is it efficient is it B
SQL injection is it three Adidas attack
or fourth crypto Jack let us know your
answer in the comments below and let's
start by learning about what a cyber
security expert does a cyber security
expert specializes in preventing
unwanted access to or theft of computer
systems and data more people and
organizations rely on the internet and
computers to conduct the day-to-day
activities in today's digital
environment because of this increased
Reliance on technology it has become a
major Target for criminals looking to
get access to confidential data or wreak
havoc on networks as a result there is
an increasing demand for qualified cyber
security Specialists who can assist in
mitigating these dangers experts in
cyber security typically have a computer
science or engineering backgrounds and
use their Computing systems expertise to
create sufficient Security Solutions and
create efficient Security Solutions
cyber Security Professionals need to be
technically proficient but they also
need to be able to think tactically and
keep up with the latest emerging
advancements in danger cyber Security
Professionals have the necessary skills
and expertise to identify suspicious
signals before the poser risk they can
also keep track of the most recent
dangers and neutralize them before they
hurt the business but that being said
the key responsibilities include but are
definitely not limited to Gathering data
on current security measures for threat
assessment and keeping regular records
of the status of systems regularly
checking for assaults and if any are
detected implementing the necessary
preventive measures performing
vulnerability scanning to identify weak
spots and collaborating with a cyber
security team to update security
protocols as needed considering Security
First while setting up firewall software
Network firewall programs data servers
and Antivirus systems providing
credentials for unauthorized users
presenting tasks linked to access and
looking for changes to non-listered
information helping lead staff members
receive trainings on phishing and other
common threats with so many duties on
the board it's bound to expect multiple
categories in this domain let's take a
look at the different types of cyber
security number one we have network
security this branch of network
engineering as opposed to focus on
individual databases or devices protects
against breaches for a network of
interconnected devices Network Security
Experts use firewalls physical
protective hardware and security
awareness to prevent breaches and retain
lost data email and user security may
also be a focus of network security the
professionals may lead organizational
initiatives to enforce tougher password
policies or to restrict web browsing to
reputable websites only the
professionals or have a more focused
area of work than cyber security
Personnel cyber security protects
attacks from attacks on individuals
networks hardware and software in
contrast network security focuses on
weak links between a network of
interconnected devices only
at number two we have information
security cyber security and information
security overlap to some extent but
cyber security is just a sub category of
the latter information security includes
digital and physical data across all
media whereas cyber security focuses
solely on securing digital assets
specialists in information security and
cyber security both Safeguard sensitive
data information but information
security considers factors like the
accessibility and confidentiality of
data to prevent access by cyber
criminals the number three is
infrastructure secured this domain can
concentrate on using vaults security
systems and generators to protect
sensitive valuables infrastructure
security the digital fear refers to
building and maintaining systems
protected from breaches Professionals in
this field defined critical applications
and data while building infrastructure
to protect these devices the experts
create and Implement efficient databases
at the app level to block access by
malicious Parties by creating systems
for encryptions and backups the
professional secure data against the
hackers the skill set needed to become a
cyber security expert can be vary from
domain to domain but the major chunk of
skills remain the same so let's go
through some of these skills in our next
section at the top of our list is being
technically Adept cyber Security
Professionals must have a solid grasp of
computer networking and how they operate
you should also be aware of typical
security flaws and how to mitigate them
cyber Security Professionals must
recognize how hackers operate and think
and function to defend systems from
assault this enables them to predict
assaults and put effective
countermeasures in place number three is
having a methodical approach type
security work frequently demands a high
level of precision and a meticulous
attention to detail paying this
attention to nuances to find evidence
that could result in a successful attack
is very crucial to cyber security cyber
security issues are usually complex and
multifaceted as a result Specialists
must be able to spot issues and develop
Innovative solution using their problem
solving skills cyber Security
Professionals must be able to describe
technicalities to non-technical
colleagues and consumers fully you must
also be able to collaborate with others
on their team effectively so let's say
you have mastered the skills needed to
become a cyber security expert what
about the next steps our next section
will cover a roadmap that will provide
the exact sequence of steps needed to
become a cyber security expert in 2023
at number one we have basic computer
skills usually meaning the relevant
computer skills and systems knowledge
that is necessary to work your way
around hundreds of platforms while a
computer science degree is highly
preferable and helpful when starting in
this domain people from non-technical
backgrounds can also work in cyber
security if they train themselves in
basic Computing skills number two is
networking skills networking skills are
absolutely essential since a lot of the
work will revolve on a wireless access
and network security protocols with
everything going Wireless networking
skills and particularly Wireless
networking should be the next step in
your journey after polishing your
networking skills the third obstacle
should be getting your knowledge of
Linux operating systems to at least
above average standards more scanning
tools and exploit Frameworks done
exclusively on Linux based distributions
like Kali Linux and parrot security
making it an absolute must before moving
forward basic scripting skills should be
the next step since developing and
combating exploits will require some
programming skills while not mandatory
these scripting skills will help you
modify exploits that can later be used
to secure infrastructure the next step
is the pH certification by TCM or the
Cyber Mentor this course will teach the
Practical aspects of ethical hacking
this course covers tools and Concepts to
help you succeed as an ethical hacker or
a cyber security analyst the training is
quite Hands-On and will cover a wide
range of fundamental subjects websites
like hack the box and try hack me are
virtual Labs that function as targets
for ethical hackers practicing their
craft as a cyber security professional
practicing on these rooms can help you
stay updated with the latest and most
complex tools available to penetration
testers today next is the ejpd
certification or the e-learn security
Junior penetration tester this
certification is a Hands-On course in
penetration testing and information
security fundamentals passing the exam
proves to businesses that you a cyber
security specialist is now ready for a
successful new job the last step is
getting an oscp or a pnpt certification
regarding a professional certification
that can help you grow further in the
domain you have these two options the
oscp online course can be completed at
your speed and schedule it covers
penetration testing tools and
methodologies through Hands-On practice
the program teaches the skills and
mindset needed to be a successful
vulnerability researcher and a cyber
security analyst the pnpd exam or the
Practical Network penetration tester
certification is a one-of-a-kind
vulnerability scanning certification
exam that evaluates a student's capacity
to perform a networking penetration test
at a professional level now that you
know the roadmap that needs to be
followed to become a cyber security
expert let's look into some of the best
certifications available on the market
today at number one we are going to have
the cissp certification it is based on a
common body of knowledge that covers a
broad range of topics including network
security cryptography and access control
to be eligible for the cisp though
candidates must have at least five years
of real life work experience in at least
two or more of the eight cisp domains at
number two we have the CES certification
or the certified ethical hacker the
certification validates the candidate's
ability to identify assess and mitigate
risks in an organization system to earn
the CH certification candidates must
pass an exam that covers topic searches
Network scanning enumeration social
engineering and SQL injection number
three we have the ccsp the certified
Cloud security professional credential
is a globally recognized certification
demonstrating a deep understanding of
cloud security architecture design
operations and services the ccsp
validates an individual ability to
secure cloud data along with its
applications and manage workloads
effectively
the port certification we have for you
is the cisa this exam tests the
candidate knowledge of information
system auditing control and security
candidates who pass the exam must
maintain the certification through
continued education and professional
development the CIS certification is
widely recognized as a benchmark of
excellence in information security as
you've already discussed there are many
facets to cyber security needless to say
there are a variety of rows to choose
from in this domain so let's go through
some of the most popular roles in the
cyber security division today at number
one we have the application security
engineer application Security Experts
can build deploy and manage computer
software and applications in various
sectors they work almost entirely in an
office setting with most of the time
spent writing and debugging software
fluency in several programming languages
like C C sharp Java Python and
JavaScript is necessary at number two we
have the security engineer they are
responsible for Designing and
implementing strategies that ensure the
security of an organization's products
and systems they must be able to examine
an organization's procedures and predict
future difficulties as a result they
must be skilled at incident response and
have solid computer forensics knowledge
number three is the network security
engineer network security Engineers are
critical in deploying setting and
managing Network and security hardware
and software examples being some
firewalls routers or network management
tools along with vpns they are also
responsible for undertaking network
security assessments and may be asked to
assist in the network infrastructure
design information security analysts are
in charge of investigating the security
issues and providing fixes the
responsibilities include researching the
sector identifying potential issues
implementing ways to secure the firm the
role leads a diverse set of abilities it
requires professionals to collaborate
with diverse people including analysts
inside and outside the business and
Senior Personnel I.T Security
Professionals examine an organization
security strategy and previous breaches
to determine how attacks happen and what
can be done to prevent them because it
and cyber security are such vast areas
firms typically employ many security
specialist each specializing in a
distinct area for example one may Focus
solely on online applications while
another is responsible for the
organization's Networks
when it comes to web app hacking It
generally refers to the exploitation of
applications by HTTP which can be done
by manipulating the applications via its
graphical user interface this is done by
tampering with the uniform resource
identifier also known as a URI or
tampering with the HTTP elements
directly which are not a part of the URI
the hacker can send a link via an email
or a chat and may trick the users of a
web application into executing actions
in case the attack is on an
administrator account the entire web
application can be compromised
anyone who uses a computer connected to
the internet is susceptible to the
threats that computer hackers and online
Predators post these online billions
typically use phishing scams spam email
or instant messages and bogus websites
to deliver dangerous malware to a
computer and compromise a computer
security
computer hackers can also try to access
your computer and private information
directly if you are not protected by a
firewall they can monitor your
conversations or produce the back end of
your personal website usually disguised
with a bogus identity Predators can lure
you into revealing sensitive personal
and financial information
a web server which can be referred to as
the hardware the computer or the
software which helps to deliver content
that can be accessed through the
internet the primary function of a web
server is to deliver these web pages on
the request to clients using the
hypertext transfer protocol or http
so hackers attack the web server to
steal credential information passwords
and business information by using
different types of attacks like DDOS
attacks syn flooding pink flood port
scan and social engineering attacks in
the area of web security despite strong
encryption on the browser server Channel
web users still have no Assurance about
what happens at the other end
although wireless networks offer great
flexibility they have their own security
problems a hacker can sniff the network
packets without having to be in the same
building where the network is located as
wireless networks communicate through
radio waves a hacker can easily sniff
the network from a nearby location
most attackers use Network sniffing to
find the SSID and hack a wireless
network an attacker can attack a network
from a distance and therefore it is
sometimes difficult to collect evidence
against the main hacker
social engineering is the art of
manipulating users of a Computing system
into revealing confidential information
which can be later used to gain
unauthorized access to a computer system
the term can also include activities
such as exploiting human kindness greed
and curiosity to gain access to
restricted access buildings or getting
the users to installing backdoor
software knowing the tricks used by
hackers to trick users into releasing
vital login information is fundamental
in protecting computer systems
coming to our main focus for today let
us have a look at the top 5 most
essential ethical hacking tools to be
used in 2021
at the top of the chain lies and map
nmap which stands for network mapper is
a free and open source utility for
network discovery and security auditing
many systems and network administrators
also find it useful for tasks such as
Network inventory managing service
upgrade schedules and monitoring host or
service sometime
it is most beneficial in the early
stages of ethical hacking where a hacker
must figure the possible entry point to
a system before running the necessary
exploits thus allowing the hackers to
leverage any insecure openings and thus
Bridge the device
and map uses raw IB packets in novel
ways to determine what hosts are
available on the network what service
they are running what operating systems
are installed what type of packet
filters and firewalls are in use and
dozens other characteristics it was
designed to rapidly scan large networks
but works finest against single host as
well
since every application that connects to
a network needs to do so via a port the
wrong port or a server configuration can
open a can of worms which lead to a
thorough breach of the system and
ultimately a fully hacked device
next on our list we have Metasploit
the betasploit framework is a very
powerful tool that can be used by cyber
criminals as well as ethical hackers to
probe systematic vulnerabilities on both
networks and servers
because it's an open source framework it
can be easily customized and used with
most operating systems
with Metasploit the ethical hacking team
can use ready-made or custom code and
introduce it into a network to probe for
weak spots as another flavor of threat
hunting once the flaws are identified
and documented the information can be
used to address systemic weaknesses and
prioritize Solutions
once a particular vulnerability is
identified and the necessary exploit is
value to the system there are a host of
options for the hacker depending on the
vulnerability hackers can even run root
commands from the terminal allowing
complete control over the activities of
the compromise system as well as all the
personal data stored on the device
a big advantage of Metasploit is the
ability to run full-fledged scans on the
target system which gives a detailed
picture of the security index of the
system along with the necessary exploits
that can be used to bypass the antivirus
software having a single solution to
gather almost all the necessary points
of attack is very useful for ethical
hackers and penetration testers as
denoted by its high rank in the list
moving on we have the accunatics
framework
iconetix is an end-to-end web security
scanner which offers a 360 degree view
of an organization security
it is an application security testing
tool that helps the company address
vulnerability across all their critical
web assets
the need to be able to test application
in depth and further than traditional
vulnerability management tools has
created a market with several players in
the application security space
accuratics can detect over 7000
vulnerabilities including SQL injections
cross-site scripting misconfigurations
weak passwords exposed database and
other out-of-band vulnerabilities
it can scan all pages web apps and
complex web applications running HTML5
and JavaScript as well it also lets you
scan complex multi-level forms and even
password protected areas of the site
iconetix is a dynamic application
security testing package which has
definite perks over status application
security testing Frameworks which are
also known as sast scanners
sast tools only work during development
and only for specific languages and have
a history of reporting lot of false
positives whereas Dynamic testing tools
also known as dest have the ability to
streamline testing from development to
deployment with minimal issues
next on our list we have air Garden
this is a multi-use bash script used for
Linux systems to hack and audit wireless
networks like our everyday Wi-Fi router
and its counterparts
along with being able to launch denial
of service attacks on compromise
networks this multipurpose wi-fi hacking
tool has very rich features which
support multiple methods for wi-fi
hacking including WPS hacking modes WP
attacks handshake captures evil twin and
so much more
it usually needs an external network
adapter that supports monitor mode which
is necessary to be able to capture
Wireless traffic that reverse the air
channels
thanks to its open source nature air
Garden can be used with multiple
Community plugins and add-ons thereby
increasing its Effectiveness against a
wide variety of routers both in the 2.4
gigahertz and the 5 gigahertz band
finally at number 5 we have John the
Ripper
John the Ripper is an open source
password security auditing and the
password recovery tool which is
available for many operating systems
John the Ripper jumbo supports hundreds
of hash and Cipher types including for
user passwords of operating systems web
apps database servers encrypted keys and
document files
some of the key features of the tool
include offering multiple modes to speed
up the password cracking automatically
deselecting the hashing algorithm used
by the passwords and the ease of running
and configuring the tool to make it
password cracking easier
it can use dictionary attacks along with
regular brute forcing to speed up the
process of cracking the correct password
without wasting additional resources
the word is being used in these
dictionary attacks can be used by the
users and allowing for a completely
customizable process
we also have a few honorary mentions in
our list that just missed the cut
let's Parker for instance is an
automated yet fully configurable web
application security scanner that
enables you to scan websites web
applications and web services the
scanning technology is designed to help
you secure web applications easily
without any fuss so you can focus on
fixing the reported vulnerabilities
the bobsled professional is one of the
most popular penetration testing and
vulnerability finder tools and is used
for checking web application security
the term burp as it is commonly known is
a proxy based tool which is used to
evaluate the security of web-based
application and to do Hands-On testing
moving away from websites and
applications Wireshark is a free and
open source packet analyzer which was
launched in 2006. it is used for Network
troubleshooting analysis software and
Communications protocol development and
education
it captures Network traffic on the local
network and stores data for offline
analysis
vaisha captures Network traffic from
ethernet Bluetooth wireless networks and
frame relay connections
now that we learn about the different
types of tools that can be used when
conducting an ethical hacking audit
let's learn about some potential
benefits of such campaigns and why
organizations prefer to pay for such
audits
being able to identify defects from an
attacker's perspective is game changing
since it displays all the potential
Avenues of a possible hack one can only
prepare for the known vulnerabilities as
a defensive specialist but proactively
trying to breach a network or device can
make hackers think of techniques that no
defense contractors can account for this
kind of unpredictability goes a long way
in securing a network against malicious
actors
another advantage of hiring ethical
hackers is the ability to preemptively
fix possible weak points in a company's
Network infrastructure as seen on many
occasions a real breach will cause loss
of data and irreparable damage to the
foundation of an organization
being able to gauge such shortcomings
before they become public and can be
used exploited is a benefit most
organizations make use of
this is not to imply that such security
audits are only beneficial to the
organization paying for it when coming
across companies that provide certain
Services a reliable third-party security
audit goes a long way in instilling
trust and confidence over their craft if
the ethical hackers cannot find any
major vulnerabilities that can be
leveraged by hackers it just accentuates
the technical Brilliance of the
organization and its Engineers thereby
increasing the clientele by a
substantial amount
Jude is waiting at the airport to hop on
her flight back home when she realizes
that she missed making an important Bank
payment
she connects her laptop to the public
Wi-Fi at the airport and goes ahead to
carry out the bank transaction
everything goes well and Jude completes
her transaction
after a couple of days she was wiped off
her feet when she learned that her bank
account was subjected to a Cyber attack
and a hefty amount was wiped from her
account
after getting in touch with the bank
Authority she learned that her account
was hacked at the airport
she didn't realize that the public Wi-Fi
she used might have caused her this
trouble Jude wishes that Hatter bank
transfer escaped the Hacker's eyes she
would not have been a victim of a Cyber
attack
Bank officials advise her to use a VPN
for future transactions especially when
connecting to an open or public network
like most of us Jude had come across the
term VPN several times but didn't know
much about it and little did she think
that the repercussions of not using a
VPN would be this bad
let's understand how the hacker would
have exploited Jude's transaction in the
absence of a VPN
in this process Jude's computer first
connects to the internet service
provider ISP which provides access to
the internet
she sends her details to the bank's
server using her IP address
Internet Protocol address or IP address
is a unique address that recognizes a
particular device be it a laptop or
smartphone on the internet
when these details pass through the
public network the hacker who passively
watches the network traffic intercepts
it this is a passive Cyber attack where
the hacker collects Jude's Bank details
without being detected
more often or not in such an attack
payment information is likely to be
stolen the targeted data here are the
victims username passwords and other
personal information
such an unsecured connection exposed
Jude's IP address and Bank details to
the hacker when it passed through the
public network
so would you have been able to secure
her transaction with the help of a VPN
well yes
picture Jude's Bank transaction to be
happening in a tunnel that is invisible
to the hacker in such a case the hacker
will not be able to spot a transaction
and that is precisely what a VPN does
a virtual private Network more often
known as VPN creates a secure tunnel
between your device and the internet
for using a VPN Jude's First Step would
be to install software-based technology
known as the VPN client on our laptop or
smartphone that would let her establish
a secure connection the VPN client
connects to the Wi-Fi and then to the
ISP
here the VPN client encrypts Jude's
information using VPN protocols data is
encrypted to make sure it is secure
next the VPN client establishes a VPN
tunnel within the public network that
connects to the VPN server
the VPN tunnel protects Jude's
information from being intercepted by
the hacker
Jude's IP address and actual location
are changed at the VPN server to enable
a private and secure connection
finally the VPN server connects to
Jude's Bank server in the last step
where the encrypted message is decrypted
this way Jude's original IP address is
hidden by the VPN and the VPN tunnel
protects her data from being hacked this
explains how VPN makes your data
Anonymous and secure when it passes
through the public network and the
difference between a normal connection
and a VPN connection
after learning about this Jude was
certain that she should start using a
VPN to carry out her online transactions
in the future this is also applicable to
each one of us even if you work remotely
or connect to public Wi-Fi using a VPN
is the safest option
in addition to providing a secure
encrypted data transfer vpns are also
used to disguise your whereabouts and
give you access to Regional web content
VPN servers act as proxies on the
internet this way your actual location
cannot be established VPN enables you to
spoof your location and switch to a
server to another country and thereby
change your location
for example by doing so you can watch
any content on Netflix that might be
unavailable for your region meet
Jonathan he is an investigative
journalist who occasionally researches
and publishes news articles contrary to
the government's ideologies
on one such occasion he could not access
a Global News website dealing with
uncensored information it seemed his IP
was blocked from visiting the news
website
with his IP blocked Jonathan turned to a
popular proxy service that was able to
unblock the news website thereby
allowing an open internet to all users
just like how your friend gives a proxy
attendance for you a proxy server serves
as a stand-in user to keep the real
client private
but what is a proxy let's understand
it's working by taking a look at how
Jonathan was able to access geoblock
content without much hassle
a proxy server acts as a Gateway or
intermediary server between a user and
its destination website when Jonathan
wasn't able to access the news website
he connected his system to a global
proxy server once connected the proxy
server assigns a new IP address to
Jonathan's system an IP address of a
different country where the website is
not censored following this process
whenever Jonathan visits that website
the website administrators see the new
IP address assigned via proxy server and
sees no reason to deny access to their
account once the proxy server is able to
access the website it's passed on to
Jonathan's system via the same channel
regarding accessibility to proxy servers
you must first set it up on your
computer device or network next check
the steps required for your computer or
network as each operating system has its
setup procedures
in most cases however setup entails
using an automated configuration script
there are plenty of free proxy services
available on the internet
however the safety of such proxies is
rarely verified most free proxies will
provide an IP address and a relevant
port for connection purposes repeated
proxy providers like smart proxy and
write data that run on subscription
models will most likely provide
credentials to log into when
establishing the connection this extra
step acts as authentication that
verifies an existing subscription on the
proxy provider server unlike free
providers that are open to all
when it comes to hiding IP addresses
many people consider a VPN to be the
primary solution
while that's true up to some extent
there are a few things proxies do
differently
in the case of vpns extra encryption is
also carried out to create a secure
tunnel between the user's device and a
VPN server a VPN is usually much faster
more secure thanks to multiple layers of
encryption and has little to no downtime
proxies tend to be comparatively unsafe
with the service owners having the exact
IP address of the end user and having no
guarantees regarding down times and
reliability
if you want to know more about how vpns
work do watch how Jude could have
protected her banking credentials using
vpns in our detailed video linked above
now let's take a small quiz to check how
much we have learned
what can a VPN connection provide that a
proxy service cannot
a new IP address B multiple layers of
encryption
C access to geoblock content
D authentication credentials
think about it and leave your answers
Below in the comments section and three
lucky winners will receive Amazon gift
vouchers
what about the benefits of a proxy
service though
besides allowing access to block content
proxies can serve as an efficient
firewall system they can also filter
content from third-party websites
allowing control over internet usage in
many cases browsing speeds are
stabilized compared to vanilla Internet
thanks to proper optimization on the
base proxy server the element of privacy
proxies provides is highly lucrative to
people looking to hide their actual IP
address from as many crying eyes as
possible
one can easily argue the benefits of
using vpns over proxies for added
security measures however a few basic
tasks don't warrant maximum privacy for
the user's side as in other cases
for example many consumers worldwide
find proxy Services more convenient
since all major operating systems
starting from Windows to Android allow
proxy configuration without the hassle
installing new applications as is in the
case of a VPN
in addition there are services online
that function as web proxies allowing
users to access block content without
any setup from therein they can enter
the target URL and the web proxy will
route data from its physical server
this level of freedom is hard to come by
in the case of vpns making proxies an
ideal solution for casual browsing with
the next generation of Internet
exchanges focused on maximum privacy and
security a variety of ways have been
enforced to maintain them as such
censorship has been shifted from the
streets to the digital domain it forces
the standard citizen to derive
alternative ways to maintain anonymity
major weapon in this battle for privacy
and security is the Tor Browser an
independent browser meant to browse the
internet while reeling information
through the Tor Network it serves as a
meaningful alternative to the standard
internet browsing habits to better
understand the purpose of this browser
and such we must learn about the work of
the Tor Network featuring its own
routing protocol the top browser is an
easy way to maintain anonymity while
browsing without emptying one's wallet
let's take a look at the topics to be
covered today
we start at the explanation of what is
the Tor Network and its significance in
the working of the top browser
we take a look at the onion routing
protocol and how it transmits the data
from the client devices to the tort
directories in order to circumvent
government censorship
moving on we learn a few features of the
Tor Browser and the distinct advantages
the Tor Network provides
next we learn the difference between
using a VPN and a Tor to anonymize
internet usage and finally we have a
live demonstration of the Tor Browser
anonymization features in action
let's move on to learning about the Tor
Network
Tor short for the onion router it's an
open source privacy Network that permits
users to browse the web anonymously the
torque was initially developed and
solely used by the US Navy to protect
sensitive government Communications
before the network was made publicly
available
the digital era has disrupted the
traditional way of doing things in every
sector of the economy the rapid rise in
development and innovation of digital
products has given way to frequent data
breaches and cyber thefts in response
consumers are increasingly operating for
products that offer data privacy and
cyber security
Tor is one such underground Network that
was implemented for the purpose of
protecting users identities the Tor
Network is one example of the many
emerging technologies that attempt to
fill a data privacy void in a digital
space plagued by cyber security concerns
the Tor Network intercepts the traffic
from your browser and bounces a user's
request of a random number of other user
IP addresses then the data is passed to
the user requester Final Destination
these random users are volunteer devices
which are called as nodes or relays the
Tor Network disguises your identity by
encrypting the traffic and moving it
across different Tower relays within the
network
the Tor Network uses an onion routing
technique for transmitting data hence
the original name of onion router
to operate within the Tor Network a user
has to install the Tor Browser any
address or information requested using
the browser is transmitted through the
Tor Network it has its own feature set
which we will be covering over later in
this video
as we discussed already the data passing
through the Tor Network must follow a
unique protocol known as The Onion
routing protocol let us learn more about
its unique characteristics
the non-normal network usage the data is
transmitted directly the sender has data
package to transmit which is done
directly over a line of communication
with either a receiving party or a
server of some kind however since the
data can easily be captured while being
transmitted the security of this
exchange is not very reliable moreover
it becomes very easy to trace the origin
of such requests on many occasions
websites with questionable and
controversial content are blocked from
the ISP this is possible since the ISP
is able to detect and spy on user
information passing through the network
apart from isps there is a steady chance
of your private information being
intercepted by hackers unfortunately
easy detection of the source and
contents of a web request make entire
network extremely vulnerable for people
who seek anonymity over the internet
however in the onion routing protocol
things take a longer route we have a
sender with the top browser installed on
the client system the network sends the
information to node one's IP address
which encrypts the information and
passes it on to node 2's address which
performs another encryption and passes
it on to node 3 address
this is the last address which is also
known as the exit node this last node
decrypts the encrypted data and finally
relays the request to the Final
Destination which can be another device
or a server end this final address
thinks the request came from the exit
node and grants access to it the
encryption process across multiple
computers repeats itself from the exit
node to the original user
the Tor Network obfuscates user IP
addresses from unwanted surveillance by
keeping the user's requests untraceable
with multiple servers touching the data
it makes the tracking very difficult for
both isps and malicious attackers
now that we understand the way Tor works
let us learn more about the Tor Browser
the top browser was developed by a
non-profit organization as a part of the
Tor project in 2008 and its first public
release was announced
the Tor Browser is a browser Fork from
the popular Firefox that anonymizes your
web traffic using the torn Network
if you are investigating a competitor
researching and opposing litigant in a
legal dispute or just think it's creepy
for your ISP or the government to know
what websites you visit the top browser
might be the right solution
before the top browser were developed
using that Network to maintain anonymity
was a huge task for everyday consumers
starting from the setup to the usage the
entire process demanded a lot of
knowledge and practice the top browser
managed to make it easy for users to
Traverse the relay servers intor and
guarantee the privacy of the data
Exchange
a major feature of the Tor Browser is
the ability to delete all browser
history cookies and tracking data the
moment it is closed every new launch of
the browser opens an empty slate having
a usage habits from being tracked and
singled out
a major feature that is the highlight of
the Tor Network is the availability of
onion links
only a small portion of the World Wide
Web is available to the general public
we have the Deep Web that contains links
that are not allowed to be indexed by
standard search engines like Google and
Bing the dark web is a further subset of
the Deep Web which contains onion links
Tor Browser gives you access to these
dot onion websites which are only
available within the Tor Network
onion is a special use top level domain
which designates an anonymous onion
service which is also known as a hidden
service similar to The Links of the Deep
Web these onion links provide services
like online shopping cryptocurrency and
many other products not available in the
consumer Internet space
often being considered as a Haven for
illegal activities and sales on your
links provide both information and
Assets in a private manner without the
risk of spying by authorities
browsing the web over Tor is slower than
the clear net due to the multiple layers
of encryption
some web services also blocked our users
Tor Browser is also illegal in
authoritarian regimes that want to
prevent citizens from Reading publishing
and communicating anonymously
journalists and dissidents around the
world have embraced store as a
Cornerstone of democracy and researchers
are hard at work at improving towards
anonymity properties
let us take a look at some of the
advantages of using the Tor Browser of a
standard web browsers
the highlight of using the Tor Browser
is to maintain anonymity over the
Internet the cause for such requests can
differ from person to person but all of
these concerns are answered by the torn
Network routing the information via
multiple nodes and relay servers make it
entirely difficult for the ISP to keep a
track of usage data
the entire top project is designed to be
completely free and open source allowing
the code for the browser to be inspected
and audited by Third parties helps in
the early detection of faulty
configurations and critical bugs it is
present for multiple operating system
starting from laptops to mobile devices
a number of websites are blocked by
governments for a variety of reasons
journalists under authoritarian regimes
have difficulty in getting the word out
regarding the situation since the onion
routing protocol transfers data between
multiple servers of random countries the
domains being blocked become available
when used via tor usage of these
encryption messaging platforms is easily
enforced using the Tor Browser which
otherwise would have been a difficult
task under oppressive circumstances
many people believe that a VPN offers
the same benefits as the top browser
let's put both of them to the test and
see the differences between them
coming to the first point of difference
Tor is completely free and open source
all of the code for the browser and the
network can be audited and has been
cleared for security concerns when it
comes to VPN there are many different
brands which have open source clients
but the same cannot be said for their
counterparts some have partly open
source while some have completely locked
up their code so that they cannot be
stored in further
moving on Tor has multiple relay points
in its data transfer protocol between
the server and the receiver there are
three different IP nodes that number can
increase but it will always be more than
two
once the data is passed from the
surrender it goes through all of those
Julia points while in the case of a VPN
the connection is made from the client
device to the VPN server and then to the
requested destination there is no other
IP node that comes into work here
thereby making the connection a one to
one between the client and a VPN
as a next Point since store handles
multiple layers of encryption and the
data passes through multiple systems
along the way the performance is slow
compared to a VPN where the performance
is relatively fast due to the less
number of nodes the data passes through
similarly the multi-layer encryption of
Tor is consistent if you use Tor Browser
every single request passes through the
same layer of encryption and follows the
same routing protocol in the case of a
VPN different companies offer different
levels of encryption some have multi-hop
some prefer a single one-to-one
connection and these kind of differences
make the choice much more variable
finally the nodes and relays being used
in the Tor Network are volunteer there
is no company holding over them so
jurisdiction becomes relatively
straightforward for instance in the case
of vpns many such vpns are hosted by
adware companies or are being monitored
by Central governments to note the usage
information
now that we have a better understanding
of the Tor Browser and its routing let
us take a look at how the Tor Browser
can anonymize and protect our internet
usage
on opening up the Tor Browser for the
first time this is the page that you are
going to be welcomed with you have the
option of connecting to the Tor Network
before we start our browsing
so let's press connect
and we can see that it is connected
coming to the anonymization let's check
my current location on Google Chrome
currently is showing as Navi Mumbai in
Maharashtra
if we check this same link on the Tor
Browser we should get a different
address
now every link that you open in the Tor
Browser will be little delayed and the
speed will be hampered because of the
multiple layers of encryption like we
discussed now as you can see
it's showing a German IP and the state
of Bavaria
this is how the anonymization works
there is no VPN configured there is no
proxy attached it's straight up this out
of the box settings that come inbuilt
with the Tor Browser
similarly we have an option of cleaning
up the data let's say if you want to
refresh your location and you want to
use a different ID for the next browsing
session if we just restart it once
and you can have to check it again
we should be seeing a different country
this time
as you can see we have Netherlands right
now so this is how we can keep
refreshing your address you can keep
refreshing your host location so that it
cannot be tracked when it browsing the
internet
like we discussed we have some onion
links that can only be used on the Tor
Network
as you can see these kind of links do
not open in the Google Chrome browser
but once we copy these over to the Tor
Browser
as you can see we have opened the hidden
wiki which is available only on the Tor
Network
this is kind of an alternative Wikipedia
website where we can find articles to
read and more information to learn
similarly we have another onion link
over here
which is once again available only for
the tall browser
now these kind of delays are expected
but they are a valid compromise because
they maintain the anonymity that many
people desire
similarly we have found a hidden wallet
which is a cryptocurrency wallet which
is specifically for dark web members
this operates over the Tor Network and
this is used by mostly journalists and
people who want to anonymize their
internet transactions when it comes to
dealing money
all of the transactions that occur over
the torn Network are almost impossible
to track therefore these kind of
cryptocurrency wallets are very big on
the Deep Web this is just one example
while having multiple different wallets
for every single cryptocurrency
available imagine our houses without a
fence or boundary wall
this would make our properly easy
accessible to trespassers and robbers
and place our homes at Great risk right
hence fencing our property helps
Safeguard it and keeps trespassers at
Bay
similarly imagine our computers and
networks without protection
this would increase the probability of
hackers infiltrating our Networks to
overcome this challenge just like how
boundary walls protect our houses a
virtual wall helps Safeguard and secure
our devices from Intruders and such a
wall is known as a firewall firewalls
are security devices that filter the
incoming and outgoing traffic within a
private Network
for example
if you were to visit your friend who
lives in a gated community you would
First Take permission from the security
guard the security guard would check
with your friend if you should be
allowed to entry or not if all is well
your access is granted on the other hand
the security guard would not Grant
permission to a trespasser looking to
enter the same premises here the entry
access depends solely on your friend the
resident's discretion
the role of the security guard in this
case is similar to that of a firewall
the firewall works like a gatekeeper at
your computer's entry point which only
welcomes incoming traffic that it has
been configured to accept firewalls
filter the network traffic within your
network and analyzes which traffic
should be allowed or restricted based on
a set of rules in order to spot and
prevent cyber attacks your computer
communicates with the internet in the
form of network packets that hold
details like the source address
destination address and information
these Network packets enter your
computer through ports a firewall works
on a set of rules based on the details
of these Network packets like their
Source address a destination address
content and port numbers only trusted
traffic sources or IP addresses are
allowed to enter your network
when you connect your computer to the
internet there is a high chance of
hackers infiltrating your network
this is when a firewall comes to your
Rescue by acting as a barrier between
your computer and the internet
firewall rejects the malicious data
packet and thus protects your network
from hackers on the other hand traffic
from trusted websites is allowed access
to your network
this way the firewall carries out quick
assessments to detect malware and other
suspicious activities thereby protecting
your network from being susceptible to a
Cyber attack
firewalls can either be Hardware or
software software firewalls are programs
installed on each computer this is also
called a host firewall meanwhile
Hardware firewalls are equipments that
are established between the Gateway and
your network Linksys routers are a good
example of a hardware firewall
besides this there are other types of
firewalls designed based on their
traffic filtering methods structure and
functionality the firewall that compares
each outgoing and incoming Network
packet to a set of established rules
such as the allowed IP addresses IP
protocols port number and other aspects
of the packet is known as a packet
filtering firewall
the incoming Network traffic is not for
the predefined rules that traffic is
blocked a variant of the packet
filtering firewall is the stateful
inspection firewall these types of
firewalls not only examine each Network
packet but also checks whether or not
that Network packet is part of an
established network connection such
firewalls are also referred to as
Dynamic packet filtering firewalls our
next type of firewall is called a proxy
firewall
this draws close comparison to how you
give proxy attendance for a friend like
how you take the authority to represent
your friend the proxy firewall pretends
to be you and interacts with the
internet they come between you and the
internet and thereby prevents direct
connections this protects your device's
identity and keeps the network safe from
potential attacks only if the incoming
data packet contents are protected the
proxy firewall transfers it to you they
are also known as application Level
Gateway
the firewall can spot malicious actions
and block your computer from receiving
data packets from harmful sources in
addition to preventing cyber attacks
firewalls are also used in educational
institutions and offices to restrict
users access to certain websites or
applications it is used to avoid access
to unauthorized content it's the year
2015 and Richard has just finished
playing games on his computer
after a long gaming session Richard
tries to shut it down to find some
random text file on the desktop that
says Ransom note the text file mentioned
how a hacking group had encrypted
Richard's game files and private
documents and he had to pay a ransom of
500 worth of bitcoin in the specified
Bitcoin address Richard quickly checked
his files only to see them being
encrypted and unreadable
story of how the Tesla Crypt ransomware
spread in 2015 which affected thousands
of Gamers before releasing the master
key used for encrypting the files so
what is ransomware
for Richard to be targeted by such an
attack he must have installed
applications from untrusted sources or
clicked an unverified link both of them
can function as gateways for a
ransomware breach ransomware is a type
of malware that encrypts personal
information and documents while
demanding a ransom amount to decrypt
them this Ransom payment is mainly done
using cryptocurrency to ensure anonymity
but can also employ other routes once
the files are encrypted or locked behind
a password a text files available to the
victim explaining how to make the ransom
payment and unlock the files for it just
like Richard found the ransom note text
file on his desktop even after the money
has been paid there's no guarantee that
the hackers will send the decryption key
or unlock the files but in certain
sensitive situations victims make the
payment hoping for the best having never
been introduced to ransomware attacks
before this gave Richard an opportunity
to learn more about this and he began
his research on the topic
spread of ransomware mostly starts with
phishing attacks to know more about
phishing attacks click the link in the
button above users tend to click on
unknown links received via emails and
chat applications promising rewards of
some nature once clicked the ransomware
files installed on the system that
encrypts all the files or blocks access
to computer functions they can also be
spread via malware transmitted via
untrusted application installation or
even a compromised wireless network
another way to breach a system with
ransomware is by using the remote
desktop protocol or RDP access
a computer can be accessed remotely
using this protocol allowing a hacker to
install malicious software on the system
with the owner unaware of these
developments coming to the different
types of ransomware first we have Locker
ransomware which is the type of malware
that blocks standard computer functions
from being accessed until the payment to
the hackers is complete it shows a lock
screen that doesn't allow the victim to
use the computer for even basic purposes
another type is crypto ransomware which
encrypts the local files and documents
in the computers
once the files are encrypted finding the
decryption key is impossible unless the
ransomware variant is old and the keys
are already available on the internet
scareware is fake software that claims
to have detected a virus or other issue
on your computer and directs you to pay
to resolve the problem some types of
scareware lock the computer While others
simply flood the screen with pop-up
alerts without actually damaging files
to prevent getting affected by
ransomware Richard could have followed a
few steps to further enhance his
security
one must always have backups of their
data cloud storage for backup is easy
but a physical backup in a hard drive is
always recommended
keeping the system updated with the
latest security patches is always a good
idea
apart from system updates one must
always have reputed antivirus software
installed
mini antivirus software like Kaspersky
and bitdefender have anti-ransomware
features that periodically check for
encryption of private documents when
browsing the internet a user must always
check for the lock Sim on the address
bar which signifies the presence of
https protocol for additional security
if a system is infected with ransomware
already there is a website
nomoreransom.org it has a collection of
decryption tools for most well-known
ransomware packages it can also help
decrypt specific encrypted files if the
list of anti-ransomware tools didn't
help the victim
if you are looking to dive deep into the
world of cyber security then become an
expert with postgraduate program and
cyber security so hurry up and end on
now get the complete course details in
the description box if you are looking
to have a smart entry in this field then
simply learn offers a six months program
Caltech cyber security boot camp find
the complete course details from the
link in the description box and pin
comment the year was 1971. an engineer
named Bob Thompson at BBN an American
research and development company later
acquired by ratheon created the world's
first virus proof of concept dubbed The
Creep
although credited and referenced by
various entities as the world's first
computer virus the creeper actually
exhibited the behavior of a war
I am the creeper and Catch Me If You Can
this is what the virus said and the
world was never the same with over 12
types of malwares and over 100 types of
viruses lurking around the network
channels of the internet waiting to curb
innocent users and exploit
vulnerabilities the 21st century saw a
tremendous growth in cyber crimes so
let's start with what is malware malware
is a short form for malicious software
and it's like a sneaky digital Intruder
that infiltrates your device without
permission it's created by cyber
criminals who want to disrupt damage or
gain unauthorized access to your
personal information financial data or
even control your device remotely
think of malware as a digital bully
that's up to no good
so let's understand how does a malware
work
Step 1 intrusion malware sneaks into
your device through various entry points
like malicious email attachments
infected websites software
vulnerabilities or even through
removable storage devices like USB
drives
Step 2 is execution once inside the
malware starts executing its malicious
code it may install additional files
modify system settings or create hidden
processes in the background to evade
detection
step 3 is persistence to maintain
control over your device malware often
tries to establish persistence it may
create registered entries modify startup
settings or hide in system folders
ensuring it launches every time you boot
up your device
next step is exploitation malware takes
advantage of vulnerabilities in your
operating system applications or network
to spread its reach it may exploit
security weaknesses to propagate across
networks in fact other devices are steel
sensitive information
the step 5 is malicious activities now
that the malware has settled in it
carries out its intended actions
depending on its type this could include
stealing personal information capturing
keystrokes encrypting files displaying
unwanted ads or even hijacking your
device for cyber criminals remote
control
the next step is concealment malware
often employs techniques to hide its
presence and avoid detection it may use
rootkit technology to hide its files and
processes employee anti-analysis
measures or encrypt its communication
with command and control servers to
evade security measures the last step is
damage or profit ultimately malware aims
to achieve its malicious objective it
may cause damage to your system
compromise your privacy steal financial
information or create opportunities for
cyber criminals to profit have you ever
wondered how it feels to be a cyber
security expert after gaining a
certification so let's take a minute to
hear it out from our Learners who have
experienced massive success in their
career after taking the cyber security
course now that we have a good idea of
how does a malware work let's understand
the different types of malware more than
12 types of malwares are present in the
world today and each of them is
threatening to different extent so let's
discuss some of the most common and
hazardous malwares the first is virus a
classic Troublemaker that attaches
itself to a program or file replicating
and spreading across your system it can
corrupt or destroy data and even render
your device useless
the second one is warm a sneaky creature
that replicates itself and spreads
across networks causing congestion and
slowing down systems it can also exploit
vulnerabilities to gain unauthorized
access
the next one is Trojan Horse inspired by
the ancient Greek tale this malware
disguises itself as a legitimate
software tricking you into installing it
once inside it opens a back door giving
cyber criminals remote control over your
device
the next is ransomware this villainous
malware holds your data hostage by
encrypting it the Cyber criminals then
demand a ransom to restore axis leaving
you feel like a character in a digital
hostage situation next is spyware a nosy
little malware that secretly monitors
your activities collecting sensitive
informations like password browsing
habits and even keystrokes talk about an
Envision of privacy
the next one is adware
an annoying Troublemaker that bombards
you with unwanted advertisements pop-ups
and redirects it's like a clingy digital
salesperson that never takes no foreign
answer
so those are some of the truly menacing
types of malware but knowledge is power
so how can we protect ourselves from
these digital villains
the first step is keep your software up
to date regularly update your operating
system into virus software and
applications these updates often include
security pages to fix vulnerabilities
use strong and unique passwords avoid
using common or easy to guess passwords
opt for a combination of letters numbers
and symbols next is be cautious while
you are online avoid clicking on
suspicious links downloading files from
untrustworthy sources or opening email
attachments from unknown senders stay
vigilant next one is install reputable
antivirus software
invest in reliable antivirus software
that can detect and remove malwares last
is backup your data regularly backup
your important files and data to an
external hard drive or cloud storage
that way even if your device gets
infected you can restore your files
anytime
so I guess you guys must have got a good
idea about what is a malware and how to
stay safe from a malware let's take a
look at the introduction for two
different types of malware virus
androgen
firstly let's take a look what exactly
is a virus program
a computer virus is a type of malicious
program that on execution replicates
itself
they get attached to different files and
programs which are termed as host
programs by inserting their code if the
attachment succeeds the targeted program
is termed as infected with a computer
virus now let's take a look at the
trojanos
Trojan Horse program is a program that
disguises itself as a legitimate program
but harms a system on installation
they hide within the attachments and
emails then transfer from one system to
another they create bad doors into a
system to allow the Cyber criminal to
steal our information
let's take a look how they function
after getting installed into a system
firstly we have virus programs the
computer virus must contain two parts to
infect the system
first is a surge routine which locates
new files and data that is to be
infected by the virus program
and the second part is known as the copy
routine which is necessary for the
program to copy itself into the targeted
file which is located by the search
routine now let's take a look at the
Trojan Horse functioning
for Trojan horses entryway into a system
is through emails that may look
legitimate but may have unknown
attachments and when such files are
downloaded into the device the closure
program gets installed and infects the
system
they also infect the system on the
execution of infected application or the
executable file an attacks the system
now that we understand what virus and
Trojans are let's understand different
types of virus androgens
let's take a look at different types of
viruses
the first one is known as the boot
sector virus this type of virus damages
the booting section of the system by
infecting the masterbot record which is
also known as MBI
this damages the booth sector section by
targeting the hard disk of the system
then we have the macro virus microvirus
is a type of virus that gets embedded
into the document related data and is
executed when the file is open
they also are designed to replicate
themselves and infect the system on a
larger scale
and lastly we have the direct action
virus
this type of virus gets attached to
executable files which on execution
activates the virus program and infects
the system
once the infection of the file is
completed they exit the system which is
also the reason it is known as a
non-resident virus
let's take a look at different types of
Trojans
the first type of Trojan is the back
door
they are designed to create a back door
in the system on execution of an
infected program
they provide remote access of a system
to the hacker this way the Cyber
criminal can steal our system data and
may use it for illegal activities next
we have
quick source Frozen
they enter the system by clicking the
random pop-ups which we come across on
the internet
they attempt the user to give their
personal details for different
transactions or schemes
which may provide remote access of a
system to the Cyber Criminal
and the last Rosen type is Ransom Trojan
this type of corrosion program after
entering the system blocks the user from
accessing its own system and also
affects the system function
the Cyber criminal Demands a ransom from
the targeted user for the removal of the
Trojan program from the device now that
we understand some details regarding
viruses and Trojan let's solve a
question
the question is Jake was denied access
to his system and he wasn't able to
control the data and information in a
system
now the actual question is what could be
the reason behind a systems problem
option a macro Iris option b Ransom
Trojan option C Backlot version
give your answers in the comment section
now let's understand how to detect the
activity of viruses and Trojan in our
system
to detect virus or Trojan activity in a
system we can refer to the following
points for viruses we have slowing down
of the system and frequent application
freeze shows that the infection of the
virus is present in the system
then we have the viruses can also steal
sensitive data including passwords
Account Details which may lead to
unexpected logout from the accounts or
Corruption of the sensitive data and
lastly we have frequent system crashes
due to virus infection which damages the
operating system
for Trojan we have frequent system
crashes and system also faces slow
reaction time
then we have there are more random
pop-ups from the system which may
indicate Trojan activity and lastly we
have modification in the system
application and change of the desktop
appearance can be also due to the
infection of a Trojan program
next let's take a look at a famous Cyber
attack for virus and nitrogenous
for virus we have the midum virus which
was identified in the ER 2004 which
affected over 50 million systems by
creating a network of sending spam
emails
which was to gain backdoor access into
our systems
next for the Trojan Horse we have the
emote atrogen program
which is specifically designed for
financial theft and for stealing Bank
related information
next we have few points for how to
prevent virus entry or Trojan attack for
a system
the most basic way of virus protection
is to using antivirus and do regular
viruses can this will prevent virus
entry in the system and also having more
than one antivirus provides much better
protection
then avoid visiting uncertified websites
can also prevent virus entry into a
system
then we have using regular driver
updates and system updates to prevent
virus entry
for corrosion we have using certified
softwares from legal sites to prevent
any Trojan activity in our system
and also avoid clicking random pop-ups
that we often see on the internet
and lastly using antivirus and firewalls
for protection against Trojan horses is
a good habit
now that we have reached the end of the
video Let's Take a look what we learned
for the first part we saw the main
objective of the virus is to harm the
data and information in a system whereas
for the Trojan we have stealing of the
data files and information
effect of viruses is more drastic in
comparison to the Trojan horses
then we have viruses which are
non-remote programs whereas Trojan
horses are remote accessed and lastly
viruses have the ability to replicate
itself to harm multiple files whereas
Trojan does not have the replication
ability so let's begin with what is SQL
injection
as the name suggests SQL injection
vulnerability allows an attacker to
inject Mauritius input into a SQL
statement so SQL stands for structured
query language which is a language used
by an application to interact with the
database now normally this attack is
targeted towards the database to extract
the data that is stored within however
the vulnerability does not lie in the
database itself the vulnerability will
always lie in the application
it is the developer's prerogative of how
to develop the application how to
configure it to prevent SQL injection
queries from happening a database is
created to answer questions and if a
question is asked it is supposed to
answer it database needs to be
configured for some amount of security
but the vulnerability the flaw here for
SQL injection will always lie in the
application itself it does how the
application interacts with the database
that needs to be modified that needs to
be maintained by the developer rather
than just configuring the database
itself so the attacker at this point in
time when they send a query to the
application will form a malformed query
by injecting a particular command or an
operator that is recognized by the SQL
language and if that operator is passed
through the application to the database
then the database basically gets cracked
or does a data dump because of that
unwanted character coming in so this
character needs to be filtered at the
application Level itself now let's look
at a quick demo so what we have done
here is I have this virtual machine
called ovasp broken web applications
virtual machine version 1.2 I'm going to
power this on
till this power is on I'm going to show
you where we can download this utility
from so you can just
look for ovasp broken web application
project download you'll find it on
sourcefold.net click on the link
you can download the broken web
application project from here this is a
1.9 GB download and you can have a zip
machine directly for VMware or every
Oracle virtual box
now this is an application that has been
developed by ovasp which stands for open
web application security project which
is a not-for-profit organization and
periodically releases the most top 10
risks that an application uh will face
for that particular year
so they have given a web application
with inbuilt vulnerabilities for
professionals like us to practice upon
to developables our skills upon because
doing this in the real world is illegal
I cannot go onto a website to
demonstrate how a SQL injection attack
works
uh neither should you try your hands on
it till you become very well rehearsed
with it so till to upgrade your skills
to upskill yourself please download this
machine host it in a VMware Workstation
or a Oracle virtual box and you can uh
then try your skills on it right so just
going back to the browser here if I open
up uh a new tab you'll see that this
machine has booted up and has an IP
address called 71.132 so if I just go on
to that IP address and I type in 192 168
71.132
and you'll see the OS broken web
application project and there are a lot
of training applications realistic
intentionally vulnerable applications
old versions of real applications and so
on so forth so there is a lot of
applications in built over here that you
can try your skills upon we are going to
try to use the ovas mutility over here
uh this gives you the uh OS top 10 risks
for 2010 2013 2017 is the latest one so
far uh but the difference between 2013
and 2017 is that some of these have
changed but not all of them the order
has changed a little bit but you can see
that SQL injection is on the top A1
amongst the injection attacks right and
you can see there are multiple types
that have been given here the SQL
injection for extracting data or SQL
injection for bypass authentication or
insert your injection
attacks blind SQL injection and then
there is a tool called SQL map which is
available freely on on your Linux
machines Kali Linux or parrot Linux
whichever you want to use uh for your
practice targets and so on so forth so
if I just take you here for bypass
Authentication
and this is a regular login page that an
application may have right you look at a
username you look at password you type
that in and you log in so let's say I
don't know a password here I'm just
going to type in a username test
password is
passwrd I'll try to log in and it shows
me that the account does not exist so
the authentication mechanism does work I
did try type in a username and password
it wasn't recognized so the account does
not exist now let's try to type in a SQL
query here I'm going to just give it a
single quote which is an operator that
is recognized by the SQL language which
when the database tries to execute uh
will cause the database to dump some
data or to bypass authentication in this
case and I'm going to give it a
condition single quote
or one equals one space hyphen hyphen
space and I'm going to click on login
now right now I'm not logged in at all
and we tried our username and password
and we weren't able to log in so now if
I log in you will see that it gives me a
status update saying the user has been
authenticated and I'm logged in as admin
got root so that is what these SQL
queries can achieve I'm going to log out
right now and we're going to look at the
basics of SQL injection so looking at
that small demo looking now let's look
at what types of secret injections are
available so the first is inbound SQL
injection the uh there are two subtypes
within in band error based injection
attack and a union based injection
attack the second type is blind SQL
injection attack where there's a Boolean
based and a time-based attack and the
third one is out of bound SQL injection
attack now what is Advanced SQL
injection attack in bandage where we are
either attempting the error base or the
union base what is error based uh we
send a query to the database we craft a
query to the database and it generates
an error message and it dumps the error
message right in front of us on the
screen that makes us realize that there
is a flaw and there there is some
information that is dumped on the screen
which we can then further utilize to
craft our further queries as we go ahead
whereas Union based is the it is where
we combine multiple statements at the
same time so if you look at the URL
earlier in the URL you would see a large
structure in that URL uh we can try to
add more two or more statements within
the URL itself to combine them and then
confuse the database into executing both
the statements together and giving a
data dump at the same time right so what
would a error based uh SQL injection
look like if I go back to the same
database uh which is here right and if
you remember the username we gave it a
single quote or one equals one space
hyphen hyphen space we gave it the
condition right so basically what it did
was this a single quote is an operator
that goes to the database selects the
default uh table in the user tables in
this database column and then Compares
it to the condition that is given so the
condition that we gave was of 1 equals 1
which is always true so what it did was
it selected the default user table that
was available in the database and
instead of comparing it to a password it
compared it to the condition so if I
give it 1 equals 2 where the condition
is false and if I log in you will see
that the account doesn't exist comes
back again because the condition was
false and instead of comparing the user
account to the password it basically
compared the user account to the
condition so if I give it a single quote
or 1 equals one hyphen iPhone space
and login you can see that this is a
correct condition and thus we are able
to log in now before we even go to that
extent if I just forget the condition
over here and just give it a single
quote the operator and I send this
operator to the database and I click on
login you will see that it generates an
error which is right on top and it tells
us the line the file the error happened
and you can see it happened in the MySQL
handler.php file right and then it gives
us the message you have an error in your
SQL syntax check the manual that
corresponds to your MySQL server version
for the right syntax to use now why
would a hacker want to do this in the
first place because there are different
types of databases so there is a MySQL
Ms SQL or Microsoft SQL Oracle SQL IBM
db2 all of these are variations of the
SQL database they use the SQL language
however every database has its own
Command right there they have their own
syntax they have their own uh specific
commands that are utilized for the
database so in this scenario the hacker
wants to identify what database is being
currently utilized so they can craft
those particular queries so now with
this injection with just me sending the
quote and the error getting generated I
now come to know that we are using a
MySQL server and the version of that
server is 5.1.73 and uh the rest of the
information about uh where the handlers
are located and so on so forth
right this gives the information to the
hacker of how they want to proceed next
what kind of queries they want to create
what kind of syntax they want to utilize
so error base attack is where you
generate these kind of Errors uh and you
get this information the union base is
where you craft your queries within the
URL or you can try to combine multiple
statements within the input fields and
try to generate a response from that
when we come to Boolean based SQL
injection uh sends a SQL query to the
database which forces the application to
return a different wizard depending on
whether the query runs a true or a false
result so basically if the input is
false the input both the inputs are
false the output would be false there's
one input that is false the other input
that is true input B the output would be
true and so on so forth right so
depending on the result from the inputs
the attacker will come to know which
input is true with this you can then
access the database of the website so
you're trying to figure out by sending
out multiple inputs and then analyzing
the output to see what exactly which
command exactly worked what was the
resultant output of that command thus
from this kind of an information the
hacker can infer their next step forward
then you have time based SQL injections
uh now there are times when a database
administered or an application
administrator has done some security
configuration and thus have disabled
verbose error messages now what is a
verbose error message the error message
that we saw right here
is a verbose error message that means
that the message gives out details the
message gives out details about what the
database is the version and whatnot so
if
they have sanitized these errors
and you no longer can generate these
errors and thus you cannot figure out
what database is then what do you do
right for example if I just take you to
Simply learn
okay
foreign
take you to a URL that is supposedly not
accessible you can see that it gives a
generic error oops like it looks like
you have crash landed on Mars it doesn't
give you a verbose error that we saw
here so this gives us a detail error of
what went wrong where it gives us the
database the version of the database and
where the query went wrong and etc etc
etc whereas on this side where there's
some there's a lot of security that goes
in here so you can see that it doesn't
generate a error it just get a generic
page in front of you so in that case
what does a hacker do so the hacker then
injects a time-based
uh query in the URL which allows us to
verify whether the command is being
executed or not so we put in a Time
weight
let's say 10 seconds of time wait so if
we the moment we inject the query if the
query times for 10 seconds and then gets
executed that means that the SQL
injection is possible however
if we inject the query and it just gets
executed without the delay that means
that the time uh injection attack would
not be uh possible on that particular
site out of bound is not a very common
attack it depends on the features being
enabled on the database management
system that has been used by the web
application so this can be a somewhat of
a misconfiguration error by the database
administrator where you have enabled
functions and not sanitize them so you
have not done in access controls
properly you have not given account
control so queries should never be
executed at an administrative level they
should always be executed a user level
with minimum privileges that are
required for that query to be executed
now if you're allowing these kind of
functions
to be to be enabled at the dbms and
there is an administrative account that
can have access to them at that point in
time and out of bound injection attack
is possible so let's look at how our
website works right uh how SQL works on
a website now the website is constructed
of HTML hypertext markup language which
would include JavaScript for
functionality cascading style sheets for
the mapping of the website right and
then react.js and whatnot uh for for the
functionality now when we send a query
to the website it is normally using the
HTTP protocol or https protocol when the
query reaches the application the
application would then go ahead and
generate the SQL query uh at the client
side you'll have all these scripting
languages coming in on the front end
that we can utilize to craft queries and
then send them across at the server side
you'll have uh databases like Oracle
MySQL MSC well and so on so forth that
will then execute those queries right so
just to give you an example if I use a
tool called Postman
what we generally do when we craft a
query is we send out a get request
to the website and then we'll see a
response from the site with the HTML
code and everything so this is a tool
that is utilized by software testers to
test the responses that you're going to
get from various websites so yeah on the
left hand side you can see I've used it
on quite a bit uh here we have an
example for gmail.com so let's continue
with that so this is a get request being
sent to Gmail the moment I sent it is
going to create an HTTP request and send
it across the response that I get is
this this is the HTML code for gmail.com
right these are the cookies these are
the headers that include information so
it you can see this is a text HTML
character set utilized is utf-8 and the
configuration uh that has been done with
the application right so this is where
uh everything comes in this is the
cookie that has been sent with that
particular request that I had sent out
now if you Analyze This query right so
when we went on to this application and
I typed in that single quote and we
generated this error right uh you can
see that the application converted this
into a SQL query so the query was select
username from accounts where the
username in quote single quotes and we
use this code right the single code
right there so uh that's where we use
that operator and that's where the
exception error occurred so these are
the kind of queries that are structured
by the application and then taken on to
the database for execution when we type
in uh it is a HTTP get request with the
username and password within that query
that is sent to the application the
application converts it into a SQL query
sends it to the database and the
database responds with the appropriate
response so how do we prevent SQL
injection in the first place
use prepared statement and parameterized
queries these statements make sure that
the parameters pass into SQL statements
are treated in a safe manner so for
example we saw that the single code was
an operator
this shouldn't be allowed to be utilized
in the first place right so here what we
are doing here is a secure way of
running a SQL query in the jdbc using a
parameterized statement Define which
user we want to find so there's a string
the email comes in connection to the
database we are going to figure out how
the connection is going to be passed how
it is going to be created construct the
SQL statement we want to run specifying
the parameter right so we Define how is
it going to be uh created what is going
to be created what can be passed to the
database and what should not be passed
to the database
so that is one way of utilizing prepaid
statements and parameterized queries
then we have object relational mapping
most development teams prefer to use
objection object relational mapping
Frameworks to evade the translation of
SQL results set into code objects more
seamless so this is an example of object
relational mapping
where we map certain objects
and allow that to be executed and then
escaping inputs in a simple way to
protect against most SQL injection
attacks many languages have standard
functions to achieve this right so you
need to be very careful while using
Escape characters in your code base when
a SQL statement is constructed not all
injection attacks rely on abuse of code
characters so you need to know what
characters are being utilized in the
configuration that you have created in
the structure that you have created in
the code that you have created uh which
characters are being recognized as
operators you need to sanitize those
operators and you need to uh basically
ensure that these operators cannot be
accepted as user input if they are
they're feeded or well application and
they never reach the database other
methods of preventing SQL injection are
password hashing so that passwords
cannot be bypassed the passwords cannot
be recovered passwords cannot be cracked
uh third party authentication you use
oauth or some other service for a single
sign-on mechanism does you rely on a
third party
to maintain the security of
authentication and what kind of
parameters are passed for example uh
using LinkedIn logins or Facebook logins
right uh for the Layman you normally go
on to Facebook and you allow if you're
using a game right if you start playing
a game you're allowed to log into the
game using your Facebook credentials or
your Google credentials now that is not
just for ease of use but the game user
the developer has outsourced the
authentication mechanisms to third
parties such as Facebook or Google
because they understand that that
authentication mechanism is as safe as
can be Facebook and Google are wealthy
organizations uh hire a lot of Security
Experts and the development for their
authentication mechanisms is Top Notch
small organization cannot spend that
kind of money on security itself right
so you use a third party authentication
mechanism to ensure that these kind of
attacks may not happen then web
application firewalls uh having a web
application firewall and configuring it
properly uh for SQL injection attacks is
one of the Sure Shot method of
mitigating or minimizing the threat in
the first place so at this point in time
you have realized that the application
has some vulnerabilities for SQL
injection and instead of recoding or
restructuring the application uh you
want to take the easier way out or the
cheaper way out so what you do is you
you install a web application firewall
and you configure the web application
firewall to identify malicious queries
and stop them at the firewall level
itself so they never reach the
application and thus the vulnerabilities
on the application don't get executed
buy better software
and keep on updating the software so
it's not necessary that once you have a
software you install it it's going to be
safe for Life new vulnerabilities are
discovered every day every hour and it
may so happen what is secure today
may be completely insecure tomorrow or
the day after right so you need to keep
on upgrading the software if there are
no upgrades available and the volume it
is still exists you might want to
migrate to a better software and thus
ensure that you don't get hacked right
always update and use patches
organizations keep on sending out
updates and patches as and when they are
released you need to install them to
enhance your security postures and then
continuously monitor SQL statements and
databases use protocol monitors uh use
different softwares use the firewalls to
keep on monitoring what kind of queries
you're getting and based on those
queries you want to ensure the inputs
and the queries that are creating uh are
not detrimental to the health of the
software that you have
Jane is relaxing at home when she
receives an email from a bank that asks
her to update her credit card pin in the
next 24 hours as a security measure
judging the severity of the message Jane
follows the link provided in the email
on delivering her current credit card
pin and the supposedly updated one the
website became unresponsive which
prompted her to try sometime later
however after a couple of hours she
noticed a significant purchase from a
random website on that same credit card
which she never authorized frantically
contacting the bank Jane realized the
original email was a counterfeit or a
fake message with a malicious link that
Intel credit card fraud this is a
classic example of a phishing attack
fishing attacks are a type of social
engineering where a fraudulent message
is sent to a Target on the premise of
arriving from a trusted Source its basic
purpose is to trick the victim into
revealing sensitive information like
passwords and payment information it's
based on the word fishing which works on
the concept of baits if a supposed
victim catches the bait the attack can
go ahead which in our case makes Jane
the fish and the phishing emails the
bait if Jane never opened the malicious
link or was cautious about the email
authenticity an attack of this nature
would have been relatively ineffective
but how does the hacker gain access to
these credentials a phishing attack
starts with a fraudulent message which
can be transmitted via email or chat
applications even using SMS
conversations to impersonate legitimate
sources is known as smishing which is a
specific category of phishing attacks
irrespective of the manner of
transmission the message targets the
victim in a way that coaxes them to open
a malicious link and provide critical
information on the requisite website
more often than not the websites are
designed to look as authentic as
possible once the victims submit
information using the link be it a
password or credit card details the data
is sent to the hacker who designed the
email and the fake website giving him
complete control over the account whose
password was just provided often carried
out in campaigns or an identical fishing
mail sent to thousands of users the rate
of success is relatively low but never
zero between 2013 and 2015 corporate
giants like Facebook and Google were
tricked off of 100 million dollars due
to an extensive fishing campaign where a
known common associate was impersonated
by the hackers apart from credit access
some of these campaigns Target the
victim device and install malware when
clicked on the malicious links
which can later function as a botnet or
a target for ransomware attacks there is
no single formula for there are multiple
categories of phishing attacks the issue
with Jane or the hacker stole our bank
credentials falls under the umbrella of
deceptive fishing a general email is
sent out to thousands of users in this
category hoping some of them fall prey
to this scam
spearfishing on the other hand is a bit
customized version the targets are
researched before being sent an email
for example if you never had a Netflix
subscription sending you an email that
seems like the Netflix Team sends it
becomes pointless this is a potential
drawback of deceptive phishing
techniques on the other hand a simple
screenshot of a Spotify playlist being
shared on social media indicates a
probable point of entry
the hacker can send counterfeit messages
to the Target user while applying the
source of such messages being Spotify
tricking them into sharing private
information
since the hacker already knows the
target uses Spotify the chances of
victims taking the bait increase
substantially
for more important targets like CEOs and
people with a fortune on their back the
research done is 10 full which can be
called a case of whaling the hackers
prepare and wait for the right moment to
launch their phishing attack often to
still industry secrets for rival
companies or sell them off at a higher
price
apart from just emails farming focuses
on fake websites that resemble their
original counterparts as much as
possible the prevalent method is to use
domain names like Facebook with a single
o or YouTube with no e these are
mistakes that people make when typing
the full URL in the browser leading them
straight to a counterfeit webpage which
can fool them into submitting private
data a few more complex methods exist to
drive people onto fake websites like ARP
spoofing and DNS cache poisoning but
they are rarely carried out due to time
and resource constraints
now that we know how phishing attacks
work let's look at ways to prevent
ourselves from becoming victims while
the implications of a phishing attack
can be extreme protecting yourself
against these is relatively
straightforward Jane could have saved
herself from credit card fraud had she
checked the link in the email for
authenticity and that are redirected to
a secure website that runs on the https
protocol even suspicious messages
shouldn't be entertained one must also
refrain from entering private
information on random websites or pop-up
Windows irrespective of how legitimate
they seem it is also recommended to use
secure anti-fishing browser extensions
like cloudfish to sniff out malicious
emails from legitimate ones the best way
to prevent phishing is browsing the
internet with care and being on alert
for malicious attempts at all times
start by learning about cross-site
scripting from a Layman's perspective
cross-site scripting also known as xss
is a type of code injection attack that
occurs on the client side
the attacker intends to run harmful
scripts in the victim's web browser by
embedding malicious code in a genuine
webpage or online application
the real Attack takes place when the
victim hits the malicious code infected
web page or online application
the web page or application serves as a
vehicle for the malicious script to be
sent to the user's browser forums
message boards and online pages that
enable comments are vulnerable vehicles
that are frequently utilized for
cross-scripting assaults
a web feature web application is
vulnerable to xss if the output it
creates contains unsanitized user input
the victim's browser must then pass this
user input
in vbscript ActiveX Flash and even CSS
cross-site scripting attacks are
conceivable they are nevertheless most
ubiquitous in JavaScript link to the
fact that JavaScript is most important
to most browser experiences nowadays
the main purpose of this attack is to
steal the other user's identity be it
via cookies session tokens and other
information
in most of the cases this attack is
being used to steal the other person's
cookies
as we know cookies help us to log in
automatically therefore with the stolen
cookies we can log in with other
identities and this is one of the
reasons why this attack is considered as
one of the riskiest attacks it can be
performed with different client-side
programming languages as well
cross-site scripting is often compared
with similar client set attacks as
client-side languages are mostly being
used during this however an xss attack
is considered riskier because of its
ability to damage even less vulnerable
Technologies
most often this attack is performed with
JavaScript and HTML JavaScript is a
programming language that runs on web
pages inside your browser the
client-side code add functionality and
interactivity to the web page and is
used extensively on all major
applications and CMS platforms unlike
server-side languages such as PHP
JavaScript code runs inside your browser
and cannot impact the website for other
visitors it is sandbox to your own
Navigator and can only perform actions
within your own browser window
while JavaScript is client-side and does
not run on the server it can be used to
interact with the server by performing
background requests attackers can then
use these background requests to add
unwanted spam content to a web page
without refreshing it they can then
gather analytics about the client's
browser or perform actions
asynchronously
the manner of attack can range in a
variety of phase it can be a single link
which the user must click on to initiate
a JavaScript piece of code it can be
used to show any piece of images that
can be later used as a front-end for
malicious code being installed as
malware
with the majority of Internet users
unaware of how metadata works or the
ways in which web requests are called
the chances of victims clicking on a
redirecting links is far too high
cross-site scripting can occur on the
malicious script executed at the client
side using a fake page or even a form
that is displayed to the user on
websites with displayed advertisements
malicious emails can also be sent to the
victim
these attacks occur when the malicious
user finds the vulnerable parts of the
website and sends it as appropriate
malicious input
now that we understand the basics of
cross-site scripting let us learn more
about how this kind of attack works
the first place we have the website or
the web browser which is used to show
content to the victim or which is the
user in our case
whenever the user wants to grab some
content from the website the website
asks the data from the server the server
provides this information to the website
and the web browser which ultimately
resists the victim
how the hacker comes into play here
it passes on certain arguments to the
web browser which is can be then
forwarded back to the server or to the
user at hand the entire cross-site
scripting attack Vector means sending
and injecting malicious code or script
this attack can be performed in
different ways depending on the type of
attack the malicious script may be
reflected on the victim's browser but
stored in the database and executed
every time when the user calls the
appropriate function
the main reason for this attack is
inappropriate users input validation
where the malicious input can get into
the output
a malicious user can enter a script
which will be injected onto the
website's code then the browser is not
able to know if the executed code is
malicious or not
therefore this malicious script is being
executed on the victim's browser or any
faked form if that is being displayed
for the users
there are many ways to trigger an
exercise attack for example the
execution could be triggered
automatically when the page loads or
when a user hovers over specific
elements of the page like hyperlinks
potential consequences of cross-site
scripting attacks include capturing
keystrokes of a user redirecting a user
to malicious websites running web
browser-based exploits obtaining cookie
information of a user who is logged into
a website and many more in some cases
cross-site scripting attack leads to
complete compromise of the victim's
account attackers can trick users into
entering credentials on a fake form
which can then provide all information
to the attacker
with the basic working of a cross-site
scripting attack out of the way let us
go over the different ways hackers can
leverage vulnerable web applications to
gather information and eventually Bridge
those systems
the prime purpose of Performing exercise
attack is to steal the other person's
identity as mentioned it may be cookies
session tokens Etc
xss may also be used to display fake
Pages or forms for the victim however
this can be performed in several ways
we have a reflected attack this attack
occurs when a malicious script is not
being saved on the web server but is
reflected in the website results
reflected xss code is not being saved
permanently in this case the malicious
code is being reflected in any website
result
the attack code can be included in the
faked URL or in the HTTP parameters it
can affect the victim in different ways
by displaying fake malicious speech or
by sending a malicious email
in a reflected cross-site scripting
example the input of a search form is
reflected on the page to show what the
search key was an attacker May crafter
URL that contains malicious code and
then spread the same URL via email or
social media a user who clicks on this
link opens the valid web application
which then runs the malicious code in
the browser the script is not stored in
the web application and malicious code
is shown only to one user the user that
opens the link executes the strip and
the attack is not necessarily visible on
the server side or to the app owner
itself
the next variant is a stored cross-site
scripting attacks
this occurs when a malicious script is
being saved on the web server
permanently
this can be considered a riskier attack
since it has leverage for more damage
in this type of attack the malicious
code or script is being saved on the
server for example in the database of
the website it is executed every time
the users call the appropriate
functionality
this way stored xss attack can affect
many users also as the script is being
stored on the web server it will affect
the website for a longer time
in order to perform stored xss attack
the malicious scripts should be sent
through the vulnerable input form for
example can be a comment field or review
field
this way the appropriate script will be
saved in the database and evaluated on
the page load or appropriate function
calling
in a stored xss example the script might
have been submitted by an input field to
the web server which did not perform a
sufficient validation and stores the
script permanently in the database
the consequence of this might be that
the script is now being delivered to all
users visiting the web application and
if for example able to gain access to
the user session cookies
in this attack the script is permanently
stored in the web app the users visiting
the app after the information retrieve
the script
the malicious code then exploits the
flaws in the web application and the
script and the attack is visible on the
server side or to the app owner as well
the third variant is Dom based
cross-site scripting attacks
this type of attack occurs when the Dom
environment is being changed but the
client-side code does not change
when the Dom environment is being
modified in the victim's browser the
client-side code executes differently
in order to get a better understanding
of how excess Dom attack is being
performed let us analyze the following
example if there is a website called
texting.com we know default is a
parameter therefore in order to perform
exercise Dom attack we should send a
script as parameters
a down-based exercise attack may be
successfully executed even when the
server does not embed any malicious code
into the web page by using a flaw in the
JavaScript executed in the browser for
example if the client-side JavaScript
modifies the Dom tree or the web page it
can be based on an input field or the
get parameter without validating the
input this allows the malicious code to
be executed
the malicious code the exploits flaws in
the browser on the user side and the
script and the attack is not necessarily
visible on the server side or to the app
owner
by now it is clear that cross-site
scripting attacks are difficult to
detect and even tougher to fight against
there are however plenty of fails one
can Safeguard against such attacks let's
go through some of these preventive
measures
like mentioned earlier xss attacks are
sometimes difficult to detect
however this can be changed if you get
some external help a way to prevent
exercise attacks is using automated
testing tools like crash test security
suit or a kinetic security suit
still manual testing is highly time
consuming and costly and therefore not
possible to be done for every iteration
of your web application
consequently your code shouldn't be
untested before any release
using automated security you can scan
your web application for cross-site
scripting and other critical
vulnerabilities before every release
this way you can ensure that a web
application slide version is still
secure whenever you alter or add a
feature
input fields are the most common point
of entry for xss attack script therefore
you should always screen and validate
any information input into data fields
this is particularly important if the
data will be included as HTML output
this can be used to protect against
reflected xss attacks
validation should occur on both the
client side and server side as an added
precaution
the cells validating the data before
it's being sent to the servers and can
also protect against persistent xss
Scripts
this can be accomplished using
JavaScript
exercise attacks only appear if any user
input is being displayed on the web page
therefore try to avoid displaying any
untrusted user input if possible
if you need to display user data
restrict the places where the user input
might appear
any input displayed inside a JavaScript
tag or a URL shown on the site is much
more likely to be exploited than the
input that appears inside a division or
span element inside the HTML body
protecting against exercise
vulnerabilities typically requires
properly escaping user provided data
that is placed on the page
rather than trying to determine if the
data is user provided and could be
compromised we should always play it
safe and Escape data whether it is user
provided or not
unfortunately because there are many
different rules for escaping you still
must choose the proper type of escaping
before settling on a final code
encoding should be applied directly
before user controllable data is written
to a page because the context you're
writing into determines what kind of
encoding you need to use for example
values inside a JavaScript string
require a different type of escaping to
those in an HTML context
sometimes you'll need to apply multiple
layers of encoding in the correct order
for example to safely embed user input
inside an event handler you need to deal
with both JavaScript context and the
HTML context so you need to First
Unicode escape the input and then HTML
encode it
content security policy or CSP is a
computer security standard introduced to
prevent cross-site scripting click
checking and other code injection
attacks resulting from the execution of
malicious content in The Trusted web
page context
it is a candidate recommendations of the
w3c working group on a web application
security
it's widely supported by modern web
browsers and provides a standard method
for website owners to declare approved
origins of content the browser should be
allowed to load on that website
HTTP only is an additional flag included
in a set cookie HTTP response header
using the HTTP only flag when generating
a cookie helps mitigate the risk of
client-side script accessing the
protected cookie that is if the browser
supports it if the HTTP only flag is
included in the HTTP response header the
cookie cannot be accessed through a
client-side script again this is if the
browser supports the select
as a result even if a cross-site
scripting flow exists and a user
accidentally accesses a link that
exploits this flop the browser will not
reveal the cookie to a third party
if a browser does not support HTTP only
and a website attempts to set an HTTP
only cookie the HTTP only flag will be
ignored browse the browser thus creating
a traditional script accessible cookie
as a result the cookie becomes
vulnerable to theft of modification by
any malicious script
next on our docket is a live
demonstration where we solve a set of
cross-site scripting problems starting
from the basic level to the topmost
level 6. we're going to start at level
1.
in this web application it demonstrates
a common cause of cross-site scripting
where user input is directly included in
the page without proper escaping
if you interact with a vulnerable
application window here and find a way
to make it execute JavaScript of our
chosen
we can take actions inside the
vulnerable window or directly edit its
URL bar
this task needs only basic knowledge
let's see why the most primitive
injections work here right away
let's do a simple query and inspect the
resulting HTML page
I am going to use this phrase
with a single quote as a special
character
we can now inspect the HTML page
we can see here in this line
the special character single quote
appears in the result over here
the provided query text is placed
directly in a b tag as in a body element
we need to perform a reflected xss into
the web application because they are
non-persistent xss attacks and the
preload should be included in the URL to
perform successful exploitation
we can use any payload but we're going
to use the simple one to perform an
alert in this web application it's
simple and can be shown easily
we're just going to write the script
over here
foreign
as you can see we have successfully
launched our first cross-site scripting
attack we can see an alert box pop-up
with the necessary message and a similar
process can be used to steal browser
cookies and passwords albeit with
different commands
now we have the option to move to level
2.
in this web application it shows that
how easily accessed bugs can be
introduced in complex chat applications
chat app conversations are stored in a
database and retrieved when a user wants
to see the conversation therefore if a
malicious user injects some JavaScript
code all visitors will be infected this
kind of cross-site scripting attack is
more powerful
and it is more riskier than reflected
Crosshair scripting attacks and that's
why it's known as stored xss
I posted my query
with a special character of a single
quote
and this is what I get
whatever I typed in simply appeared on
the page right after I click on share
status
let's see the source
you can see here the text I posted seems
directly put inside a block code tag so
even a simple script tag we used in
level 1 should work here but it will not
let us examine the code to understand
why
we're going to toggle the code over here
and check the index.html file
important part
is line 32.
the generated HTML fragment which is the
HTML variable in the code is added to
the mail HTML using the inner HTML
method so when the browser passing this
HTML fragment it will not execute any
script tag defined within that HTML
fragment
HTML parser will not execute a script
tag when it passes htmls via this method
this is why the script tag like we used
in level 1 is not going to work here our
solution is to use events events will
execute the defined javascripts
we're going to use an image over here
and when we press on share status
in the above injection we are loading an
image that doesn't exist which causes to
trigger an on error event
in honor event the it will execute our
alert method
with that we are able to beat level 2
and we can now move up to the next level
in our challenge
as you can see clicking on any tab
causes the tab number to be displayed in
the URL fragment
this hints that the value after the
hashtag controls the behavior of the
page that is it is an input variable
to confirm let's analyze the code
as you can see in line 43 inside the
event handling
the value provided after the hash in the
URL
is directly passed onto the chew tab
method no input validation is being
performed
the value passed to the choose tab
method is directly injected into the IMG
tag in line 17.
this is an unsafe assignment and it is
the vulnerable part of the code
now all we have to do now is to craft a
payload that would adjust the IMG tag to
execute our JavaScript
remember the script tag from Level 1
would not work here since the variable
HTML is used to add the Dom dynamically
hence the events are Aces here once
again
I will choose to use the existing IMG
tag and change the source to something
that doesn't exist hence forcing it to
fall into execute an honor even which I
will pass the URL
once we visit that URL we can see that
our Java pop-up has opened up here with
the same message of exercise level 3 has
been completed
with this we can now move on to level 4
which is going to present a different
kind of attack
in this web application there is a timer
on the page that means whatever numbers
we put in the Box a countdown starts and
then when it finishes the application
alerts
that the countdown is finished
and we can see the time is a pop-up
appearing over here and this resets the
timer again
now it is obvious that the value entered
in the text box is transferred to the
server over the timer parameter in the
URL
let us examine the code to see how the
timer parameter is being handled
we're going to visit timer.html over
here
and we're going to check over here
in line 21
the start timer method is being called
in the onload event
however the timer parameter is being
directly passed to the start timer
method
we need to perform a pop-up Alert in the
web application which escapes the
content of the function start timer
without baking the JavaScript code
the parameter value is directly added
the start timer method without any
filtering what we can try to do here is
to inject an alert function to be
executed inside the on loan event along
with the start timer method
we're going to remove this argument
and put a script over here
yeah
when we press on create timer
and we have a pop-up with exercise level
4 completed
we can now move on to level 5.
in this web application this application
xss is different because this challenge
description says cross-site scripting
isn't just about correctly escaping data
sometimes attackers can do bad things
even without injecting new elements into
the Dom it's kind of open redirect
because the attack payload is executed
as a result of modifying the Dom
environment in the victim's browser
this environment is used by the original
client side script so that the
client-side code runs in an unexpected
manner
the vulnerability can be easily detected
if the next Link in the sign up page
is inspected
the href attribute value of next link is
confer which is exactly the value of the
next URL query parameter
as you can see over here this means
using the next query parameter can be
used to inject a JavaScript code to the
href attribute of the next link
the following is the best way to do it
as soon as the user clicks on the link
the script will be triggered
I'm going to press anything at random
and now that we click next we can see
the xss level 5 that we had provided in
the URL as a parameter to the next
variable
since the value of next provided appears
in a pop-up we can consider the
attacker's success and move on to the
final level 6.
in the sub application it shows some of
the external Javascript is received
if you analyze the URL
you can see that the script is loaded
already
the vulnerability lies within how the
code handles a value after the hashtag
if we check on line 45 the value right
after the hashtag
is taken as the gadget name
and then in line 48
the value is directly passed on to the
include Gadget method
and in the include Gadget method that we
can see over here
you can see in line 18
a script tag is created and the URL
Gadget name parameter value is directly
used as the source attribute of the
script tag in line 28.
this means we can completely control the
source attribute of the script tag that
is being created
that is with this vulnerability we can
inject our own JavaScript file into the
code
we can inject a URL of our own hosted
JavaScript into the web applications URL
after the hashtag and the URL should not
be using https but anything like that to
bypass the regular expression for
security checking
going to remove
the pre-store URL
and we're going to load our own
Javascript file
finally we have reached the end of our
challenge
we completed six different varieties of
cross scripting attacks and used
different solutions for all of the six
questions with work from home being the
norm in today's era people spend
considerable amount of time on the
internet often without specific measures
to ensure a secure session apart from
individuals organizations worldwide that
host data and conduct business over the
internet are always at the risk of a
DDOS attack
these DDOS attacks are getting more
extreme with hackers getting easy access
to botnet farms and compromised devices
as can be seen in the graph three of the
six strongest DDOS attacks were launched
in 2021 with the most extreme attack
occurring just last year in 2020 lately
cyber criminals have been actively
seeking out new services and protocols
for amplifying these DDOS attacks active
involvement with hat machines and
botnets allow further penetration into
the consumer space allowing much more
elaborate attack campaigns apart from
General users multinational corporations
have also had their fair share of
problems
GitHub a platform for software
developers was the target of a DDOS
attack in 2018. widely suspected to be
conducted by Chinese authorities this
attack went on for about 20 minutes
after which the systems were brought
into a stable condition it was the
strongest leaders attack to date at the
time and made a lot of companies
reconsider the security practices to
combat such attacks even after years of
experimentation DDOS attacks are still
at large and can affect anyone in the
consumer and corporate space
hey everyone this is Baba from Simply
learn and welcome to this video on what
is a DDOS attack let's learn more about
what is a DDOS attack
a distributed denial of service attack
or DDOS is when an attacker or attackers
attempt to make it impossible for a
service to be delivered
this can be achieved by thwarting access
to virtually anything servers devices
Services networks applications and even
specific transactions within
applications
in a Dos attack it's one system that is
sending the malicious data or requests a
detours attack comes from multiple
systems
generally these attacks work by Drowning
a system with requests for data this
could be sending a web server so many
requests to serve a page that it crashes
under the demand or it could be a
database being hit with a higher volume
of queries the result is available
internet bandwidth CPU and RAM capacity
become overwhelmed
the impact could range from a minor
annoyance from disrupted services to
experiencing entire websites
applications or even entire businesses
taking offline more often than not these
attacks are launched using machines in a
botnet a botnet is a network of devices
that can be triggered to send requests
from a remote Source often known as the
command and control center
the bots in the network attack a
particular Target thereby hiding the
original perpetrator of the DDOS
campaign
but how do these devices come on
robotnet and what are the requests being
made to the web servers let's learn more
about these and how DDOS attack work
Adidas attack is a two-phase process
in the first phase a hacker creates a
botnet of devices
simply put a vast network of computers
are hacked via malware ransomware or
just simple social engineering
these devices become a part of the
botnet which can be triggered anytime to
start bombarding a system or a server on
the instruction of the hacker that
created the botnet
the devices in this networks are called
Bots or zombies
in the second phase a particular Target
is selected for the attack
when the hacker finds the right time to
attack all the zombies in the botnet
network send these requests the target
thereby taking up all the servers
available bandwidth these can be simple
ping requests or complex attacks like
SYM flooding and UDP flooding the aim is
to overwhelm them with more traffic than
the server or the network can
accommodate the goal is to render the
website or service inoperable
there is a lot of wiggle room when it
comes to the type of DDOS attack a
hacker can go with depending on the
target's vulnerability we can choose one
of the three broad categories of DDOS
attacks
volume based attacks use massive amounts
of bogus traffic to overwhelm a resource
it can be a website or a server they
include icmp udap and spoofed packet
flood attacks
the size of volume based attack is
measured in bits per second
these attacks focus and clogging all the
available bandwidth for the server
thereby cutting the supply short
several requests are sent to the server
all of which warrant a reply thereby not
allowing the target to cater to the
general legitimate users
next we have the protocol level attacks
these attacks are meant to consume
essential resources of the target server
they exhaust the load balances and
firewalls which are meant to protect the
system against the DDOS attacks
these protocol attacks include syn
floods and Smurf DDOS among others and
the sizes measured in packets per second
for example in an SSL handshake server
replies to the Hello message sent by the
hacker which will be the client in this
case but since the IP is poofed and
leads nowhere the server gets stuck in
an endless loop of sending the
acknowledgment without any end in sight
finally we have the application Level
attacks application air attacks are
conducted by flooding applications with
maliciously crafted requests the size of
application layer attacks is measured in
request per second
these are relatively sophisticated
attacks that Target the application and
operating system level vulnerabilities
they prevent the specific applications
from delivering necessary information to
users and Hawk the network bandwidth up
to the point of a system crash
examples of such an attack are HTTP
flooding and bgp hijacking a single
device can request data from a server
using HTTP post or get without any
issues
however when the requisite botnet is
instructed to bombard the server with
thousands of requests the database
bandwidth gets jammed and it eventually
becomes unresponsive and unusable
but what about the reasons for such an
attack there are multiple lines of
thought as to why a hacker decides to
launch a DDOS attack on unsuspecting
targets let's take a look at a few of
them
the first option is to gain a
competitive advantage
many DDOS attacks are conducted by
hacking communities against rival groups
some organizations hire such communities
to stagger their Rivals resources at a
network level to gain an advantage in
the playing field
since being a victim of a detours attack
indicates a lack of security the
reputation of such a company takes a
significant hit allowing the rivals to
cover up some ground
secondly some hackers launch these DDOS
attacks to hold multinational
corporations at Ransom
the resources are jammed and the only
way to clear the way is if the target
company agrees to pay a designated
amount of money to the hackers
even a few minutes of inactivity is
detrimental to a company's reputation in
the global market and it can cause a
spiral effect both in terms of market
value and product security index most of
the time a compromise is reached and the
resources are freed after a while
tdos attacks have also found use in the
political segment certain activists tend
to use DDOS attacks to voice their
opinion spreading the word online is
much faster than any local Rally or
forum
primarily political these attacks also
focus on online communities ethical
dilemmas or even protests against
corporations
let's take a look at a few ways that
companies and individuals can protect
themselves against DDOS attacks
the company can employ load balances and
firewalls to help protect the data from
such attacks load balances reroute the
traffic from one server to another in a
DDOS attack this reduces the single
point of failure and adds resiliency to
the server data
a firewall blocks unwanted traffic
indoor system and manages the number of
requests made at a definite rate it
checks for multiple attacks from a
single IP and occasional slowdowns to
detect a DDOS attack in action
early detection of a DDOS attack goes a
long way in recovering the data lost in
such an event
once you've detected the attack you will
have to find a way to respond for
example you will have to work on
dropping the malicious DDOS traffic
before it teaches your server so that it
doesn't throttle and exhaust your
bandwidth here's where you will filter
the traffic so that only legitimate
traffic reaches the server by
intelligent routing you can break the
remaining traffic into manageable chunks
that can be handled by a cluster
resources
the most important stage in DDOS
mitigation is where you will look for
patterns of redo's attacks and use those
to analyze and strengthen your
mitigation techniques for example
blocking an IP that's repeatedly found
to be offending is a first step
Cloud providers like Amazon web services
and Microsoft Azure who offer high
levels of cyber security including
firewalls and threat monitoring software
can help protect your assets and network
from DDOS criminals the cloud also has
greater bandwidth than most private
networks so it is likely to fail if
under the pressure of increased tdos
attacks
additionally reputable Cloud providers
are for Network redundancy duplicating
copies of your data systems and
equipment so that if your service
becomes corrupted or unavailable due to
a DDOS attack you can switch to a secure
access on backed up versions without
missing a Beat
one can also increase the amount of
bandwidth available to a host server
being targeted
since DDOS attacks fundamentally operate
on the principle of overwhelming systems
with heavy traffic simply provisioning
extra bandwidth to handle unexpected
traffic spikes can provide a measure of
protection
the solution can prove expensive as a
lot of that bandwidth is going to go
unused most of the time
a Content delivery Network or a CDN
distributes your content and boosts
performance by minimizing the distance
between your resources and end users it
stores the cached version of your
content in multiple locations and this
eventually mitigates DDOS attacks by
avoiding a single point of failure when
the attacker is trying to focus on a
single Target popular cdns include
Akamai CDN cloudflare AWS cloudfront Etc
let's start with our demo regarding the
effects of DDOS attacks on a system
for a demo we have a single device that
will attack a Target making it a dose
attack of sorts
once a botnet is ready multiple devices
can do the same and eventually emulate a
DDOS attack
to do so we will use the virtualization
software called VMware with an instance
of parrot security operating system
running
for a Target machine we will be running
another VMware instance of a standard
Linux distribution known as Linux light
in a Target device we can use Wireshark
to determine when the attack begins and
see the effects of the attack
accordingly
this is Linux like which is a target
machine and this is parrot security
which is used by the hacker when trying
to launch a DDOS attack this is just one
of the distros that can be used
to launch the attack we must first find
the IP address of our Target
so to find the IP address we open the
terminal
we use the command ifconfig
and here we can find the IP address
now remember we're launching this attack
in VMware now the both the instances of
parrot security and Linux light are
being run on my local network so the
address that you can see here is
192.168.72.129 which is a private
address this IP cannot be accessed from
outside the network basically anyone who
is not connected to my Wi-Fi
when launching attacks with public
servers or public addresses it will have
a public IP address that does not belong
to the 192.168 subnet
once we have the IP address
we can use a tool called
hp3
hping 3 is an open source packet
generator and analyzer for the TCP IP
protocol
to check what are the effects of an
attack we will be using Wireshark
Wireshark is a network traffic analyzer
we can see whatever traffic that is
passing through the Linux slide distro
is being displayed over here with the IP
address the source IP and the
destination IP as to where the request
is being transferred to
once we have the Dos attack launched you
can see the results coming over here
from The Source IP which will be parrot
security Now to launch the hp3 command
we need to give sudo access to the
console which is the root access
now we have the root access for the
console
the hp3 command will have a few
arguments to go with it which are as you
can see on the screen
minus s and a flood
a hyphen V
hyphen p80 and the IP address of the
target which is 192.168 72.129
in this command we have a few arguments
such as the minus s which specifies syn
packets like in an SSL handshake we have
the syn request that the client sends to
the server to initiate a connection
The Hyphen flood aims to ignore the
replys that the server will send back to
the client in response to the syn
packets here the parrot security OS is
the client and Linux slide being the
server
minus v stands for verbosity as in where
we will see some output when the
requests are being sent
The Hyphen p80 stands for Port 80 which
you can replace the port number if we
want to attack a different port
and finally we have the IP address of
our Target
as of right now if we check Wireshark it
is relatively clear and there is no
indication of a DDOS attack incoming now
once we launch the attack over here
we can see the request coming in from
this IP which is
192.168 72.128
till now even the network is responsive
and so is Linux light
the requests keep on coming and we can
see the http
flooding has started in flood mode
after a few seconds of this attack
continuing
the server will start shutting down
now remember Linux light is a distro
that can focus on that serves as a
backend
now remember Linux light is a distro and
such Linux distros are served as backend
to many servers across the world for
example a few seconds have passed from
the attack
now the system has become completely
irresponsive
this has happened due to the huge number
of requests that came from Pilot
security
you can see whatever I pressed nothing
is responded even the Wireshark has
stopped capturing new requests because
the CPU usage right now is completely
100 and at this point of time anyone who
is trying to request some information
from this Linux distro or where this
Linux this row is being used as a
backend for a server or a database
cannot access anything else the system
has completely stopped responding and
any request any legitimate request from
legitimate users will be dropped
once you stop the attack over here it
takes a bit of time to settle down now
remember it's still out of control but
eventually the traffic dies down and the
system regains its strength
it is relatively easy to gauge right now
the effect of a Dos attack now remember
this Linux light is just a VM instance
actual website servers and web databases
they have much more bandwidth and are
very secure and it's tough to break into
that is why we cannot use a single
machine to break into them that is where
Adidas attack comes into play what we
did right now is a Dos attack as in a
single system is being used to penetrate
a Target server using a single request
now
when a DDOS attack multiple systems such
as multiple para security instances or
multiple zombies or bots in a botnet
network can attack a Target server to
completely shut down the machine and
drop any legitimate request thereby
rendering the service and the target
completely unusable and inoperable
as a final note we would like to remind
that this is for educational purposes
only and we do not endorse any attacks
on any proven domains only test this on
servers and networks that you have
permission to test on cyber security has
become one of the most rigid Industries
in the last decade while simultaneously
being the most challenged with every
aspect of corporate culture going online
and embracing cloud computing there is a
plethora of critical data circulating
through the internet all worth billions
of dollars to the right person
increasing benefits require more complex
attacks and one of these attacks is a
Brute Force attack
a Brute Force are known as Brute Force
cracking is the Cyber attack equivalent
of trying every key on your keyring and
eventually finding the right one
Force attacks are simple and reliable
there is no prior knowledge needed about
the victim to start an attack most of
the systems falling prey to Brute Force
attacks are actually well secured
attackers let a computer do the work
that is trying different combinations of
usernames and passwords until the final
one that works
due to this repeated trial and error
format the strength of password matters
a great deal although with enough time
and resources brute force will break a
system since they run multiple
combinations until they find the right
passcode hey everyone this is pava from
Simply run and welcome to this video on
what is a Brute Force attack
let's begin with learning about Rufus
attacks in detail
a Brute Force attack also known as an
exhaustive search is a cryptographic
hack that relies on guessing possible
combinations of targeted password until
the current password is discovered
it can be used to break into online
accounts encrypted documents or even
Network peripheral devices
the longer the password the more
combinations that will need to be tested
a Brute Force attack can be time
consuming and difficult to perform if
methods such as data obfuscation are
used and at times downright impossible
however if the password is weak it could
merely take seconds with hardly any
effort
dictionary attacks are an alternative to
Brute Force attacks while the attacker
already has a list of usernames and
passwords that need to be stretched
against the target it doesn't need to
create any other combinations on its own
dictionary attacks are much more
reliable than brute force in a real
world context but the usefulness depends
entirely on the strength of passwords
being used by the general population
there is a three-step process when it
comes to brute forcing a system let's
learn about each of them in detail
in Step 1 we have to settle on a tool
that we are going to use for brute
forcing there are some popular names on
the market like hashcat
Hydra
and John the Ripper
while each of them has its own strength
and weaknesses each of them perform well
with the right configuration all of
these tools come pre-installed with
certain Linux distributions that cater
to penetration testers and cyber
security analysts like Kali Linux and
parrot security
after deciding what tool to use we can
start generating combinations of
alphanumeric variables whose only
limitation is the number of characters
for example while using Hydra a single
six digit password will create 900 000
passwords with only digits involved and
alphabets and symbols to that sample
space and that numbers grows
exponentially
the popular tools allow customizing this
process
let's say the hacker is aware of the
password being a specific eight digit
word containing only letters and symbols
this will substantially increase the
chances of being able to guess the right
password since we remove the time taken
to generate the longer ones we omit the
need for including digits in such
combinations these small tweaks go a
long way in organizing an efficient
Boost Force attack since running all the
combinations with no filters will
dramatically reduce the odds of finding
the right credentials in time
in the final step we run these
combinations against the file or service
that is being broken
we can try and break into a specific
encrypted document a social media
account or even devices at home that
connect to the internet let's say there
is a Wi-Fi router
the generated passwords are then fed
into the connection one after the other
it is a long and arduous process but the
work is left to the computer other than
someone manually clicking and checking
each of these passcodes
any password that doesn't unlock the
router is discarded and The Brute Force
tool simply moves on to the next one
this keeps going on until we find the
right combination which unlocks the
router
sometimes reaching the success stage
takes days and weeks which makes it
cumbersome for people with low computing
power at their disposal however the
ability to crack any system in the world
purely lead to bad password habits is
very appealing and the general public
tends to stick with simple and easy to
use passwords
now that we have a fair idea about how
Brute Force Works let's see if we can
answer this question we learned about
how complex passwords are tougher to
crack by Brute Force among the ones
listed on the screens which one do you
believe will take the longest to be
broken when using Brute Force tools
leave your answers in the comment
section and we will get back to you with
the correct option next week
let's move on to the harmful effects of
getting a system compromised due to
Brute Force attacks
a hacked laptop or mobile can have
social media accounts logged in giving
the hackers free access to the victim's
connections it has been reported on
multiple occasions where compromised
Facebook accounts are sending malicious
links and attachments to people on their
friends list
one of the significant reasons for
hacking malware infusion is best done
when spread from multiple devices
similar to Distributing spam this
reduces the chance of circling back the
source to a single device which belongs
to the hacker
once brute forced A system can spread
malware via email attachments sharing
links file upload via FTP Etc
personal information such as credit card
data usage habits private images and
videos are all stored in our systems be
it in plain format or root folders a
compromised laptop means easy access to
these information that can be further
used to impersonate the victim regarding
Bank verification among other things
once a system is hacked it can also be
used as a mail server that distributes
spam across lists of victims since the
hack machines all have different IP
addresses and Mac addresses it becomes
challenging to trace the spam back to
the original hacker
with so many harmful implications
arising from a boot Force attack it's
imperative that the general public must
be protected against such let's learn
about some of the ways we can prevent
ourselves from becoming a victim of
Brute Force attacks
using passwords consisting of alphabets
letters and numbers have a much higher
chance of its standing Brute Force
attacks thanks to the sheer number of
combinations they can produce
the longer the password the less likely
it is that a hacker will devote the time
and resources to brute force them
having alphanumeric passwords also
allows the user to keep different
passwords for different websites this is
to ensure that if a single account or
password is compromised due to a breach
or a hack the rest of the accounts are
isolated from the incident
two-factor authentication involves
receiving a one-time password on a
trusted device before a new login is
allowed this OTB can be obtained either
via email SMS or specific 2fa
applications like authi and Aegis
email and SMS based otps are considered
relatively less secure nowadays due to
the ease with which SIM cards can be
duplicated and mailboxes can be hacked
applications that are specifically made
for 2fa Cores are much more reliable and
secure
captures are used to stop Bots from
running through web pages precisely to
prevent brute forcing through their
website since Brute Force tools are
automated forcing the hacker to solve
captcha for every iteration of a
password manually is very challenging
the capture system can filter out these
automated Bots that keep refreshing the
page with different credentials thereby
reducing the chances of Brute Force
considerably
a definite rule that locks the account
being hacked for 30 minutes after a
specific number of attempts is a good
way to prevent Brute Force attempts many
websites lock account for 30 minutes
after three failed password attempts to
secure the account against any such
attack and an additional note some
websites also send an email instructing
the user that there have been three
insecure attempts to log into the
website
let's look at a demonstration of how
Brute Force attacks work in a real world
situation
the world has gone Wireless with Wi-Fi
taking the reins in every household it's
natural that the security will always be
up for debate
to further test the security index and
understand Brute Force attacks we will
attempt to break into the password of a
Wi-Fi router for that to happen we first
need to capture a handshake file which
is a connection file from the Wi-Fi
router to a connecting device like a
mobile or a laptop
the operating system used for this
process is parrot security a Linux
distribution that is catered to
penetration testers all the tools being
used in this demo can easily be found
pre-installed in this operating system
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
start a demo we're going to use a tool
called air Garden which is made to hack
into wireless network specifically
at this point it's going to check for
all the necessary scripts that are
installed in the system
to crack into a Wi-Fi and to capture the
handshake file we're going to need an
external network card
the significance of the external network
card is a managed mode and a monitor
mode
for now the wlx1 named card is my
external network adapter which I'm going
to select
to be able to capture data over the air
we're going to need to put it in monitor
mode as you can see above it's written
it is in manage mode right now
so we're going to select option 2 which
is to put the interface in monitor mode
and its name is now wlan0 monitor
the monitor mode is necessary to capture
data over the air
that is the necessary Json why we need
an external card since a lot of inbuilt
cards that come with the laptops and the
systems they cannot have a monitor mode
installed
once we select the mode we can go into
the fifth which is the handshake tools
menu
with the first step we have to explore
for targets and it is written that
monitor mode is necessary to select a
Target so let's explore for targets
and press enter
we have to let this run for about 60
seconds to get a fair idea about the
networks that are currently working in
this locality for example this ESS ID is
supposed to be the Wi-Fi name that we
see when connecting to a network jio 24
recover me these are all the names that
we see on our mobile when trying to
search for the Wi-Fi's this BSS ID is
supposed to be an identifier somewhat
like a MAC address that identifies this
network from other devices
those channels features on one or two or
there are some many channels that the
networks can focus on
this here is supposed to be a client
that is connected to one such Network
for example
the station that you can see 5626 this
is supposed to be the MAC address of the
device that is connected to a router
this basis ID is supposed to be which
wi-fi it is connected to for example
5895 d8
is this one
which is the jio 24 router so we already
know which router has a device connected
to it and we can use our attack to
capture this handshake
now that we it has already run for one
minute now that we press Ctrl C
we will be asked to select a Target see
it has already selected the number five
which is the jio 24 router as the one
with clients so it is easy to run an
attack on and it is easy to capture a
handshake for
select Network 5
and we run a capture handshake
it says we have a valid WPA WPA2 Network
Target selected and that the script can
continue
now to capture the handshake we have a
couple of attacks a Dior air replay
attack what this attack does is kick the
clients out of the network
in return when they try to reconnect to
the Wi-Fi as they are configured that
way that when a client is disconnected
it tries to reconnect it immediately it
tries to capture a handshake file which
in turn contains the security key which
is necessary to initiate the handshake
for our demo let's go with the second
option that is the dioc air replay
attack
select a timeout value let's say we give
it 60 Seconds
and we start the script
we can see it capturing data from the
jio 24 Network and here we go
we have the WPA handshake files
once the handshake file is captured you
can actually close this and here we go
congratulations in order to capturing a
handshake it has verified that a peak MK
ID from the target network has
successfully been captured this is the
file that is already stored
the chart cap file for the path we can
let's say we can keep it in a desktop
okay we give the path
and the handshape file is generated we
can already see
a Target over here same Geo 24 router
with the BSS ID
now if we return to its main menu
we already have the handshake file
captured with us now our job is to Brute
Force into that handshake capture file
the capture file is often encrypted with
the security key of the Wi-Fi network if
we know how to decrypt it we will
automatically get the security key
so let's go to the offline WPA WP to
decrypt menu
since you'll be cracking personal
networks we can go with option 1
now to run the Brute Force tool we have
two options either we can go with the
air crack or we can go with the hash cat
let's go with lcac plus crunch which is
a Brute Force attack against a handshake
file we can go with option two
it can already detect the capture file
that we have generated
so we select yes
the bssid is the one which denotes the
jio 24 router so we're going to select
yes as well the minimum length of the
key for example it has already checked
that the minimum length of a Wi-Fi
security key which is a WPA to psk key
will always be more than 8 digits and
Below 64 digits so we have to select
something in between this range so if we
already know let's say that the password
is at least 10 digits we can go with the
minimum length as 10. and as a rough
guess let's say we put the maximum
length as 20.
the character set that we are going to
use for checking the password
will affect the time taken to Brute
Force for example if we already know
that or we have seen a user use the
password while connecting to the router
as something that has only numbers and
symbols then we can choose accordingly
let's say if we go with only uppercase
characters and numeric characters
go with option seven
and it's going to start decrypting
so how aircrack is working right here
you can see this passphrase over here
the first five or six digits are a
it starts working its way from the end
from the last character it keeps trying
every single combination you can see the
last the fourth character from the right
side the D it will eventually turn to E
because it keeps checking up every
single character from the end
this will keep going on until all the
single characters are tested and every
single combination is tried out
since the handshake file is encrypted
using the security key that is the WPA
Tookie of the router whichever
passphrase is able to decrypt the
handshake key completely will be the key
of the Wi-Fi router this is the way we
can Brute Force into Wi-Fi routers
anywhere in the world cyber attacks are
frequently making headlines in today's
digital environment at any time everyone
who uses a computer could become a
victim of a Cyber attack
there are various sounds of cyber tanks
ranging from phishing to password
attacks in this video we'll look into
one such attack that is known as botnet
but before we begin if you love watching
Tech videos subscribe to our Channel and
hit the Bell icon never to miss an
update to begin with let's take a look
at some of the famous potent attacks
the first one is Mirai botnet which is a
malicious program designed to attack
vulnerable iot devices and infect them
to form a networker Bots that on command
perform basic and medium level denial of
service attacks
then we have the zoo's bot specifically
designed for attacking the system for
Bank related information and data now
let's see what exactly a botnet is
botnet refers to a network of hijacked
interconnected devices that are
installed with malicious quotes known as
malware
each of these infected devices are known
as Bots the hijacked criminal known as
bot hoarder remotely controls them the
Bots are used to automate large scale
attacks including Data Theft
server failure malware propagation
and denial of service attacks
now that we know what exactly a button
it is let's dive deeper into learning
how botnet works
during the preparation of a bottleneck
Network the first step involves
preparing the botnet Army after that the
connection between the botnet Army and
the control server established and the
end the launching of the attack is done
by the bot hoarder
let's understand through our
illustration
firstly we have a bot order that
initiates the attack
according to the control server commands
the devices that are infected with the
malware programs and begins to attack
the infected system let's see some
details regarding the preparation of the
botnet army
the first step is known as the prepping
the botnet army the first step is
creating a botnet is to infect as many
as connected devices as possible this
ensures that there are enough Bots to
carry out the attack
this way it creates Bots either by
exploiting the security gaps in the
software or websites or using phishing
attacks they are often deployed through
Trojan horses
for the next step we have establishing
the connection
once it hacks the device as per previous
step it infects it with a specific
malware that connects the device back to
the control bottom server a bot holder
uses command programming to drive the
bot's actions
and the last step is known as launching
the attack once infected a bot allows
access to admin level operation like
Gathering and stealing of data reading
and rewriting the system data monitoring
user activities performing the analogs
of its attacks including other cyber
crimes
now let's take a look at the important
architecture
the first type is known as client server
model the client server model is a
traditional model that operates with the
help of a command and control center
server and communication protocols like
IRC
when the bot order issues a command to
the server it is then relayed to the
clients to perform malicious actions
then we have peer-to-peer model
here controlling the infected Bots
involves a peer-to-peer Network that
relies on a decentralized approach that
is the ports are topological
interconnected and acts as both CNC
servers that is the server and the
client today hackers adopt this approach
to avoid detection and single point
failure
in the end we will see some points on
some counter measure against botnet
attacks
the first step is to have updated
drivers and system updates
after that we should avoid clicking
random pop-ups or links that we often
see on the internet
and lastly having certified antivirus
anti-spyware softwares and firewall
installed into a system will protect
against malware attack the internet is
an endless source of information and
data still in some cases we come across
some occurrences like cyber attacks
hacking 4th Century which may affect a
Time on the web
hi everyone and welcome to the simple
learn Channel today we will discuss a
topic that secretly records our input
data that is known as key loggers but
before we begin if you like watching
Tech videos subscribe to our Channel and
hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update
to understand the key logging problem
better let's take a look at an example
this is June she works in a business
firm where she manages the company's
data regularly
this is Jacob from the information
Department who is here to inform her
about some of the security protocols
during the briefing she informed him
about some of the problems a system was
facing with which included slow reaction
speed and unusual internet activity
as Jacob heard about the problems with
the system he thinks of the possibility
what could be the reason behind these
problems a system was facing with
the conclusion that he came across was
the key logging issue
unknown to the problem her system was
facing with she asked him about some of
the details regarding it
for today's topic we learn what exactly
keyloggers are and how they affect our
system what are the harmful effects that
key logging can bring into the system to
begin with we learn what exactly the key
logging program is
as your name suggests keylogger is a
malicious program or a tool that is
designed to record keystrokes that are
typed during data input and record them
into a log file then the same program
secretly sends these log files to its
origin
where they can be used for malicious
acts by the hacker
now that we know what the key logging
program is let's take a look how they
enter into the system
searching for a suitable driver for a
system can often lead to the
installation of the key logging program
into the system if we often visit
suspicious sites and uncertified
software are installed into a system
then if we use unknown links or visiting
unknown websites which come through
unknown addresses can also be a reason
behind a key logging issue entering into
the system
and lastly there are often cases where
different pop-ups that we often see on
social sites or different media sites
can lead to the installation of key
logging program into a system
now that we know how the problem gets
into the system let's take a look how to
identify whether the system is infected
by the key logging issue
the key logging issue can be identified
if there are often cases when a keyboard
lags behind the system
the data that we enter sometimes is
stuck in between when we type through
the input
then there are cases when the system
freeze occurs unknowingly to what
exactly could be the reason behind them
and also there are delayed reaction time
for different applications that run on
the system
and lastly there are different cases
when we often see suspicious internet
activity on the system that we don't
know about this could lead to the
identification of a problem into the
system
now we'll take a look at different types
of key loggers that are present on the
net which can harm our system
differently
the first problem that keyloggers arouse
is API based the most common key logging
case which uses apis to keep a log of
the type data and share it to its origin
for malicious purposes
each time we press a key the key logger
intercepts the signal and locks it then
we have form grabbing based key loggers
as the name suggests they are a best key
loggers that store the form data that is
if we often use waveforms or different
kinds of forms to enter different data
they can be recorded into the system by
the program and send it to its origin
then we have kernel based keyloggers
these key loggers are installed deeply
into the operating system where they can
hide from different antivirus if not
checked properly and they record the
data that we type on the keyboard and
send it to its origin
and lastly we have Hardware Key loggers
these key loggers are present directly
into the hardware that is they are
embedded into system where they record
the data that we type on the keyboard
now let's take a look how hackers
differentiate different type of recorded
data and exploit them
when hackers receive information about
the target they might use it to
Blackmail the target which may affect
the personal life of the Target and also
blackmail them for different money
related issues
then in case of company data that is
recorded by the key logging program can
also affect the economic value of the
company in the market which may lead to
the downfall of the company
also in some cases the key logging
program can also log data about military
Secrets which may include nuclear codes
or security protocols which are
necessary to maintain the security of a
country
now let's take a look whether mobile
devices get infected with the key
logging issue or not
in the case of hand devices infection of
keyloggers are low in comparison to the
computer systems as they use on-screen
keyboard or virtual keyboard
but in some cases we often see different
kinds of malicious programs getting
installed into the hand device if we
often visit different uncertified
websites or illegal websites or torrent
sites
and also the device that is infected
with the key login issue or different
kind of malicious program can often lead
to the exploitation of data that
includes photos emails or important
files by the hacker or the Cyber
criminal that install the particular
malicious program into the system
now to prevent a system from getting
infected by the key locking program
let's take a look at different points
the first point includes using of
different antivirus softwares or tools
which can prevent the entering of
malicious program into the system
then keeping system security protocols
regularly updated is also a good habit
and lastly using virtual keyboard to
input are sensitive data which may
include Bank details login details or
different passwords related to different
websites
now that we have some understanding
about the topic of keyloggers let's take
a look at the demo to further increase
the knowledge about the topic
for the first step we have to download
some of the important libraries that are
required into the system
which is
this Library
now we'll run it
the system says the library is already
installed into the system
now let's take a look what exactly
modules are required from the particular
Library
from this Library we will import
the keyboard module which will help us
to record the data that we type on the
keyboard
now from the same we'll also import
key module
and The Listener module
and also
the logging module which will help us to
record the data into a log file
for the next part
we'll write a piece of code that will
allow us to save the data that is
recorded by the program into our text
file that will be named as key
underscore log text file along with the
date and time stamp let's take a look
now
we'll provide it with the file name
that will be given as
key log dot txt file
and also so the part where the format of
the data is recorded
put the brackets over here to contain
the file name now we'll write the format
in which the data will be recorded into
the log file which will be given as
the format would be
the message and the timestamp which
would be given as
foreign
and ending it with the bracket
now for the next step we will Design
two of the functions that will be used
into the program that will be termed as
while press function and while release
function let's take a look
while press function
would be a function that will come into
play when the keyboard key has been
pressed
is
and
this would go for the
format that we designed
in the above line
and
logging
the Press key
info
a string file
to be recorded
into the log file
now
we'll design a function that is while
release
that will come into play
Finn
the Escape key has been pressed that is
the program will terminate itself and
the program will stop from running
and in the end
we require for the functioning of the
program to Loop these functions that is
while press and while it leads to
continuous cycle
that will be going for
while
press
and
on
release will contain while release
function
as
listener
and now
this part
would join the different threads and
store them into the log file
now that we have completed the code for
the program let's run it
we have to wait for a moment so the
program runs it
now
to verify the program let's open Notepad
and on the notepad
we'll write
hello world
which will be the basic whether the
program is working or not let's take a
look
and we will go for the main page on
Jupiter notebook and refresh the page
go to the bottom
over here we see the key log text that
is a text file that we created let's
open it
and over here we have the data that is
created
as we started with Note
then this is a Hello World part that we
created just now
which shows that the program we created
is working properly
now that we have reached the end of the
module let's take a look at the summary
firstly we learn what exactly key
loggers are
then we understood what different modes
are present how the system get infected
with the key logging problem then we
learned how to detect the problem into
our system then we learn what different
types of key loggers are present on the
net
we also understood how hackers use the
recorded data from the program and we
also learn whether mobile devices get
infected with the key logging problem or
not and lastly we understood what
different points can be taken to prevent
the entering of the key logging problem
into the system before we learn about
the Pegasus platform let us understand
what spyware is and it's working spyware
is a category of malware that can gather
information regarding a user or a device
straight from the host machine it is
mostly spread by malicious links via
email or chat applications when a link
with the malware is received clicking on
this link will activate the spyware
which allows the hacker to spy on all
our user information
but some spyware systems even clicking
on the link isn't necessary to trigger
the malicious payload
this can ultimately cause security
complications and further loss of
privacy
one such spyware system that is making
the rounds in the tech industry today is
Pegasus the Pegasus is a spyware system
developed by an Israeli company known as
the NSO group it runs on mainly mobile
devices spanning across the major
operating systems like the Apple's IOS
on iPhone and the standard Android
versions this is not a newly developed
platform since Pegasus has existed since
as early as 2016. a highly intricate
spyware program that can track user
location read text messages scan through
mobile files access device camera and
microphone to record voice and video
Pegasus has all the tools necessary to
enforce surveillance for any clan that
wishes to buy its services initially the
NSO group had designed the software to
be used against terrorist factions of
the world with more and more encrypted
communication channels coming to the
Forefront Pegasus was designed to
maintain control over the data
transmission that can be a threat to
National Security
unfortunately the people who bought the
software had complete control over who
how and up to what level they can put
surveillance limits on eventually the
primary clients became Sovereign Nations
spying on Public Information that is
supposed to stay private became really
easy with this service
multiple devices can be affected with
the same spyware system to create a
network information this network keeps
feeding data to the host to understand
how a network can be created let's know
how a mobile device can be affected by
Pegasus
we all communicate with friends and
family over instant messaging
applications and email in some instances
if you check your inbox on a regular
basis you must have noticed that we
received some spam emails that the mail
providers like Gmail and Yahoo can just
filter into the spam folder some of
these messages bypass this filter and
make their way into a person's inbox
they look like generic emails which are
supposed to be safe the Pegasus spyware
targets such occurrences bypassing
malicious messages and links which
install the necessary Spy software on
the user's mobile device be it Android
or an iPhone
this isn't unique to the email ecosystem
since it's equally likely to be targeted
by SMS text WhatsApp Instagram or even
the most secure messaging apps like
signal and threema once the malicious
links are clicked a spyware package is
downloaded and installed on the device
after the spyware is successfully
installed the perpetrator who sent the
payload to the victim can monitor
everything the user does
Pegasus can collect private emails
passwords images videos and every other
piece of information that passes through
the device Network all this data is
transmitted back to the central server
by the primary spying organization can
monitor the activities at a granular
level this is not even surface level
since complex spyware software like
Pegasus can access the roots files on
our mobiles these root files hold
information that is crucial to the
working of the Android and iOS operating
systems
leaking such private information is a
massive blow to the security and the
privacy of an individual the information
that may seem trivial like the name of
your Wi-Fi connection or the last time
you ordered an item from Amazon are
indeed all valuable information this
exploitation is primarily possible due
to the zero day vulnerabilities known as
bugs in the software development process
the zero day bugs are the ones that have
just been discovered by some independent
security company or a researcher once
they are found reporting these
vulnerabilities to the developer of the
platform which would be either Google
for Android or Apple for iOS is the
right thing to do however many such
critical bugs make their way onto the
dark web where hackers can use them to
create exploits
these exploits are then sent to innocent
users with a link or a message like we
had discussed before
Pegasus was able to affect the latest
devices with the all the security
patches installed but some bugs are not
reported to the developers or just
cannot be fixed without breaking some
core functionality
these become the Gateway for spyware to
enter into the system you can never be
100 safe but you sure can give it all in
protecting yourself the one thing where
Pegasus stands out is that zero click
action feature usually in spam emails
the malicious code is activated when the
user clicks the malware link a user
doesn't need to click the link in the
new version of the Pegasus and a few
other spyware programs once the message
arrives in the inbox of WhatsApp Gmail
or any other chat applications the
spyware gets activated and everything
can be recorded and sent back to the
central server the primary issue with
being affected by spyware as a victim is
detection
unlike crypto Miners and Trojans spying
Services usually do not demand many
system resources which makes them tough
to detect after they have been activated
since many devices slow down after a
couple of years any kind of Performance
Set due to such spyware is often
attributed to poor software longevity by
the users they do not check meticulously
for any other causes that is causing the
Slowdown
when left unchecked these devices can
capture voice and video from the mobile
sensors while keeping the owner in the
dark let's take a moment to check if we
are well aware of the causes of such
attacks how do users fall prey to such
spyware programs a by installing
untested software B by clicking on the
third party links from email and
messages
see by not keeping the apps and phones
updated or deep all of the above let us
know your answers in the comment section
below and we will revive the correct
answer next week but what about the
unaffected devices the vulnerable ones
while we cannot be certain of our
security there are a few things we can
do to boost our device be it against
Pegasus or the next big spyware on the
market
let's say we are safe now and we have
the time to take the necessary steps to
prevent a spyware attack what are the
things we can go for a primary goal must
always be to keep our apps and the
operating system updated with the latest
security patches the vulnerabilities
that the exploits targets are often
discovered by developers from Google and
apple which send the security patches
quickly
this can be done for individual apps as
well so keeping them updated is of
utmost importance
while the most secure devices have
fallen prey to Pegasus as well a
security patch from developers may help
in minimizing the damage at a later
stage or maybe negate the entire spyware
platform altogether another big factor
is the spread of malware is the trend of
side loading Android applications using
dot APK files downloading such apps from
a third party website have no security
checks involved and are mostly
responsible for adware and spyware
Innovations on user devices avoiding the
side loading of apps would be a major
step in protecting yourself
we often receive spam emails or texts
from people we may not know on social
media they are accompanied with links
that allow malware to creep into a
device you should try to follow the
trusted websites and not click on any
links that redirect us to unknown
domains
spiver is a controversial segment in
governance while the ramifications are
pretty extreme in theory it severely
impacts user privacy against
authoritarian regimes sufficient
resources and a contingent plan can
alter the false veil of democracy
altogether
even if our daily life is rather
simplistic we must understand that
privacy is not about what we have to
hide instead it portrays the things we
have to protect it stands for everything
we have to share with the outside world
both rhetorically and literally hey
everyone
today we look at the hack which took the
World by storm and affected multiple
governments and corporations the
solarwinds attack
the global statistics indicate that
upward of 18 000 customers have been
affected potentially needing billions to
recover the losses incurred before we
have a look at this hack Make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
notification Bell to never miss an
update from simpler
the date is December 8 2020. FireEye a
global leader in companies specializing
in cyber security released a blog post
that got the attention of the entire IIT
Community a software known as Orion
which was developed by solarwinds
Incorporated had become a victim of a
remote access Trojan or a rat the breach
was estimated to be running since the
spring of 2020 and when virtually
unnoticed for months the reveals and the
developers of the Orion software into a
frenzy as they quickly released a couple
of hot fixes for their platform in order
to mitigate this threat and prevent
further damage but how did this come
into existence
we first need to understand the platform
which was responsible for this breach
solo wins a software company based in
Texas United States had developed a
management platform known as Orion
catering to corporations and governments
worldwide Orion was responsible for the
monitoring and management of ID
Administration this included managing
the client's servers virtualization
components and even the organization's
Network infrastructure that bought the
platform
solarwinds claims they have more than
300 000 clients including U.S government
agencies and several Fortune 500
companies this entire chain can be
classified as a supply chain attack in
this variant of cyber crime the hackers
Target relatively weaker links in an
organization's chain of control and
delivery these are preferability
services rendered by a third party since
there is no direct jurisdiction over it
in this case the Orion platform was the
primary target the culprit however was
software updates the update server for
solarwinds Orion had a malicious version
attached with malware or a Trojan to be
precise this was made possible since the
code repository that handled the
software updates was breached once the
update server repository was compromised
the source code of the applications
became open to modification and
malicious code found its way onto the
software the remote access Trojan was
attached to a potential update nicknamed
the Sunburst update this update gave
hackers backdoor access to any client
that uses the correct version on its
release many clients believe the update
to be legitimate since it came from the
right source and they had no reason to
believe otherwise
American government agencies were
supposedly hit the hardest as the list
of victims included the U.S departments
of Homeland Security treasury and health
several private companies like Cisco
Nvidia and Intel were compromised
according to a list published by the
cyber security firm trusec
most of the companies had issues quick
updates to fix this vulnerabilities
introduced by the software while the
actual perpetrators have never been
found it is believed that this was an
act of cross-border corporate Espionage
conducted by state-sponsored hackers
either from Russia or China
before we move forward let's take a
recap of the things we learned
what category of malware was responsible
for the solarwinds hack was it one a
virus a remote access Trojan a spyware
or a worm let us know your answers in
the comment section right away and we
will reveal the correct answer in a week
coming to possible reparations the Biden
government has launched a full
investigation on the effects and the
repercussions of this breach there are a
couple of things that we as consumers
must always tend to when working our way
through the World Wide Web
using a password manager is highly
recommended which can generate secure
alphanumeric passwords you must also use
different passwords for different
accounts thereby reducing the chances of
a single point of failure should one of
those accounts get breached usage of
two-factor authentication applications
is also encouraged since it acts as a
safety net if hackers directly get a
hold of our credentials
clicking on unknown links transmitted
via emails is also a strict no as is
installing applications from unverified
sources the solarwinds hack is estimated
to cost the payment company nearly 18
million dollars as reparations making it
one if not the biggest hacks in
cyberspace history
as recently as of July 2021 the hackers
access some U.S attorneys Microsoft 365
email accounts as part of the attack
criminal organizations like the FBI and
CIA are determined to figure out the
culprits responsible for this debacle
however the intricacy and the full
extent of the breach makes it a way more
complicated job than it looks on paper
the day is 26 February 2022
the world is hit with breaking news that
Russian State tv channels have been
hacked by Anonymous a hacktivist
Collective and movement who have made a
name taking part in multiple Cyber Wars
in the past decade
this was in response to the Russian
aggression on Ukrainian territory in the
hopes of annexation
Anonymous hacked the Russian State TV
networks to combat propaganda in Russia
and highlight the damage to life meted
out by the Kremlin in Ukraine they also
hacked 120 000 Russian troops personal
information and the Russian Central Bank
stealing 35 000 files
this served as a clear indicator of how
cyber War can change the momentum in
battle something which people had never
seen so closely
so what is cyber War
a digital assault or series of strikes
or hacks against a country is sometimes
referred to as a cyber War it has the
ability to cause havoc on government and
civilian infrastructure as well as
disrupt essential systems causing State
harm and even debt
in this day and age the internet plays a
bigger role than just watching videos
and learning content it where you have
your personal data and carry Financial
transactions so rather than resorting to
physical violence Cyber Wars become the
new means to cause Havoc considering the
vulnerability of the data passing
through the internet
in most circumstances cyber warfare
involves the nation state attacking
another in certain cases the assaults
are carried out by terrorist
organizations or non-state actors
pursuing a hostile nation's aim in June
2021 Chinese hackers targeted
organizations like Verizon to secure
remote access to their Networks stuxnet
was a computer worm designed to attack
Iran's nuclear facilities but evolved
and expanded to many other industrial
and energy producing sites in 2010.
since the definition of cyber war is so
vague the flying rules and sanctions
based on digital assault is even tougher
making the field of cyber warfare a
lawless land not bound by any rules or
policies there are multiple ways in
which these attacks can be carried out a
major category of Cyber attack is
espionage
Espionage entails monitoring other
countries to steal critical secrets this
might include compromising vulnerable
computer systems with botnets or spear
phishing attempts before extracting
sensitive data in cyber warfare
the next weapon in cyber war is sabotage
government agencies must identify
sensitive data and its dangers if it is
exploited Insider threats such as
disgruntled or irresponsible Personnel
or government staff with ties to the
attacking country can be used by hostile
countries or terrorists to steal or
destroy information
by overwhelming a website with bogus
requests and forcing it to handle them
denial of service attacks prohibit real
users from accessing it attacking
parties may use this form of assault to
disrupt key operations and systems and
prevent citizens military and security
officials and research organizations
from accessing sensitive websites but
what benefits does Cyber War offer in
contrast to traditional physical Warfare
the most important Advantage is the
ability to conduct attacks from anywhere
globally without having to travel
thousands of miles
as long as the attacker and Target are
connected to the internet organizing and
launching Cyber Wars is relatively less
tedious Than Physical Warfare
people living in or battling for a
country are subjected to propaganda
attacks in an attempt to manipulate
their emotions and thoughts digital
infrastructure is highly crucial in
today's modern world
starting from communication channels to
Secure Storage servers crippling a
country's footprint and control on the
Internet is very damaging
but what are some of the ways we as
Citizens protect ourselves in the case
of a cyber war in the unfortunate event
that your country is involved in Warfare
be sure to fact check every piece of
information and follow only trusted
sources in that frame of time even
conversations online should be limited
to a need to know basis considering
propaganda campaigns have the power to
influence the tide of War drastically
it is highly crucial to follow basic
security guidelines to secure our
devices like regularly updating our
operating systems occasionally running
full system antivirus scans Etc
your country or organization is being
attacked having devices segregated in a
network goes a long way in bolstering
security
try to avoid sharing a lot of personal
data online
in this era of Instagram and Facebook
divulging private information can be
detrimental to keeping a secure firewall
for your data the more information an
attacker has access to the highest
chances of being able to devise a plan
to infiltrate defenses in this video we
bring you the top 10 computer hacks of
all time but before we begin if you are
new here and haven't subscribed already
make sure to hit the Subscribe button
and the bell icon for interesting Tech
videos every day let's see what we have
at number 10. from April 27 2007 Estonia
the European country faced a series of
cyber attacks that lasted for weeks this
happened when the Estonian government
decided to move the bronze soldier from
Thailand Center to a less prominent
military cemetery located on the city's
outskirts
unprecedented levels of internet traffic
took down Estonian Banks online services
media Outlets broadcasters and
government bodies
botnet sent massive waves of spam and
vast amounts of automated Online
requests according to researchers the
public faced DDOS attacks there were
conflicts to edit the English language
version of The Bronze soldiers Wikipedia
page as well although there is no
confirmation Russia is believed to be
behind these cyber attacks that largely
crippled the Estonian Society let's now
move on to the next attack on December
23 2015 several parts of Ukraine
witnessed a power outage and this was
not a typical blackout it was indeed the
result of a Cyber attack
Information Systems of three energy
distribution companies in Ukraine were
compromised it is the first known
Victorious Cyber attack on a par grid it
is said that here hackers send out
phishing emails to the power companies
30 substations were Switched Off and
about 230 000 people were left in the
dark for about one to six hours U.S
investigators believed that russia-based
hackers were responsible for this
experts have warned that other countries
could also be vulnerable to such attacks
let's see what we have at number eight
in the year 1999 a Cyber attack cost a
21-day shutdown of NASA computers
unbelievable isn't it the hacker was
none other than the then 15 year old
Jonathan James he first penetrated U.S
Department of Defense divisions
computers and installed a back door on
its servers
this allowed him to intercept more than
a thousand government emails including
the ones containing usernames and
passwords this helped James steal a
piece of NASA software and crack the
NASA computers that support the
International Space Station which caused
a space exploration agency's forty one
thousand dollars assistance were shut
down for three weeks
he was the first person to carry out a
computer hack against the American space
agency let's now move on to the next
attack in late November 2014 there was a
leak of confidential data from the film
studio of Sunni pictures
information about Sony Pictures
employees their emails copies of the
then unreleased Sony films future
propositions and other crucial data were
leaked
this Cyber attack was carried out by a
hacker grouped named Guardians Of Peace
So what are the hackers want well they
demanded that Sony withdraw its then
upcoming movie the interview this movie
was a comedy storyline to assassinate
the North Korean leader Kim Jong-un Sony
then decided to cancel the film's
theatrical release due to the threats at
Cinema screening the movie it is indeed
hard to trace the roots of a Cyber
attack in this case after evaluation the
U.S intelligence officials arrived at
the theory that the attack was in a way
related to the government of North Korea
however North Korea had denied the same
moving on to our number six
in December 2006 TJX the U.S retailer
company identified that 45.6 million
debit and credit card details were
stolen
this happened from one of its systems
over 18 months by an unknown number of
intruders it was one of the first
largest ever cyber attacks involving the
loss of personal data
as a result banks in the affected
regions had to reissue and block
thousands of payment cards a group of
hackers did this Albert Gonzalez being
The Mastermind the group was from Miami
the place where the TJX Heist was
believed to have originated reports said
that the TJX data breach occurred
because of weak web encryption at two of
its martial stores in Miami next moving
on to our top five let us see what we
have at number five the year 2010
witnessed the discovery of the deadly
computer worm stuxnet this malware's
motive was unlike any other usual cyber
attacks it aimed at destructing the
equipment the computers controlled
stuxnet came with the deadly purpose of
damaging Iran's nuclear infrastructure
it infected more than 200 000 computers
including 14 Industrial sites and a
uranium enrichment plant in Iran
stuxnet initially spread via Microsoft
Windows and targeted Siemens industrial
control systems
although it was discovered only in 2010
It is believed to have been silently
sabotaging Iran's nuclear facilities
it was one of the first discovered
malware that was capable of hampering
hardware systems it largely damaged the
centrifuges of the Iranian reactors this
is believed to be a cyber weapon created
by the US and the Israeli intelligence
although there is no documented evidence
or acceptance by either of the countries
for the same moving on to number four in
the year 2014 Home Depot was the victim
of one of the deadliest cyber attacks 56
million payment cards were compromised
along with 53 million customer email
addresses stolen
this security breach happened from April
to September 2014. criminals were
believed to have used a third-party
vendors username and password to enter
the perimeter of Home Depot's Network
the attackers were then able to deploy
custom-built malware on its
self-checkout systems in the U.S and
Canada
moving on to our top three
as you might be aware the PlayStation
gaming system is one of Sony's most
popular products unfortunately in April
2011 Sony Executives witnessed abnormal
activity on the PlayStation Network this
resulted in the compromise of
approximately 77 million PlayStation
users accounts and prevented users of
PlayStation 3 and PlayStation Portable
consoles from accessing this service
this forced Sony to turn off the
PlayStation Network on April 20th on May
4th Sony confirmed that personally
identifiable information from each of
the 77 million accounts had been exposed
the outage lasted for 23 days Sony
released almost daily announcements
concerning the system outage in the end
Sony is believed to have invested
approximately 170 million dollars to
improve the network security to
investigate the attack and to cover the
expenses of caring for the consumers
that had been affected let's now move on
to the next attack at number two in May
2017 one of the most dangerous cyber
attacks took place
it was known as the Warner cry
ransomware attack caused by the wannacry
cry crypto worm the victims were the
users that used the unsupported version
of Microsoft Windows and those who
hadn't installed the new security update
this did not take place through fishing
like other attacks but through an
exposed vulnerable SMB port
the attack originated in Asia and then
eventually spread across the globe in a
day more than 200 000 computers were
infected across 150 countries
the wannacry crypto worm locked the
users out of the targeted systems and
encrypted their data the users were
asked for a ransom of 300 to 600 dollars
which had to be paid via Bitcoin in
exchange for their data this attack took
a toll on both private and government
organizations it resulted in Damages
from hundreds of millions to billions of
dollars in a matter of few days the
emergency patches released by Microsoft
halted the attack also the discovery of
a kill switch prevented the infected
computers from spreading the crypto worm
Security Experts in a few countries
believed that North Korea was behind
this attack and finally let's see what
we have at number one more than two
decades ago in March 1999 the Melissa
virus a mass mailing macro virus was
released it targeted Microsoft Word and
outlook-based systems and created
considerable Network traffic Melissa
virus infected computers via emails the
email would look like an important
message well yes it was fake if the
recipient opens the attachments in the
mail and downloads the document and then
opens it with Microsoft Word a virus was
released on their computers
this would then Mass mail itself to the
first 50 people in the victim's contact
list and then disable multiple Safeguard
features on Microsoft Word and Microsoft
Outlook this began spreading like a
wildfire across the internet David L
Smith released the virus the virus cost
nearly 80 million worth of Damages it
did not steal data or money however it
cost a Havoc almost 1 million email
accounts were disrupted worldwide
agencies were overloaded and some had to
be shut down entirely and internet
traffic in some locations were slowed
down security was traditionally
considered an afterthought in software
development it is becoming an
increasingly important concern for all
aspects of app development from design
to deployment and Beyond
the number of programs produced
distributed deployed and patched across
Network continually increases as a
result application security features
must deal with a wide range of risks
let's take an example
a malicious script may be mirrored on
the victim's web browser or kept in a
database and run whenever the user
contacts the proper function depending
on the kind of attack in question here
this allows malicious code to be entered
in the case of an output the major cause
of this attack is faulty user input
validation which allows malicious input
to enter the final output an evil user
can enter a script that will be injected
into the website's code
the browser will then be unable to
determine whether the process code is
harmful
as a result a malicious script is
performed on the victim's browser or a
bogus form is shown to the users are you
aware of which attack this is if not do
stay till the end to find the correct
answer are you aware of which attack
this is if not please stay till the end
of the video to know the correct answer
hey everyone welcome to today's video on
application security before we move
forward subscribe to our Channel and hit
the Bell icon to never miss an update
from us let's take a look at the topics
to be covered today
we start by learning about application
security and its different times we
learn about the most common
vulnerabilities in app set followed by
the importance of application Security
in today's cyber security space
next we cover some attacks against
application layer security and end the
video with some protection techniques to
enforce application security parameters
so let's start by learning about
application security from a Grassroots
perspective
application security which is often
known as app set protect application
software from external security threats
by utilizing security software Hardware
methodologies best practices and
different processes
organizations require application
security technologies that Safeguard all
of their programs from internal to
popular external apps on consumer mobile
phones
these Solutions must address the whole
development cycle and provide testing
after an application has been deployed
to detect possible issues application
security mechanisms are capable of
testing web pages for possible and
exploitable vulnerabilities analyzing
code and assisting the administration of
development and Safety Management
processes the testing solution must also
be simple and easy to install for system
administrators worldwide
consumers utilize hundreds of
applications daily to access
theoretically important and favored
services such as e-commerce banking
music
Etc
to be productive these professionals use
a variety of software Solutions as well
ranging from online word Checkers to
tablet based creative tools among other
things
back-end software of course exists to
automate essential operations and
processes and decrease this human labor
but to make matters worse the quantity
and complexity of these apps and the
backend code is increasing
the software security problem 10 years
ago was about securing desktop apps and
static web pages that were natively
harmless and easy to scale through and
effect
because of Outsource development the
number of Legacy programs and in-house
development that uses third-party open
source and commercialized off-the-shelf
software modules the software supply
chain has become considerably more
convoluted
now that we understand application
Security on a general level let us go
through some of the different categories
or the types of application security
the three major types to be covered in
this section
web application security API security
and Cloud native application security
a web application is a program available
to the internet and it operates on a web
server the client is accessed using a
web browser
the applications by definition must
allow connections from clients across
unsecured networks this exposes them to
a variety of risks many online apps are
mission critical and include sensitive
customer data making them an attractive
Target attackers and a top concern for
any cyber security program or framework
the Advent of https which offers an
encrypted channel of communication
guards versus man in the middle attacks
or mitm attacks has addressed several
online application weaknesses
many weaknesses though still persist
many security providers have created
Solutions specifically geared to
safeguard online applications in
response to the rising challenge of web
application security
a web application firewall is an example
of a security technology meant to
identify and provide application layer
salts in the case of web applications
when it comes to apis
apis are of security flaws are the root
of many major data breaches they have
the potential to reveal sensitive data
and disrupt vital corporate processes
API security flaws include unsufficient
authentication unintended data
disclosure and a failure to apply rate
restriction which allows API abuse
the requirement for API security like
the necessity for web application
security this led to the creation of
sophisticated equipment that can
discover API vulnerabilities and protect
apis in production level
the third type is cloud native
application security
infrastructure and environments are
often built up automatically in Cloud
native apps depending on declarative
configuration which is known as
infrastructure as core or IEC
developers are tasked to developing
declarative settings and application
code both of which should be secure
because practically everything is
defined during the development stage
shifting left is even more crucial in
Cloud native setups traditional testing
techniques can help Cloud native apps
but they are insufficient
dedicated Cloud native Security
Solutions are mandatory at this point of
time which are capable of instrumenting
vessels container clusters and
serverless operations reporting on
security concerns and providing
developers with a quick feedback loop
now that you have covered the different
types of application security let us go
through some of the most common
vulnerabilities that these Frameworks
face on a daily basis
first is cryptographic failure
when data is not adequately safeguarded
in transit and addressed cryptographic
failures which are formerly known as
sensitive data exposures occurs it has
the potential to reveal credentials
health information credit card details
and personal information as well
depending on the type of data being
protected in that particular case
injection attacks six attackers can use
injection burner abilities to convey
malicious information to a web
application interpreter it has the
potential to assemble and execute this
data on the server
SQL injection is a popular type of
injection which I've already covered in
an introduction for this video
another major vulnerability are outdated
components vulnerable and Auto Trade
components Encompass any vulnerability
caused by obsolete or unmaintained
software it can happen if you construct
or even use an application without first
learning about its core components and
versions
authentication failures
identification and authentication
failure which are previously known as
broken authentication Encompass any
security issue involving user identities
identity attacks and exploitation may be
avoided by implementing secure session
Administration authentication and
validation for all identities in their
organization
in the next section let us cover some of
the protection mechanisms employed by
cyber security firms and third-party
automated software to prevent the
application layer from being bombarded
with SQL injections and other attacks
the first is a web application firewall
or Waf
a web application firewall monitors and
filters HTTP traffic within a web
application and the World Wide Web
application firewall architecture does
not address all risks but it may be used
in conjunction with other defense
mechanisms it can be used to the
portfolio of Security Solutions to
provide a comprehensive defense against
diverse attack roads
it is a protocol layer 7 protection in
the open systems interconnection or the
OSI module paradigm
that helps different online application
against attacks such as cross-site
scripting cross-site fraud skill
injection and file infusion
unlike a proxy server which conceals the
identity of client computers by an
intermediary a wire functions as a
reverse proxy shielding the server from
exposure it acts as a barrier in front
of a web application protecting it from
the internet so clients must pass
through the web application firewall
before they can access the application
the second is threat assessment a list
of sensitive assets to save guard will
assist you in understanding the threat
to your firm and how to minimize them
considering how a hacker can infiltrate
an application if the existing security
protections are in place and whether
additional tools or defense capabilities
are required it's also crucial to keep
your security expectations in check
nothing is impenetrable even at the most
stringent security measures
it would be best if you were realistic
about what you believe your team can
handle in the long run when pushed to
aggressively safety regulations and
procedures might be disregarded remember
that safety is a lengthy and time-taking
project that requires the collaboration
of other employees and sometimes even
your customers
the next topic is privilege management
limiting privileges is vital especially
for Mission critical and sensitive
systems the least privileged principle
states that access to programs and data
should be limited to those who require
them when they require them
for two reasons the least privileged
principle is absolutely critical
the first is that hackers May compromise
less privileged accounts and ensuring
they do not acquire access to highly
sensitive systems is critical
the second is that internal readers are
equally harmful as external adversaries
if insiders go bad it's critical to
ensure they never have more power than
they need minimizing the half that they
may be able to cause to the organization
network security is a set of
technologies that protects the usability
and integrity of a company's
infrastructure by preventing the entry
or proliferation within a network
it architecture comprises of tools that
protect the network itself and the
applications that run over it
effective network security strategies
employ multiple lines of defense that
are scalable and automated each
defensive layer here enforces a set of
security policies which are determined
by the administrator beforehand
and accessibility of the data and the
network
the every company or organization that
handles a large amount of data has a
degree of solutions against many cyber
threats the most basic example of
network security is password protection
it has the network the user chooses
the recently network security has become
the central topic of cyber security with
many organizations involving
applications from people with skills in
this area it is crucial for both
personal and professional networks most
houses with high-speed internet have one
or more wireless routers which can be
vulnerable to attacks if they are not
adequately secured
data loss theft and sabotages may be
decreased with the usage of a strong
network security system
the workstations are protected from
hazardous spiral thanks to network
security
additionally it guarantees the security
of the data which is being shared over a
network
by dividing information into various
sections encrypting these portions and
transferring them over separate Pathways
network security infrastructure offers
multiple levels of protection to thwart
man in the middle attacks preventing
situations like eavesdropping among
other harmful attacks it is becoming
increasingly difficult in today's
hyper-connected environment as more
corporate applications migrate to both
public and private talks additionally
modern applications are also frequently
virtualized and dispersed across several
locations some outside the physical
control of the IT team
Network traffic and infrastructure must
be protected in these cases since
assaults on businesses are increasing
every single day
you now understood the basics of network
security
but we need to understand how network
security works in the next section in
slightly more detail
network security revolves around two
processes authentication and
authorization
the first person which is authentication
is similar to access path which ensure
that only those who have the right to
enter a building
in other words authentication checks and
verifies that it is indeed the user
belonging to the network who is trying
to access or enter it thereby preventing
unauthorized introductions
next comes authorization
this process decides the level of access
provided to the recently authenticated
user
for example Network admin needs access
to the entire network whereas those
working within it probably need access
to any certain areas within the network
based on the network user's role the
process of determining the level of
access or permission level is known as
authorization
today's Network architecture is complex
and pieces a threat environment that is
always changing and attackers that are
always trying to find an exploit
vulnerabilities
these vulnerabilities can exist in many
areas including devices data
applications users and locations
for this reason many Network Security
Management tools and applications are in
use today that address individual
threats
when it's just a few minutes of down
times can cause widespread disruption
and massive damage to an organization's
bottom line and reputation it is
essential that these protection measures
are in place beforehand
now that I know a little about network
security and it's working let's cover to
the different types of network security
the fundamental tenet of network
security is the layering of protection
for massive networks and stored data
that ensure the acceptance of rules and
regulations
and Suppose there are three types the
first of which is physical security
the next being Technical and the third
being administrative
let's look into physical security post
this is the most basic level that
includes protecting data and network to
unauthorized Personnel from acquiring
control over the confidentiality of the
network
this include external peripherals and
routers that might be used for cable
connections the same can be achieved by
using devices like biometric systems
physical security is critical especially
for small businesses that do not have
many resources to devote to security
personnel and the tools as opposed to
large firms
when it comes to technical network
security it focuses mostly on
safeguarding data either kept in the
network or engaged in network
transitions
this kind fulfills two functions one is
defense against unauthorized users the
other is a difference against manipulate
actions
the last category is Administrative
this level of network security protects
user Behavior like how the permission
has been granted and how the
authorization process takes place
this also ensures the level of
sophistication the network might need to
protect it through all the attacks
this level also suggests necessary
amendments that have to be done to the
infrastructure
I think there's all the basics that we
need to cover on network security in
which our next topic we're going to go
through two mediums of network security
which are the transport layer and the
application layer
so transport layer is a way to secure
information as it is carried over the
Internet with users browsing websites
emails instant messaging Etc
TLS aims to provide a private and secure
connection between a web browser and a
website server it does this with the
cryptographic handshake between two
systems using public key cryptography
the two parties to the connected in
exchange a secret token and once each
machine validates this token it is used
for all Communications
the connection employs lighter symmetric
cryptography to save bandwidth and
processing power
since the application layer is the
closest layer to the end user it
provides hackers with the largest threat
surface poor app layer security can lead
to a performance and stability issues
data theft and in some cases the network
being taken down examples of application
layer attacks include distributed denial
of service attacks or pdos attacks HTTP
plugs SQL injections cross-site
scripting
Etc
most organizations have an arsenal of
application layer security protections
to combat these and more such as web
application firewalls secure web Gateway
Services
Etc
now that you have the theory behind
network security has been covered in
detail let us go through some of the
tools that can be used to enforce these
network security policies
the first two to be covered in this
section is a firewall
a firewall is a type of network security
device that keeps track of incoming and
outgoing Network traffic and it decides
which traffic to allow or deny in
accordance to a set of security rules
for more than 25 years firewalls have
served Network Securities first line of
defense they provide a barrier between
trustworthy internal protected and
regulated networks from Shady external
networks like the internet at some
points
the next tool which can be used to
bolster network security is a virtual
private Network or VPN for sure
it's an encrypted connection between a
device and a network via the Internet
the encrypted connection is the secure
transmission of sensitive data it makes
it impossible for unauthorized parties
to eavesdrop on the traffic and enables
remote work for the user the usage of
VPN technology is common in both
corporate and personal networks next we
cover the importance of inclusion
prevention systems in network security
or IPS Frameworks
an intuition prevention system is a
network security tool that continually
scans the network for harmful activity
and responds to it when it does occur by
reporting blocking or discarding it
it can be either Hardware or software
it's more sophisticated than an
intuition detection system or an IDs
framework which can just warn an
administrator and merely identify
harmful activities while in the case of
an IPS it actually takes against that
activity
the next tool in this section and the
final one are going to be behavioral
Analytics
Behavior analytics focus more on the
statistics that are being carried over
and stored through months and years of
usage
on some kind of similar pattern is noted
by the ID administrator can detect some
kind of attack the similar attacks can
be stopped and the security can be
further enhanced
but now that you have covered all that
we need to know about network security
the necessary tools and different types
Etc let's go to the benefits of network
security as a port
the first which is protection against
external threats the objective for cyber
assaults can be as varied as the
Defenders themselves
although they're typically initiated for
financial gain whether they are
industrial spies activists or cyber
criminals these Bad actors all have one
thing in common which is how quick
clever and cohort the attacks are
getting a strong cyber security posture
that considers routine software updates
May assist Works in identifying and
responding to the abuse techniques tools
and the common entry points
the next benefit is protection against
internal threats the human aspect
continues to be the cyber security
system's weakest link Insider risk can
originate from current or former workers
third party vendors or even trusted
partners and they can be unintentional
careless or downright even
aside from that the rapid expansion of
remote work and the personal devices
used for business purposes while even
iot devices in remote locations can make
it easier for these kind of threats to
go undetected until it's too late
however by proactively monitoring
networks and managing access these
ranges may be identified and dealt with
before they become expensive disasters
the third benefit is increase
productivity it's nearly impossible for
employees to function when Network and
personal devices are slowed to a crawl
by viruses and other cyber attacks
during the operation of website and for
the company to run you must
significantly minimize violations and
the amount of downtime required to fix
the breach by implementing various cyber
security measures such as enhanced
firewalls by the scanning and automatic
backups
employee identification of possible
email phishing schemes suspicious links
and other malicious criminal activities
can also be aided by Education and
Training
another benefit is brand trust and
reputation
customer retention is one of the most
crucial elements in business development
customers today place a premium on
maintaining brand loyalty through a
strong cyber security stance since this
is the fastest way to get other
businesses back get referrals and sell
more tickets overall
additionally it helps manufacturers get
on the vendor list with bigger companies
as a part of the supply chain which is
only as strong as the weakest link
this opens possibilities for potential
future endeavors and development if you
are looking to dive deep into the world
of cyber security then become an expert
with postgraduate program and cyber
security so hurry up and enroll now get
the complete course details in the
description box if you are looking to
have a smart entry in this field then
simply learn offers a six months program
Caltech cyber security boot camp find
the complete course details from the
link in the description box and pin
command with the rise in censorship and
general fear over privacy loss consumer
security is at an all-time high risk
technology has made our life so much
easier while putting up a decent Target
on our personal information it is
necessary to understand how to
simultaneously Safeguard our data and be
up to date with the latest technological
developments maintaining this balance
has become easier with cryptography
taking its place in today's digital
world so hey everyone this is bever from
Simply learn and welcome to this video
on cryptography but before we begin if
you love watching Tech videos subscribe
to our Channel and hit the Bell icon to
never miss an update from Simply learn
so here's a story to help you understand
cryptography meet Anne and wanted to
look for a decent discount on the latest
iPhone she started searching on the
internet and found a rather Shady
website that offered a 50 discount on
the first purchase once and submitted
her payment details a huge chunk of
money was withdrawn from a bank account
just moments after
devastated and quickly realized she had
failed to notice that the website was
their HTTP webpage instead of an https
one
the payment information submitted was
not encrypted and it was visible to
anyone keeping an eye including the
website owner and hackers Hatcher used a
reputed website which has encrypted
transactions and employs cryptography
our iPhone Enthusiast could have avoided
this particular incident this is why
it's never recommended to visit unknown
websites or share any personal
information on them now that we
understand why cryptography is so
important let's take a look at the
topics to be covered today
we take a look into what cryptography is
and how it works we learn where
cryptography is being used in our daily
lives and how we are benefiting from it
then we will understand the different
types of cryptography and their
respective users
moving on we will look at the usage of
cryptography in ancient history and a
live demonstration of cryptography and
encryption in action
let's Now understand what cryptography
is
cryptography is the science of
encrypting or decrypting information to
prevent unauthorized access we transform
our data and personal information so
that only the correct recipient can
understand the message as an essential
aspect of modern data security using
cryptography allows the Secure Storage
and transmission of data between willing
parties
encryption is a primary route for
employing cryptography by adding certain
algorithms to Jumble up the data
decryption is the process of reversing
the work done by encrypting information
so that the data becomes readable again
both of these methods form the basis of
cryptography
for example when simply run is jumbled
up or changed in any format not many
people can guess the original word by
looking at the encrypted text the only
ones who can are the people who know how
to decrypt the coded word thereby
reversing the process of encryption
any data pre-encryption is called plain
text or clear text to encrypt the
message we use certain algorithms that
serve a single purpose of scrambling the
data to make them unreadable without the
necessary tools these algorithms are
called ciphers
they are a set of detailed steps to be
carried out one after the other to make
sure the data becomes as unreadable as
possible until it reaches the receiver
we take the plain text pass it to the
cipher algorithm and get the encrypted
data this encrypted text is called the
ciphertext and this is the message that
is transferred between the two parties
the key that is being used to scramble
the data is known as the encryption key
these steps that is the cipher and the
encryption key are made known to the
receiver who can then reverse the
encryption on receiving the message
unless any third party manages to find
out both the algorithm and the secret
key that is being used they cannot
decrypt the messages since both of them
are necessary to unlock the hidden
content
wonder what else we would lose if not
for cryptography
any website where you have an account
can read your passwords important emails
can be intercepted and their contents
can be read without encryption during
the transit more than 65 billion
messages are sent on WhatsApp every day
all of which are secured thanks to
end-to-end encryption
there is a huge Market opening up for
cryptocurrency which is possible due to
blockchain technology that uses
encryption algorithms and hashing
functions to ensure that the data is
secure if this is of particular interest
to you you can watch our video on
blockchain the link of which will be in
the description
of course there is no single solution to
a problem as diverse as explained there
are three variants of how cryptography
works and is in practice
they are
symmetric encryption
asymmetric encryption
and hashing
let's find out how much you have
understood until now do you remember the
difference between a cipher and
ciphertext leave your answers in the
comments and before we proceed if you
find this video interesting make sure to
give it a thumbs up before moving ahead
let's look at symmetric encryption first
symmetric encryption uses a single key
for both the encryption and decryption
of data it is comparatively less secure
than asymmetric encryption but much
faster it is a compromise that has to be
embraced in order to deliver data as
fast as possible without leaving
information completely vulnerable
this type of encryption is used when
data rests on servers and identifies
Personnel for payment applications and
services the potential drawback with
symmetric encryption is that both the
sender and receiver need to have the
same secret key and it should be kept
hidden at all times
Caesar Cipher Enigma machine are both
symmetric encryption examples that we
will look into further for example if
Alice wants to send a message to Bob she
can apply a substitution Cipher or a
shift Cipher to encrypt the message but
Bob must be aware of the same key itself
so he can decrypt it when he finds it
necessary to read the entire message
symmetric encryption uses one of the two
types of ciphers stream ciphers and
block ciphers
block ciphers break the plain text into
blocks of fixed size and use the key to
convert it into ciphertext stream
ciphers convert the plain text into
ciphertext one bit at a time instead of
resorting to breaking them up into
bigger chunks
in today's world the most widely used
symmetric encryption algorithm is AES
256 that stands for advanced encryption
standard which has a key size of 256 bit
with 128-bit and 196 bit key sizes also
being available other primitive
algorithms like the data encryption
standard that is the Des the triple data
encryption standard 3des and Blowfish
have all fallen out of favor due to the
rise of AES AES chops UPS the data into
blocks and performs 10 plus rounds of
obscuring and substituting the message
to make it unreadable
asymmetric encryption on the other hand
has a double whammy at its disposal
there are two different keys at play
here a public key and a private key the
public key is used to encrypt
information pre-transit and a private
key is used to decrypt the information
post Transit if Alice wants to
communicate with Bob using asymmetric
encryption she encrypts the message
using Bob's public key after receiving
the message Bob uses his own private key
to decrypt the data this way nobody can
intercept the message in between
transmissions and there is no need for
any secure key exchange for this to work
since the encryption is done with the
public key and the decryption is another
private key that no one except Bob has
access to both the keys are necessary to
read the full message
there is also a reverse scenario where
we can use the private key for
encryption and the public key for
decryption a server can sign
non-confidential information using its
private key and anyone who has its
public key can decrypt the message this
mechanism also proves that the sender is
authenticated and there is no problem
with the origin of the information
RSA encryption is the most widely used
asymmetric encryption standard it is
named after its Founders revised Shamir
and Edelman and it uses block ciphers
that separate the data into blocks and
obscure the information
widely considered the most secure form
of encryption albeit relatively slower
than AES it is widely used in web
browsing secure identification vpns
emails and chat applications
with so much hanging on the key secrecy
there must be a way to transmit the keys
without others reading our private data
many systems use a combination of
symmetric encryption and asymmetric
encryption to bolster security and match
speed at the same time since asymmetric
encryption takes longer to decrypt large
amounts of data the full information is
encrypted using a single key that is
symmetric encryption that single key is
then transmitted to the receiver using
asymmetric encryption so you don't have
to compromise either way another route
is using the diffie-helpman key exchange
which relies on a one-way function and
is much tougher to break into
the third variant of cryptography is
termed as hashing
hashing is the process of scrambling a
piece of data beyond recognition it
gives an output of fixed size which is
known as the hash value of the original
data or just hash in general the
calculations that do the job of messing
up the data collection form the hash
function they are generally not
reversible without resilient Brute Force
mechanisms and are very helpful when
storing data on website servers that
need not be stored in plain text for
example many websites store your account
passwords in a hashed format so that not
even the administrator can read your
credentials when a user tries to log in
they can compare the entered passwords
hash value with the hash value that is
already stored on the servers for
authentication since the function will
always return the same value for the
same input
cryptography has been in practice for
centuries
Julius Caesar used a substitution shift
to move alphabets a certain number of
spaces beyond their place in the
alphabet table a spy can't decipher the
original message at first glance for
example if he wanted to pass
confidential information to his armies
and decides to use the substitution
shift of plus 2 a becomes c b becomes D
and so on the word attack when passed
through a substitution shift of plus 3
becomes dww d f n this Cipher has been
appropriately named the Caesar Cipher
which is one of the most widely used
algorithms
the Enigma is probably the most famous
cryptographic Cipher device used in
ancient history
it was used by the Nazi German armies in
the world wars they were used to protect
confidential political military and
administrative information and it
consisted of three or more rotors that
scramble the original message depending
on the machine's State at that time the
decryption is similar but it needs both
machines to stay in the same state
before passing the cipher text so that
we receive the same plain text message
let's take a look at how our data is
protected while we browse the internet
thanks to cryptography here we have a
web-based tool that will help us
understand the process of RSA encryption
we see the entire workflow from
selecting the key size to be used until
the decryption of the ciphertext in
order to get the plain text back
as we already know RSA encryption
algorithm falls under the umbrella of
asymmetric keyptography
that basically implies that we have two
keys at play here a public key and a
private key
typically the public key is used by the
sender to encrypt the message and the
private key is used by the receiver to
decrypt the message there are some
occasions when this allocation is
reversed and we will have a look at them
as well
in RSA we have the choice of key size we
can select any key from our 512 bit to
1024-bit all the way up to a 4096 bit
key the longer the key length the more
complex the encryption process becomes
and thereby strengthening the ciphertext
although with added security more
complex functions take longer to perform
the same operations on similar size of
data we have to keep a balance between
both speed and strength because the
strongest encryption algorithms are of
no use if they cannot be practically
deployed in systems around the world
let's take a 1024 bit key over here
now we need to generate the keys this
generation is done by functions that
operate on pass freezes the tool we are
using right now generates this
pseudorandom keys to be used in this
explanation once we generate the keys
you can see the public key is rather
smaller than the private key which is
almost always the case these two keys
are mathematically linked with each
other
they cannot be substituted with any
other key and in order to encrypt the
original message or decrypt the
ciphertext this pair must be kept
together the public key is then sent to
the sender and the receiver keeps the
private key with himself
in this scenario let's try and encrypt
the word simply learn
we have to select if the key being used
for encryption is either private or
public since that affects the process of
scrambling the information since we are
using the public key over here let's
select the same and copy it and paste
over here
the cipher we are using right now is
plain RSA there are some modified
ciphers with their own pros and cons
that can also be used provided we use it
on a regular basis and depending on the
use case as well
once you click on encrypt we can see the
ciphertext being generated over here
the pseudorandom generating functions
are created in such a way that a single
character change in the plain text will
trigger a completely different
ciphertext this is a security feature to
strengthen the process from Brute Force
methods
now that we are done with the encryption
process let's take a look at the
decryption part
the receiver gets this ciphertext from
the sender with no other key or
supplement he or she must already
possess the private key generated from
the same pair no other private key can
be used to decrypt the message since
they are mathematically linked we paste
the private key here and select the same
the cipher must always so be the same
used during the encryption process
once you click decrypt you can see the
original plain text we had decided to
encrypt this sums up the entire process
of RSA encryption and decryption
now some people use it the other way
around we also have the option of using
the private key to encrypt information
and the public key to decrypt it this is
done mostly to validate the origin of
the message since the keys only work in
pairs if a different private key is used
to encrypt the message the public key
cannot decrypt it conversely if the
public key is able to decrypt the
message it must have been encrypted with
the right private key and hence the
rightful owner here we just have to take
the private key and use that to encrypt
the plain text and select the same in
this checkbox as well you can see we
have generated a completely new
ciphertext
this ciphertext will be sent to the
receiver and this time we will use the
public key for decryption
let's select the correct checkbox and
decrypt
and we still get the same output
now let's take a look at practical
example of encryption in the real world
we all use the internet on a daily basis
and many are aware of the implications
of using unsafe websites let's take a
look at Wikipedia here pretty standard
https website where the edge stands for
secured let's take a look at how it
secures the data
Wireshark is the world's foremost and
most widely used Network protocol
analyzer it lets you see what's
happening on your network at a
microscopic level and we are going to
use this software to see the traffic
that is leaving a machine and to
understand how vulnerable it is
since there are many applications
running in this machine let's apply a
filter that will only show us the
results related to Wikipedia
[Music]
let's search for something that we can
navigate the website with
okay once we get into it a little you
can see some of the requests being
populated over here
let's take a look at the specific
request
these are the data packets that
basically transport the data from our
machine to the internet and vice versa
as you can see there's a bunch of
gibberish data here that doesn't really
reveal anything that we searched or
watched similarly other secured websites
function the same way and it is very
difficult if at all possible to Snoop on
user data this way
to put this in perspective
let's take a look at another website
which is a HTTP webpage
this has no encryption enabled from the
server end which makes it vulnerable to
attacks there is a login form here which
needs legitimate user credentials in
order to Grant access
let's enter a random pair of credentials
these obviously won't work but we can
see the manner of data's transfer
unsurprisingly we weren't able to get
into the platform instead we can see the
data packets
let's apply a similar filter that will
help us understand
what request this website is sending
these are the requests being sent by the
HTTP login form to the internet if we
check here
see whatever username and password that
we are entering we can easily see it
with the Wireshark
now we used a dummy pair of credentials
if we select the right data packet we
can find the correct credentials
if any website had asked for a payment
information or a legitimate credentials
it have been really easy to get a hold
of these
to reiterate what we have already
learned we must always avoid HTTP
websites and just unknown or not
trustworthy websites in general because
the problem we saw here is just the tip
of the iceberg even though cryptography
has managed to lessen the risk of cyber
attacks it is still prevalent and we
should always be alert to keep ourselves
safe online
there are two types of encryption in
cryptography
symmetric key cryptography
and asymmetric key cryptography both of
these categories have their pros and
cons and differ only by the
implementation
today we are going to focus exclusively
on symmetrical cryptography
let us have a look at its applications
in order to understand its importance
better
this variant of cryptography is
primarily used in banking applications
where personally identifiable
information needs to be encrypted with
so many aspects of banking moving on to
the internet having a reliable safety
net is crucial
symmetric cryptography helps in
detecting bank fraud and boosts the
security index of these payment gateways
in general
[Music]
they are also helpful in protecting data
that is not in transit and rests on
servers and data centers these centers
house a massive amount of data that
needs to be encrypted with a fast and
efficient algorithm so that when the
data needs to be recalled by the
respective service there is the
Assurance of minor to no delay
while browsing the internet we need
symmetric encryption to browse secure
https websites so that we get an
all-around protection it plays a
significant role in verifying website
server authenticity exchanging the
necessary encryption Keys required and
generating a session using those keys to
ensure maximum security
this helps us in preventing the rather
insecure HTTP website format
so let us understand how symmetric key
cryptography works first and before
moving on to the specific algorithms
symmetric key cryptography relies on a
single key for the encryption and
decryption of information
both the sender and receiver of the
message need to have a pre-shared secret
key that they will use to convert the
plain text into ciphertext and vice
versa as you can see in the image the
key used for encryption is the same key
needed for decrypting the message at the
other end the secret key shouldn't be
sent along with the cipher text to the
receiver because that would defeat the
entire purpose of using cryptography key
exchange can be done beforehand using
other algorithms like the diffie-hellman
key exchange protocol for example
for example if Paul wants to send a
simple message to Jane they need to have
a single encryption key that both of
them must give secret to prevent
snooping on by malicious actors
it can be generated by either one of
them but must belong to both of them
before the messages start flowing
suppose the message I am ready is
converted into ciphertext using a
specific substitution Cipher by Paul in
that case Jane must also be aware of the
substitution shift to decrypt this
ciphertext once it reaches her
irrespective of the scenario where
someone manages to grab the ciphertext
mid transit to try and read the message
not having the secret key renders
everyone helpless looking to Snoop in
the symmetric key algorithms like the
data encryption standard have been in
use since the 1970s while the popular
ones like the AES have become the
industry standard today
with the entire architecture of
symmetric cryptography depending on the
single key being used you can understand
why it's of Paramount importance to keep
it secret on all locations
the side effect of having a single key
for the encryption and decryption is it
becomes a single point of failure anyone
who gets their hand on it can read all
the encrypted messages and do so mainly
without the knowledge of the sender and
with the receiver
so it is the priority to keep the
encryption and decryption key private at
all times
should it fall into the wrong hands the
third party can send messages to either
the sender or the receiver using the
same key to encrypt the message upon
receiving the message and decrypting it
with the key it is impossible to guess
its origin
if the sender somehow transmits the
secret key along with the ciphertext
anyone can intercept the package and
access the information
consequently this encryption category is
turned private key cryptography since a
big part of the data's Integrity is
riding on the promise that the users can
keep the key secret this terminology
contrasts with asymmetry key
cryptography which is called public key
cryptography because it has two
different keys at play one of which is
public
provided we managed to keep the keys
secret we still have to choose what kind
of ciphers we want to use to encrypt
this information in symmetric key
cryptography there are broadly two
categories of ciphers that we can employ
let us have a look
stream ciphers are the algorithms that
encode basic information one bit at a
time
it can change depending on the algorithm
being used but usually it relies on a
single bit or byte to do the encryption
this is the relatively quicker
alternative considering the algorithm
doesn't have to deal with blocks of data
at a single time
every piece of data that goes into the
encryption can and needs to be converted
into binary format in stream ciphers
each binary digit is encrypted one after
the other the most popular ones are the
rc4 salsa and Panama
the binary data is passed through an
encryption key which is a randomly
generated bitstream upon passing it
through we receive the ciphertext that
can be transferred to the receiver
without fear of men in the middle
attacks the binary data can be passed
through an algorithmic function it can
have either X or operations as it is
most of the time or any other
mathematical calculations that have the
singular purpose of scrambling the data
the encryption key is generated using
the random bitstream generator and
attacks as a supplement in the
algorithmic function the output is in
binary form which is then converted into
the decimal or hexadecimal format to
give our final Cipher text
on the other hand block ciphers dissect
the raw information into chunks of data
of fixed size the size of these blocks
depend on the exact Cipher being used a
128-bit block Cipher will break the
plain text into blocks of 128 bit each
and encrypt those blocks instead of a
single digit once these blocks are
encrypted individually they are chained
together to form a final ciphertext
block ciphers are much slower but they
are more tamper-proof and are used in
some of the most widely used algorithms
employed today
just like stream ciphers the original
ciphertext is converted into binary
format before beginning the process once
the conversion is complete the blocks
are passed to the encryption algorithm
along with the encryption key
this would provide us
with the encrypted blocks of binary data
once these blocks are combined we get a
final binary string
all right
this string is then converted into
hexadecimal format to get our ciphertext
today the most popular symmetric key
algorithms like AES des and 3des are all
block Cipher methodology subsets
with so many factors coming into play
there are quite a few things
symmetrically cryptography excels at
while falling short in some other
symmetrical cryptography is much faster
variant when compared to asymmetric
cryptography there is only one key in
play unlike asymmetric encryption and
this drastically improves calculation
speed in the encryption and decryption
similarly the performance of symmetric
encryption is much more efficient under
similar computational limitations fewer
calculations help in better memory
management for the whole system
bulk amounts of data that need to be
encrypted are very well suited for
symmetric algorithms since they are much
quicker handling large amounts of data
is simple and easy to use in servers and
data forms this helps in better latency
during data recall and fewer mixed
brackets
thanks to its simple single key
structure symmetric key cryptography
algorithms are much easier to set up a
communication Channel with and offer a
much more straightforward maintenance
duties once the secret key is
transmitted to both the sender and
receiver without any prior mishandling
the rest of the system aligns easily and
everyday Communications becomes easy and
secure if the algorithm is applied as
per the documentation symmetric
algorithms are very robust and can
encrypt fast amounts of data with very
less overhead
Des algorithm stands for data encryption
standard it is a semester key Cipher
that is used to encrypt and recoup
information in a block by block manner
each block is encrypted individually and
they are later chained together to form
our final ciphertext which is then sent
to a receiver
DS takes the original unaltered piece of
data called the plain text in a 64-bit
block and it is converted into an
encrypted text that is called the
ciphertext
it uses 48-bit Keys during the
encryption process and follows a
specific structure called the fiscal
Cipher structure during the entire
process
it is a symmetric key algorithm which
means Des can reuse the keys used in the
encryption format to decrypt the
ciphertext back to the original plain
text once the 64-bit blocks are
encrypted they can be combined together
before being transmitted
let's take a look at the origin and the
reason the es was founded
Des is based on a fistel block Cipher
called Lucifer developed in 1971 by IBM
cryptography researcher host Fester Des
uses 16 rounds of the system structure
using a different key for each round it
also utilizes a random function with two
inputs and provides a single output
variable
DS becomes the organization's approved
encryption standard in November 1976 and
was later reaffirmed as a standard in
1983 1988 and finally in 1999 but
eventually DS was cracked and it was no
longer considered a secure solution for
all official routes of communication
consequently triple Ds was developed
triple 3s is a symmetric key block
Cipher that uses a double Ds Cipher
encrypt with the first key delete
encryption with the second key and
encrypt again with a third key there is
also a variation of the two keys where
the first and second key are duplicate
of each other but triple dsos ultimately
deemed too slow for the growing need for
fast communication channels and people
eventually fell back to using vs for
encrypting messages
in order to search for a better
alternative a public Point competition
was organized and helped cryptographers
develop their own algorithm as a
proposal for the next global standard
this is where the vindile algorithm came
into play and was later credited to be
the next Advanced encryption standard
for a long time BS was the standard for
data encryption for data and security
its rule ended in 2002 when finally the
advanced encryption standard replaced
Des as an acceptable standard following
a public competition for a place
to understand the structure of a fistral
cipher we can use the following image as
a reference the block being encrypted is
divided into two parts one of which is
being passed on to the function while
the other part is xored with the
functions output
the function also uses the encryption
key that differs for each individual law
this keeps going on until the last step
until where the right hand side and the
left hand side are being swapped here we
receive our final ciphertext
for the decryption process the entire
procedure is reversed starting from the
order of the keys to the block sorting
if the entire process is repeated in a
reverse order we will eventually get
back our plane text and this Simplicity
helps the speed
overall This was later detrimental to
the efficiency of the algorithm hence
the security was compromised
official blocks Alpha is a structure
used to derive many symmetric block
ciphers such as Des which as we have
discussed in our previous comic
Crystal Cipher proposed a structure that
implements substitution and permutation
alternately so that we can obtain
ciphertext from the plain text and vice
versa this helps in reducing the
redundancy of the program and increases
the complexity to combat Brute Force
attacks
the pistol Cipher is actually based on
the Shannon structure that was proposed
in 1945 the crystal Cipher is the
structure suggested by host feistel
which was considered to be a backbone
while developing many symmetric block
ciphers
the Shannon structure highlights the
implementation of alternate confusion
and diffusion
and like we already discussed the fistel
cipher structure can be completely
reversed depending on the data however
we must consider the fact that to
decrypt the information by reversing the
final structure we will need the exact
polynomial functions and the key orders
to understand how the blocks are being
calculated we take a plane test which is
of 64-bit and when that is later divided
into two equal half of 32 bit each
in this the right half is immediately
transferred to the next round to become
the new Left half of the second row
the right hand is again passed off to a
function which uses an encryption key
that is unique to each round in the
festel cipher
whatever the function gives off as an
output it is passed on as an xor input
with the left half of the initial plain
text
the next output will become the right
half of the second round for the plain
text
this entire process constitutes of a
single round in the pistol Cipher
taking into account what happens in a
polynomial function
we take one half of the block and pass
it through an expansion box the work of
the expansion box is to increase the
size of the half from 32-bit to 48 bit
text
this is done to make the text compatible
to a 48-bit keys we have generated
beforehand
once we pass it through the xor function
we get a 48 bit text as an output now
remember a half should be of 32-bit so
this 48 bit output is then later passed
on to a substitution box this
substitution box reduces its size from
48 bit to 32-bit output which is then
later xor with the first half of the
plain text
a block Cipher is considered the safest
if the size of the block is large but
large block sizes can also slow down
encryption speed and the decryption
speed generally the size is 64-bit
sometimes modern block ciphers like AES
have a 128-bit block size as well
the security of the block server
increases with increasing key size but
larger key sizes may also reduce the
speeds of the process earlier 64-bit
keys were considered sufficient modern
ciphers need to use 128 bit Keys due to
the increasing complexity of today's
computational standards
the increasing number of rounds also
increase the security of the block
Cipher similarly they are inversely
proportional to the speed of encryption
a highly complex round function enhances
the security of the block Cipher always
we must maintain a balance between the
speed and security
the symmetric block Cipher is
implemented in a software application to
achieve better execution speed
there is no use of an algorithm if it
cannot be implemented in a real life
framework that can help organizations to
encrypt or decrypt the data in a timely
manner
now that we understand the basics of
fiscal ciphers we can take a look at how
Des manages to run through 16 rounds of
the structure and provide the ciphertext
at the end
now that we understand the basics of
festel ciphers we can take a look at how
Des manages to run through 16 rounds of
this structure and provide a ciphertext
in simple terms DS takes the 64-bit
plain text and converts it into a 64-bit
ciphertext and since we are talking
about asymmetric algorithms the same key
is being used when it is decrypting the
data as well
we first take a 64-bit clip plane text
and we pass it through an initial
permutation function the individual
permission function it has the job of
dividing the block into two different
parts so that we can perform Crystal
Cipher structures on it
there are multiple rounds being procured
in the DS algorithm namely 16 rounds of
pistol Cipher structure each of these
rounds will need keys
initially we take a 56-bit cipher key
but it is a single key we pass it on to
a round key generators which generates
16 different keys for each single round
that the fiscal Cipher is being run
these keys are passed on to the rounds
as 48 bits the size of these 48 bits
case is the reason we use the
substitution and permutation Bonds in
the polynomial functions of the special
ciphers
when passing through all these rounds
with each round 16 where the final key
is passed on from the round key
generator and we get a final permutation
in the final permutation the Rhymes are
swapped and we get a final Cipher text
this is the entire process of Des with
16 rounds of pistol servers and compost
in it to decrypt a ciphertext back to
the plain text we just have to reverse
the process we did in the Des algorithm
and reverse the key order along with the
functions this kind of Simplicity is
what gave Des the bonus when it comes to
speed but eventually it was detrimental
to the overall efficiency of the program
when it comes to security factors Des
have five different modes of operation
to choose from
this one of those is electronic code
book each 64-bit block is encrypted and
decrypted independently in the
electronic code book format we also have
Cipher blockchaining or the CBC method
here each 64-bit block depends on the
previous one and all of them use an
initialization vector
we have a cipher feedback block
mechanism where the preceding ciphertext
becomes the input for the encryption
algorithm
it produces a pseudo random output which
in turn is xored with the plain text
there is an output feedback method as
well which is the same as Cipher
feedback except that the encryption
algorithm input is the output from the
preceding Des
a counter method has a different way of
approach where each plain text block is
xored with an encrypted counter the
counter is then incremented for each
subsequent block
there are a few other alternatives to
these modes of operation but the five
mentioned above are the most widely used
in the industry and recommended by
cryptographers worldwide
let's take a look at the future of Tes
the dominance of Des ended in 2002 when
the advanced encryption standard
replaced the DS encryption algorithm as
the accepted standard it was done by
following a public competition to find a
replacement
nist officially withdrew the global
acceptance standard in May 2005 although
triple Ds is approved for some sensitive
government information through 2030.
an ISD also had to change the DS
algorithm because its key length was too
short given the increased processing
power of the new computers encryption
power is related to the size of the
queue and vs found itself a victim of
ongoing technological advances in
Computing we have received a point where
56-bit was no longer a challenge to the
computers of packing note that because
Des is no longer the nist federal
standard does not mean that it is no
longer in use triple Ds is still used
today and is still considered a legacy
encryption algorithm
to get a better understanding of how
these keys in ciphertext look like we
can use an online tool for our benefit
as we already know to encrypt any kind
of data a key is mandatory this key can
be generated using mathematical
functions or computerized key generation
program such as this website offers
it can be based on any piece of texting
let's say the word is simply learn
in our example
once the key is settled we provide the
plain text or the clear text that needs
to be encrypted using the aforementioned
key
suppose a sentence for this example is
this is my first message
we have satisfied two prerequisites the
message and the key
another variable that goes into play is
the mode of operation
we have already learned about five
different modes of operation while we
can see some other options here as well
let us go with the CBC variant which
basically means the cipher blockchaining
method
one of cbc's key characteristics is that
it uses a chaining process it causes the
decryption of a block of ciphertext to
depend all on the preceding ciphertext
blocks as a result the entire validity
of all the blocks is contained in the
previous adjacent blocks as well a
single bit error in a ciphertext block
affects the decryption of all the
subsequent blocks the rearrangement of
the order of these for example can cause
the decryption process to get corrupted
regarding the manner of displaying
binary information we have two options
here we can either go with base64 or the
hexadecimal format
let's go with the base64 right now
as you can see the ciphertext is readily
available b64 is a little more efficient
than heads so we will be getting a
smaller ciphertext when it comes to
base64.
albeit the size of both the formats will
be the same the hex has the longest
hypertext since base64 takes four
characters for every three bytes while
hex will take two characters for each
batch hence base64 turns out to be more
efficient
now to decrypt the cipher text we go by
the same format
choose base64
we copy the ciphertext onto a decryption
tool and we have to make sure that the
key we are using is exactly the same
we choose similar mode of operation
and we choose the correct encoding
format as well which is base64 in this
case
as you can see
the decryption is complete and we get
our plain text back
even if you keep everything the same but
we just change the encoding format it
will not be able to decrypt anything
unfortunately DS has become rather easy
to crack even without the help of a key
the advanced encryption standard is
still on top when it comes to symmetric
encryption security and will likely stay
there for a while
eventually with so much computing power
growth the need for a stronger algorithm
was necessary to safeguard a personal
data
as solid as Des was the computers of
today could easily break the encryption
with repeated attempts thereby rendering
the data security helpless to counter
this dilemma a new standard was
introduced which was termed as the
advanced encryption standard or the AES
algorithm
let's learn what is Advanced encryption
standard
the AES algorithm also known as the
redial algorithm is a symmetric block
Cipher with a block size of 128 bits it
is converted into ciphertext using keys
of 128 192 or 256 bits it is implemented
in software and Hardware throughout the
world to encrypt sensitive data
the National Institute of Standards and
Technology also known as nist started
development on AES in 1997 when it was
announced the need for an alternative to
the data encryption standard
the new internet needed a replacement
for Des because of its small key size
with increasing computing power it was
considered unsafe against entire key
search attacks
the triple Ds was designed to overcome
this problem however it was deemed to be
too slow to be deployed in machines
worldwide
strong cases were present by the Mars
rc6 Serpent and the two fish algorithms
but it was the rindel encryption
algorithm also known as AES which was
eventually chosen as the standard
symmetric key encryption algorithm to be
used
its selection was formalized with the
release of federal information
processing standards publication 197 in
the November of 2001. it was approved by
the U.S Secretary of Commerce
now that we understand the origin of AES
let us have a look at the features that
make AES encryption algorithm unique
the AES algorithm uses a substitution
permutation or SP Network it consists of
multiple rounds to produce a ciphertext
it has a series of linked operations
including replacing inputs with specific
outputs that is substitutions and others
that involve bit shuffling which is
permutations
at the beginning of the encryption
process we only start out with a single
key which can be either a 128 bit key a
192-bit key or a 256-bit key eventually
this one key is expanded to be used in
multiple rounds throughout the
encryption and the decryption cycle
interestingly AES performs all its
calculations on byte data instead of bit
data as seen in the case of the DS
algorithm therefore AES treats 128 bits
of a clear text block as 16 bytes
the number of rounds during the
encryption process depends on the key
size that is being used
the 128-bit key size fixes 10 Rounds the
192-bit key size fixes 12 rounds and the
256 bit key holds 14 nodes
a round key is required for each of
these rounds but since only one key is
input into the algorithm the single key
needs to be expanded to get the key for
each arm including the round 0.
with so many mathematical calculations
going on in the background there are
bound to be a lot of steps throughout
the procedure let's have a look at the
steps followed in AES
before we move ahead we need to
understand how data is being stored
during the process of AES encryption
everything in the process is stored in a
4 into 4 Matrix format
this Matrix is also known as a state
array and we'll be using these State
arrays to transmit data from one step to
another and from one round to the next
row
each round takes straight array as input
and gives a straight array as output to
be transferred into the next round
it is a 16 byte Matrix with each cell
representing one byte
with each four bytes representing a word
so every state array will have a total
of four words representing it
as we previously discussed we take a
single key and expand it to the number
of rounds that we need the key to be
used in let's say the number of rounds
are n then the key has to be expanded to
be used with n plus 1 rounds because the
first term is the key zero round
let's say n is the number of rounds the
key is expanded to n plus 1 rounds it is
also a state array having four words in
its vicinity
every key is used for a single round and
the first key is used as a round key
before any round begins
in the very beginning the print text is
captured and passed through an xor
function with a round key as a
supplement
this key can be considered the first key
from the N plus 1 expanded set
moving on the state array resulting from
the above step is passed on to a byte
substitution process
beyond that there is a provision to
shift rows in the state arrays
later on the state array is mixed with a
constant Matrix to shuffle its column in
the mix column segment after which we
add the round key for that particular
round
the last four steps mentioned are part
of every single round that the
encryption algorithm goes through the
state arrays are then passed from one
round to the next as an input
in the last one however we skip the mix
columns portion with the rest of the
process remaining unchanged
but what are these byte substitution and
row shifting processes let's find out
regarding each step in more detail
in the first step the plain text is
stored in a state array and it is xorbed
with the K is 0 which is the first key
in the expanded key set
this step is performed only once on a
block while being repeated at the end of
each round as per iteration demands
the state array is xored with the key to
get a new state array which is then
passed off as input to the sub bytes
process
in the second stage we have byte
substitution
we leverage an Xbox called as a
substitution box to randomly switch data
among each element
every single byte is converted into a
hexadecimal value having two parts the
first part denotes the row value and the
second part denotes the column value
the entire State array is passed through
the s box to create a brand new state
array which is then passed off as an
input to the row shifting process
the 16 input bytes are replaced by
looking at a fixed table given in the
design we finally get a matrix with four
rows and four columns
when it comes to row shifting each bit
in the four rows of the Matrix is
shifted to the left an entry that is a
fall off is reinserted to the right of
the line the change is done as follows
the first line is not moved in any way
the second line is shifted to a single
position to the left
the third line is shifted two positions
to the left and the fourth line is
shifted three positions to the left
the result is a new Matrix that contains
the same 16 bytes but has been moved in
relation to each other to boost the
complexity of the program
in mixed columns each column of 4 bytes
is now replaced using a special
mathematical function
the function takes 4 bytes of a column
as input and outputs four completely new
bytes
we will get a new Matrix with the same
size of 16 bytes and it should be noted
that this phase has not been done in the
last round of the iteration
when it comes to adding a round key the
16 bytes of the Matrix are treated as
128 bits and the 128 bits of the round
key are X Out if it is the last round
the output is the ciphertext if you
still have a few rounds remaining the
resulting 128 bits are interpreted as 16
bytes and you start another similar
round
let's take an example to understand how
all these processes work if our plain
text is the string 2192 we first convert
it into a hexadecimal format as follows
we use an encryption key which is that's
my Kung Fu and it is converted into a
hexadecimal format as well
as per the guidelines we use a single
key which is then later expanded into n
plus one number of keys in which case is
supposed to be 11 keys for 10 different
rounds
in round 0 we add the round key the
plain test is xored with the k0 and we
get a state array that is passed off as
an input to the substitution by its
process
when it comes to the substitution bytes
process we leverage an s-box to
substitute the elements of each byte
with a completely new byte this way the
state array that we receive is passed
off as an input to the row shifting
process on the next step
when it comes to row shifting each
element is shifted a few places to the
left with the first row being shifted by
zero places second row by one place
third row by two places and the last by
three
the state array that we received from
the row shifting is passed off as an
input to mixed columns in mixed columns
we multiply the straight array with a
constant Matrix after which I receive a
new state array to be passed on onto the
next step
we add the new state array as an xor
with the round key of the particular
iteration
whatever state array we receive here it
becomes an output for this particular
round
now since this is the first round of the
entire encryption process the state
array that we receive is passed off as
an input to the new round
we repeat this process for 10 more
rounds and we finally receive a cipher
text
once the final State array can be
denoted in the hexadecimal format this
becomes our final ciphertext that we can
use for transferring information from
the sender and receiver
let's take a look at the applications of
AES in this world
AES finds most use in the area of
wireless security in order to establish
a secure mode of authentication between
routers and clients
highly secure mechanisms like WPA and
WPA to psk are extensively used in
securing Wi-Fi endpoints with the help
of indiles algorithm
it also helps in SSL TLS encryption that
is instrumental in encrypting our
internet browser sessions
AES Works in tandem with other
asymmetric encryption algorithms to make
sure the web browser and web server are
properly configured and use encrypted
channels for communication
AES is also prevalent in general file
encryption of various formats ranging
from critical documents to the media
files having a large key allows people
to encrypt media and decrypt data with
maximum security possible
AES is also used for processor Security
in Hardware Appliances to prevent
machine hijacking among other things
as a direct successor to the Des
algorithm there are some aspects that
AES provides an immediate advantage in
let us take a look
when it comes to key length the biggest
flaw in DS algorithm was its small
length was easily vulnerable by today's
standards AES has managed to NAB up 128
192 and 256 bit key lens to bolster the
security further
the block size is also larger in AES a
wing to more complexity of the algorithm
the number of rounds in Des is fixed
irrespective of the plain text being
used in AES the number of round depends
on the key length that is being used for
the particular iteration thereby
providing more Randomness and complexity
in the algorithm
the Des algorithm is considered to be
simpler than AES even though AES beats
Des when it comes to relative speed of
encryption and decryption this makes
Advanced encryption standard much more
streamlined to be deployed in Frameworks
and systems worldwide when it compares
to the data encryption standard hello in
our last video on cryptography we took a
look at symmetric key cryptography we
used a single private key for both the
encryption and decryption of data and it
works very well in theory let's take a
look at a more realistic scenario now
let's meet Joe
Joe is a journalist who needs to
communicate with Ryan via long distance
messaging
due to the critical nature of the
information people are waiting for any
message to leave Joe's house so that
they can intercept it
now Joe can easily use symmetric
cryptography to send the encrypted data
so that even if someone intercepts the
message they cannot understand what it
says but here's the tricky part
how will Joe send the required
decryption key to Ryan
the sender of the message as well as the
receiver need to have the same
decryption key so that they can exchange
messages otherwise Ryan cannot decrypt
the information even when he receives
the cipher text if someone intercepts
the key while transmitting it there is
no use in employing cryptography since a
third party can now decode all the
information easily key sharing is a risk
that will always exist when symmetric
key cryptography is being used
thankfully asymmetric key encryption has
managed to fix this problem
this is Baba from Simply learn and
welcome to this video on asymmetric geek
cryptography let's take a look at what
we are going to learn today
We Begin by explaining what asymmetry
key cryptography is and how it works
we take a look at its application and
uses we understand why it's called
public key cryptography and then learn a
little bit about RS encryption and then
we learn about the advantages of
asymmetric key cryptography over
symmetric key cryptography
let's understand what asymmetric
cryptography is
asymmetric encryption uses a double
layer of protection
there are two different keys at play
here a private key and a public key a
public key is used to encrypt the
information pre-transit and a private
key is used to decrypt the data post
Transit
these pair of keys must belong to the
receiver of the message the public keys
can be shared via messaging blog posts
or key servers and there are no
restrictions
as you can see in the image the two keys
are working in the system the sender
first encrypts the message using the
receiver's private key after which we
receive the cipher text the cipher text
is then transmitted to the receiver
without any other key on getting the
ciphertext the receiver uses his private
key to decrypt it and get the plain text
back there has been no requirement of
any key exchange throughout this process
therefore solving the most glaring flaw
faced in symmetric cryptography
the public key known to everyone cannot
be used to decrypt the message and the
private key which can decrypt the
message need not be shared with anyone
the sender and receiver can exchange
personal data using the same set of keys
as often as possible
to understand this better take the
analogy of your mailbox
anyone who wants to send you a letter
has access to the box and can easily
share information with you in a way you
can say the mailbox is publicly
available to all but only you have
access to the key that can open the
mailbox and read the letters in it
this is how the private key comes to
play no one can intercept the message
and read its contents since it's
encrypted once the receiver gets its
contents he can use his private key to
decrypt the information
both the public key and the private key
are generated so they are interlinked
and you cannot substitute other private
keys to decrypt the data
in another example if Anis wants to send
a message to Bob let's say it reads call
me today she must use Bob's public key
while encrypting the message upon
receiving the cipher message Bob can
proceed to use his private key in order
to decrypt the message and hence
complete Securities attained during
transmission without any need for
sharing the key
since this type of encryption is highly
secure it has many users in areas that
require High confidentiality
it is used to manage digital signature
so there is valid proof of a document's
authenticity
with so many aspects of business
transitioning to the digital sphere
critical documents need to be verified
before being considered authentic and
acted upon thanks to asymmetric
cryptography senders can now sign
documents with their private Keys anyone
who needs to verify the authenticity of
such signatures can use the sandals
public key to decrypt the signature
since the public and the private keys
are linked to each other mathematically
it's impossible to repeat this
verification with duplicate keys
document encryption has been made very
simple by today's standards but the
background implementation follows the
stimulus approach
in blockchain architecture asymmetric
cryptography is used to authorize
transactions and maintain the system
thanks to its two key structures changes
are reflected across the blockchain's
peer-to-peer Network only if it is
approved from both ends along with a
symmetric key cryptography Stamper proof
architecture its non-repudiation
characteristic also helps in keeping the
network stable
we can also use asymmetric cryptography
combined with symmetrical cryptography
to monitor SSL or TLS encrypted
browsering sessions to make sure nobody
can still up personal information when
accessing banking websites or the
internet in general it plays a
significant role in verifying websites
of authenticity exchanging the necessary
encryption Keys required and generating
a session using those keys to ensure
maximum security instead of the rather
insecure HTTP website format security
parameters differ on a session by
session basis so the verification
process is consistent and utterly
essential to Modern data security
another great use of the asymmetric
keyptography structure is transmitting
keys for symmetric key cryptography with
the most significant difficulty in
symmetric encryption being key exchange
asymmetric keys can help clear the
shortcoming the original message is
first encrypted using a symmetric key
the key used for encrypting the data is
then converted into the ciphertext using
the receiver's public key now we have
two Cipher tags to transmit to the
receiver on receiving both of them the
receiver uses his private key to decrypt
the symmetric key he can then use it to
decrypt the original information on
getting the key used to encrypt the data
while this may seem more complicated
than just asymmetricy cryptography alone
symmetric encryption algorithms are much
more optimized for vast amounts of data
on some occasions
encrypting the key using asymmetric
algorithms will definitely be more
memory efficient and secure
you might remember us discussing why
symmetric encryption was called private
key cryptography let us understand why
asymmetric falls under the public key
cryptography
we have two keys at our disposal the
encryption key is available to everyone
the decryption key is supposed to be
private
unlike symmetric key cryptography there
is no need to share anything privately
to have an encrypted messaging system
to put that into perspective we share
our email address with anyone looking to
communicate with us it is supposed to be
public by Design so that our email login
credentials are private and they help in
preventing any data mishandling since
there is nothing hidden from the world
if they want to send us any encrypted
information this category is called the
public key cryptography
there are quite a few algorithms being
used today that follow the architecture
of asymmetric cryptography none more
famous than the RS encryption
RSA encryption is the most widely used
encryption or public key encryption
standard using asymmetric approach named
after its Founders reverse Shamir and
Edelman it uses block ciphers to obscure
the information
if you are unfamiliar with how block
ciphers work their encryption algorithms
that divide the original data into
blocks of equal size
the block size depends on the exact
Cipher being used once they are broken
down these blocks are encrypted
individually and later chained together
to form the final ciphertext
widely considered to be the most secure
form of encryption albeit relatively
slower than symmetric encryption
algorithms it is widely used in web
browsing secure identification vpns
emails and other chat applications
with so many variables in play there
must be some advantages that give
asymmetrical cryptography and Edge over
the traditional symmetric encryption
methodologies let's go through some of
them
there is no need for any reliable key
sharing channel in asymmetric encryption
it was an added risk in private key
cryptography that has been completely
eliminated in public key architecture
the key which is made public cannot
recup any confidential information and
the only key that can decrypt doesn't
need to be shared publicly under any
circumstance
we have much more extensive key lens in
RSA encryption and other asymmetric
algorithms like 2048 bits key and 4096
bit keys larger keys are much harder to
break into via brute force and are much
more secure
asymmetric key cryptography can use as a
proof of authenticity since only the
rightful owner of the keys can generate
the messages to be decrypted by the
private key the situation can also be
reversed encryption is done using a
private key and decryption is done by
the public key which would not function
if the correct private key is not used
to generate the message hence proving
the authenticity of the owner
it also has a tamper protection feature
where the message cannot be intercepted
and changed without invalidating the
private key used to encrypt the data
consequently the public key cannot
decrypt the message and it is easy to
realize the information is not 100
legitimate when and where the case
requires
now that we have a proper revision let's
understand what digital signatures are
before moving on to the algorithm
the objective of digital signatures is
to authenticate and verify documents and
data
this is necessary to avoid tampering and
digital modification or forgery of any
kind during the transmission of official
documents
they work on the public key cryptography
architecture with one exception
typically an asymmetric key system
encrypts using a public key and decrypts
with a private key for digital
signatures however the reverse is true
the signature is encrypted using a
private key and is decrypted with the
public key because the keys are Inked
together decoding it with the public key
verifies that the proper private key was
used to sign the document therefore
verifying the signature's provenance
let's go through each step to understand
the procedure thoroughly
in Step 1 we have M which is the
original plain text message
and it is passed on to a hash function
denoted by hash to create a Digest
next it bundles the message together
with the hash digest and encrypts it
using the sender's private key
it sends the encrypted bundle to the
receiver who can decrypt it using the
sender's public key
once the message is decrypted it is
passed through the same hash function
hash to generate a similar Digest
it compares the newly generated hash
with the bundled hash value received
along with the message if they match it
verifies data integrity
in many instances they provide a layer
of validation and security to messages
through non-secure Channel
properly implemented a digital signature
gives the receiver reason to believe
that the message was sent by the claimed
sender digital signatures are equivalent
to traditional handwritten signatures in
many respects but properly implemented
digital signatures are more difficult to
forge than the handwritten type
digital signature schemes in the sense
used here are cryptographically based
and must be implemented properly to be
effective they can also provide
non-repudiation meaning that the signer
cannot successfully claim that they did
not sign a message while also claiming
their private key remains Secret
further some non-reparation schemes
offer a timestamp for the digital
signature so that even if the private
key is exposed the signature is valid
to implement the concept of digital
signature in real world we have two
primary algorithms to follow the RSA
algorithm
and the DS algorithm but the latter is a
topic of learning today
so let's go ahead and see what the
digital signature algorithm is supposed
to do
digital signature algorithm is fips
standard which is a federal information
processing standard for digital
signatures
it was proposed in 1991 and globally
standardized in 1994 by the National
Institute of Standards and Technology
also known as the nist
it functions on the framework of modular
exponiation and discrete logarithmic
problems which are difficult to compute
as a force brute system
unlike DSA most signature types are
generated by signing message digest with
the private key of the originator this
creates a digital thumbprint of the data
since just the message digests is sign
the signature is generally much smaller
compared to the data that was signed as
a result digital signatures impose less
load on processors at the time of
signing execution and they use small
volumes of bandwidth
DSA on the other hand does not encrypt
message digest using private key or
decip message digest using public key
instead it uses mathematical functions
to create a digital signature consisting
of two 160-bit numbers which are
originated from the message digest and
the private key
DCS make use of the public key for
authenticating the signature but the
authorization process is much more
complicated when compared with RSM DSA
also provides three benefits which is
the message authentication Integrity
verification and non-repadiation
in the image we can see the entire
process of DSF validation a print text
message is passed onto a hash function
where the digest is generated which is
passed on to a signing function
shining function also has other
parameters like a global variable G of
random variable k
and the private key of the sender
the outputs are then bundled onto a
single pack with the plain text and sent
to the receiver
the two outputs we receive from the
signing functions are the two 160 bit
numbers denoted by S and R
on the receiver and we pass the plain
text through the same hash function to
regenerate the message Digest
it is passed on to verification function
which has other requirements such as the
public key of the sender Global variable
G and SNR received from the sender
the value generated by the function is
then compared to R
if they match then the verification
process is complete and data Integrity
is verified
this was an overview of the way the DSA
algorithm works you already know it
depends on logarithmic functions to
calculate the outputs so let us see how
we can do the same in our next section
we have three phases here the first of
which is key generation
to generate the keys we need some
prerequisites we'd select a queue which
becomes a prime divisor we select a
prime number P such that P minus 1 mod Q
equal to 0. we also select a random
integer G which must satisfy the two
formulas being mentioned on the screen
right now
once these values are selected we can go
ahead with generating the keys the
private key can be denoted by X and it
is any random integer that falls between
the bracket of 0 and the value of Q
the public key can be calculated as y
equal to G to the power x mod P where y
stands for the public key
the private key can then be packaged as
a bundle which comprises of values of p
q G and X
similarly the public key can also be
packaged as a bundle having the values
of p q G and Y
once we're done with key generation we
can start verifying the signature and
this generation
repeat
once the keys are generated we can start
generating the signature
the message is passed through a hash
function to generate the digest H first
we can choose any random integer K which
falls under the bracket of 0 and Q
to calculate the first 160 bit number of
a signing function of r we use the
formula G to the power K mod P into mod
Q similarly to calculate the value of
the second output that is s we use the
following formula that is shown on the
screen
the signature can then be packaged as a
bundle having r and s
this bundle along with a plain text
message is then passed on to the
receiver
now with the third phase we have to
verify the signature we first calculate
the message I just received in the
bundle by passing it to the same hash
function
we calculate the value of w U1 and U2
using the formulas shown on the screen
we have to calculate a verification
component which is then to be compared
with the value of R being sent by the
sender this verification component can
be calculated using the following
formula
once calculated this can be compared
with the value of R if the value is
match then the signature verification is
successful and the entire process is
complete starting from Key generation to
the signature Generation all the way up
to the verification of the signature
with so many steps to follow we are
bound to have a few advantages to boot
this and we would be right to think so
DSA is highly robust in the security and
stability aspect when compared to
Alternative signature verification
algorithms we have a few other ciphers
that aim to achieve the Simplicity and
the flexibility of DSA but it has been a
tough ask for all the other suits
the key generation is much faster when
compared to the RSA algorithm and such
while the actual encryption and
decryption process May falter a little
in comparison a quicker start in the
beginning is well known to optimize a
lot of Frameworks
DSA requires Less storage space to work
its entire cycle
in contrast its direct correspondent
that is RSA algorithm needs a certain
amount of computational and storage
space to function efficiently this is
not the case with DSL which has been
optimized to work with weaker hardware
and lesser resources
the DSA is patented but nist has made
this pattern available worldwide royalty
free a draft version of the speculation
fips 1865 indicates that DSA will no
longer be approved for digital signature
generation but it may be used to verify
signatures generated prior to the
implementation date of that standard
the RSA algorithm is a public key
signature algorithm developed by a Ron
reverse ADI Shamir and Leonard Edelman
the paper was first published in 1977
and the algorithm uses logarithmic
functions to keep the working complex
enough to withstand brute force and
streamlined enough to be fast post
deployment
RSA can also encrypt and decrypt general
information to securely exchange data
along with handling digital signature
verification
let us understand how it achieve this
we take our plain text message M we pass
it through a hash function to generate
the digest H which is then encrypted
using the sender's private key this is
appended to the original plain text
message and sent over to the receiver
once the receiver receives the bundle we
can pass the plain text message to the
same hash function to generate a digest
and the ciphertext can be decrypted
using the public key of the sender the
remaining hashes are compared if the
values match then the data Integrity is
verified and the sender is authenticated
apart from digital signatures the main
case of RSA is encryption and decryption
of private information before being
transmitted across communication
challenge
this is where the data encryption comes
into play when using RSA for encryption
and decryption of General data it
reverses the key set usage unlike
signature verification it receives the
receivers public key to encrypt the data
and uses the receiver's private key in
decrypting the data thus there is no
need to exchange any keys in this
scenario there are two broad components
when it comes to RSA cryptography one of
them is key generation key generation
employs a step of generating the private
and the public keys that are going to be
used for encrypting and decrypting the
data
the second part is the encryption and
decryption functions these are the
ciphers and steps that need to be run
when scrambling the data or recovering
the data from the ciphertext you will
Now understand each of these steps in a
next subtopic
keeping the previous two concepts in
mind let us go ahead and see how the
entire process works starting from
creating the keeper to encrypting and
decrypting the information
you need to generate the public and
private Keys before running the
functions to generate ciphertext and
plain text to use certain variables and
parameters all of which are explained
we first use two large prime numbers
which can be denoted by P and Q
we can compute the value of n as n equal
to P into q and compute the value of Z
as P minus 1 into Q minus 1.
a number e is chosen at random
satisfying the following conditions and
a number D is also selected at random
following the formula e d mod J equal to
1 and it can be calculated with the
formula given below
public key is then packaged as a bundle
with n and E and the private key is
packaged as a bundle using n and D
this sums up the key generation process
for the encryption and decryption
function we use the formula C and M the
ciphertext can be calculated as c equal
to m to the power e mod n and the
plaintext can be calculated from the
cipher text as C power D mod n when it
comes to a data encryption example let's
take p and Q as 7 and 13. the value of n
can be calculated as 91.
if we select the value of e to be 5 it
satisfy all the criteria that we needed
to the value of D can be calculated
using the following function which gives
it as 29. the public key can then be
packaged as 91 comma 5 and the private
key can then be packaged as 91 comma 29.
the plane test if it is 10 which is
denoted by m ciphertext can be
calculated as a formula c equal to m to
the power e mod n which gives us 82. if
somebody receives this Cipher text they
can calculate the plain text using the
formula C to the part D mod n which
gives us the value of 10 as selected as
our plain text
we can now look at the factors that make
the RSA algorithm Stand Out versus its
competitors and the advantages topics of
this lesson
RSA encryption depends on using the
receiver's public key so that you don't
have to share any secret key to receive
the messages from others this was the
most glaring flaw faced by symmetric
algorithms which were eventually fixed
by asymmetric cryptography structure
since the keypads are related to each
other a receiver cannot intercept the
message since they didn't have the
correct private keys to decrypt the
information
if a public key can decrypt the
information the sender cannot refuse
signing it with his private key without
admitting the private key is not in fact
private anymore
the encryption process is faster than
that of the DSA algorithm
even if the key generation is slower in
RSA many systems across the world tend
to reuse the same keys so that they can
spend less time in key generation and
more time on actual Cipher text
management
data will be tamper-proof in transit
since meddling with the data will alter
the usage of the keys the private key
won't be able to decrypt the information
hence alerting the receiver of any kind
of manipulation in between
the receiver must be aware of any third
party who possesses the private key
since they can alter the data made
Transit the cases of which are rather
low
imagine creating an account on a new
website
you provide your email address and set a
password that you are confident and you
would not forget
what about the website owner how
securely are they going to store your
password
for website administrators they have
three Alternatives they can either store
the passwords in a plain text format
they can encrypt the passwords using an
encryption and decryption key
or they can store the passwords in a
hash value
let's have a look at each of these
when a password is stored in plain text
format it is considered to be the most
unsafe option since anyone in the
company can read your passwords a single
hack and a data server breach will
expose all the accounts credentials
without needing any extra effort
to counter this owners can encrypt the
passwords and keep them in the servers
as a second alternative
but that would mean they also have to
store the decryption key somewhere on
their servers in the event of a data
breach or the server hack both the
decryption key and encrypted password
should be leaked thus making it a single
point of failure
what if there was an option to store the
passwords after scrambling them
completely but with no way to decrypt
them this is where hashing comes to play
since only the hashed values are stored
in the server though encryption is
needed with no plain text passwords to
protect your credentials are saved from
the website administrators
considering all the pros hashed
passwords are the industry standard when
it comes to storing credentials nowadays
before getting too deep into the topic
let's get a brief overview of how
hashing works
hashing is the process of scrambling a
piece of information or data beyond
recognition
we can achieve this by using hash
functions which are essentially
algorithms that perform mathematical
operations on the main plain text
the value generated after passing the
plain text information through the hash
function is called the hash value digest
or in general just the hash of the
original data
while this may sound similar to
encryption the major difference is
hashes are meant to be irreversible no
decryption key can convert a digest back
to its original value
however a few hashing algorithms have
been broken due to the increase in
computational complexity of today's new
generation Computer Zen processors there
are new algorithms that stand the test
of time and are still in use among
multiple areas for password storage
identity verification Etc
like we discussed earlier websites use
Hashim to store the user's passwords so
how do they make use of these hash
passwords
when a user signs up to create a new
account the password is then run through
the hash function and the resulting hash
value is stored on the servers so the
next time a user comes to log into the
account the password he enters is passed
through the same hash function and
compared to the hash stored on the main
server
if the newly calculated hash is the same
as the one stored on the website server
the password must have been correct
because according to Hash functions
terminology same inputs will always
provide the same outputs
if the hashes do not match then the
password enter during login is not the
same as the password entered during the
sign out hence the login will be denied
this way no plain text passwords gets
stored preventing both the owner from
snooping on user data and protecting
users privacy in the unfortunate event
of a data breach or a hack
apart from password storage Hashim can
also be used to perform Integrity checks
when a file is uploaded on the internet
the files hash value is generated and it
is uploaded along with the original
information when a new user downloads
the file he can calculate the digest of
the downloaded file using the same hash
function
when the hashes values are compared if
they match then file Integrity has been
maintained and there has been no data
corruption
send so much important information is
being passed under the hash function we
need to understand how they work
a hash function is a set of mathematical
calculations operated on two blocks of
data the main input is broken down into
two blocks of similar size the block
size is dependent on the algorithm that
is being used
hash functions are designed to be one
way they shouldn't be reversible at
least by Design some algorithms like the
previously mentioned md5 have been
compromised but most secure algorithms
are being used today like the Sha Famine
of algorithms
the digest size is also dependent on the
respective algorithm being used md5 has
a digest of 128 bits while sh-256 has a
digest of 256 bits
this digest must always be the same for
the same input irrespective of how many
times the calculations are carried out
this is a very crucial feature since
comparing the hash value is the only way
to check if the data is untouched as the
functions are not reversible
there are certain requirements of a hash
function that need to be met before they
are accepted while some of them are easy
to guess others are placed in order to
preserve Security in the long run
the hash function must be quick enough
to encrypt large amounts of data at a
relatively Fast Pace but it also
shouldn't be very fast running the
algorithm on all cylinders makes the
functions easy to boot force and a
security liability there must be a
balance to allow the hash function to
handle large amounts of data and not
make it ridiculously easy to Brute Force
by running through all the possible
combinations
the hash function must be dependent on
each bit of the input
the input can be text audio video or any
other file extension if a single
character is being changed it doesn't
matter how small that character may be
the entire digest must have a distinctly
different hash value this is essential
to create unique digests for every
password that is being stored
but what if two different users are
using the same password
since the hash function is the same for
all users both the digest will be the
same this is called a hash Collision you
may think this must be a rare occasion
where two users have exactly the same
password but that is not the case we
have techniques like salting that can be
used to reduce these hash collisions as
we will discuss later in this video
you would be shocked to see the most
used passwords of 2020. all of these
passwords are laughably insecure and
since many people use the same passwords
repeatedly on different websites hash
Collision series are more common than
one would expect
let's say the hash functions find two
users having the same password
how can they store both the hashes
without messing up the original data
this is where sorting and peppering come
to play
salting is the process of adding a
random keyword to the end of the input
before it is passed on to the hash
function
this random keyword is unique for each
user on the system and it is called the
solid value or just the sort
so even if two passwords are exactly the
same the solved value will differ and so
will that I just
there is a small problem with this
process though since the salt is unique
for each user they need to be stored in
the database along with the passwords
and sometimes even in plain text to
speed up the process of continuous
verification if the server is hacked
then the hashes will need to be brute
forced which takes a lot of time but if
they receive the salts as well the
entire process becomes very fast
this is something that preparing aims to
solve
peppering is the process of adding a
random string of data to the input
before passing them to the hash function
but this time the random string is not
unique for each user it is supposed to
be common for all users in the database
and the extra bit added is called the
pepper in this case
the pepper is installed on the servers
it is mostly hard coded onto the website
source code since it's going to be the
same for all credentials this way even
if the servers get hacked they will not
have the right paper needed to crack
into all the passwords
many websites use a combination of
salting and peppering to solve the
problem of hash collision and bolster
security
since Brute Force takes such a long time
many hackers avoid taking the effort the
returns are mostly not worth it and the
possible combinations of using both
sorting and peppering is humongous
with the consensus aiming towards an
educated public on digital privacy it's
no surprise to see an increasing
interest in encryption algorithms we
have already covered the major names
like the Des and the AES algorithm
75 algorithm was one of the first
hashing algorithms to take the global
stage as a successor to the md4
despite the security vulnerabilities
encountered in the future md5 Still
Remains a crucial part of data
infrastructure in a multitude of
environments
the md5 hashing algorithm is a one-way
cryptographic functions that accepts a
message of any length as input and it
returns as output of fixed length digest
value to be used for authenticating the
original messages the digest size is
always 128 bits irrespective of the
input
the md5 hash function was originally
designed for use as a secure
cryptographic hash algorithm to
authenticate digital signatures
md5 has also been depreciated for users
other than as a non-cryptographic
checksum to verify data integrity and
detect unintentional data corruption
Ronald reverse founder of RSA data
security and Institute professor at MIT
design md5 as an improvement to a prior
message digest algorithm which was the
md4
as already iterated before the process
is straightforward we pass a plain text
message to the md5 hash functions which
in turn perform certain mathematical
operations on the clear text to scramble
the data the 128-bit digest received
from this is going to be radically
different from the plain text
the goal of any message digest function
is to produce digest that appear to be
random to be considered
cryptographically secure the hash
functions should meet two requirements
first that it is impossible for an
attacker to generate a message that
matches a specific hash value and second
that it is impossible for an attacker to
create two messages that produce the
same hash value
even a slight change in the plain text
should trigger a drastic difference in
the two digests this goes a long way in
preventing hash collisions which take
place when two different plaintiffs have
the same Digest
to achieve this level of intricacy there
are number of steps to be followed
before we receive the Rises
let us take a look at the detailed
procedure as to how the md5 hash
algorithm works
the first step is to make the plain text
compatible with the hash function to do
this we need to Pat the bits in the
message
when we receive the input string we have
to make sure the size is 64-bit short of
a multiple of 512. when it comes to
padding the bits we must add one first
followed by zeros to round out the extra
characters
this prepares the string to have a
length of just 64 bits less than any
multiple of 512.
here on out we can proceed On To The
Next Step where we have to Pat the
length bits initially in the first step
we appended the message in such a way
that the total length of the bits in the
message was 64 bit short of any multiple
of 512. now we add the length width in
such a way that the total number of bits
in the message is perfectly a multiple
of 512.
that means 64-bit lens to be precise are
added to the message our final string to
be hashed is now a definite multiple of
512.
The Next Step would be to initialize the
message digest buffer
the entire hashing plain text is now
broken down into 512-bit blocks
there are four buffers or registers that
are of 32 bits each named a b c and d
these are the four words that are going
to store the values of each of these sub
blocks
the first iteration to follow these
registers will have fixed hexadecimal
values as shown on the screen below
once these values are initial
of these 512 blocks we can divide each
of them into 16 further sub blocks of 32
bits each
for each of these sub blocks we run four
rounds of operations having the four
buffer variables a b c and d these
rounds require the other constant
variables as well which differ with each
round of operation
the constant values are stored in a
random array of 64 elements since each
32-bit sub block is Run 4 times 16 such
sub blocks equals 64 constant values
needed for a single block iteration
the sub blocks can be denoted by the
alphabet M and the constant values are
denoted by the alphabet T
coming to the actual round of operation
we see our four buffers which already
have pre-initialized values for the
first iteration at the very beginning
the values of buffers b c and d are
passed on to a non-linear logarithmic
function
the formula behind this function changes
whether particular round being worked on
as we shall see later in this video
once the output is calculated it is
added to the raw values stored in buffer
a
the output of this addition is added to
the particular 32-bit sub-block using
which we are running the four operations
the output of this requisite function
then needs to be added to a constant
value derived from the constant array k
since we have 64 different elements in
the array
repeat
since we have 64 different elements in
the array we can use a distinct element
for each iteration of a particular block
The Next Step involves a circular shift
that increases the complexity of the
hash algorithm and is necessary to
create a unique digest for each
individual input
the output generated is later added to
the value stored in the buffer B
the final output is now stored in the
second buffer of B of the output
register
individual values of c d and a are
derived from the preceding element
before the iteration started meaning the
value of b gets stored in C
value of C is stored in D and the value
of D in a
now that we have a full register ready
for this subblock the values of a b c d
are moved on as input to the next sub
block
once all 16 sub blocks are completed the
final register value is saved and the
next 512-bit block begins
at the end of all these blocks we get a
final digest of the md5 algorithm
regarding the non-linear process
mentioned in the first step the formula
changes for each round it's being run on
this is done to maintain the
computational complexity of the
algorithm and to increase randomness of
the procedure
the formula for each of the four rounds
uses the same parameters that is b c and
d to generate a single output the
formula is being used are shown on the
screen right now
algorithm unlike the latest hash
algorithm families a 32-bit digest is
relatively easier to compare when
verifying the digests they don't consume
a noticeable amount of disk storage and
are comparatively easier to remember and
reiterate
passwords need not be stored in plain
text format making them accessible for
hackers and malicious actors when using
digest the database security also gets a
boost since the size of all the hash
values will be the same
in the event of a hack or a breach the
malicious actors will only receive the
hashed values so there is no way to
regenerate the plain text which should
be the user passwords in this case since
the functions are irreversible by Design
hashing has become a compulsion when
storing user credentials on the server
nowadays
things
a relatively low memory footprint is
necessary when it comes to integrating
multiple Services into the same
framework without a CPU overhead
the digest size is the same and the same
steps are run to get the hash value
irrespective of the size of the input
string
this helps in creating a low requirement
for computational power and is much
easier to run on older Hardware which is
pretty common in server farms around the
world
we can monitor file corruption by
comparing hash values before and after
Transit
once the hashes match file Integrity
checks are valid and we can avoid data
corruption
hash functions will always give the same
output for the similar input
irrespective of the iteration parameters
it also helps in ensuring that the data
hasn't been tampered with on route to
the receiver of the message
we use our Wi-Fi every day for work and
we use the internet for entertainment
and communication
the dependency on technology is at an
all-time high thanks to the radical
developments and innovation in these
last two decades
a big portion of this belongs to
ensuring secure channels of
communication and data transmission
the secure hash algorithm are a family
of a cryptographic hash functions that
are published by the National Institute
of Standards and Technology along with
the NSA
it was passed as a federal information
processing standard also known as fips
it has four different families of hash
functions ssj0 is a 160-bit hash
function published in 1993 and it was
closed down later after an undisclosed
significant flow
sha1 is also a 160 bit hash function
which resembles the earlier md5
algorithm this was designed by the NSA
to be a part of the digital signature
algorithm
sha2 is a family of two similar hash
functions with different block sizes
known as the sha-256 and the sha-512
they differ in the word size sat 256
uses 32-bit words while sha 512 uses
64-bit words
sha3 is a hash function properly known
as kick it was chosen in 2012 after a
public competition among non-nsa
designers it supports the same hash lens
as hj2 and its internal structure
differs significantly from the rest of
the Sha family
as we have already iterated the process
is straightforward we pass a plain text
message to the Sha hash function which
in turn performs certain mathematical
operations on the clear text to scramble
the data the 160 bit digest receipt from
this is going to be radically different
from the print text the goal of any hash
function is to produce digest that
appear to be random to be considered
cryptographically secure the hash
function should meet two requirements
first that it is impossible for an
attacker to generate a message that
matches a specific hash value and second
it should be impossible for an attacker
to create two messages producing the
exactly same hash value even a slight
change in the plain text should trigger
a drastic difference in the two Digest
this goes a long way in preventing hash
collisions which takes place when two
different plain texts have the same
Digest
the Sha family functions have some
characteristics that they need to follow
while generating the Digest let's go
through a few of them
the length of the clear text should be
less than 2 to the power 64 bits in the
case of sha1 and sh256
this is essential to keep the plain text
compatible with the hash function and
the size needs to be in comparison area
to keep the digest as random as possible
the length of the hash digest should be
256 bits in the sha256 algorithm 512
bits in the Sha 512 algorithm and so on
bigger digest usually suggests
significantly more calculations at the
cost of speed and space we typically go
for the longest digest to bolster
security but there must be a definite
balance between the speed and security
of a hash function
by Design all hash function of the Sha
512 sh-256 are irreversible
you should neither get a plain text when
you have the digest beforehand nor
should the digest provide the original
value when you pass it through the same
hash function again
another case of protection is that when
the hash digest is passed into the Sha
function for a second time we should get
a completely different digest from the
first instance
this is done to reduce the chance of
Brute Force attacks
to achieve this level of intricacy there
are a number of steps to be followed
before we receive the Digest
let us take a look at the detailed
procedure as to how the Sha algorithm
works
the first step is to make the plain text
compatible with the hash function
to do this we need to pad the bits in
the message
when you receive the input string you
have to make sure the size is 64-bit
short of a multiple of 512. when it
comes to padding them bits you must add
one first followed by the remaining
zeros to round out the extra characters
this prepares our string to have a
length just 64 bits less than any
multiple of 512.
here on out we can proceed to The Next
Step where we have to Pat the length
bits initially in the first step we
appended the message in such a way that
the total number of bits in the message
was 64-bit short from becoming a
multiple of 512. now we add the length
of bits in such a way that the total
number of bits in the message is a
perfect multiple of 512.
that means 64 bits plus the length of
the original message becomes a multiple
of 512. this becomes a final string that
needs to be hashed
in the next step we have to initialize
this chaining variables
the entire plain text message can now be
broken down into blocks of 512 bits each
unlike other hash algorithms like md5
which use four registers or buffers sha
family use five buffers of 32 bits each
they are named a b c d and e these
registers go through multiple rounds of
operation where the first iteration has
fixed has a decimal values as can be
seen in the screen
moving on we have to process each of the
512-bit blocks by breaking each of them
into 16 sub blocks of 32 bits each
of them goes through four rounds of
operation that use the entire register
and have the 512 bit block along with
the constant array out of those four
rounds each round has 20 iterations so
in general we have 80 rounds sum total
the constant value of K is an array of
80 elements
of those 80 16 elements are being used
each round so that comes out to 80
rounds for each of those elements
the value of T differs by the number of
rounds as can be seen in the table below
a single formula is necessary to
calculate the output of each round and
iteration
the formula can be a b c d e register is
equal to e plus a non-linear process P
along with the circular shift of a plus
WT plus KT
in this formula ABCD is the register
value of the chaining variables as we
discussed before
p is a logical process which has a
different formula for each round
S5 is a circular shift by 5 bits
and WT is a 32 bit string derived from
the existing sub block this can be
calculated depending on the iteration at
hand
in KT signifies a single element of the
80 character element array which changes
depending on the particular round at
hand
for the values of WT the first 16 values
are the same as that of the sub blocks
so there is no extra calculation needed
for the next 64 elements the value of WT
can be calculated as shown in the
formula here
to better understand this let's take a
look at how each of this goes in a
sequential process we have our initial
register using the five words of 32 bits
each in the first step we put the values
of a b c and d to the subsequent
register as the output
next we use a non-linear process P that
changes depending on the round and uses
the values of b c and d as input
whatever output is generated from the
non-linear process it is added with the
value of the E register
next the value of a is circular shifted
by 5 bits and is added with the output
generated in the previous step
the next step is adding the value of WT
and the constant element of KT the
current output is then stored in the
register a similarly this iteration is
repeated every round and for each
subblock in the process once all the
registers are complete and all the sub
blocks are joined together to form the
single ciphertext message we will have
our hashed output regarding the
non-linear process P that uses the
values of b c and d as input
the formula changes every round to
maintain a complexity of the program
that can withstand Brute Force attacks
depending on the round the values are
passed through a logical operation which
is then added with the values of WT KT
and so on now that we understand how to
get our hash digest from the plain text
let us learn about the advantages we
obtain when using the Sha hash algorithm
instead of relying on data in a plain
text format
digital signatures follow asymmetric
encryption methodology to verify the
authenticity of a document or a file
hash algorithms like sh-256 and the
industry standard sha 512 go a long way
in ensuring the verification of
signatures
passwords need not be stored in a plain
text format which makes them accessible
to hackers and other malicious actors
when using digest the database security
also gets a boost since the size of all
hash values will be the same
in the event of a hack or a breach the
malicious actor will only receive the
hash values with no way to regenerate
the plain text
in this case the plain text would be
user credentials
since the hash functions are
irreversible by design it has become a
compulsion when storing passwords on the
servers
the SSL handshake is a crucial segment
of the web browsing sessions and it's
done using sha functions it consists of
your web browsers and the web servers
agreeing on encryption keys and hashing
authentication to prepare a secure
connection
it relies on a combination of symmetric
and asymmetric algorithms which ensure
the confidentiality of the data
transmitted between a web server and a
web client like the browsers
you can monitor file corruption by
comparing hash values before and after
Transit
once the hashes match file Integrity
checks are valid and data corruption is
avoided
hash functions will always give the same
output for the same input irrespective
of the iteration parameters it also
helps in ensuring that the data hasn't
been tampered with on route to the
receiver of the message passwords are by
far the most common type of user
Authentication
they are popular because the theory
makes perfect sense to individuals and
is reasonably simple to implement for
Developers
on the other hand poorly constructed
passwords can post security flaws a
well-designed password-based
authentication process does not save the
user's actual password this would make
it far too simple for a hacker or a
malevolent Insider to access all of the
system's user accounts
in this video you will learn how to
crack passwords and simultaneously try
to make your passwords as Brute Force
resistant as possible let's take a look
at the topics to be covered today
we start by learning about what is
password cracking in general
next we take a look at the different
techniques of password cracking that
hackers use in order to generate user
credentials for hacking
moving on we take a look at the multiple
tools that hackers can use to generate
these hashes and the passwords
finally we take a look at the steps and
the guidelines that users can follow to
prevent their passwords from being
cracked
let's start by giving a basic idea about
password cranking
password cracking is the process of
identifying an unknown password to a
computer or a network resource using a
program code
it can also assist a threat actor in
gaining illegal access to resources
malicious actors can engage in various
criminal activities with the information
obtained through password tracking the
procedure might entail comparing a set
of words to guest credentials or using
an algorithm to guess the password
repeatedly password tracking can be done
for several reasons but the most
malicious reason is in order to gain
unauthorized access to a computer
without the owner's awareness this
results in cyber crime such as stealing
passwords for the purpose of accessing
banking information other non-malicious
reasons for password cracking occur when
someone has misplaced or forgotten a
password another example of
non-malicious password cracking may take
place if a system administrator is
conducting tests on password strength as
a form of security test this enables so
that the hacker cannot easily access
protected systems the best way that
users can protect their passwords from
cracking is to ensure that they choose
strong passwords
typically passwords must contain a
combination of mixed case random letters
digits and symbols
strong passwords should never be actual
words in addition strong passwords are
at least 8 characters long in many
password protected applications users
are notified of the strength of the
password they have chosen upon entering
it the user can then modify it and
strengthen the password based on the
indications of its strength
now that we understand the basics of
password cracking let's go to the basic
techniques hackers use to retrieve
passwords from General victims
asking the customer for their password
is simple approach to hacking a phishing
email directs the unwarya reader to a
counterfeit login page linked with
whatever service the hacker wants to
access generally by demanding the user
fix some critical security flaw or Aid
in a database reset
that page then captures the password
which the hacker can subsequently
exploit for their own purpose
social engineering influences the victim
to get personal information such as bank
account numbers or passwords the
strategy is popular among hackers
because they realize that humans are the
gateway to vital credentials and
information
through social engineering the employee
tried and true tactics to exploit and
influence age-old human Tendencies
rather than devising novel means to
breach secure and Advanced Technologies
it has been demonstrated that many firms
either lack adequate security or are
overly friendly and trustworthy even
they should not be
they allow granting access to critical
facilities based on a uniform or a sob
story
a hacker searches a password dictionary
for the correct password in the case of
a dictionary attack
password dictionaries cover many themes
in a mixture of topics such as politics
movies and music groups
users failure to create a strong
password is why this approach
efficiently cracks passwords till today
simply said this assault employs the
same terms that many individuals use as
passwords a hacker can compare the
password hash obtained to hashes of the
password dictionaries to find the
correct plain text password
now that the passwords have been hashed
the hackers attempt to achieve
authentication by breaking the password
hash they accomplish this by applying a
rainbow table which is a set of
pre-computed hashes of portable password
combinations
hackers can use the rainbow table to
crack the hash resulting in guessing
your password
as a result it retrieves a password hash
from the system and eliminates any need
to break it
furthermore it does not necessitate the
discovery of the password itself the
breach is accomplished if the hash
matches
in a Brute Force assault the attacker
attempts multiple password combinations
until the correct one is identified
the attacker uses software to automate
this process and run exhaustive password
combination in a substantially shorter
length of time
with the growth of hardware and
technology in recent years such programs
have been invigorated
it won't be quick if your password is
more than a few characters lengthy but
it will eventually reveal your password
boot Force assaults can be sped up by
throwing more processing resources at
them
with so many different techniques coming
together to correct passwords none of
them are useful without the right tools
there are a pressure of scripts and
Snippets of code that can retrieve
passwords from either encrypted storage
or from the hash digest let's go through
some of these tools
Kane and Abel is a password recovery
tool for Microsoft operating systems it
allows easy recovery of various kinds of
passwords by sniffing the network
cracking encrypted passwords using
dictionary brute force and crypt
analysis attacks recording VoIP
conversations decoding scramble
passwords recovering wireless network
Keys Etc or some of the other features
of k n enable
the latest version is faster and
contains a lot of new features like ARP
poison routing which enables sniffing on
Switched lens and man in the middle
attacks the sniffer in this version can
also analyze encrypted protocols such as
ssh1 and https while containing filters
to capture credentials from a wide range
of authentication mechanisms
it also ships routing protocol
authentication monitors and Route
extractors
dictionary and boot first crackers are
also present along with common hashing
algorithms and several specific
authentications password hash
calculators and other features
John the Ripper is a password tracking
application that was first released in
1996 for Unix based computers it was
created to evaluate password strength
Brute Force encrypted hash passwords and
break passwords using dictionary attacks
it can use dictionary attacks rainbow
tables and other attacks depending on
the target type
rainbowcrack is a password tracking
application that uses time memory
trade-off algorithm to crack password
hashes with rainbow tables
rainbow tables make password tracking
more easier and faster than traditional
Brute Force attacks it is like a
dictionary containing nearly every
possible password and the pre-calculated
hashes
creating this kind of dictionary takes
much more time than cracking a single
hash but after that you can use the same
dictionary over and over again
this procedure might take a long time
however once the table is ready it can
break passwords far quicker than Brute
Force methods
with so many tools ready to NAB our
passwords there are certain set of rules
users can follow to protect their
credentials from being compromised
let's cover some of these guidelines
longer passwords are required making the
Brute Force mechanism tougher to
implement
longer passwords and pass phrases have
been demonstrated to boost security
significantly however it is still
critical to avoid lengthy or passwords
that have previously been hacked or that
feature often in cracking dictionaries
this password policy encourages users to
establish passwords that do not contain
personal information
as previously said most users create
passwords utilizing personal information
such as Hobbies nicknames pet or family
member names Etc
if a hacker has access to personal
information about a specific user for
example via social media they will test
password combinations based on that
knowledge
password regulations should compel users
to distinguish between security and
convenience users should be prohibited
from using the same password for all
services
password sharing between users including
those who work in the same department or
use the same equipment should be avoided
a single breached password doesn't
affect your other accounts with this
policy
some password regulations necessitate
the creation of a passphrase rather than
a password
while passphrases serve the same
objective the length make them more
difficult to break
in addition to letters a good pass
should include numbers and symbols
passwords may be easier for users to
remember than pass phrases however the
latter is much more breach resistant
two-factor authentication or 2fa can
help secure an online account or even a
smartphone
2fa does this by asking the user to
provide two forms of information a
password or a personal identification
PIN and a code texted to the user
smartphone or a fingerprint before
accessing whatever is secured this helps
discourage unauthorized entries to an
account without the original owner's
permission at this point you may wonder
why you need a strong password in the
first place
even if most websites are safe there is
still a danger that someone will try to
access or exploit your information
the strong password is among the most
effective ways to protect your accounts
and personal information from hackers
you should follow certain rules and
guidelines while creating a strong
password
managers are also recommended to help
remember the created passwords for
convenience of usage
with that being said let's take a look
at the topics we are covering today
you start by learning about the state of
password cracking in today's world and
why creating strong passwords is an
absolute must for every account
next we will look at some guidelines and
rules that help strengthen passwords and
make password cracking a daunting task
for hackers moving on we understand why
past faces have gone in popularity and
are being recommended for credential
protection over traditional passwords
and finally we take a look at how
password managers help alleviate the
problem of creating and remembering
complex passwords along with other
critical personal information
let's start by learning about why strong
passwords have become an absolute
necessity
one of the most common ways that hackers
break into computers is by guessing
passwords simple and commonly used
passwords enable Intruders to easily
gain access and control a Computing
device
conversely a password that is difficult
to guess makes it prohibitively
difficult for common hackers to break
into a machine and will force them to
look for another Target
the more difficult the password the
lower the likelihood that once computer
will fall victim to an unwanted
intrusion
many individuals opt to tie their
websites to something they can readily
recall to generally easy memorable
combos however this does not make the
password unique in fact it's the reverse
passwords are handled by 53 percent of
individuals using their Recollections
and memory
with modern computational standards
simple passwords take seconds and a
couple of minutes at worst to be
completely brute forced
according to Global surveys more than 60
percent of people use the same passwords
for their personal and job applications
while this may allow the user never to
forget the password it makes a single
point of failure the only pin to drop if
one of the accounts gets breached all
subsequent accounts are as good as
hacked
to further elaborate on how you can
create strong passwords let's go through
some of the guidelines
let's go through some do's and don'ts to
understand how to create new passwords
for accounts
it is recommended to keep the password
length at least 12 characters to ensure
brute forcing to be difficult
a combination of upper and lowercase
alphabets is an absolute necessity when
creating strong passwords
it is also recommended to use numerix
along with those alphabets to create a
complicated password
finally special characters help in
making a password much more Brute Force
assistant than any number of alphabets
or letters can make
moving over to the Dome section
it's absolutely not recommended to keep
Simple dictionary terms such as computer
or even the word password as your
credential because those are very easy
to be brute forced and are usually
present in majority of the dictionary
attack word list
similarly changing a single alphabet or
a single character in a dictionary word
does not make it boot forces instant
considering there are already algorithms
present that can counter this tactic
using the same character multiple times
in a password also reduces the strength
and makes it easier to crack for hackers
apart from using single characters
multiple times following patterns that
are present on this traditional English
keyboard such as ewerty or the line
below the main alphabet such as the
zxcvbnm
ETC make it easier to guess since these
are once again common combinations that
are present in word list already
finally the most important part being
not using personal information such as
birthdays addresses and other important
information in the passwords more often
than not if a hacker is trying to break
into your account there has been some
amount of research done be it via social
media or any other medium
if they have already this information
present with them breaking into account
becomes all the more easier
now that you understand how to create
strong password look at how passphrases
have become prevalent as a replacement
for plain text passwords
a passphrase is a sentence like string
of words used to authentication that is
longer than a traditional password easy
to remember and difficult to crack
typical passwords range on an average
from 8 to 16 characters while
passphrases can reach up to 100
characters or more using a long fast
phrase instead of a short password to
create a digital signature is one of the
many ways that users can strengthen the
security of their data devices and
accounts the longer a passphrase is the
more likely a user is to incorporate
bits of entropy of factors that make it
less predictable to potential attackers
as more websites applications and
services increase the user security
requirements apostrates is the fast and
easy way to meet these criterias
let's take a look at some of the
advantages that passphrases have over
common passwords
passwords are simpler to remember than
just a random assortment of symbols and
characters
it's easier to comprehend a line from
your favorite song or a quotation than a
short but difficult password
passwords are reasonably easy for humans
and robots to guess or crack online
thieves have also Advanced and created
cutting-edge hacking tools to crack even
the most complex passwords
passphrases are nearly hard to crack
since most efficient password tracking
programs fail at approximately 10
characters
as a result even the most sophisticated
cracking tool will be unable to guess
brute force or pre-compute these
passwords
compliance with password setting rules
with ease pass phases
the usage of punctuation and upper and
lowercase password satisfy the password
complexity criteria
most operating systems and apps support
pass phases
freezes of up to 127 characters are
permitted on all major operating systems
including Windows Linux and Mac as a
result for optimal protection you can
use lengthier passphrases
but when creating a strong password the
major problem people come across is
remembering these passwords or the past
phrases
this is where you can find a use for a
password manager
when you establish accounts or change
passwords password managers generate new
strong passwords and they keep all of
them in one place protected by a single
strong master password
if you maintain your master password the
manager will retain everything else
including your username and passphrases
and fill them in for you whenever you
sign on to a website or app on your
computer or phone
there is no good memory needed for this
implies that everyone may use the most
recent suggestions for strong passwords
such as extended phrases symbols grammar
and capitalization
password managers enable consumers to
write a single master password and
automatically fill each website with
their own unique set of credentials
and not just passwords credit card
information may be stored securely with
several password managers some others
make multi-factor authentication or use
a second test such as answering a
question once the correct password is
input it is a simple and effective
solution to verify legitimate login
inputs
among the global players and password
managers services like bitwarden keep us
and Dashlane have been running for years
now and are very worthy recommendations
if you want to get started with password
management now that we understand what
is hacking let's take a look at some
points to know whether our system is
already high or not
the first point regarding how to check
whether a system is hacked or not can be
cases where the system security is
Switched Off by unknown means and it is
not visible to the user this is one of
the most primary checkpoint to know if a
system is hacked or not
next point to check whether a system is
hacked or not would be frequent
antivirus software failures which are
due to the interference from hacking
attempts performed by a professional
hacker or a cyber Criminal
then we also face problems regarding
systems reaction speed which is affected
due to the execution of unknown
applications in the background of the
system
which also affects the hardware
resources in the device
next we also face problems regarding
passwords which are no longer working or
are changed without the user's
Intervention which might indicate that
there was some unknown hacking activity
that took place in our account
let's take a look at some more points
regarding the topic
there are often cases when the system's
cursor move on its own and perform tasks
indicating that the system is being used
by someone else using an illegal hacking
method there are also cases when we
often see files and folders being
created in the storage disk on the
system
which is unknown to us
to better understand the points
regarding how to identify whether our
system is hacked or not let's take a
look
then let's start with the first point
if we want to check whether a system is
hacked or not the first point would be
to choose the settings option
and using privacy and security and
moving on to the Windows security
this option that is available on our
system allows us to see various
protection applications that are
available on the system
if we see any problem regarding any one
of them for example
apps and browser control in my system it
says there's a problem with it which
might be due to hacking attempts that
was done on my system
now let's take a look at the other
option how we can check whether a system
is hacked or not
that would be checking the antivirus
software that is installed in a system
if you face problems regarding that
this might be the issue
according to my antivirus software it
says my computer is at risk
this might be due to the interference
from cyber criminal or a hacker while
using different illegal software during
its hacking attempt
then there are also cases
where we see there are unknown programs
being executed in the background of our
system
which we can take a look using the task
manager software
using the task manager we can take a
look at each and every application that
is being executed in the system
and see the origin
if we find any unknown program or
application we can assume that it might
be due to a hacking attempt
moving on if we want to check further
whether a system is hacked or not we can
check for files or folders that are
being created or known to us for example
this unknown folder
which contains some security details
that are unknown to me
this might be also due to a hacking
attempt by a hacker or a cyber Criminal
then there are also cases when the
systems cursor move on its own and
perform tasks that are not initiated by
us and performs copying of different
folders or data from one file to other
this is YouTube a hacking attempt that
was done on a system and the hacker has
taken control of a system
then there are also cases regarding
login issues or password problem
for example
if I want to access into my account
and there's a problem with the password
it might be
due to
the attempt of hacking into my account
by a professional hacker
seems like there's a problem with the
username
which means there was a hacking attempt
by a professional hacker
we can further check hacking attempts
by accessing a web browser and checking
whether there's some extra add-ons or
unknown add-ons that wasn't installed by
us this might also indicate a hacking
attempt on the system
now that we are clear about how to check
whether a system is hacked or not let's
take a look at some of the counter
measure against hacking let's begin
the first point regarding how to avoid
hacking is do regular manual Security
checks and keep a system security
updated
using certified antivirus softwares is a
basic countermeasure against hacking
attempts
and if possible visit only secure
websites for surfing on the Internet or
use VPN or other Internet Security
applications to mask your systems
Network to avoid any hacking attempts
for the device
then we have avoid clicking on random
web pop-ups and ads to avoid Hackers
from getting into a system and accessing
a device data
and lastly use strong passwords or
complex passwords for your login details
applying these counter measures we can
avoid hacking to a certain extent
the concept of instant messaging crossed
into the mainstream in the 1990s
allowing friends acquaintances
colleagues and like-minded thinkers from
all over the world to connect in real
time
since then instant messaging has
revolutionized how we communicate and
today over a billion people are signed
up for at least one messaging app the
present instant messaging experience is
seamless and it intuitively integrates
features like video photos voice
e-commerce and gaming with plain old
messaging
among these apps WhatsApp has
comfortably found its place among the
most popular messaging platforms like
everyone associated with the internet a
matter of security is never far away
considering the huge user base of this
messaging app hackers are always on the
lookout for compromised accounts to grab
today we are going to cover some of the
ways we can protect our WhatsApp account
from falling into malicious hands
we start by learning about the
importance of security when it comes to
WhatsApp and instant messaging apps in
general
next we cover some of the most important
steps that should be followed in order
to protect our WhatsApp accounts from
hackers
finally we learn what we should do when
a WhatsApp account gets compromised
let's start by learning why we need to
focus on the safety of WhatsApp
in the year of 2020 the big news was
about Amazon CEO Jeff Bezos and his
phone being hacked by Saudi Arabia
a report coming from the guardian
suggested that Bezos phone was hacked
via a video file sent on WhatsApp
the report said that Bezos mobile phone
was hacked by Saudi Arabian prince in
the year 2018 and gigabytes worth of
data was stolen from the device
well there are some issues being raised
about the report which states with the
medium to high confidence that Jeff
Bezos phone was hacked it does raise a
security fear for regular users after
all if the phone of one of the world's
most powerful men can be hacked the same
can happen to any one of us as well
when it comes to regular users we
exchange messages with a loved ones
regarding a paradigm of topics
the information which may seem trivial
initially can later function as
ammunition for a campaign regarding
identity theft basic information like
preferred Banks occasional dining places
can go a long way in Social Engineering
attacks further increasing the need for
secure messaging habits
WhatsApp uses end-to-end encryption to
protect all communication on its
platform
these encryption keys not only make it
impossible to decrypt messages but they
also prevent third parties and even
WhatsApp from accessing messages or
calls
but not entirely
although end-to-end encryption makes
WhatsApp more secure than other
communication apps no app is 100 safe to
use
like any application or digital device
WhatsApp is often targeted by Bad actors
it also has access to your contacts and
tracks where and how long you use it
putting your privacy and personal
information at risk
we all have access to our cell phones so
it's no surprise that SMS two-factor
authentication is one of the most
widespread types of MFA available you
don't need any apps or digital keys and
it's not tied to a specific ecosystem
unfortunately it's also not a secure
multi-factor authentication method the
nature of SMS itself opens up your
organization to a host of risks hackers
may have many ways to leverage SMS to
find a way into your accounts and
Network
be it via support SIM cards or message
hijacking WhatsApp to fa using SMS isn't
a foolproof solution
now that we understand the variety of
reasons why WhatsApp needs extra
security let's go through some of the
ways we can achieve this
it is more than probable that one fine
day you might receive a WhatsApp message
or even an SMS that reads that your
order is delayed please check its data
here or your account is locked and
please unlock it here or even some
tempting messages like win free 3G and
movie tickets here
some of them may sound intimidating and
some of them may be lucrative but they
all have one purpose to trick you into
clicking that link and once you do that
it's already over it will install
malware on your phone and you won't have
a clue about it only when you start
noticing that your phone bills are
abnormally high or your bank account has
been used without your permission the
realization will Dawn upon you that
something is wrong with your phone but
by then it may be too late
WhatsApp in itself provides various
privacy options to users the messaging
platform provides users with option to
choose who they want to share with their
profile photo status and other details
with
it's a good idea to change the settings
to contacts only this means only phone
numbers that are saved on your
smartphone will be able to see your
profile photo status phone number and
auto delete status as well
make sure you enable the option to lock
the screen every time WhatsApp is closed
this will ensure no one else but you can
open your WhatsApp account just head to
the settings menu privacy and select the
screen lock option you will then need to
register your fingerprint after the
process is completed you will have to
scan your fingerprint every time you
open the WhatsApp app this adds an extra
layer of security
the two-step verification works as an
extra layer of security and helps
WhatsApp users to protect the otps and
documents shared through WhatsApp it's
very easy to set up a PIN to activate a
two-step verification users have to
enter it periodically once it is
activated
WhatsApp will sometimes keep asking
users to enter this six digit passcode
users cannot disable this without
disabling the two-step verification
feature altogether
in case users do not provide WhatsApp
with an email ID and want to disable
two-step verification then the number
will be permitted to re-verify on
WhatsApp without the passcode after 7
Days however the users will lose all
pending messages upon re-verifying
we often have the tendency to log into
WhatsApp web at the office and then
leave the account open on the desktop
this habit can actually create problems
for you someone else sitting on the same
PC can access all your chats without you
even realizing it it's a good practice
to log out from WhatsApp before leaving
the office it just takes a few seconds
to log in again by just scanning the
code and you're done
all WhatsApp users should ensure that
the chats are end-to-end encrypted to
verify that a chat is end-to-end
encrypted open the chat tap on the name
of the contact to open the contact info
screen and then tap encryption to view
the QR code and a 60 digit number
WhatsApp end-to-end encryption ensures
that only you and your contact can read
the messages that are being exchanged
and nobody in between not even WhatsApp
with the necessary guidelines out of the
way let us go through the recommended
course of action should our WhatsApp
accounts be compromised
the first and most important thing that
you need to do is report the issue to
the WhatsApp support team for assistance
make sure that you reach out to the
support team through its help desk and
Report the hacking attempt
WhatsApp help center will take the
shortest time to resolve your issue via
email or within the app itself
this will help you to take prompt legal
action against the hackers if you can't
access your email call the support team
in some cases the support will
deactivate your WhatsApp account and
request you to reactivate it within 30
days if you don't want it to be deleted
completely
when someone compromises your WhatsApp
account they can now send messages to
your contacts stating that the company
sent your verification code and gain
access to the account
that's why one of the first things
you'll want to do is send a message to
your friends and family letting them
know that you've lost access to your
account this action prevents further
exploitation of your account and others
another reason you'll want to let your
contacts know you have no access to your
WhatsApp account is that they may fish
for personal information
from your banking number to your email
address hackers will cleverly attempt to
gain as much access to your personal
information as possible
WhatsApp web is an extension of WhatsApp
messenger over the web that facilitates
easy synchronization of our smartphone
and personal computer
this is the biggest security threat that
hackers can easily exploit to get into
your personal data over WhatsApp
therefore it is highly recommended that
you use this WhatsApp feature carefully
once you notice that your WhatsApp
Messenger has been hacked go to your
WhatsApp web and tap or click on the
logout from all computers option this
will deactivate all the web extensions
of your account
another unfortunate circumstances where
the account recovery doesn't seem likely
you can always ask WhatsApp support to
delete your account permanently
while far from the ideal solution it can
act as a Fail-Safe option if you want to
protect your personal data at any cost
possible you can always open a new
account later with the security issues
mitigated it's no secret that the
majority of our internet usage set the
risk of being hacked be it via unsafe
messaging applications or misconfigured
operating systems counteract this void
of digital security penetration testing
has become the knob when it comes to
vulnerability assessment Kali Linux is
an operating system that has become a
well-known weapon in this fight against
hackers a Linux distribution that is
made specifically for penetration
testers Kali Linux has layers of
features that we will be covering in
today's lesson let's take a look at the
topics to be covered in this video
we start by learning about Kali Linux
and a basic explanation of its purpose
we take a look at the history of Carl
Linux from the story of its origin to
its current day exploits
next we learn a few distinct features of
Kali that make it an attractive choice
for penetration testers worldwide
finally we take a look at the multiple
ways we can install Kali Linux to start
a journey in the world of penetration
testing
let's start by learning about Kali Linux
in general
Kali Linux which is formerly known as
backtrack Linux is an open source Linux
distribution aimed at Advanced
penetration testing and security
auditing
it contains several hundred tools that
are targeted towards various information
security tasks such as penetration
testing security research computer
forensics and reverse engineering
Kali Linux is a multiple platform
solution accessible and freely available
to Information Security Professionals
and hobbyists
among all the Linux distributions Kali
Linux takes its routes from the Debian
operating system Debian has been a
highly dependable and stable
distribution for many years providing a
similarly strong Foundation to the Kali
desktop
while the operating system is capable of
practically modifying every single part
of our installation the networking
components of Kali become disabled by
default this is done to prevent any
external factors from affecting the
installation procedure which may pose a
risk in critical environments apart from
boosting security it allows a deeper
element of control to the most
enthusiastic of users
we did not get Kali Linux since the
first day how did it come into existence
let's take a look at some of its history
Kali Linux is based on years of
knowledge and experience in building
penetration testing and operating
systems during all these project
lifelines there have been only a few
different developers as the team has
always been small the first project was
called wapix which stands for white hat
knopex as can be inferred from the name
it was based on the nopics operating
system as its underlying OS Optics had
releases ranging from version 2.0 to 2.7
this made way for the next project which
was known as wax or the long hand being
white hat slacks the name change was
because the base OS was changed from
gnopics to slacks wax started at version
3 as a Nord at carrying on from mop X
there was a similar OS being produced at
the same time auditor security
collection often being shorted to just
auditor which was once again using
gnopics
its efforts were combined with wax to
produce backtrack backtrack was based on
slackware from version 1 to version 3
but switched to Ubuntu later on with
version 4 to version 5. using the
experience gained from all of this Kal
Linux came after backtrack in 2013. Kali
started off using Debian stable as the
engine under the hood before moving to
Debian testing when Kali Linux became a
rolling operating system
now that we understand the history and
the purpose of Kali Linux let us learn a
little more about its distinct features
the latest version of Kali comes with
more than 600 penetration tools
pre-installed after reviewing every tool
that was included in backtrack
developers have eliminated a great
number of tools that either simply did
not work or which duplicated other tools
that provided the same or similar
functionality
the Kali Linux team is made up of a
small group of individuals who are the
only ones trusted to commit packages and
interact with the repositories all of
which is done using multiple secure
protocols restricting access of critical
code bases to external asset greatly
reduces the risk of source contamination
which can cause Kali Linux users
worldwide a great deal of damage as a
direct victim of cybercrime
although penetration tools tend to be
written in English the developers have
ensured that Kali includes true
multilingual support allowing more users
to operate in their native language and
locate the tools they need for the job
the more comfortable a user feels with
the intricacies of the operating system
the easier it is to maintain a
stronghold over the configuration and
the device in general
since arm-based single board systems
like the Raspberry Pi are becoming more
and more prevalent and inexpensive the
development team knew that kali's arm
support would need to be as robust as
they could manage with fully working
installations
Linux is available on a wide range of
arm devices and has arm repositories
integrated with the mainland
distributions so the tools for arm are
updated in conjunction with the rest of
the distribution
all this information is necessary for
users to determine if color Linux is the
correct choice for them if it is what
are the ways that they can go forward
with this installation and start the
penetration testing Journey
the first way to use Kali Linux is by
launching the distribution in the live
USB mode this can be achieved by
downloading the installer image file or
the ISO file from the Kali Linux website
and flashing it to a USB drive with a
capacity of at least 8 GB
some people don't need to save their
data permanently and a live USB is the
perfect solution for such cases after
the iso image is flashed the thumb drive
can be used to boot a fully working
installation of the operating system
with the caviar that any changes made to
the OS in this mode are not written
permanently some cases allow persistent
usage in live USBS but those require
further configuration than normal
situations
but what if the user wants to store data
permanently in the installed OS the best
and the most reliable way to ensure this
is the full-fledged hard disk
installation this will ensure the
complete usage of the system's Hardware
capabilities and will take into account
the updates and the configurations being
made to the OS this method is supposed
to override any pre-existing operating
system installed on the computer be it
windows or any other variant of Linux
the next alternative route for
installing Kali Linux would be to use
virtualization software such as VMware
or virtualbox the software will be
installed as a separate application on
an already existing OS and Kali Linux
can be run as an operating system in the
same computer as a window
the hardware requirements will be
completely customizable starting with
the allotted Ram to the virtual hard
disk capacity
the usage of both a host and guest
operating system like car Linux allows
users a safe environment to learn while
not putting the systems at risk if you
want to learn more about how one can go
forward with this method we have a
dedicated video where Kali Linux is
being installed on VMware while running
on a Windows 10 operating system you can
find the link in the description box to
get started with your very own virtual
machine
the final way to install Kali Linux is
by using a dual boot system to put it in
simple words the Kali Linux OS will not
be overrating any pre-installed
operating system on a machine but will
be installed alongside it when a
computer boots up the user will get a
choice to boot into either of these
operating systems many people prefer to
keep both the windows and Kali Linux
installed so the distribution of work
and recreational activities is also
allotted effectively it gives users a
safety valve should their custom Linux
installation run into any bugs that
cannot be fixed from within the
operating system now for the convenience
of explanation we're going to install
Kali Linux today on a virtual machine
software known as VMware
VMware is able to run multiple operating
systems on a single host machine which
in our case is a Windows 10 system
to get started with Kali Linux
installation we have to go to the
website to download an image file
we go to get Kali
and as you can see there are multiple
platforms on which this operating system
can be inverted as per our requirement
we're going to go with the virtual
machine section as you can see it is
already recommended by the Developers
this is the download button which will
download a 64-bit ISO file we can
download 32-bit but that is more
necessary for hard metal machines or if
you're going to use it for older devices
which do not support 64-bit operating
systems yet
after clicking on the download button
we can see we have a window archive
which will have the ISO files
for now we have downloaded the ISO file
and it is already present to think so we
can start working on the VMS side of
things
once the ISO file is downloaded we open
up VMware Workstation
go to file
and we create a new virtual machine
in these two options it is highly
recommended to go with the typical setup
rather than the custom one the custom is
much more advanced and requires much
more information from the user which is
beneficial for developers and people who
are well versed with virtualization
software but from 90 of the cases
typical setup will be enough
here we can select the third option
which will be I will install the
operating system later and some
operating systems we can use the ISO
file here directly and VMware will
install it for us but for right now in
the case of Kali Linux the third option
is always the safest
color Linux is a Linux distribution so
we can select Linux over here and the
version as you can see here I have
multiple versions such as the multiple
kernels
every distribution has a parent
distribution for example Kali Linux has
Debian and there are other distributions
which are based or forked from some
parent distribution curliness is based
off Debian so we can go with the highest
version of Debian which is the Debian
10.x 64-bit
go on next we can write any such name we
can write Kali Linux so that it will be
easier to recognize the virtual machine
among this list of virtual machine
instances the location can be any
location you decide to put by default it
should be the documents folder but
anywhere you put it will hold up all the
information of the operating system all
the files you download all the
configurations you store everything will
be stored in this particular location
that you provide
when we go next
we are asked about the disk capacity
this disk capacity will be all the
storage that will be provided to your
virtual machine of Cal Linux think of
your Windows device if you have a one
terabyte of hard drive you have the
entirety of the hard disk to store data
on how much data you give here you can
only store up to that amount of data not
to mention some amount of capacity will
be taken up by the operating system
itself to store its programs and
applications
for now we can give around let's say 15
GB of information or if a recommended
size for type in is 20 you can just go
ahead at 20 it depends all on the user
case if you are going to use it
extensively you can even go as high as
50 or 60 GB if you have plans to
download many more applications and
perform multiple different tests
another option we get over here is
storing virtual disks as a single file
or storing them into multiple files
as we already know this virtual machine
run entirely on VMware
sometimes when transferring these
virtual machine instances let's say from
a personal computer to a work computer
you're going to need to copy up the
entire folder that we had mentioned
before over here
instead all virtual machines have a
portability feature now this portability
feature is possible
for all scenarios except it is much
easier if the split the virtual disk
into multiple files now even if this
makes a reporting virtual machines
easier from either system to system or
software to software let's say if you
want to switch from VMware to virtualbox
or vice versa the performance takes a
small hit it's not huge but it's
recommended to go with storing the
virtual disk as a single file if you
have no purposes of ever moving the
virtual machine even if you do it's not
a complete stop that it cannot be ported
it's just easier when using multiple
files but in order to get the best
performance out of the virtual machine
we can store it as a single file over
here
this is a summary of all the changes
that we made and all the configurations
that have been settled until now now at
this point of time we have not provided
the dot ISO file yet which is the
installation file for the Kali Linux
that we downloaded from this website
as of right now we have only configured
the settings of the virtual machine so
we can press on finish
and we have Kali Linux in the list now
to make the changes further we press on
edit virtual machine settings
the memory is supposed to give the ram
of the virtual machine
the devices with ram of 8 GB odds below
that giving high amount of ram will
cause performance issues and the host
system
if the memory has some amount of free
storage left let's say on idle storage
my Windows machine takes about 2GB so I
have 6 GB of memory to provide although
if you provide all of the 6gb it will be
much more difficult for the host system
to run everything properly so for this
instance we can keep it as 2GB of memory
for the virtual machine instance
similarly we can use the number of
processors and we can customize it
according to our liking let's say if you
want to use One processor but we want to
use two different cores we can select
them as well
hard disk is pre-set up as the SCSI hard
disk and it does not need to be changed
for the installation of this operating
system at all
cdid DVD this is where the installation
file comes
you can think of the ISO file that we
downloaded as a pen drive or a USB thumb
drive which is necessary to install an
operating system to provide this
we're going to select use ISO image file
we're going to click on browse
go on go to downloads and select the Im
so file over here
select open
and we can see it is already loaded up
next in the network adapter it is
recommended to use Nat this helps the
virtual machine to draw the internet
from the host machine settings if your
host machine is connected to the
internet then the virtual machine is
connected as well there are some other
options such as host only or custom
segments or Lan segments but those are
not necessary for installation
rest of them are pretty standard which
do not need any extra configuration and
can be left as it is
press OK and now we can power on this
virtual machine
in this screen we can choose how we want
to proceed with the installation
we have a start installer option over
here
so we're going to press enter on that
you're going to wait for the things to
load from the ISO file
the first step in the installation is
choosing the language of the operating
system
for this we can go with English as
standard
this is a location this will be used for
setting up the time and some of the
internal settings which depend entirely
on the location of the user so for this
we're going to go with India
configuring the keyboard it's always
recommended to go with the American
English first many people make a mistake
of going with the Indian keyboard if it
is possible and it provides a lot of
issues later on so it's always prefer to
go with the American English and if
later we see some necessity of another
keyboard dialect adaptiveness required
we can install it later but for now we
should always stick with American
English as a basic
at this point it's going to load the
installation components from the dot ISO
file it is a big file of 3.6 GB so it
has a lot of components that need to be
put into the virtual machine which can
also be used to detect Hardware
once the hardware and the network
configuration is done by the ISO file we
want to write a hostname for the system
this hostname can be anything which is
used to recognize this device on a local
network or a lan cable let's say if we
use the name Kali
domain name you we can skip it for now
it's not necessary as such for the
installation
this is the full name for the user
let's say we can provide the name as
simply learn as a full name
next we're going to set up a username
this username is going to be necessary
to identify the user from its use root
accounts and the subsequent below
accounts for now we can give it as
something as simply one two three
now we have to choose a password for the
user now remember since this is the
first user that is being added onto this
newly installed operating system it
needs to be a password for the
administrator
we can use whichever password we like
over here
and use the same password below and
press on continue
at this point it's going to detect on
the components on which the operating
system can be installed
like here there are multiple options
like the use entire disk use entire disk
and setup lvm this entire disk and setup
encrypted lvm for newcomers it is
recommended to just use the first one
since lvm encryption is something that
we can learn afterwards when you are
much more Hands-On with the Linux
operating system for now we're going to
use the use entire disk guided
installation and press on continue
when we set up the virtual machine on
VMware we had set up a disk capacity
that we gave our prepares 20 GB that is
the hardest which is being discovered
here even though it is a virtual disk on
VMware it acts as a normal hard disk on
which an operating system can be
installed so we select this one and
press on continue
here there is a multiple partition
system
all the operating systems that are
installed have different components one
is used for the keeping of the
applications one for the files other for
the RAM management and other things for
newcomers it is always recommended to
keep it in one partition
and we're going to select that and press
on continue
this is just an overview of the
partition it's going to make as you can
see it has a primary partition of 20.4
GB and a logical partition of one GB
used for swap memory now these kind of
naming can be confusing for people who
are not well versed with Linux operating
systems or in general virtualization but
for now you can go ahead and press on
continue as this will be fine
we can press on finish partitioning and
write changes to disk and continue
it's just a confirmation page as you can
see it showed that SCSI 3 is our virtual
hard disk of 20 GPS disk capacity
we write the changes to the disk we
press yes and click on continue
at this point the installation has
started now this installation will take
a while depending on the num amount of
ram provided the processors provided and
how quickly the performance of the
system is being hampered by the host
machine on quicker systems this will be
rather quick while on the smaller ones
this will take a while
since this is going to take some time to
install as it is being run on a virtual
machine with only 2GB of RAM we're going
to speed up this part of the video so we
don't have to waste any more time just
watching the progress bar
now that our core installation is
completed it's asking us to configure a
package manager the work of a package
manager on Linux operating system is
similar to the Google Play Store on
Android mobile devices and on the app
store for the Apple devices
it's an interface to install external
applications which are not installed by
default let's say for Google Chrome or
any other browser which can be used to
browse the internet
at this point of time is ask us to
select our Network mirror we're going to
select as yes and move forward with this
next
it's going to ask us for an HTTP proxy
which we can leave it as blank and press
it as continue forward
at this point of time it's looking for
updates to the Kali Linux installation
this will fetch the new builds from the
Kali server so the installation is
always updated to the latest version
now that the package manager is
configured we have the grub bootloader
the grub is used for selecting the
operating system while booting up its
core functionality is to allow the
operating system to be loaded correctly
without any faults so at this point of
time if it has installed the grub
bootloader to your primary drive we can
select this as yes and press continue
remember the installation was conducted
on dev SDA
so we're going to select installation of
the Guard loader on the same hard disk
that we have configured
we press this one and press continue
so now the grub bootloader is being
installed
the grub is highly essential because it
is it shows the motherboard where to
start the operating system from even if
the operating system is installed
correctly and all the files are in
correct order the absence of a
bootloader will not be able to launch
the OS properly
as you can see the installation is
finally complete so now we can press on
continue
and it's going to finalize the changes
now you can see Carl Linux being booted
up straight away it doesn't check for
the ISO file anymore since the operating
system is now installed onto the virtual
hard disk storage that we had configured
before
here we're going to enter our username
and password that we had set up before
and we have the calendar system booted
up
and this is your home page
we can see the installed applications
over here which are being used for
penetration testing by multiple security
analysts worldwide
all of these come pre-installed with
Carl Linux and others can be installed
using the APT package manager that we
had configured
we can see a full name over here
and with this our installation of the
Kali Linux is complete hey everyone
it's no secret that the majority of our
internet usage is at the risk of getting
hacked be it via unsafe messaging
applications or misconfigured operating
systems to counteract this void of
digital security penetration testing has
become the norm when it comes to
vulnerability assessment
is an operating system that has become a
well-known weapon in this fight against
hackers a Linux distribution more
catered towards penetration tester
specifically parent security has layers
of features that we will be covering in
today's lesson
let's take a look at the topics for this
video
we start by learning about what valid
security is and why it should be
considered as a viable alternative next
to call Linux for penetration testers
next we take a look at the minimum
system requirements necessary to obtain
Optimum performance from an installation
of parrot security
moving on we learn about some unique
features that make parrots Stand Out
Among the multiple ethical hacking
operating systems available on the
market
and finally we look at the multiple ways
that parallel security OS can be
installed be it on a single system or
for portable media
so let's start out by learning what
parrot security is
paratos is a Debian based index
distribution with an emphasis on
security privacy and development it is
built on debian's testing branch and
uses a custom hard Linux kernel while
being founded in 2013.
parrot security contains several hundred
tools targeted towards various
information security tasks such as
penetration testing security research
computer forensics and reverse
engineering it has become a
multi-platform solution accessible and
freely available to Information Security
Professionals and hobbies
it features a distinct for n6 mode that
does not Mount any of the system hard
disks or partitions and has no influence
on the host system making it more
stealthy than regular mode this mode is
used on the host system when there is a
need for executing forensic procedures
in software development a rolling
release is a paradigm in which software
upgrades are rolled out constantly
rather than in batches of versions this
ensures that the software is constantly
up to date a rolling release
distribution such as parrot security OS
follows the same concept providing the
most recent Linux kernel and software
versions as they become available on the
market
with a basic introduction to the
operating system out of the way let us
have a look at the bare minimum system
requirements necessary to be able to run
this operating system
first up we got a CPU requirement which
states that a one gigahertz dual core
CPU is the absolute minimum in order to
use parrot OS while multiple core
systems will provide more Optimum
performance a small beginner has been
included
a very distinct thing to be noted is
that the operating system can be
installed on all variants of chipsets
build 32-bit 64-bit and the newly
popular arm portfolio of devices
unlike Kali Linux which requires some
amount of graphical acceleration needed
to display the operating system
correctly paratoos has no such
requirements and can be used with the
leanest of machines
taking into account the ram issue a
minimum of 256 MB to 512 MB free Ram
provides the optimum usage scenarios
even when the OS is installed on a hard
drive storage media it should
theoretically occupy around 8 GB
information which may extend up to 16 GB
depending on the tools being installed
out of the box
when it comes to booting options you
have the option of going with the Legacy
BIOS settings or with the more modern
UEFI settings
these are just some of the requirements
for the installation of parrot security
OS to understand this process more
vividly and to learn how visualization
can help install an OS in our existing
computer please follow the link to our
parrot security installation video
linked right above
let's understand what some of the things
that make parrot security unique among
all the other penetration testing
operating systems
along with all the giant catalog scripts
parent security has its own custom
hardened Linux kernel which has been
modified explicitly to provide as much
security and resistance to hackers as
possible as a first line of defense
the configurations in the operating
system act as a second Gateway taking
care of malicious requests and dropping
them off
this is particularly beneficial since
should there be a scenario where the
latest Linux kernel is causing some
particular issue the paratos development
team will most likely iron it out first
before passing it on as an update
the custom hardened kernel wasn't
reasoning enough parrot security
developers managed to install more
hacking tools and scripts to ensure a
smooth transition for the Kali Linux
users
all the tools you found in Kali are
present in Pirate OS and then a few
extra ones for good measure this has
been achieved while keeping roughly the
same size of the installation file
between both operating systems
however it's not all productivity points
for parrot OS they provide a choice
between two different desktop
environments the main desktop which
comes pre-installed by default and KDE
for those unfamiliar with Linux
terminology you can think of desktop
environments as the main UI for a Linux
system
being highly modular in nature one can
use Kali Linux or parrot OS while adding
another desktop environment which they
find appealing
has only a single option paratos has
managed to provide two optimized bills
with made desktop and KDE desktop
ready-made on their website
one of the primary advantages of parrot
OS over Kali is at its relatively
lightweight
this implies that it takes frequently
less disk space and computing power to
function properly with as little as 320
MB of ram required in reality paratos is
also designed to operate successfully of
a USB stick but Kali Lux does not work
well from a USB stick and is generally
installed in a virtual machine
panel OS can be seen as more of a niche
distribution if you're searching for
something lighter than color Linux there
are multiple ways to go about with this
installation
many people prefer to install it
directly onto a hard disk where the
parrot security OS will overwrite
whichever data the hard disk already has
now this is beneficial if you want to
preserve your data for the long term but
this might pose some trouble to people
who do not have a spare hard disk or do
not want to lose their current
installation of Windows operating system
another way to use parrot security is by
using the live boot but whatever changes
you make to the live boot operating
system those changes are removed the
moment we restart or shut down the
system
a very good Common Ground between both
these installations is virtualization
using virtualization software like
VMware or virtualbox we can install
parrot Security on our systems while
simultaneously saving our data and
having the convenience of a host machine
such as a Windows operating system in
case things go wrong
to start the installation we first need
to get a ISO file for the parrot
security operating system
this can be found in the current website
parrotsac.org
once you enter the website move into the
download section
and select the get security Edition over
here
parent security OS has multiple desktop
environments to you to choose from these
desktop environment serves as a
different user interface for the user
for example right now we have the made
desktop and the KDE desktop as you can
see from the screenshots both of these
look quite different while having a
similar look and feel to them
for our example let's go with the made
desktop
we have two options either we can go
with the direct download or we can get
the torrent file
for this example if we press on the
download button
and our download will start
I have already downloaded this file but
the ISO file provided over here will
serve as an installation it will have
around four and a half GB of space it
will be used to install this operating
system in VMware
once the file is downloaded we can close
this and open VMware Workstation
VMware can also be used as a player
version or the Workstation version if
you have much more familiarity with
using virtualbox or virtualization
application we can use that as well
once the VMware is open
we'll click on file and select a new
virtual machine
for the first time installation we're
going to go with the typical and
recommended installation procedure
instead of an advanced one if you have
already installed multiple virtual
machine OSS going with the advanced
option will give you much more control
over the hardware customization but for
now we're going to stick with a typical
option
moving on it will ask us for a source to
where to install the operating system
from since you're going to use a live
ISO first we're going to select the
third option which will be I will
install the operating system later and
press next
as we already know parent security is a
Debian derivative so When selecting the
guest operating system type we're going
to go with Linux
and the selection we're going to choose
whichever the highest version of Debian
is along with a 64-bit OS
we're going to click on next we're going
to name our virtual machine let's say
parrot security
OS
we're going to select the location where
we want to save the virtual machine this
will have all the hard disk of the
operating system installation
we're going to click on next
for the disk size we're going to specify
how much of the current memory are we
going to allocate this is the hardest
memory of the operating system
installation whatever changes you make
in the operating system whatever
applications will install on the virtual
instance will all be stored in this
amount of memory while it is recommended
to go with at least 15 GB of storage you
can go as high as possible and we're
going to select the recommended 20 GB as
written
when given the choice of storing the
virtual disk as a single or multiple
files many people want to keep their
virtual instance in a way so that helps
them stay portable people change systems
and sometimes they want to swap their
instances between the work and their
personal computer
if there is no portability in mind
storing the virtual disk as a single
file gives the best performance and
should be the recommended go to when
installing for the first time
we click on next here and it's going to
give us a summary of the settings we
have already settled till now
we're going to press on finish
and there we go we have our installation
First Step completed
here on out we're going to click on edit
virtual machine settings
here we're going to have a look at some
of the requirements that the parrot
security OS will need
it is known to be a memory lightweight
operating system but just to have the
almost Optimum performance we're going
to provide around 2 GB of RAM from our
host system which is a Windows 10
machine
when it comes to the processors I'm
going to increase it to 2 and the number
of course to 2 as well so giving out a
total four processor cores to the
operating system now this depends on
what are your computer rig and how much
resources you can justify so these need
to be customized according to the system
at hand
Hardware Sales has already been set at
20 GB and the rest of them are pretty
standard and we can go on
one thing that we need to make sure is
selecting the CD DVD IDE here we have to
use a ISO image file over here
previously it should be used physical
drive and at Auto detect we're going to
use a use ISO image file over here we're
going to click on browse
we're going to go to where we have
downloaded the ISO file which is over
here
and select it
press OK here
and we can now power on this virtual
machine
at this point of time there are two
options we can go with the try install
option using the graphical user
interface or we can go using the
terminal mode
to get a better user experience we're
going to go with the try install mode
specifically press enter
and it's going to start the live boot
ISO meanwhile
VMware has an prompt over here where it
will try to install some VMware tools on
it while this is not mandatory it is
much more recommended to install these
tools so that you can get some
additional features like drag and drop
with a host system and many more things
for now we're going to close this prompt
thank you
as you can see this is the live boot ISO
of the parrot security operating system
currently it's running the mate desktop
as we have downloaded in the website
the live boot ISO is necessary to get a
good feel of the operating system there
are many good Linux distros that have
this live boot option so that you can
give a try of the operating system
before installing it permanently
once you are into the live board we can
start up with the installation using the
shortcut as you can see install parrot
I'm going to double click it
and this is a calamaris installer
choose your language as American English
and press next
you can select your time zone according
to your location
character and we can go next
at this point of time you have to choose
the correct keyboard now what many
people go get confused is choosing their
own language keyboard but people must
keep in mind is what keyboard the laptop
provides
most of the systems that come pre-built
provide the English US keyboard so
whatever keyboard you choose make sure
to type here and test that all the
buttons including the superscript and
the subscript buttons are working
correctly before moving forward with
this step
once you've settled on the keyboard that
you need to install
you can go ahead
here it'll ask you to select storage
device and the only option you are going
to get is the amount of hard disk
storage you have given in the virtual
machine settings we have already
provided 20 GB of storage we're going to
choose that
and we're going to erase this disk
manual partitioning can be useful when
you are going to install parrot Security
on an operating system or on a hard disk
where it is already including a Windows
OS for now we're going to select erase
disk and press next
we're going to give our full name Let It
Be simply learn
you can give the name of the computer
and if this is the username which you
will use to log in
this is your root password that we are
going to give over here the root
password of this Kali Linux will act as
the administrative access and it will be
necessary it will make changes to the
system or installing and updating
software
enter the password
and repeat it over here
you have the option to login
automatically without asking for the
password but for security purposes it is
recommended to keep this disabled
click on next
this is another summary of the
installation that we are going to move
forward with have a look that whatever
changes we have made is according to
your requirements and once everything is
checked we can press uninstall
click on install now
and we're going to let it complete the
work
as you can see the installation of
parrot security is now completed we're
going to make sure that we have the
restart Now button over here disabled
I am going to click on done
we're going to shut down this live boot
ISO
I'm going to click on menu
turn of the device
and shut down
but not restarting straight away because
if you remember correctly in the virtual
machine instance settings we had given
it an ISO file
please remove the live medium and press
enter to continue we can just press
enter to continue
and it's going to shut down now to move
on we're going to click on edit virtual
machine settings
you go into CD DVD and we're going to
use physical drive now
we're going to remove it from the iso
image file because installation has
already been completed and we don't want
to use the same ISO file again and again
by using physical drive over here it's
going to detect the 20 GB hard disk that
we have already provided and
installation is done on it
I'm going to press ok
and we're going to power on this virtual
machine for testing
make sure this you clicky s over here
this is the grub menu
at this we get different choices for
example which NVIDIA drivers off or with
some other Advanced options
more often than not we're going to
choose the first option and press enter
if you remember clearly we did not get
the option of try install or a terminal
run just like we did in the live boot
ISO since this is running straight from
the 20 GB hard drive storage it's going
to start the OS directly
now with the login screen you can see
our username over here as we provided in
the installation
we're going to enter our root password
and press enter
and this is a currently working desktop
of the Paris security operating system
you can open the terminal over here
thank you
and we're going to try our root password
and installation
to install any software we're going to
use the keyword sudo apt
install and Neo fetch
we're going to use the root password
that we use to log in
going to press y for yes
this is just an additional step that
we're doing to check that the
installation is done correctly with the
correct amount of Hardware requirements
that we had provided
now that we have installed a Neo fetch
we can write the command Neo fetch
and this is going to give us some
information about our installation
you can see the OS name as parrot OS
4.11 is running on a VMware host it's
the kernel versions and some of the
other information like the number of
packages installed the current shell
version resolution of the VMware
instance that we are running the desktop
environment which is made as we had
downloaded once
and some other things you can see the
memory is supposed to be 1951 megabytes
which is supposed to equal around 2GB of
RAM usage that we had provided
Gull Linux and parrot os are two popular
by nutrition testing distributions
while these operating systems each have
unique offerings the overall Choice can
differ between Personnel thanks to the
various tools and Hardware
specifications
today we will look at both these
distributions and settle on the perfect
choice for each type of user
let's go through the agenda for this
video
we will learn about Kali Linux and
pirate security Os from scratch while
understanding their primary selling
points as a Linux distribution catered
towards penetration testers
next we know about some features of
these operating systems that stand out
of their package
finally we directly compare Carl Linux
and pirate security OS thereby making a
clear-cut conclusion on which OS is
perfect on a per requirement basis
so let's start by learning about Carl
Linux from a ground level
Kal Linux which is formerly known as
backtrack Linux is an open source Linux
distribution aimed at Advanced
penetration testing and security
auditing
it contains several hundred tools
targeted towards various information
security tasks such as penetration
testing security research computer
forensics and reverse engineering
Kali Linux is a multi-platform solution
accessible and freely available to
Information Security Professionals and
hobbyists
among all the Linux distributions Colin
Linux takes its rules from the Debian
operating system
Debian has been a highly dependable and
a stable distribution for many years
providing a similarly strong Foundation
to the Kali Linux desktop
while the operating system can
practically modify every single part of
our installation the networking
components of Carly Linux come disabled
by default
this is done to prevent any external
factors from affecting the installation
procedure which may pose a risk in
critical environments apart from
boosting security it allows a more
profound element of security control to
the most enthusiastic of users
now let's take a look at parent security
operating system
parent security OS is a Debian based
Linux distribution with an emphasis on
security privacy and development it is
built on the Damian's testing branch and
uses a custom hardened Linux kernel
parrot security contains several hundred
tools targeted towards tasks such as
penetration testing computer forensics
reverse engineering and security
research it is seen as a generally
lightweight distribution that can work
under rigorous hardware and software
specifications
it features a distinct forensics mode
that does not Mount any of the system's
hard disks or partitions and has no
influence on the host system making it
much more stealthy than its regular
occurrence this mode is used on the host
system to execute forensic procedures
a rolling release is a paradigm in which
software upgrades are rolled out
constantly rather than in batches of
versions in software development this
ensures that the software is constantly
up to date a rolling release
distribution such as parrot security OS
follows the same concept
it provides the most recent Linux kernel
and software versions as soon as they
become available
with the basic introduction to the
operating systems out of the way let us
take a look at the unique features of
both Kali Linux and parrot security OS
the latest version of Kali Linux comes
with more than 600 penetration tools
pre-installed after reviewing every tool
included in backtrack developers have
eliminated a significant number of tools
that either simply did not work or
duplicated other tools that provided the
same and similar functionality
the Kali Linux team comprises a small
group of individuals who are the only
ones trusted to commit packages and
interact with the repositories all of
which is done using multiple secure
protocols
restricting access of critical code
bases to external assets dramatically
reduces the risk of source contamination
which can cause Kali Linux users
worldwide a great deal of damage as a
direct victim of cyber crime
although penetration tools tend to be
written in English the developers have
ensured that Kali includes proper
multilingual support allowing more users
to operate in the native language and
locate the tools they need for their job
the more comfortable a user feels with
the intricacies of the operating system
the easier it is to maintain a strong
hold over the configuration and the
device in general
since arm-based single board systems
like the Raspberry Pi are becoming more
prevalent and inexpensive the
development team knew that kali's arm
support would need to be as robust as
they could manage with fully working
installations
Kali Linux is available on a wide range
of ERM devices and has ERM repositories
integrated with the mainline
distribution so the tools for arm are
updated in conjunction with the rest of
the distribution
let's take a look at some of the
features of parrot security operating
system now
along with a giant catalog of scripts
parent security OS has its own Hardware
Linux kernel modified explicitly to
provide as much security and resistance
to hackers as possible in the first line
of defense
the configurations in the operating
system act as the second Gateway taking
care of malicious requests and dropping
them off this is particularly beneficial
since should there be a scenario where
the latex Linux kernel is causing some
particular issue the parrot OS
development team will most likely iron
it out first before passing it on as an
update
foreign
kernel was increasing enough parent
security developers managed to install
more hacking tools and scripts to ensure
a smooth transition for the Kali Linux
users
all the tools you find in Kali are
present in parent OS and a few extra
ones for good measure
and this has been achieved while keeping
roughly the same operating system size
between both of them
however it's not all productivity points
for parrot OS they provide a choice
between two different desktop
environments made which comes
pre-installed by default and KDE
for those unfamiliar with Linux
terminology you can think of desktop
environments as the main UI for a
distribution
being highly modular in nature one can
use parent security OS while adding
another desktop environment that they
find appealing while car Learners has
only a single option parent security has
provided two optimized bills with made
desktop and KDE desktop
one of the primary advantages of parrot
OS over Kali Linux is that it's
relatively lightweight this implies that
it takes significantly less disk space
and computing power to function
correctly with as little as 320 MB of
ram required in reality Paratus is
designed to operate successfully of a
USB stick but Kali Linux does not work
well from a USB drive and is generally
installed in a virtual machine
parrot OS is more of a niche
distribution if you're searching for
something lighter than College
features are great but what about
Performance Real World metrics let us
compare both these operating systems
directly with respect to their Hardware
specifications and usability
in the end we can decide on what
distribution is fit for each type of
user
for a first point of comparison let's
take a look at the ram required
for Optimum performance of the operating
system which is highly essential when
trying to crack hashes or something of
similar nature Prime usage is a very
important facet while College Linux
demands at least 1GB of ram parallel
security can operate optimally with a
minimum of 320 MB of RAM
for correctly displaying graphical
elements Kali Linux requires GPU based
acceleration while this is not the case
with parrot security OS which doesn't
require any graphical acceleration
needed from the user side
once these operating systems are
installed on VMware using their live
boot isos
they take up a minimum amount of
Hardware storage both of these operating
systems have a recommended disk storage
of minimum of 20 GB in Kali Linux and a
minimum of 15 GB in parrot security so
they can install all the tools necessary
in the ISO file
when it comes to the category and the
selection of tools Carl Linux has always
been the first in securing every single
tool available for hackers in the
penetration testing industry Security on
the other hand has managed to take it up
a notch
while specializing in Wireless pen
testing parrot security makes it a point
that all the tools that Kali Linux
provides has been included in the iso
while simultaneously adding some extra
tools that many users will have to
install from third party sources in Kali
Linux
being a decade role penetration testing
distribution Kali Linux has formed up a
very big Community with strong support
signature parrot Security on the other
hand is still growing and it is
garnering much more interest among
veteran penetration testers and ethical
hackers
a primary drawback of Kali Linux is the
extensive Hardware requirement
to perform optimally it requires higher
memory than parallel security it also
needs graphical acceleration while
demanding more virtual hard disk storage
parrot Security on the other hand was
initially designed to run off a USB
drive directly thereby requiring very
minimal requirements from a hardware
perspective like just 320 MB of RAM and
no graphical acceleration needed this
means parrot security is much more
feasible for people who are not able to
devote massive resources to either their
virtual machine or on their laptop hard
disk directly
with the comparison done between both of
these operating systems let's take a
look at the type of users both of these
are catered to
one can go with color Linux if they want
the extensive Community Support offered
by its users if they want to go with a
trusted development team that have been
working on this distribution since many
years
if they have a powerful system which can
run Kali Linux optimally without having
to bottleneck performance
and if they are comfortable with a
semi-professional environment which may
or may not be very useful for new
beginners
one can decide to go with parrot
security if they want to go with a very
lightweight and lean distribution that
can run pretty much on all systems
it also has a lot of tools pre-installed
and some of them are not even present on
car Linux
it is much more suitable for
underpowered rigs where users do not
have a lot of Hardware resources to
provide to the operating system and
thereby it is much more feasible for
people with underpowered laptops or no
graphical acceleration
compared to Kali Linux parrot Securities
desktop environment is also relatively
easier to use for new beginners for
people who are just getting into ethical
hacking parent security does a
relatively better job of introducing
them to the operating system and the
various tools without having to dump
them into the entire intricacies with
ethical hacking and penetration testing
becoming mainstream and corporate
environments trained personal and
relevant equipment are in high demand
the right software framework can be the
Tipping Point in a hacking Campaign
which deals with intricate Hardware
one such tool that has become a Mainstay
for decades is nmap
when it comes to scanning machines for
open ports and services nmap has always
been the first choice for hackers
being lightweight and open source nmap
has strong Community backing and
receives regular updates
let's take a look at the topics to be
covered today
we start by learning about the different
phases in ethical hacking and where nmap
is most valuable to ethical hackers
you learn the basics of nmap and its
purpose during a penetration testing
campaign
next we take a look at the top level
approach of nmap as a scanning tool and
how it conducts these scans on host
machines
moving on
we cover the multiple modes and types of
scans that can be performed using nmap
on unsuspecting users
we also look at some Alternatives that
users can prefer if nmap is not
something they are comfortable with well
a live demonstration of the powers of
nmap will help in shedding light on the
topics being taught today
let us first understand where and why
and map is essential
there are essentially five phases in
ethical hacking
the reconnaissance phase is the first
phase of the penetration test
here the security researcher collects
information about the target it can be
done actively or passively or both
attempt security firms gather
information about the target system
Network components active machines Etc
this activity can be performed by using
the information publicly available and
by using different tools
the scanning phase is more tool oriented
rather than being performed manually
the tester runs one or more scanner
tools to gather more information about
the target
by using various scanners such as war
dialers port scanners Network mappers
and vulnerability scanners the
penetration tester collects as many
vulnerabilities which help in turn to
attack a Target in a more sophisticated
manner
in the gaining access phase the
penetration tester tries to establish a
connection with the Target and exploit
the vulnerabilities found in the
previous phase
the exploitation may be a buffer
overflow attack denial of service attack
session hijacking and many more
basically the penetration tester
extracts information and sensitive data
from the servers by gaining access with
different tools
in the maintaining access phase the
penetration tester tries to create a
backflow for himself
it helps him to identify hidden
vulnerabilities in the system while
allowing him to come back to the system
to retrieve more data further on
in the clearing tax phase the tester
tries to remove all logs and Footprints
which might help the administrator
identify his presence this helps the
tester to think like a hacker and
perform corrective actions to mitigate
those activities
nmap is most beneficial in the early
stages of ethical hacking where a hacker
must figure the possible entry point to
a system it is necessary to know this
before running the necessary exploits
thus allowing the hackers to leverage
any insecure openings and breach the
device
so the reconnaissance and the scanning
phase are the points where nmap finds
the most use
let us now understand what nmap is from
a Layman's perspective
nmap which stands for network mapper is
a free and open source utility for
network discovery and security auditing
many systems and network administrators
also find it useful for tasks such as
Network inventory managing service
upgrade schedules and monitoring hosts
and service uptime
the program is most commonly used via a
command line interface and is available
for many different operating systems
such as Linux free PSD and gento
it is most beneficial in the early
stages of ethical hacking where a hacker
must figure the possible entry point to
a system before running the necessary
exploits
nmap was developed for Enterprise scale
networks and can scan through thousands
of connected devices however in recent
years nmap is being increasingly used by
smaller companies as well
nmap uses raw IP packets in novel ways
to determine what hosts are available on
the network what services these hosts
are offering what operating systems they
are running what type of packet filters
and firewalls are in use and dozens of
other characteristics
it was designed to rapidly scan large
networks but works fine against single
hosts as well the rise of the iot in
particular now means that networks used
by these companies have become more
complex and therefore harder to secure
since every other application that
connects to a network needs to do so via
a port the wrong port or server
configuration can open a can of firms
that leads to a thorough breach of the
system the recent emergence of iot
botnets like Mirai has also simulated
interest in nmap not least because of
its ability to interrogate devices
connected via the UPnP protocol but also
to highlight any devices that may be
malicious
now that we understand what nmap is let
us take a look at the workflow of how an
ethical hacker uses this tool in
penetration testing
at a practical level nmap is used to
provide detailed real-time information
on your networks and other devices
connected to them we have the hacker
running nmap on a system with a victim
machine running a standard installation
of the operating system with Windows Mac
OS or Linux
the nmap interface will send specially
crafted packets to generate some reply
from the victim machine
the victim machine in return will send
some information back to the nmap host
with replying some of the services and
hosts that are being run on the
computers
lmap allows the network admins to find
which devices are running discover some
open ports and other services this in
turn helps discover the vulnerabilities
and the possible entry points for
hackers to breach into
we are now aware of how nmap works on a
basic level
but the many varieties of cans that
users can run on local machines
let's take a look at some of them
the pink sweep is a simple type of nmap
scan where it pings to all the available
IP addresses to check which IPS respond
to icmp protocol
if the users need to know only the
number of IP addresses and not many
details the Ping sweep is very useful
it's fast and hence the results to be
known are fetched very easily
the sin scan is the most useful type of
nmap scan which does work very quietly
it sends an syn packet via the TCP
protocol or the transfer control
protocol to all the intended ports if an
acknowledgment pack is received to the
system it is sure that a port is open
there no response means that the port is
either closed or not available
here the acknowledgment pack is not sent
back to the system assuming that the
connection is not valid
the scan is not shown in most of the
scan logs and hence it is safe to use
syn scan to identify the open ports
the TCP connect scan is similar to syn
scan in many aspects as it uses the TCP
layer to send packets and is passed to
all the ports
here the difference is that the full
connection is done by setting the
acknowledgment packets back
the logs can easily find the TCP scan
and need more power from the machines to
do the work but it is more accurate
if all the access is related to the OS
are available to the user it is better
to do a TCP scan than an SIM scan as all
the low level and high level accesses
are required for the scan the network is
also loaded more and hence users must be
careful about overloading the system and
the networks
the idle scan is really used to check
whether any malicious attacks are
planned on any particular Network
users need not control the external host
but an IP address and a port should be
given to the same
all other requirements are taken from
the scanner itself
the RPC scans or remote procedure calls
are done by hackers to make the system
vulnerable to virus attacks it is thus
necessary to know whether our systems
answer such calls and make our system
open to malware
RPC scan is done to check this by
finding the ports open with certain
commands being run by RPC
the windows scan is a simple scan where
the application scans the acknowledgment
packets received from the post once the
SYM packets are sent if there are any
abnormalities in the ack package
received the scan reports the same and
helps in recognize them which ports are
functioning in a different manner
the bound scan is used to check the
security in the file transfer protocol
layer
FTP layers mostly do not accept any
packets and once it is rejected from the
FTP layers there are chances that it
might be sent to an internal layer so
that it can access the internal machines
pounds can check this loophole by doing
exactly the same process and identifies
whether rftp layout is open to
vulnerability or not
the fin scan is similar to syn scan
where the system that sends the packets
receives the response back and it will
be mostly be a TCP fin packet if the
system sends an rst packet it is a false
alarm and users need not be worried
about the SIM
the null scan is useful for other
systems than Windows where the systems
can easily identify what kind of packets
they have received and respond back with
either TCP packets or not responses
null scans are not useful for Windows as
they may not always produce the desired
results
when it comes to looking at Alternatives
there is a wide range of free network
monitoring utilities as well as free
open source vulnerability scanners
available to network administrators and
security auditors
what makes nmap stand out as a tool ID
and network security managers need to
know is its flexibility and Power
there are some alternatives to nmap but
most of them are focused on providing
specific Niche functionality than the
average system administrator does need
frequently Mass scan for instance is
much faster than Aetna but provides less
detail
in reality however nmap provides all the
functionality and speed that the average
user requires especially when used along
with other similar tools like netcat
which can be used to manage and control
Network traffic and zenmap which
provides a graphical user interface for
nmap but as an all-under solution to
network scanning nobody can go wrong
with nmap as their tool of choice
let's now take a tour of nmap based on
all the things we have covered today
in this live demonstration we start by
learning of how to install nmap on a
fresh operating system that doesn't come
pre-installed with the tool
we also covered the different types of
scans that can be run on local machines
along with checking multiple inferences
on ethical hacker can gather based on
the scan output of an nmap screen
finally we run scans on vulnerable
machines to get an idea of how to
proceed with the outputs We Gather using
this tool if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit skillup by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
the first step in our demonstration is
installing nmap
now it depends heavily on what Linux
distribution you are going to use to
perform ethical hacking
right now I am using parrot security
operating system if you are not aware of
what parrot security is or even what
Kali Linux is we highly suggest that you
check out the videos of those two
operating systems on our YouTube channel
so that you can get a fair idea of what
they serve
now if you are using any of these two
operating systems nmap should come
pre-installed by default
to check if nmap is pre-installed or not
you can just press on applications over
here
go to the pen testing section
go to this information gathering tab
and you should be able to see a map
right here now let's say you do not have
nmap pre-installed enable you using a
Linux distribution like Ubuntu or Linux
Mint or something that is based on
depend operating systems
one thing you have to make sure that
nmap should be in the distribution
Repository
once you check that or even if you do
not know if it is present you can just
this command should be sudo which is to
give root permissions for installation
apt apt is the package manager of all
Linux distributions that are based on
Debian that goes for Debian stable
Ubuntu Linux Mint Kali Linux paired
security and anything of that nature
apt is the package manager which handles
the installation and removal of
applications in these specific operating
systems once you are here just write
install
and and map
press enter and it's going to ask you
for the root password that is sent when
you install the operating system in the
first place
enter your root password and press enter
again as you can see it's saying that
nmap is already installed the newest
version since I am running pirate
security operating system
now should you be running this operating
system or even Gali Linux you should
receive a similar message and the
installation is already done if you are
using some other distribution let's say
even black arcs Arch Linux or Manjaro
anything like that
the installation steps will be slightly
different this sudo apt install nmap
command is for distributions that are
derived from Debian and Ubuntu if you
want to install in Arch Linux based
distributions you have to use their
package manager which is known as pamac
but that is for a different step and if
you want to get an ethical hacking the
best way to start is by learning either
Kali Linux or parrot security
now that the installation is done
we're going to learn how to use nmap one
of the most basic functions of nmap is
to identify active hosts on the network
we can do this by using a ping scan the
ping scan identifies all of the IP
addresses that are currently online
without sending any packets to these
hosts now to run the ping scan we're
going to write and map the flag we're
going to mention over here is sp now
these flags are the different
traits of the nmap scan depending on
what flag we use we can send different
kinds of requests to the host that we
are scanning
now before moving forward with this let
me open another terminal over here and
check the IP address
I'm going to write the command ifconfig
and find the Subnet in which this system
is present
as you can see the IP address is 192.168
0.72.131
now this operating system is being run
on a virtual machine software known as
VMware the VMware in itself is running
on a Windows 10 operating system
considering they are now a part of the
local network this IP address is of
parrot security
and the Windows operating system which
is the host system in my scenario will
fall in this particular subnet
so to run our scan
we're going to Target
192.16
and 72.1 24.
this command then returns a list of
hosts on your network and the total
number of assigned IP addresses
I think it's going to be capital p
yeah
if you spot any host or IP addresses on
that list that you cannot account for
you can then run further commands to
investigate them further
as of right now you can see the machine
that is the parrot security
this IP address can be detected in the
subnet
the
192.168.72.1 is my local Windows machine
that is running VMware software and
ultimately this virtual machine
the 72.2 is the DHCP server that hosts
the internet connection of the parrot
security this we can ignore for now
now the Windows machine that we have
over here let's run some tests on that
I'm going to clear
a terminal
then you can close this actually
when scanning hosts nmap commands can
use server names ipv for addresses or
IPv6 addresses
a basic nmap command
will produce information about the given
host
to run the basic port scan we can just
use nmap along with the IP now as you
remember the IP
is 192.168 72.1 this is the IP of my
local Windows 10 machine
as you can see
it shows the ports that are opened and
the particular service that these ports
are running
now we can also have a detection of the
operating system
now mind you this is not 100 correct and
the reliability depends on the
installation and what kind of
fingerprinting measures are available
now since this does TCP IP
fingerprinting it needs some extra
permissions
the flag that we are going to use is
nmap minus o
along with the same IP address
like I said since this is a TCP IP
fingerprinting it requires root
privileges now to provide root
privileges we're just going to add the
nmap
and sudo keyword
going to repeat the same command that we
wrote above
as you can see it has successfully
detected that I am running Microsoft
Windows 10
with this Mac address
it has also shown the correct build
number of the windows and system that I
am using
this is useful for troubleshooting
scanning for few vulnerabilities or even
locating some services that need to be
updated
now look at the necessary information
about these services for example what
versions they are using we have a
command known as SV which stands for
service version
we use the same IP address
and press enter
now as you can see
the scan is complete and if you can
check the results of the scan above here
we don't see any version number for the
services
here we can actually check what version
they are running now this becomes
helpful when we are trying to find
specific versions to exploit for example
a VMA workstation
16.1.2 had some particular vulnerability
we can exploit it by checking this
command
apart from the host scanning Port
scanning is one of the most basic
utilities there are a few ways that this
command can be customized as well
for example
I have already checked that the 443
command is open
but I have found out after running this
lengthy scan let's say I only want to
check if command if the port 443 is open
and map
I'm going to use the
flag of minus P which stands for Port
and give
443 as an argument here
using the same IP address
and you can see it says it's open
but we already knew it is open let's say
there was something else
if let's say we're going to scan if the
Apache web server port is open which
usually runs on 80.
obviously since I'm not running an
Apache web server it says it's closed
now we can combine these two commands by
running both both simultaneously
to do that we can just put a comma
and complete the rest
similarly
expected it is closed and 443 is open
another feature of nmap for both
scanning is showing of ranges
now ranges can be beneficial when you're
trying to see up to a certain limit for
example nmap minus B we're going to
check what ports are open between 100
to let's say 2000.
this acts as a range
everything else is the same
and it checks all ports in the range of
100 to 2000.
whatever post is open in between that
range it can be mentioned over here
we're going to clear the skin now
another flag that can be used with nmap
is the SS command
this runs a stealth scan which is a
little harder to detect if you're the ID
admin of the system that is being
scan
the results will more or less be the
same although this will need elevated
root privileges
2.1
as you can see this is more or less
similar to a port scan it just adds an
extra mac address as well for good
measure but like I said it's more about
the stealth the normal scans usually are
easier to detect when the logs are being
checked
stealth scans are relatively tougher to
check on much more intricate systems
this takes longer as well
now that we're done with both scanning
let's look at a vulnerable machine
the system that you're scanning right
now is this my own personal system with
everything is pretty locked down as much
as it can be
there is an attack box running
in the cloud the IP address of which is
over here
now to be able to get into this network
we need to connect to their personal
network using a VPN
so what I'm going to do is switch to a
different workspace over here
but open a terminal
and if you can see over here there is a
hacktest.ovpn file
I'm going to connect to their VPN
network using this ovpn file
foreign
sequence completed message we know that
the connection has been established
like we discussed this is the vulnerable
device IP
we're going to copy this
and we're going to try to Ping this
let's open a new terminal
we're going to try to Ping this and
check if we are able to reach this
machine
and as you can see we're getting a reply
back which means we are now part of the
local network
where the vulnerable machine is present
let's run a service scan map
with the respective versions
we run the similar scan on my local
machine where we were able to detect
what version each service was running
what we're going to do over here is by
checking what kind of services are open
on the machine running on the cloud
we're going to decide what we are going
to do next and we're going to see if
nmap alone can point us to a Direction
Where We can gain access to the machine
as you can see the scan is now completed
and we have some of the ports that are
being opened over here and what kind of
service they are running
now
like we discussed this is the first
stage or sometimes even the second stage
of ethical hacking
what we can infer from here is what are
the services that are being run now
these two ports 139 and 445 are actually
Windows SMB server ports which are above
the Windows sambar server
now every service has a particular
attached to it that will be consistent
whichever machine you can use Apache
server will always run on Port 80 SMB
servers will function on these two ports
now assembly servers have had a
vulnerability known as the Eternal blue
exploit which was pretty well known
as of right now from the scan results we
are not able to detect if this machine
has the similar vulnerability or not but
since it has the assembly server open
it's worth a shot that we try that
exploit on this machine
now just start the exploit on this we're
going to open another terminal over here
and we're going to use Metasploit for
trying the exploit there
we're going to write sudo msf console
msf console is the keyword first
launching the Metasploit console
enter the root password and wait for
Mattress plug to Launch
other than the ports we can also see
that it has
check the hostname of the system
and the operating system as well
now that the meta spot is open
we're going to launch the exploit
now before launching we're going to have
to check what exploits are there for the
Eternal blue vulnerability
we're going to write use exploit
blue and we're going to check what kind
of results we are getting over here
as you can see
serial number nine exploit Windows SMB
ms17010 internal blue it was first
disclosed in 2017
and SMB remote kernel pool corruption
let's say we're going to use this
particular exploit now all of this may
be confusing if you're not aware of
Metasploit but remember this is the next
stage of ethical hacking which comes
into the gaining access part
we're going to use
exploit number nine as we found above
to use exploit number nine
we're going to set a payload
which is our malicious code that will
run
on the vector machine
now we're going to check
some options
as you can see it has by default pointed
to the 445 Port since that is the port
where SMB server can be accessed from
the parameter that's missing over here
is our host the r host is the IP address
of the vulnerable machine basically the
machine in which we want to attack
now I am going to use the set command
to set the IP address
now if we check
we now have
a victim IP address set
another parameter that we can change is
the L Host this is basically the IP
address of our own system where we are
going to gain access now if you remember
we had connected using a VPN
so we're going to be assign a new IP
according to the VPN so if we write
ifconfig
and check this one ton0 is the VPN
adapter this is our IP address that we
have been assigned in the server in the
network where the vulnerable machine is
present so we're going to copy this IP
address
we're going to move over this workspace
and we're going to set lhost
with that IP address
with that our options are set now we're
going to run exploit
and it's going to check if Samba server
vulnerability is present
as you can see it has written that the
target is vulnerable to this particular
exploit
it's going to send the malicious code
and the malicious code is set in the
payload that you sent above
and we now have the shell command of the
Windows machine
as you can see see Windows system 32.
to be sure that this is in fact this
Windows machine that is being used we're
going to write ipconfig which is a
Windows only shell command
as you can see
this is the IP address that was assigned
to the victim I victim machine
now
while the major part of this process was
done on Metasploit we would not have
reached the stage had we not found out
that the 139 and 445 ports are open
which basically pointed us that we can
drive the Eternal blue exploit of the
windows Samba servers
similarly
all the scans that we run serve as a
preface to the actual stages or the
actual hacking stages of the campaigns
this SV command was necessary because we
could check what are the exact services
that are being running
in some cases if the if Apache server is
being run there are particular versions
which have particular exploits those
exploits will not work on other versions
so we're going to have to check what
particular version is being run and
accordingly apply the export that can be
done in the matters plot or you can run
some other tool but what exact exploit
you have to run and which vulnerability
we have to Target that is where nmap
comes to help if you are looking to dive
deep into the world of cyber security
then become an expert with postgraduate
program and cyber security so hurry up
and Android now get the complete course
details in the description box if you
are looking to have a smart entry in
this field then simply learn offers a
six months program Caltech cyber
security bootcamp find the complete
course details from the link in the
description box and pin command data
protection is of Paramount importance in
today's world the vast amount of data
flow between corporations and consumer
needs to be secured considering that
they are entrusted with a lot of belief
the company can spend millions of
dollars on the most secure servers but
it takes a single hacker to ruin all the
Goodwill between the organizations
to prevent these malicious attacks many
automated security systems have been
developed but none of them have been as
used as IDs platforms which are also
known as intrusion detection systems
welcome to this introductory lesson on
intrusion detection systems so let's go
through the topics that we are going to
cover today
we started a basic definition of ideas
from a Layman's perspective
and moving on we cover the multiple
types of intruders that seek to access
confidential information without any
authorization
next we cover the basic ways to detect
intrusion signatures from the
perspective of a network administrator
then take a look at the different types
of idea systems that can be used in
corporate environments today
a small explanation of the two types of
protection is Then followed by an
introduction to some of the most
well-known IDs tools on the market
so let's get started with what is an IDs
and intrusion detection system is an app
or device that monitors inbound and
outward Network traffic continuously
analyzing for activity changes and
patterns and alerts an administrator
when it detects unusual behavior
that administrator then reviews alarms
and take action to remove the threat
for example an IDs might inspect the
data carried by Network traffic to see
if it contains node malware or other
malicious content
if it detects this type of threat it
sends an alert to your security team so
they can investigate and remediate it
once your team receives the alert they
must act quickly to prevent an attack
from taking over the system
to ensure that the IDS doesn't slow down
Network performance the solutions often
use the switched Port analyzer or a text
access port to analyze a copy of the
inline data traffic so that they do not
meddle with the actual traffic
however they do not block threat once
they enter the network as intrusion
prevention systems do
regardless of whether you set up a
physical device or an IDs program the
system can recognize attack patterns
with network packets monitor user
Behavior identify abnormal network
activity or ensure user and system
activity do not go against security
policies
the main goal of an idea is to detect
the anomalies before the hackers
complete their objective once the system
detects a threat the IT team is informed
and the information is passed on given
the requirement for understanding
context an Enterprise has to be ready to
make any ideas fit its own unique needs
expert advice what this means is that an
ideas cannot be a one-size-fits-all
configuration to operate accurately and
effectively
and this requires a Savvy IDs analyst to
tailor the ideas for the interests and
needs of a given site
a knowledgeable train system analyst
asks cash the trick with ideas is that
you have to know what the attack is to
be able to identify it
the ideas has always had the patient
zero problem you have to have found
someone who got sick and died before you
can identify it
it can usually go for two types of
protection active protection and passive
in a passive system the IDS detects a
potential security breach logs the
information and signals an alert in a
reactive system or an active system the
IDS responds to the suspicious activity
by logging off a user or by
reprogramming the firewall to block
Network traffic from the suspected
malicious source
so now that we understand what an IDs is
let us go through the different types of
intruders IDs platforms must be aware of
to understand this type of intruders let
us go through a scenario
we have the servers which are protected
by the IDS Platforms in place
so let's say a hacker tries to breach
the system from outside the organization
this can be done using multiple attacks
like DDOS attacks injection attacks Etc
the category of individuals that are not
authorized to use the system but still
export users privacy and confidential
information using different techniques
are known as masqueraders
is an intruder that is an outsider who
does not have direct access to the
system and aims to attack unethically by
stealing data or information
however there is another Intruder who is
theoretically harder to detect and
uproot than a mass grader these are the
people within the organization who want
to weaken the security defenses beat for
corporate Espionage or to Aid other
masqueraders
the category of individuals that are
authorized to use a system but misuse
the granted access and privilege
these are individuals that take undue
advantage of the permissions and give
access to them and this category of
intruders are known as Miss Visa
Miss physios are people that are
insiders and have direct access to the
system which they aim to attack
analytically by stealing data or
information
let us now go through some of the ways
the ideas platforms can detect intrusion
before it is too late
intrusion detection systems primarily
use two key methods one is signature
page intrusion and the anomaly based
intuition
signature based intuition detection is
designed to detect possible threats by
comparing the given Network traffic and
log data to existing attack patterns
these patterns are called sequences and
could include byte sequence which is
also known as malicious instruction
sequences
signature based Direction enables you to
accurately detect and identify possible
lunar tags
anomaly based intrusion detection is the
opposite it's designed to pinpoint
unknown attacks such as new malware and
adapt to them on the Fly using machine
learning machine learning techniques
enable an intrusion detection system to
create baselines of trustworthy activity
which is known as a trust model then
compare new behaviors to verify trust
models
false alarms can occur when using an
anomaly based idea since previously
unknown yet legitimate Network traffic
could be falsely identified as malicious
activity
now if you combine both of those you
have the hybrid intuition detection
they use signature based and anomaly
based intuition detection to increase
the scope of your ideas
this enables you to identify as many
threats as possible a comprehensive
intuition detection system can
understand the evasion techniques cyber
criminals use to trick an IDs to
thinking there isn't an attack taking
place
these techniques could include
fragmentation low bandwidth attack
pattern change deviation and many more
we can now take a look at the type of
protection offered by IDs platforms
there are a couple of ways that can be
set up so let's go through each method
the first is a network based IDs
the sensors are deployed at strategic
points within the network such as within
the DMZ or at the networks perimeter the
sensor can monitor individual packets of
inbound and outbound traffic to and from
all devices on the network
it analyzes them for malicious activity
and depending on the network
architecture and amount of traffic
involved multiple instances of
network-based ideas may be necessary
the second category is host based
intrusion detection systems or HIDs
an agent runs on all servers endpoints
and devices in the network that have
access to both the internet and the
internal Network intuitions identified
by analyzing operating specific
activities like the modification of the
file system registry or Access Control
lists and by monitoring system
application logs as well
the augment network based idea systems
by detecting anomalous traffic which
originated within the organization or
from the host that is being monitored
for example a host infected with malware
that is attempting to spread it to other
internal hosts is an issue that a
network-based ideas could potentially
fail to detect
the third variant is a cloud-based
intuition detection system
because of the internet facing nature of
the cloud on-premises idea Solutions are
not necessarily optimized for monitoring
for example network based sensors need
to be deployed within the cloud at an
advance Network perimeter and yet a
cloud service provider may or may not
have a way to facilitate this
cloud-based servers use purpose-built
cloud sensors that use cloud service
provider application programming
interface or cloud service provider apis
to get as much visibility as possible
into your Cloud environment
now that we understand the different
types of ideas deployment tactics let us
go through some tools that excel in this
field offering top of the line
implementations in a corporate and
consumer environment
the first tool being covered is the
solar wind security event manager
the Solomon security event manager is
designed to integrate real-time log data
from across your infrastructure enabling
it to act both as a network-based idea
system and a host based idea system
the solution can let you discover all
kinds of malicious attacks and help you
protect your network from home
it is also designed to enact both
signature based and anomaly based
intuition detection by comparing
sequences of network traffic against a
set of customizable rules
next we have the McAfee livesafe
macv Live Safe is an intrusion detection
system designed to bring a real-time
threat awareness to your physical and
virtual Networks
it uses signature based intuition
prevention and anomaly based intrusion
detection along with emulation
techniques to spot and identify
malicious activity
McAfee is also built to correlate threat
activity with application usage which
can further prevent network issues
stemming from cyber attacks
next we have blomera
Romero is a security information and
event management platform built to enact
trade detection and responses across
your cloud and on-premises environments
it is designed to continuously monitor
your it infrastructure for suspicious
activity and misconfigurations both of
which could result in data leaks and
compliance breaches
it enables you to respond to an attack
in progress and stop malicious actors in
their tracks monitoring usage of
corporate data and access to privileged
information had been a daunting task
before the Advent of IAM
encompassing numerous apis single
sign-on Frameworks and data handling
policies IEM has established itself as a
key component of every it Department
but how does it enforce these rules and
what are the key benefactors of these
policies
what about the advantages of these
Frameworks and the workflow of these
systems
we are here today to answer these
questions
let's take a look at some of the topics
to be covered today
we start by learning about IAM that is
identity and access management from a
surface level so as to put a clear idea
of what it is next we cover the general
workflow and process of how IAM works
moving on we cover some of the tools
that find the place in an IAM framework
and are crucial components
finally we go through some of the
advantages of the IAM learning what
makes them a lucrative deal for
organizations
so let's get started by learning about
IIM from a surface level perspective
identity and access management or IAM is
a set of processes policies and tools
for defining and managing the roles and
access privileges of individual Network
entities to a variety of cloud and
on-premise applications
the users can include customers Partners
employees devices like computers
smartphones routers Etc
the core objective of IEM systems is one
digital identity per individual or item
once a digital identity has been
established it must be maintained
modified and monitored throughout each
users or devices access lifecycle
access and user are two vital IAM
Concepts access refers to the actions
permitted to be done by a user like view
create or change a file
users could be employees Partners
suppliers contractors or even customers
furthermore employees can be further
segmented based on their roles
IM systems are designed to perform three
key tasks identify authenticate and
authorize
meaning that only the right person
should have access to computers Hardware
software apps any it resources Etc
for the entry of new users or the
changing of the rules of existing users
the list of access privileges must be up
to date all the time IM functions
usually fall under it departments or
sections that handle cyber security and
data management
now that we understand the importance of
IEM in today's cyber security sphere let
us understand the process of this
framework
we have multiple components that Aid
this process let's start by going
through each of them individually
principle is an entity that can perform
actions on an AWS resource or any Cloud
management system a user a role or an
application can be a principle it's
always the principle who raises a
concern to access or modify data on
servers serving as the first point of
contact in the IIM workflow
authentication is the process of
confirming the identity of the principal
trying to access the product
the principle must provides its
credentials or required keys for
Authentication this step can be further
enhanced by multiple authentication
factors and geologs among other things
once the identity is confirmed the
principal has the ability to view the
data behind the wall of security take
the necessary steps
foreign
to the cloud management system
specifying the action and which resource
should perform it
in this step the user can ask to modify
delete edit or affect other users in
this particular Market of organization
by changing the data or the information
when it comes to authorization it
carries out the rest of an organization
identity and access management processes
once the user has been authenticated
users are granted authorizations
according to the role at an organization
the practice is referred to as the role
based access control or rbec
authorizations determine a Rule's
resources and level of access in the
network
these items may include systems
applications file shares printers and
more
for example an accountant Department
employee who regularly works with
payroll software must be authorized to
do such if authentication resembles a
passport these are the things your
digital identity can access with it
an authentication is fully
straightforward authorizations and their
management are far more challenging
authorizations consist of complex set of
rules and policies and groups which are
permitted explicitly configured per user
account
with the working of IM Frameworks out of
the way let's cover some of the tools
that these systems work on
SSO is an im2 that enables a user to log
into one and organization's properties
and automatically be logged into a
design set of other properties
for example when you log into Google you
automatically logged into your Gmail and
your YouTube accounts
similarly for users single sign-on
reduces fiction since they don't have to
keep track of different credentials for
every application for organizations SSO
helps in collecting valuable insights
about user behavior and preferences
since it attacks them as they move from
one application to another connected by
one single login
next is multi-factor authentication or
MFA
implementing multi-factor authentication
is crucial to protect your
organization's data from malicious
intrusions and virtually every IM
platform offers some form of MFA
however it's equally crucial to
customize MFA with the appropriate level
of security
for example in business to Consumer
scenarios you need to consider ux and
try not to create unnecessary friction
for users who don't want to be subjected
to heightened scrutiny every time they
log in
for Workforce IM you may want a more
stringent MFA since the consequences of
an unauthorized party gaining access to
your private Network can be so
devastating
a modern IM solution will allow you to
implement MFA only when it's needed this
can be accomplished through setup
authentication or adaptive
authentication in which users only
trigger MFA if they are trying to access
sensitive data or their behavior is
flagged as risky
in the past few years identity has
become the preferred Gateway for hackers
to break into systems Brute Force
attacks credential stuffing attacks and
even highly targeted phishing campaigns
are all advanced by hackers to break in
through a company's front door which is
the login box
there are multiple ways IM systems can
help detect and mitigate these malicious
attacks IM solutions to Tech attacks
were monitoring signals such as the
velocity of traffic detection of login
patterns that they perform a user's
routine use of a breached password use
of devices and IP addresses with the
poor reputation among other things
these are some of the most widely used
tools when it comes to IM Frameworks but
why do we go through setting up so many
tools and firewalls
let's go through some of the advantages
of using IM systems in both corporate
and consumer environments
IM solution helps identify and mitigate
security risks you can use IM to
identify policy violations or remove
inappropriate access privileges without
having to search through multiple
distributed systems we can also leverage
IEM to ensure that security measures are
in place to meet Regulatory and auditing
requirements
IM provides a common platform for Access
and identity management information you
can apply the same security policies
across all the operating systems and
devices used by the organization the IM
framework can help you enforce policies
related to user authentication
Privileges and validation and attend to
the privileged creep problems
IM simplify sign up and user management
processes for application owners end
users and system administrators it makes
it simple to provide and manage access
and promotes user satisfaction
IM Services can also lower operating
costs using Federated identity Services
means you no longer need local
identities for external users
this makes application Administration
easier cloud-based IM Services can
reduce the need to buy and maintain
on-premise infrastructure most of the
entry-level jobs in cyber security field
requires you to trace track and defend
against cyber attacks on a day-to-day
basis you are required to enable systems
against all Frontline activity and
prevent any authorized access this
requires at length the need to write
scripts in various languages such as
plunk Java JavaScript python SQL PHP
Powershell and C amongst many others as
scripts grow in complexity so does the
time to write them shared GPT on the
other hand can create these complex
queries and scripts within split seconds
along with explaining them this can help
save hundreds of hours of effort for a
cyber security professional this is just
one such use case of how chat GPT is
useful in the field of cyber security
although relatively new the uses of chat
Deputy in the field of cyber security is
innumerable from automating daily tasks
to script writing or endpoint detection
and if you want to know more about how
chatgpt can be used in the field of
cyber security and how I can change the
entire information security landscape
stay tuned with us until the end of this
video for some amazing information
and our first topic is what is chatubity
so chat Jeopardy is an advanced AI model
chat board that uses natural language
processing NLP to understand and respond
to user queries it is based on the GPT
3.5 architecture and has the ability to
learn from conversations with users
making it more intelligent and efficient
over time charity can be integrated with
various messaging platforms such as
slack and Microsoft teams to provide a
seamless and secure communication
experience
so this was about charge repeating
now let's understand the uses of chat
GPT in cyber security
so use of chat GPT for cyber security
will start with number one
we have thread detection and response so
charge GPD can be used to monitor
network activity and identify potential
threats by analyzing logs and data from
various sources chat Jeopardy can
identify unusual patterns and Alert
security teams it can also provide
real-time alerts to users enabling them
to take immediate action to protect
their data by using machine learning
algorithms chat GPT can learn from past
incidents and continuously improve its
ability to detect new and emerging
threads once a thread has been detected
chat GPT can initiate an automated
response or cyber security personal to
take appropriate action this can include
blocking suspicious Network profit
isolating infected systems or disabling
compromised user accounts by providing
real-time threat detection and response
charge GPT can help organizations to
minimize the impact of cyber breaches
and reduce the risk data loss or system
downline it can also help to improve
overall security posture by identifying
vulnerabilities and recommending
proactive measures to address them and
the next we have is password management
one of the most common ways that cyber
criminals gain access to sensitive
information is through weak passwords
jgpt offers a solution to this problem
by assisting users in creating strong
passwords and storing them securely with
its Advanced natural language processing
capabilities chatgpt can suggest complex
and unique passwords that are difficult
for hackers to guess moreover it can
save these passwords in an encrypted
format ensuring that they are protected
from unauthorized access another
important feature of chat chipti's
password management tool is the ability
to remind users to change their
passwords regularly this is crucial as
it helps prevent the use of outdated
passwords that can be easily hacked and
at number 3 we have employee training
many cyber attacks are caused by human
error such as clicking on phishing
emails or using weak passwords
chatgivity can be used to provide
employee training on cyber security best
practices with its ability to simulate
clear life scenarios it can create
interactive training modules that help
employees learn how to identify and
respond to cyber attacks for example it
can provide simulation of phishing
emails when employees can learn to
identify the warning signs and avoid
clicking on malicious links or
downloading harmful attachments next up
we have Incident Management
Incident Management is an essential part
of cyber security as it involves the
process of identifying assessing and
responding to security incidents that
threaten an organization's information
or technology Assets in today's digital
age cyber attacks have become
increasingly common and sophisticated
making Incident Management even more
critical one of the ways chair GPT can
help organizations with Incident
Management is providing step-by-step
instructions on how to contain the
attack mitigate the damage and restore
normal operations when a security
incident occurs time is of the essence
and organizations need to act fast to
minimize the impact of the attack
chargity can help by providing real-time
guidance on how to respond to incident
effectively
and the next we have is compliance
management
many Industries are subject to
Regulatory Compliance requirements such
as hip double e and PCA DSS these
requirements ensure that organizations
adhere to certain standards and
regulations in order to protect the
privacy and security of sensitive
information
failure to comply with these regulations
can result in Hefty fines and
reputational damage charitivity can play
a significant role in helping
organizations and show compliance with
these regulations with its ability to
process large amounts of data in real
time it can provide alerts and guidance
on best practices and generate
compliance reports this can help
organizations identify areas where they
may be falling short of compliance
requirements and take corrective
measures to address them
and now we'll move to Hands-On
demonstration but before moving let's
take a minute to hear from our Learners
who have experienced massive success in
their careers by taking our courses so
just here to remember hi I'm Philip I am
61 years old and last year I upskill
with simply learned postgraduate program
in cyber security after working 30 years
in the IIT sector and various different
profiles I'm happy to tell you that I
was able to clear and pass my cissp and
ccsp certification exams on the first
attempt after taking the course course I
must say was packed with practical
examples it was led by highly skilled
certified instructors I worked with many
companies before the security analysts
and the architect on a contract basis
but I needed some stability which I got
with the job I just started with Infosys
as a cyber security consultant happened
after I took the course first and
foremost I've been a learner be a
learner first
and now first we'll see what is chat GPT
you could just write chargpt on web on
any browser and this is the website
where you will cling and this is the
website for charity
so you could see the samples here
and what the user has asked this this
code is not working like I expect how do
I fix it so we have pasted the over
input the command to chat GPT and pasted
his code and charge available
has answered that it's difficult to say
what's wrong with the code without more
context
so this is how chat GPD responds and
when you just click on here try chat
repeating
you will have the window here so this is
the charge Deputy window and here we'll
start with some Hands-On lab
demonstration
for our cyber security like how chat GPD
can help us in cyber security field so
we'll start with the basic questions and
we'll see what he answers us he or she
answers or what chat GP accesses so
we'll start with the basic question I
explain
the
mitmetic
okay
four beginners
so we will see what it responds
certainly a man in the middle attack is
a type of Cyber attack where an attacker
secretly intercepts and possibly holders
the communication between two parties
without their knowledge
the attacker positions themselves
between the two parties hence the term
man in the middle okay yes giveness a
very good definition
and has a simple explanation of okay
and I want to ask him
can you explain
this to a six
or seven here hold it
so we'll see how chat GPD can mitigate
or just try to understand this concept
to a seven year old
so he has answers and sure imagine you
and your friend have a secret way to
send messages to each other using a
special code to both trust and only you
to can understand the messages but one
day someone sneezing sneaking comes in
between you and your friend without you
knowing they secretly listen to your
messages and even change them without
you realizing it it's like they're
hiding and watching your conversation
the sneaky person can pretend to be you
when talking to a friend
can pretend to be you okay
so he has taken the good example
and they can also print to your friend
when talking to you so you might think
you are talking to a friend but actually
you are talking to a sneaky person bad
things like stealing yourself
and listen to everything you say and
even change or do he has taken a very
good example to get this concept clear
to a seven year old kid really
impressive
so we'll ask him some more questions and
we'll ask the last piece of question
that would be
what is SQL
injection and after that we could ask
him some code Snippets
what is SQL injection and
provide a real life
sample on a standard set so you have to
write these prompts and you have to be
very specific
and you can follow up with your prompts
also when chat Deputy answers you you
can follow up him and ask him more about
it as I have done here first I have
asked him explain the mitm attack for
beginners and he has given me the
definition that is technically
and now I have asked him can you explain
this to seven year old kid and he has
answered me with a very good example
similarly you can do the follow-ups for
any problems so now I'm asking what is
SQL injection and provide a real life
example to understand it
for a big no
and let's see what chat GP answers us so
SQL injection is a type of Cyber attack
when an attack or experts on the Middle
East in a website so he is giving us the
technical
definitions
okay impressive he's also telling us
here's how the attack might work
okay
and he has also suggested us to protect
against SQL injections developers need
to implement proper security measures
so this is the attack that is on the
database that you can read here or if
you know that is very good we are just
checking how chat sheet PD response or
give answers we are not implementing or
like we will ask him the code Snippets
but will not be able to implement in
this video we adjust we are here to just
check out what channel GPT provides us
for cyber security field
so
you can see
he has given us a very good response and
moving on
now we will ask him
or to generate a CTF challenge that
contains a SQL injection let's see
what it answers
foreign
Quest that is shown here's an example of
a CTF that is capture the flag challenge
that involves and SQL injection
vulnerability
challenge title product search Okay
Channel description welcome to the
product search challenge you have access
to an online store search feature you
can find products by typing keywords
your task is to exploit and SQL
injection vulnerability to retrieve
hidden information okay and he has
challenge code retrieve the admin
password from the database
and channel instructions with the
challenge website
find the search box and start searching
again
okay
so we could see the example solution
let's assume the website search
functionality is vulnerable
to SQL injection you can try and putting
the following in the search box okay
explanation the injector SQL statement
ready to always evaluate to True
semicolon and terminal the original
query and the random woman sound
When U is equal to search the modified
query might look like
okay
so it is Nick what response he has given
is very nearby you can have the follow
commands if you want something from him
so we are just checking but it provides
oh he has given a very impressive answer
like truly speaking a very impressive
also
so moving on we'll ask him some other
questions so
okay I will ask him
how can I scan
and I can scan for SMB vulnerabilities
with nmap so I will ask him that okay
and that is it
so let's see
so to scan for SMB you can utilize nmap
scripting engine and a specific SMB
script yes
how you can do it
okay he has given us the steps also
so you could see how chair Deputy guides
you to every process you need
so first we have to install the nmap and
you guys if you are willing to implement
this you can implement this he has given
you all the steps
I won't be implementing as I am just
querying the chat jpd how
you can answer the questions
so install nmap and I then identify
Target and then we have to run this nmap
with SMA script
okay okay
that's good and then review the results
so it's very impressive how chat Deputy
answers to these questions
and now I want him to give me a good
example to check user input for no SQL
injection
so
show me a
code example
check user input
and that would be for no SQL injection
okay certainly when it comes to
preventing no SQL injection the key is
to properly sanitize
and validate user input before using it
and database queries okay that's good
and the specific approach may vary
depending on the programming language
and database system okay but here's a
general code example in JavaScript using
node.js and normal to be okay
okay
this thing
the chat GPT has done is very good yes
explain the whole code like if a
beginner wants to learn and wants to
have some queries result he can just see
like what the function are doing and
what this code really means so in this
example we have sanitized input function
that receives user input and applies a
necessary sanitization or validation
only to prevent nosql injection
it's very good so you could just copy
and use the code
and if it gives you error you can just
have follow-up questions that
will just ask him this code might have
some error
can you rectify
so let's see what charging answers is
apologies for any confusion cost has an
updated code example that addresses
potential errors and clarifies the usage
and you could see that he has given us
I don't think he is
he has changed something and he has
provided us updated code
okay yeah there are some
changes I've seen okay
so in this updated code the Momo DB
connection is closed this is the change
here
and username and perform save query
functions now includes a try catch okay
like if there is any exception or
something
so he has updated the code if you guys
put any error you could just paste the
error here and ask him to rectify it
is very good for cyber security anything
and moving on we will have some more
like queries for jit bidding and we'll
see how it will respond
so we'll write a query
okay we can ask him to filter IP using
spunk
okay
so okay ready
expression
in plunk
to filter ID
let's see
so to filter IP addresses using regular
expression and Splunk you can use the
text command okay yeah we have to use
that
and normal development that matches ipv
for addresses
in this code and you could see that he
has explained what the script means
one command used for extracting field
based on regular Expressions field equal
to row specifies that we want to apply
the regular expression to the row field
which contains the row look data
that is very good
so Deputy is giving us answers like a
pro
so
so we could also ask my Splunk query to
detect command and control the corner
activity using subdomain DNS request
so for that we'll write write us blank
query
detect
command
and control
coding activity
and that will be using subdomain DNS
tests
foreign
works
and the color will display the domains
and he has stated what it will show as
the output so he has also told you that
is make sure to replace your index your
Source time and threshold with the
appropriate values for that environment
that's very good
so you could use this and Implement many
things in cyber security
I am very impressed with that so we'll
ask him one or two more queries and I
also want to check I will give him a
code and let's see if he can find the
errors in that or not
as we have seen on the chair jpt page
okay
so
what we can ask him now is like we can
ask him this script to get malicious IPS
from SIM and block it on my firewall
okay
so we'll ask him generate the script
get
malicious IPS
that is from cyan
and
block it
on my firewall
okay so to General script that reduce
malicious IPS from SIM that is secured
information and even management system
and blocks time on your final you will
need to integrate your SM with your
firewall good and use the appropriate
apis for command spread biofile wood
here's an example of a high level script
that demonstrates the concept
okay so we will just see
mm-hmm
okay he has provided us a good script
and please note that this is a generic
example and the actual implementation
will depend on a specific Sim and
firewall system yeah this is correct
and you will need to replace yeah you
have to replace and ensure that you
understand the ID to documentation and
guidelines provided by SCM and final
vendors for integrating and blocking IPS
good
so you could see like how is helping us
and now
um
I will ask him a last command and yeah
and after that we will ask him to get
extracted some errors from a particular
code and that code would be simple only
so we can ask him
a Shell Code that would execute CMD low
DXE okay
generate Shell Code
that executes
cmd.exe
okay sorry but I can't assist with
generating Shell Code that executes
arbitrary commands or facilitates any
malicious activities my purpose is to
provide helpful and responsible
information to users okay
so you can trick him to give you these
but I think he has been functioned to
not provide these
so no issue
will ask him to generate a macro
see if he responds to
that
generator macro
that exit shoots
CMD dot HC
let's see
okay so it won't give us this answer I
apologize but I won't be able to
generate a macro that execute simply dot
exe or facilitates any potential harmful
activities my purpose is to provide
helpful and responsible information to
users if you have any other malicious
questions or need assistance with a
different topic feel free to ask and I
will reply to a system okay guys so I
think it won't respond to this and now I
will ask him to rectify
some errors and gives the perfect code
and I will provide him a code so I'll
ask him
if I
and
working code
is code snippet
okay so let's see
certainly there are a couple of issues
in the project code snippet and here's
the rectified version
okay I know like
oh yeah I didn't pass data I missed the
brackets also here
and let's see what he has given us so
the line number is modified too
yeah he's passed the data
columns and is connected to
hey
I don't know that was there also the
rectified code now properly reads the
file data calculates the md5 hash and
returns it please ensure to provide the
correct file path and file path okay
that's very good
so I think this is for it and we have
tested the chair GPT how he can help in
like who wants to pursue in cyber
security so we can get the answers we
can write the course and in upcoming
videos we can just make a project using
this and we could have a password
generator
and I know the chair GPT is a tool which
will help us
in every field and in cyber security
field it is helping us a lot
and yeah to some questions it doesn't
answer
like that is for the security purpose or
the script shouldn't be used for
malicious activities so that's why the
software has been programmed for that if
you are looking to dive deep into the
world of cyber security then become an
expert with postgraduate program and
cyber security so hurry up and end all
now get the complete course details in
the description box if you are looking
to have a smart entry in this field then
simply learn offers a six months program
Caltech cyber security boot camp find
the complete course details from the
link in the description box and pin
command today's digital era cyber
security code is a hold button topic
it's also a field with a massive demand
for professionals cyber security has
emerged as a critical field in today's
technology driven world as a digital
Reliance grows for businesses and
governments the demand for cyber
Security Experts has skyrocketed for
those considering a cyber security
degree finding the best university is
crucial for a comprehensive education
and a successful full career in this
video we will explore the world's top
university for cyber security
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
MIT located in Cambridge Massachusetts
stands out as the best university for
cyber security globally its computer
science and artificial intelligence
laboratory csail is a renowned Research
Center with a strong focus on cyber
security
mit's program Embraces
interdisciplinarity involving faculty
from computer science electrical
engineering public policy and more MIT
cyber security program boast exceptional
faculty and offer students SS to
cutting-edge research facilities and
Technology the cyber security and
internet policy research initiative
cipri a research center within MIT
addresses cyber security policy issues
Additionally the MIT Lincoln laboratory
a federally funded research and
development center provides hands-on
experience in technique real-world cyber
security challenges other top
universities for cyber security include
Stanford University in California
Carnage Milan University in Penny
Slovenia and the University of Cambridge
each of these institutions offer a
comprehensive cyber security curriculum
outstanding faculty and access to the
state-of-the-art research facilities as
the importance of cyber security
continues to grow these universities
provide invaluable opportunities to
shape the future of cyber security and
make a significant impact in their
digital landscape but where do you start
if you are considering a career in this
exciting and ever-evolving Industry
right here in this video we'll introduce
you to the best universities for cyber
security in the USA United States of
America let's Jump Right In Here are the
five universities known for their
exceptional University programs and the
number one on the list is Carnage melon
University that is located in Pittsburgh
penis Slovenia CMU is renowned for its
excellence in cyber security education
the information networking Institute the
information networking Institute inih
CMU offers top-notch programs in
information security and cyber security
including Masters and PhD degrees the
programs cover a wide range of cyber
security topics from cryptography and
network security to digital forensics
and incident response CMU strength lies
in its strong focus on practical
application and Hands-On learning the
university is home to the CRT division a
world leading cyber security Research
Center that plays a crucial role in
advancing the field and number two on
the list is Massachusetts Institute of
Technology mid that is based in
Cambridge Massachusetts it's a world
renowned institution known for Cutting
Edge research and Innovation its
comprehensive cyber security program is
offered through the computer science and
artificial intelligence laboratory csail
a Premier Research Center in the AI and
cyber security domains students at MIT
gain a solid foundation in cyber
security Concepts while also benefiting
from the intersection of technology and
management through the Sloan School of
Management specialized program in
information technology and management
this multi-disciplinary approach
prepares graduates to excel in various
aspects of cyber security from technical
implementation to strategic decision
making and here simply learn brings you
the course in collaboration with MIT
that presents an incredible opportunity
to upskill in the field of cyber
security our postgraduate program in
cyber security is designed to equip you
with the expertise needed to thrive in
this rapidly growing industry through
this partnership with MIT schwarzmann
College of computing you will gain
access to world-class resources in
top-notch faculty ensuring a
cutting-edge learning experience and why
should you choose this program so the
number one reason is MIT thought leaders
you will attend live master classes
delivered by distinguished MIT faculty
learning from the best Minds in the
field the next is easy Council benefits
you will gain exclusive access to
learning kits exam vouchers and modules
from Easy Council a leading Authority in
cyber security education then MIT csil
Community you will become the part of
the MIT csail professional programs
community and engage with like-minded PS
and experts then we have industry case
studies you will gain practical insights
from four real-world industry case
studies led by MIT professors don't miss
this opportunity to upskill with the
best and only in a postgraduate program
in cyber security and Propel your career
to new heights with simply learn nmit's
combine expertise secure your future in
the dynamic world of cyber security
today and now number three on the list
is Stanford University that is located
in Silicon Valley and is at the heart of
technology and Innovation Stanford cyber
security programs are part of its
computer science department offering
Masters and PhD degrees with a
specialization in cyber security
Stanford's focus on research and
Innovation is evident through its
pioneering work in areas like
cryptography and secure systems
additionally the center for
International Security and cooperation
ciss at Stanford conducts valuable
research on cyber security policy
Bridging the Gap between technology and
policy considerations and the number
four on the list is Georgia Institute of
Technology Georgia Tech that is situated
in Atlanta Georgia that boasts a robust
cyber security program with a variety of
degree options students can pursue
Masters and PhD degrees in cyber
security or a specialized Masters in
cyber security and privacy Georgia tax
Institute of information security and
privacy iisp is actively engaged in
cutting-edge research across various
cyber security domains the University's
strong emphasis on research and
collaboration with industry Partners
creates ample opportunities for students
to engage in real world projects and now
number five on the list is University of
California Berkeley UC Berkeley that is
located in San Francisco Bay Area offers
a range of cyber Security Programs
through its computer science department
students can pursue Masters and PhD
degrees with a focus on cyber security
gaining a comprehensive understanding of
various cyber security challenges UC
Berkeley Center for long-term cyber
security cltc conducts research on the
societal impact of cyber security
emphasizing the broader implications of
technological advancements in the field
and these universities stand out for the
commitment to Excellence in cyber
security Education and Research each
institution offers unique strengths and
approach opportunities ensuring that
students receive a well-rounded
education and preparation for successful
careers in the dynamic and our evolving
field of cyber security these
universities have consistently
demonstrated excellence in cyber
security Education and Research making
them attractive choices for students
aspiring to build a successful career in
this Dynamic field so there you have it
the top five universities for cyber
security in the USA these schools
provide an excellent start for anyone
looking to make a splash in the cyber
security field and this was all for this
tutorial hope you guys found it
informative and helpful now let's take a
minute to hear from our Learners who
have experienced massive success in
their careers by opting for The Simpsons
postgraduate program that is in
collaboration with MIT Schwartzman
College of computing so importance of
the cyber security certification first
and foremost when I see a certification
I look at it from three different
aspects the first is the training itself
which allows me to gain the knowledge
which allows me to understand the
aspects of of security or whatever the
certification is there for the second
aspect is the exam itself how do I need
to prepare myself for the exam and how
do I need to approach the exam how do I
need to ensure that I pass in my first
attempt and the third aspect is the
certification itself which allows me to
be eligible to apply for a particular
job role so obtaining a cyber security
certification ensures or shows uh to the
organization that you're applying to
that you do have the prerequisite
knowledge and you should be shortlisted
for an interview the knowledge that you
have gained during the training will
help you when you attend that interview
and when you attempt to answer the
questions asked to you so these
certifications are designed for a
specific rule for example a forensic
investigation certificate will teach you
how to investigate a crime scene
forensically a digital crime scene for a
matter of fact a certified ethical
hacking course will teach you about
penetration testing so it is you who's
going to decide which certification you
require and then attempt get certified
on it of course a fresher with the cyber
security certification will have better
employment opportunities because they
can showcase their knowledge with the
certification that they already have
even professionals who want to enhance
their careers can get into manageable or
Advanced certifications to improve on
their knowledge and get promoted in
their job profiles so cyber security
credential certifications can be
classified in three different aspects
the first one being the foundational
level then the managerial level and the
advanced level in the previous video we
just had a small overview here we are
going to discuss about what the
certification covers how the exams are
conducted and the price points for each
and every exam so let's start with the
foundational certifications we start off
with CCNA which is the basic
certification for networking so the CCNA
routing and switching certification
basically it helps you build your
networking career you will join an
organization as a networking engineer
where you can help the organization
establish the routing uh The Parting of
how data package will travel across the
network this certification covers all
the basic concepts that you would
require to understand networking the
basic requirements for this
certification are that the candidate
must have a bachelor's degree but apart
from that there are no other
prerequisites so it's just that you need
a bachelor's degree and then you can
apply uh you can study for this you can
undergo a training and then you can
attempt the exam the certification
provider obviously is Cisco so the
knowledge that is limited to this
training and certification is for Cisco
devices only the exam fees for this
certification is approximately 325
dollars the exam when it is conducted it
has around 50 to 60 odd questions which
need to be answered in 19 minutes the
type of questions that you're going to
get is multiple choice questions where
you have a question and four answers and
you have to choose the correct answers
among those drag and drop where you have
to click on an object and drag it to its
appropriate Place probably a
architectural diagram and you have to
let's say pick on a router and place it
into a particular position in if you
place it correctly you answer the answer
the question correctly otherwise it's
wrong and a simulator where you go where
there could be a configuration you need
to configure it in a particular Manner
and then check whether the configuration
is correct or not the pass Mark is
around 800 to 850 out of a possible
thousand marks so each question will
have a different weightage depending on
the depth of the question depending on
the difficult level of the question or
the difficulty level of the question
which uh would then count towards your
marks and if you score 800 to 850 that's
when you clear the exam the job rules as
we have discussed over here would be
more more on the network administrator
side or a network engineer side
depending on the level of experience
that you have the salaries that are
expected from this job rules in the US
are around fifty five thousand dollars
to ninety thousand dollars annually the
next one is the CompTIA certification
called Security Plus compute is also a
global certification Authority for uh
infosec courses so this certification
teaches candidates on how to secure your
applications networks and devices it
focuses on Hands-On practical skills in
the field of network security I have
trained people on this certification
myself so I know this certification is
quite Hands-On it deals with the
concepts to the core it helps you
understand the concepts and then in the
Practical Hands-On demo you need to
execute the Practical yourself so that
you can gain that knowledge the
recommended level for a candidate to
attempt this training would be at least
around two years of experience in the
I.T sector in addition if you have
already been certified for Network plus
certification from comchia which is the
Baseline networking certification this
is also a preferred way to go for this
certification as said comcha is the
certificate provider and the exam fees
for this certification is 339 dollars
the exam is quite simple 90 questions in
90 minutes that's one minute per
question it sounds like a lot of time
but believe me the questions can be a
little bit confusing can be a little bit
lengthy so you will require all those 90
minutes to answer those questions
Especial when they're tricky and they're
technical in nature the questions would
be multiple choice and Performance Based
the pass Mark for this exam is around
750 points out of a possible 900. the
job profiles for this kind of
certification is when you want to apply
for a security analyst position or a
security Engineers position where you're
going to analyze some data to understand
and figure out what problems are ongoing
in the organization uh the average
annual salary of this person would be
around seventy two thousand dollars then
comes the ceh or the certified ethical
hacker training from EC account shield
now this is a very well known course and
also uh PC council is a global
certifying Authority very well accepted
across a lot of countries uh this is an
offensive certification so here you're
basically trying to become a penetration
tester you're taught how to hack your
taught how to attack a particular
organization from an ethical hackers
perspective so the job profiles that
you'll be looking here are of a pen
tester where you go into an organ
organization you test their security
controls or you'll test their devices
find out flaws within them and then
provide recommendations of how to plug
those flaws or mitigate those flaws and
improve the security of that
organization it is recommended that you
have two years of experience at least in
networking or security for these uh to
attempt this kind of trainings and
certifications again a basic
understanding of networking or maybe a
little bit of applications operating
systems would be necessary before
attempting this certification the
certification provider is EC Council and
the exam fees for this certification is
500 so the exam here would be 125
questions which needs to be attempted in
four hours and you will only get
multiple choice questions in here now
for CE there are two exams one is the
multiple choice questions and the second
is a practical exam where you need to
solve some given problems to you in an
iLab scenario and if you are able to
solve them properly you then get
certified for CE age practical the
cutoff varies from 65 to 85 percent
depending on the questions that you have
answered and the weightage associated
with each and every question as said the
job roles would be as a penetration
tester a security engineer and your
salaries would start from around 90 000
annually then comes the C and D or the
certified Network Defender also from EC
Council now this is more on the network
defense side so here again the job rules
would be where you're where there's a
network that you have and you're going
to try to secure the network and the
communications that are going to travel
over the network so you need to be a
network administrator a network security
engineer or as uh in a similar profile
to understand how networks work and then
you're going to attempt to secure those
networks the certificate provider again
is easy Council and the certification is
placed a little bit below ceh so it
becomes Network defense then ceh where
you're going to become a penetration
Tester the exam fees for this
certification is 350 US Dollars the exam
the exam is of 100 questions to be
answered in four hour was again it's
just a multiple choice questions so you
get a question with four options you
answer the correct one and you move on
to the next question the past percentage
against varies from 60 to 85 percent
depending on the questions answered and
the weightage of that question job rules
to be applied Network defense technician
CND analyst or a security analyst from a
network perspective salaries would range
from 65 000 to 75 000 per annum then
comes the forensic investigator course
which is exactly what it is digital
forensic investigator this will help you
understand how computers work where data
is stored and how you can retrieve that
data to investigate a crime that has
taken place so the candidate must have
at least two years of experience in the
information security sector they need a
good understanding of how networks work
how computers work how operating systems
work how they store data the location
where that data is stored how databases
work how those databases store those
data and so on so forth this
certification is sought after more
mainly in the law enforcement areas but
there are a few corporates that offer
forensic investigation as a service
especially when a corporate gets
compromised and they want to conduct
their own investigations the
certification provider for this is also
EC Council and the exam fees are 500
this is an advanced level certification
so understanding of applications
networks and operating systems is a must
before you attempt this the exam is
quite similar 150 questions in four
hours again it's just a multiple choice
question exam the cutoff again is from
60 to 85 percent depending on the
questions and the weightage of each and
every question job rules I.T security
Specialists network security pro the job
rules forensic investigators law
enforcement agencies security
Specialists homeland security jobs
annual salaries would be around 88 000
and above all right now let's talk about
the managerial level certifications
cobit stands for control objectives for
information and related Technologies
it's a certification that we give a
candidate in-depth knowledge of the
framework which kobit is all about and
the framework helps you manage and
govern Enterprise ID environments now
this is Advanced certification so around
eight years of manageable experiences
suggested before you attempt the kobit 5
certification to understand all the
aspects and to help you implement the
framework properly the certification
certificate provider is isaka the exam
fee is around 175 dollars now this is a
small exam 50 questions but in 40
minutes so you really have to be on your
toes you have to know the knowledge
there is a very limited time to think
and you have to be fast in your answers
the past percentage is 50 the job roles
associated with this certification would
be to when you apply for uh information
security manager or as a security
consultant or a cyber security manager
and your roles and responsibilities
would be the governed an ID space that
the organization owns so all the servers
desktops the network the data flows the
databases everything and how it needs to
be managed and how it needs to be
governed in a secure manner annual
salaries would be around a hundred
thousand dollars plus then the cism also
called as system it stands for certified
information security manager and as the
name suggests it's a security manager
certification it helps the candidate in
understanding the relationship between
business goals and information security
so now you're going into the space where
you're not only technical in nature but
you also have to understand the business
needs the goals of the business and you
have to align the information security
of your infrastructure along with the
business needs and the business goals so
it is your inputs that are going to go
to the management to see if the
infrastructure is aligned to the
business goals or if the infrastructure
or the business goals need any fine
tuning around five years of work
experience is recommended in the
information security field for
attempting the cism out of the five
years the candidate must have a bank
around as an information security
manager for three years so you have some
experience as a manager you have
implemented those things yourselves
which will give you a better
understanding and then you attempt the
certification again providing by isaka
and the exam fees for isaka members is
575 dollars for non-members it is 760
dollars the exam is where you have to
answer 150 questions in four hours uh
quite a bit of time but questions are
going to be scenario based questions
where they're going to give you a lot of
scenarios you have to think about it and
you have to give the most probable and
the correct answer for that particular
scenario the pass Mark is 450 out of
800. your job profiles should be either
a risk manager or a risk consultant
analyzing the business requirements to
the infrastructure security that that
you have and to identify if there any
risks associated with the infrastructure
highlight those risks and then put in
security controls and manage those
controls in a way where security is
mitigated your average salaries would be
around 88 000 and above then the sisa or
the cisa which certified Information
Systems auditor certification it not
only looks into security but it also
looks into auditing and controls uh in
Information Systems this is a highly
reputed certificate and you gain a
better understanding of governance
regulations and auditing your
information landscape again a minimum of
five years of working a work experience
in the field of Information Systems
auditing control or security is
necessary now here the question would be
what's the difference security is where
your technical in nature you have done
let's say a vulnerability assessment or
a penetration test you have implemented
firewalls you have architected security
controls are all about the security
controls that you're going to implement
like firewalls idss ipss data loss
prevention systems maybe even
utms and whatnot so experience in
architecting or implementing those
controls in an effective manner
mitigating your security or your your
vulnerabilities that you have identified
in the organization and auditing would
basically mean about looking at
compliance to ensure that everything is
in place you're compliant with let's say
uh ISO 27001 guidelines or the policies
that you have created yourself and
everything is working in order so it's
more of a checklist where you're going
to just check everything is in place and
you're conforming to standards this
certification is also provided by isaka
and the exam fees for isaka members of
575 dollars whereas non-isaka members
will have to pay 760 dollars for the
certification 150 questions again in
four hours multiple choice questions
scenario based so you have to really
understand this uh real world scenarios
of where what controls and what audit
mechanisms should be in place pass Mark
is 450 out of 800. your job rules would
be mainly becoming an auditor or a
senior auditor or director for
information security information or
audit manager or information technology
consultant where you provide
Intelligence on how the company should
Implement their infrastructure average
salaries would be 103 000 and above then
comes the crisc also called as crisp
certified in risk and information
systems control certification helps the
candidate design and maintain
Information Systems controls for an
organization this is one of the most
sought after certifications as far as
risk management is concerned in Europe
and in us if you have this kind of
certifications you automatically qualify
for a risk manager or a security risk
manager or a information security
consultant kind of role you should have
a minimum of three years of experience
in the field of is controls that means
information security controls you should
have knowledge about firewalls you
should know about how to mitigate risks
how to identify risks in the first place
risk analysis risk management and after
which you're going to implement security
controls to mitigate that risk or bring
it to acceptable levels at this point in
time you will also be responsible to
create policies revolving those risks
and how you want to calculate those
risks and treat those risks in their
lifetime certificate provider again is
the Saka 575 dollars for isaka members
760 dollars for non-isaka members for
the exam fees a similar question 150
questions to be answered in four hours
multiple choice based on performances so
they may give you a scenario where you
have to perform a risk analysis and
provide a report and a solution based on
your findings again the pass Mark is 450
out of 800. the job profile Associated
as discussed earlier are the it risk
management professionals where they're
going to identify risks treat those
risks calculate analyze maybe do a
business impact analysis to a certain
how the organization is going to be
affected and then you will also be
looking at compliances as far as these
job rules are concerned average annual
salary would be 119 000 and above moving
on to advanced level certification now
this this is where we come across the
cissp or the cisp certification
certified information system security
professional this is the gold standard
of all certifications if you have this
certificate it's you can basically be
assured of a job in the IT world now
just to qualify you'll have to have five
years of experience in the information
security field there are eight domains
that are specified by cisp and you have
to prove that you have knowledge and
your work experience of around five
years in at least two of those domains
if you do not have those kind of
experiences you can still attempt the
exam but you become an associate of ISE
Square which means that you get six
years to accomplish the five years of
experience requirement for this
certification before taking up the
certification we suggested that the
candidate clears all the intermediate
level certifications not all but some of
them in fact I have seen people do the
other way around they qualify for cissp
they give the exam once your cisp the
sisa or csum CIA SEO cism exams are way
easier to crack but you need to have
that kind of experience I have seen
people with 15 years of experience and
more fail at this certification in the
first attempt the certificate provider
is IC Square the exam fees is 699
dollars like I said this certification
is most sought after the gold standard
in fact there's hardly any other
certifications after this that you might
want to do the questions now the exam
has changed if it is the English version
that you're giving it's 150 questions to
be answered in three hours if it is the
non-english exam that you're attempting
then it is 250 questions in six hours
it's a marathon and if you're opting for
the six hour exam you need to plan it
really well it sounds really easy but
the questions are quite tough they're
scenario based and the answers are quite
confusing as well you would get multiple
choice questions you would get drag and
drop and you might get simulators as
well uh the pass Mark is 700 out of 1000
but each question has a different way
weightage so it depends on which
questions are asked of you and which
questions you have answered correctly
the job rules associated with this
certification would be anything and
everything in information security at
the managerial level and above so
information security manager risk
manager system uh information system
security officer the CSO role the ciso
Chief Information Security Officer any
role that you might think of as a risk
from a risk compliance strategy could be
achievable after this kind of a
certification the average annual salary
is 108 000 for this certification
technology has become more intertwined
with our daily lives hence it is no
surprise that the need for skill cyber
Security Professionals is on the rise
cyber security is a lucrative field and
there is a dearth of skilled cyber
Security Experts therefore currently a
career in cyber security is something
you should consider if you're looking
for an interesting job role on that note
hey everyone welcome to yet another
exciting video by simply learn which
will take you through the top 10 highest
paying cyber security jobs for 2022 but
before we begin if you are new here and
haven't subscribed already make sure to
hit the Subscribe button and the bell
icon for interesting Tech videos every
day so let's get started
at number 10 we have the job role of a
cyber security analyst
cyber security analysts are
professionals who keep a constant check
on any threat and monitor the company's
Network for potential vulnerabilities
they react swiftly to restore protection
if compromised they identify and correct
flaws uncovered in the company's
applications programs Security Systems
computer networks and more cyber
security analysts even recommend ways to
improve the businesses overall security
and communicate the specific measures to
be taken they compile ongoing safety
reports document security issues and
measures taken to resolve them
now let's have a look at the salary of a
cyber security analyst
according to Glassdoor or cyber security
analysts in the United States earns
about 80 000 US dollars per annum and in
India you can earn nearly 6 lakh rupees
annually
next on our list we have the job role of
a network engineer a network engineer is
a person who understands the structure
and network Essentials of the entire
organization at a macro level
they design and maintain any network
that supports the company's life cycle
and growth opportunities Network
Engineers take charge of the
configuration and installation of
network devices and services
they also collaborate with the security
team and ensure network security through
the implementation of tools and
procedures in line with them
they monitor Network performance and
ensure reliability and availability
according to Glassdoor a network
engineer in the U.S earns over 85 000 US
dollars per annum and in India the
average salary is 4 lakhs annually
moving on the next job role on our list
is that of an ethical hacker ethical
hackers are Network Security Consultants
who identify and exploit system
vulnerabilities just like how a hacker
would do
they are also known as white hat hackers
they scan the network and systems for
vulnerabilities before a black hat
hacker would ethical hackers probe and
Tesla network using various penetration
tools and software
additionally they also design new
penetration tools and document the test
results
according to pay scale in the US a
certified ethical hacker earns around 96
000 on an annual average basis and in
India they make around 5 lakh rupees per
annum
moving to our next job role we have
malware analyst a malware analyst
analyzes malicious software that
includes Bots worms and Trojans to
understand the nature of death threat a
malware analyst has a dual mentality by
being both Forward Thinking and reverse
thinking
moving on to the responsibilities of a
malware analyst firstly they use tools
and expert level knowledge to help
decide what kind of malware they are
dissembling and if they have encountered
this particular kind of malware before
you will use Dynamic malware analysis
tools to achieve insight into software
attacks secondly they also uncover
hidden indicators of compromise that
should be blocked and keep an
organization software updated to protect
against the latest malware threats
according to glassdo in the U.S a
malware analyst can earn about ninety
seven thousand dollars and the average
salary for a malware analyst is around 5
lakh rupees in India
up next we have another very interesting
job role that is information security
analyst
an information security analyst is an
expert who plans implements upgrades and
scrutinizes security protocols to
safeguard an organization's computer
networks and information
these professions play a vital role in
the public private and non-profit
business sectors because a shield
accompanies sensitive and fundamental
information they use data encryption
firewalls and other relevant security
tools and applications to cover and
protect transfers of secret digital
information
information security analysts perform
risk assessments Audits and tests to
ensure the proper functioning of data
processing activities and security
measures
as per Glassdoor the national average
salary of an information security and
list is around 99
000 per annum in the states and as per
indeed.com in India you can earn nearly
7 lakh rupees per random
let's have a look at the next highest
paying cyber security jobs that is cyber
security engineer
a cyber security engineer helps to
design and Implement methodologies to
secure the organization's cyberspace
they also help in testing and monitoring
systems frequently to make sure that all
of the systems are up to date and work
perfectly to defend the information
they troubleshoot security and network
problems and ensure that the
organization's data and infrastructure
are protected by enabling the
appropriate security controls
cyber security Engineers also conduct
tests and scans to identify any
vulnerabilities in the network and
system
talking about the salary in the United
States a cyber security engineer earns
over 101 thousand dollars per annum
as per pay scale the average salary for
a cyber security engineer in India is
nearly 7 lakh rupees
moving on to the next job role we have
senior security consultant a senior
security consultant protects their
clients Network through regular
situational assessments
senior Security Consultants are required
to carry out an assessment of security
networks to sport A System's
vulnerabilities strengths and weaknesses
following which they guide different I.T
teams in strengthening their security by
helping them pick the right Solutions
like new techniques or tools
they also create preventive measures
against future cyber attacks
according to indeed the average annual
salary of a senior security consultant
in the states is around 104 000 and in
India it is nearly 12 lakh rupees
next we have the role of an application
security engineer application security
Engineers work with product managers and
developers to plan and Implement
security releases in order to understand
any vulnerabilities Within products they
carry a threat modeling tests Dynamic
tests and Security reviews
following this they optimize a given
product's efficacy they ensure that
every step of the software development
lifecycle follows best security
practices
they also help in testing the
application against security risks
before release
according to Glassdoor in the US an
application security engineer earns
around hundred and ten thousand dollars
on an annual average basis and in India
they make around 9 lakh rupees per annum
moving on to our next job role we have
security architect a security architect
researchers and plans the security
elements for their firms
they formulate company procedures and
user guides they designed robust
security structures that are capable of
preventing malware attacks
additionally they also approve the
installation of VPN routers and
firewalls
according to Glassdoor a security
architect in the US makes a handsome sum
of 150 000 a year on an average and in
India they make around 20 lakh rupees
per annum
and finally at number one on our list we
have the role of a chief information
security officer ciso
ciso is a senior level officers in an
organization their duty is to ensure the
safety of the information they develop
Implement and maintain information
security and risk management programs
additionally they also interact with
stakeholders and regularly brief them
with information security concerns
according to Glassdoor the average
annual salary of a chief information
security officer in the states is a
whopping 195 thousand dollars and in
India it is 19 lakh rupees per annum
so those were the top 10 highest paying
cyber security jobs for 2022 now let's
have a look at the companies hiring
cyber Security Professionals
here we have Deloitte NetApp KPMG Bosch
HP Samsung CGI and GE to name a few in
this series we are going to discuss
about the interview questions that will
be asked to candidates in the cyber
security field we are going to look at
multiple options over here and we're
going to discuss various fields in which
these questions will be asked
in this video we are going to look at 10
different questions on networking then
we'll have 10 more questions on software
and programming another 20 questions on
operating systems and applications 10
questions on cyber attacks and then the
finally 10 questions on cryptography so
we're going to discuss over 50 odd
questions each in these different fields
which will help you crack your
interviews as far as cyber security is
concerned let's start off with
networking questions let's start off
with question one what is the OSI model
explain the different layers of the OSI
model OSI largely is a theoretical model
uh utilized to understand networking and
how data packets are created and how
they are being processed by a computer
this is normally used by the TCP the
transmission control protocol over
Internet Protocol software suite
so OSI is known as the open systems
interconnection model it is a reference
model that describes how applications
are going to interact via the computer
network
there are seven different layers that we
need to understand they are as follows
so in this diagram there are these seven
different layers we start off from the
bottom first is the physical layer the
data link layer Network layer transport
layer session layer presentation and
application
then such a question is asked in an
interview it is not only that we
identify these seven layers explaining
what the OSI model is in the first place
we then try to identify these seven
layers and we give a brief description
about each and every layer if there are
any additional questions they will come
after this basic question
so let's start off with the physical
layer this is the lowest layer of the
OSI model now this is where any and
every physicality of your computer comes
into the picture so it could be an uh
network interface card it could be an
RJ45 or a CAT5 cable anything that
allows data to be transmitted physically
from your machine to another machine
next comes the data link layer
so on the data link layer as far as
networking is concerned we just need to
understand that data packet is encoded
decoded into bits at this layer this is
also the layer that deals with Mac
addressing so the physical address of
every network interface card which is
the MAC address which is utilized to
Route data package over the network this
is where the MAC address resides on the
data link layer
the next layer is the network layer here
datagrams are transferred from one to
another the function of this layer
routing and logical addressing the
moment we talk about routing and logical
addressing IP addresses come into the
picture IP version 4 IP version 6. so
Network layer will deal with IP
addressing and the routing of those
packets then comes the transport layer
this is the layer responsible for
end-to-end connections that
automatically signifies that this is
where TCP and UDP will be working
TCP stands for transmission control
protocol UDP for user datagram protocol
TCP
is a connection oriented protocol
whereas UDP is a connection ledge
protocol these two Protocols are
utilized to establish connectivity
between two machines
TCP is a more reliable method of
connectivity because there are a lot of
packets that are sent across to verify
that the data has been sent data has
been received and so on so forth whereas
UDP is a connectionless protocol medata
is just dumped without verifying whether
the receiver
actually receives that data or not
so in a nutshell on the transport layer
TCP and UDP make their appearance and
this is where that functionality lies
then comes the session layer
this controls signals between the
computer it establish maintains and
terminates connections between processes
so in the transport layer we talked
about TCP and UDP UDP being a connection
less protocol where data is just
transmitted without verifying whether
the receiver received that data or not
whereas TCP we studied is more of a
reliable protocol thus there are
different packets signals that will be
sent across to verify that data has been
transmitted it has been received
properly and then the next segment of
that data is being sent so those control
signals are established using the
session layer so the three-way handshake
of TCP the acknowledgment packets and uh
those kind of packets will be taken
taken care of on the session layer of
the OSI model
then comes the presentation layer the
presentation layer is responsible to
translate data into the application
layer format so the formatting right
mine or encoding that is being utilized
the utf-8 character set that we utilize
for a presentation encryption mechanisms
all of these work on the presentation
layer
and finally comes the application layer
where
the application itself uses a particular
protocol
so that the other machine on the
receiving end
the application on that machine would be
able to understand what the
communication was about
right so in a nutshell
if I start from up top the application
layer will deal with any of the data
that the application is generating so
maybe an user input you're logging in
you're typing a username password all
that data will be constructed let's say
into an HTTP or https format that's
where your application layer comes into
picture then the formatting of which
into utf-8 and the encryption of which
would be done at the presentation layer
then this transport layer and the
session layer would kick in to establish
a TCP session do the three-way handshake
establish that connectivity IP
addressing would be done on the network
layer Mac addressing would be done on
the data link layer and when everything
is ready on the physical layer the
packet will be sent out at the receiving
end the packet will be received on the
physical layer and then all these layers
will be reversed and finally at the
application layer the data would be
presented to the application who would
then execute it and showcase it on the
screen of the recipient
so this is the way you want to explain
this question you want to be very
concise precise about what you are
explaining you don't want to go into two
hypothetical scenarios you don't want to
delete earlier with the layers you just
want to give the basic functionality you
want to demonstrate that you understand
what the OSI layer is how the computer
functions and you want to move on from
there if the interviewer has any further
follow-up questions they will ask those
specific questions
so that's question one moving on to the
question two
question two is Define unicasting
multicasting and broadcasting
now this is a question which can be very
lengthy but again most of your interview
questions are designed that way it's
basically to understand how much
conceptually you are aware about these
Technologies so you have to be reconcise
don't go rattling about technology too
much
but in a concise manner just try to
explain what these things is so when
data is being transmitted over a network
it can be transmitted either in one of
these particular manners it can either
be a unicast multicast or a broadcast so
what is unicast
unicast is when a message is sent from a
single user to a single receiver so one
to one right so uh one machine talking
to another machine and nobody else so
also known as point-to-point
Communications 1.1 the point if you have
to send information to multiple
receivers then you will have to send it
using multicast
right so this is where your multicast
networking comes into the picture so in
our case let's assume it's a network
where there are there's a Class C
Network approximately 255 odd machines
and Within These there are two machines
that want to talk to each other
if they want to talk between each other
it would be a point-to-point
communication where they will utilize
unicast where only these two machines
will have visibility of that
conversation and the other machines will
not even realize that this conversation
is taking place
if one machine wants to talk to multiple
machines then the multicast comes into
the picture as the name suggests in this
mode of communication data is sent from
one or more or more sources to multiple
destinations multicast uses the internet
group management protocol also known as
the igmp protocol to identify groups so
under this igmp protocol various groups
are created where machines are
subscribed to those particular groups
and whenever a message needs to be sent
through those groups
it will be identified by the igmp
protocol and then that particular
message will be sent to those multiple
machines that are members of those
particular groups
and then comes the broadcast
the third method is known as the
broadcast as it says it is going to
broadcast to all so this is one to all
that is communication between a single
user and it is going to be sent to all
the machines in that particular Network
right so the three ways unicast is one
two one
multicast is one to many
and broadcast is one to all then
question number three
what is DNS DNS stands for domain name
system it is like the internet's phone
book that is responsible for mapping the
domain name
into its corresponding IP address and
let me give you an example over here
whenever we go and open up let's say a
browser a Google Chrome browser we type
in
www.google.com and then we press enter
and magically Google comes in front of
us the website rather
now how does the computer know who
Google is because as far as we are
concerned humans understand Google and
words like that computers don't
computers deal with binary zeros and
ones
right and as far as Internet is
concerned they will only deal with IP
addresses and Mac addresses so how does
a computer know how to find google.com
and where is it located so the moment we
type in in the browser window in the
address bar google.com and press enter a
DNS query is generated automatically by
the browser where a packet is sent to
our DNS servers asking what the IP
address is so in short DNS resolves
domain names to their corresponding IP
addresses there is a DNS server which
will have this index a database of all
the domains associated with their IP
addresses if one particular DNS server
does not have that information that
you're looking for it may query another
DNS server who may have that particular
response so the first thing is when you
type in domain name it gets resolved
with the DNS it identifies the IP
address corresponding to that particular
domain name and thus allows the computer
to route that packet to the particular
server where that domain name resides
so in this scenario if you look at the
screen on the local PC you have typed in
cybersecurity.com there's a DNS
resolution that a query that goes to the
DNS server what is the IP of
cybersecurity.com the DNS server looks
it up in its particular database if it
has the corresponding IP address it will
then respond back the IP address is
172.17.252.1 after which the packet is
sent off to cybersecurity.com moving on
to question number four what is a
firewall
now this is a very good question and
normally a very basic answer that I've
ever heard is that a firewall is a
hardware and a software firewall but
that's the functionality of firewall
that is what how you can install a
firewall but there are different types
of firewalls and there is a specific
functionality that the firewall is
created for right so firewall is either
a hardware or software
but its responsibility is for blocking
either incoming or outgoing traffic
from the internet to your computer they
secure a network so essentially the
firewall will allow a connection to
happen or disallow a connection to
happen it won't go beyond that that's
the basic functionality of a firewall
okay so based on the configurations that
you have done based on the rules that
you have created on a firewall it will
then based on those rules identify
whether some traffic is allowed in that
Network or some traffic is to be blocked
from entering that Network so as the
screen shows
the firewall rules will analyze whether
the traffic is good if yes it will allow
if the traffic is bad it will block the
traffic and not allow that connection
from happening in the first place now
there are few common types of firewalls
that also need to be included in the
answer to this question and the first
one is a packet filtering firewall these
are the most common types that you will
come across which analyze packets and
lets them pass through only if they
match an establish security rule set now
here people do get confused when we say
that we analyze packets people think
that these firewalls will analyze the
contents of that packet which is not
correct
weather definition for a packet
filtering firewall says that these
firewalls analyze packets it means that
they are only analyzing the source and
destination IP addresses port numbers
and the protocols that are mentioned in
those packets these firewalls do not
have the capability of deep packet
inspection or a DPI as it is known if
that capability comes into the picture
you're basically looking at an intrusion
detection system or intrusion prevention
system in today's world called as a
next-gen firewall okay so packet
filtering firewall essentially will only
analyze data package for its source and
destination IP addresses port numbers
and the protocol that is being utilized
it will then map that information to the
rules that are there on the firewall and
based on those rules it will either
allow that a collection to happen or
disallow that connection from happening
the second type of is a proxy firewall
these firewalls filter Network traffic
at the application Level So when you say
application Level they work at the layer
7 of The OSI model package filtering
firewalls since we have mentioned that
did work on IP addressing and port
numbers will work on the network layer
of the OSI model also on the transporter
because we also look at protocols proxy
firewalls will work at layer 7 which is
the application layer of the OSI model
and will deal with application Level
protocols such as HTTP https FTP SMTP
and so on so forth
and the third one is a stateful
multi-layered app inspection firewall
these filter packets are the network
transport and application layers so they
basically do the job of the first and
the second type of firewalls
the packets are compared to loan trusted
packets but now the first question is if
there is a stateful multi-layer
inspection firewall why do we have type
1 and type 2 firewalls like packet
filtering and proxy firewalls that is
because that is how the firewalls have
evolved we started off with a packet
filtering then we added functionality to
it and so on so forth so if a question
comes what is a firewall you start off
with the
option saying it is a hardware or
software this is the responsibility the
functionality of a firewall is to allow
good traffic and disallow bad traffic
based on the rules that have been
configured on the firewall and then
you've got basically three types of
firewalls packet filtering proxy and
stateful multi layer and just include a
brief description of each of these
firewalls if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
then moving on to question number five
what is a VPN
VPN is also called a virtual private
Network it is a connection between a VPN
server and a VPN client
so it basically creates a encrypted
tunnel between the client and the VPN
server which is then utilized to secure
the connections that you are making with
the internet so as you can see in the
diagram
the user has a VPN client installed on
their machine the VPN client then
creates an encrypted tunnel to the VPN
server
and through this tunnel encrypted data
is transmitted which can then be
processed by the VPN server uh sent to
the internet information can receive can
be received backed by the VPN server the
VPN server will encrypt the data back
and send it back to the user so if
there's a man in the middle attack that
is happening or a hacker trying to
eavesdrop on the communication mechanism
they will not be able to do so because
of the encrypted it is very difficult to
decrypt this or hack through this
encrypted tunnel it it is possible but
it is very difficult to achieve that
moving on to question number six what
are the advantages of distributed
processing now before we go into
advantages of distributed processing we
first have to understand what is
distributed processing
so it is a term which describes various
computer systems that use more than one
processor to run an application
here multiple computers across different
locations share the same processor the
advantages of Distributing processes are
as follows but before we go into the
advantages distributed computing is
basically where multiple machines will
pool their resources together to run a
singular application so an application
that has multiple resources and you can
scale up and scale down as and when
required the advantages are that it can
be very very useful in data recovery
for example read where your striping
data on various hard disks it is
reliable it is cheaper lower cost can be
achieved and it is easy to expand
because of the scalability factor that
we just talked about if there is loss of
data in one computer it can then be
recovered by another interconnected
computer and one of the examples would
be blockchain in today's world right
what is blockchain that this data is
created live and stored on a connection
of computer so if one of the computers
goes offline the other computers in that
network will still have that data and
there the blockchain will still function
without any issues the second point a
glitch in one machine does not affect
the processing as there will be multiple
other machines like we discussed in the
blockchain several cost effective mini
computers are used instead of costly or
Mainframe machine so instead of having a
server bank I can have multiple machines
connect interconnected together and they
can function in that particular
blockchain or for that particular
distributed processing mechanic
depending on the amount of data
processing more computers can be
attached to the network thus you can
increase the number of computers that
can be a part of that blockchain or you
can reduce them as and when necessary
moving on to question number seven what
is TCP IP
tcpip or transmission control protocol
over Internet Protocol is a set of
communication protocols that are used to
interconnect networking devices on the
internet this protocol defines how data
should be transmitted over the Internet
by providing end-to-end Communications
so essentially if you want networking to
be established on your machine you will
need TCP
without TCP there will be no work groups
there will be no domains basically your
interconnectivity will go for a toss
tcpip is a software that once installed
on your machine will then interact with
the hardware which is your network
interface cards and then your switches
wires cables and all those through
protocols that have been already
pre-configured in it So within the TCP
Suite of softwares you will have all the
protocols all the functionality of the
OSI layer and each and every protocol
that works on each and every layer will
be predefined and pre-configured to work
in a particular manner the Internet
Protocol is all about routing each
individual packet to make sure it
reaches its destination so with the TCP
you are talking about the protocols that
will allow you to format the data and
generate it so that you can communicate
it over the network the IP will then
deal with the routing of those packets
so that the packet can be routed to the
correct computer and be received by the
recipient
so the TCP model is the compressed
version of The OSI the seven layers will
get converted into four layers the
network access layer internet layer
transport layer and application layer
going on to question 8
what do you mean by ipconfig and if
config both of these are commands the
first one on a Windows machine the
second one on a Linux machine
so ipconfig is known as the Internet
Protocol configuration this is a command
that is used on the command line
interface of Microsoft Windows to view
all the adapters and the configuration
of each and every adapters for their
network interfaces so as you can see on
the right hand side in the command
prompt screen if once you type in the IP
config command on the C prompt and press
enter it will give you a list of all the
adapters that are there
so you can see wireless LAN adapter
local area connection the media is
disconnected it doesn't exist at the
bottom you will see the Wi-Fi connection
wireless LAN adapter and can give you
the IP version 6 IP address IP version 4
address the subnet mask and the default
gateway so this is the configuration
that allows the machine to know on what
network it is on what is the default
gateway for communicating to the
internet what is the subnet mask so how
many computers may exist in that
particular Network and what is the IP
address of that specific computer so
that it can communicate across the
network as well ifconfig is the same
thing on a Linux Mac or Unix operating
system
so the command will also give you the
list of interfaces and the configuration
of each and every interface
it is used to configure control the
tcpip network interface parameters from
the command line interface
it allows you to see the IP address of
these network interfaces so here you can
see uh the
wlp 19s
the IP address being 192.168 43.215
subnet mask being
255.255.255.0 with the broadcast being
192.168.43.255. question 9. what is the
difference between a domain and a work
group this can be a very interesting
question and can be a very lengthy
question at the same time a work group
is nothing but a decentralized network
where you have interconnected multiple
machines together and each machine acts
in its own individual capacity
things of itself as a server right so a
decentralized network you every user
manages the resources individually on
their PC so local users on their own PCS
managing the network shares what can be
shared from that particular machine what
data should be shared should not be
shared to whom it can be shared with and
so on so forth
it is good if you got a small Network a
few machines all together uh and you
want them to interact with minimal
management effort right so each computer
each user will decide what they want to
allow other users to see on that
particular Network and all of them would
be connected over a land a local area
network either a wireless or a wired one
so if you look at your home Wi-Fi right
now that is one of the best examples of
having a work group
the domain on the other hand is a
centralized Network model so in a
corporate environment whenever you go
there and you've got a domain-based
username and password which when entered
onto a particular machine gives you
access to the entire network or whatever
applications and whatever resources have
been allocated to you that is where the
domain comes in so it it also uses a
single sign on mechanism for all the
resources that are that are to be made
Available to You whereas in a work group
your local user only meant for that
particular computer right so coming back
to the domain it is an administrator who
is going to manage the entire domain and
all of the resources connected to the
domain the resources could be switches
routers servers data stores applications
web servers Mail Exchange servers and so
on so forth so all of these are
administered by an administrator through
the domain it is the most reliable and
Optimum solution for a large Network
where multiple users are going to
interconnect and share that data amongst
each other
right the computer can be connected to
any network that means you can be on the
internet and through the internet using
a VPN you can connect to your corporate
Network authenticated and get access to
whatever resources you are allowed to
access whereas in a work group you have
to be a part of that Network to access
that particular network if you change
your location you go and connect to
another Wi-Fi you will lose access to
your previous Wi-Fi then the last
question for the networking section what
is data encapsulation in networking data
encapsulation refers to the process of
adding headers and trailers to the data
the data link layer binds each packet
into a frame that contains the hardware
address of the source and the
destination computer so in this example
when you're talking about data
encapsulation we have talked about how
data that has been created by the
application layer would have a header
and a trailer that will give
the various informations of where that
data needs to be sent so the hardware
address which is the MAC address comes
into the picture and gets added to the
header and the IP addresses port numbers
and all of those things would then be
added to this trailers as well so that
the data can be then routed to the
intended recipient of that particular
communication
with this we end the first 10 questions
in networking and in this video we are
going to look at software and
programming so we're going to look at
the first 10 questions
first question being how do you keep a
computer secure now this is going to be
a very generic question so you want to
put your best foot forward and you want
to identify the most common
methodologies on how you can keep a
computer secure so when we talk about
computers the first thing that you want
to talk about is authentication
mechanisms where you want multi-factor
authentication or two-way authentication
to ensure that your accounts are secured
now if you look at using passwords
depending on how passwords are being
stored by the application password
attacks can be possible either a Brute
Force attack or a dictionary based
attack
or even password guessing attacks are
possible to mitigate those kind of
attacks you will need multi-factor
Authentication
to ensure that accounts are kept secure
now even if we are using multi-factor
authentication we also want to look at
secure passwords which means
that the password is complex enough to
withstand most of the common attacks and
a Brute Force attack or a dictionary
attack is just not possible so we want
to randomize our passwords we want to
create a complexity where a password
meets standards such as me has at least
one lowercase one uppercase character
has numerics and
special characters and is randomized is
not based on a dictionary word doesn't
contain usernames email addresses phone
numbers or anything that is personal to
that particular user third keep regular
updates which means that there will be
patches that will be released for the
application for the software that you
are utilizing download the patches
install them on a regular basis to
ensure that you are secured against the
most recent attacks that have identified
install a good antivirus
could be a Internet Security Suite which
will have an anti-virus intuition
detection system a firewall and will
help you protect yourself against
ransomware's malware and any script
based attacks
also have a specialized firewall on your
system could be a host based firewall or
a network based firewall to ensure that
attacks are kept at a minimum and you
have your network definitions in place
to allow or disallow connections from
happening to your devices
have anti-fishing softwares installed as
well to ensure that you are not getting
any spam mails even if you do you're
able to identify that and not fall prey
or victim to those spam mails phishing
attacks are generic where they are
directed towards individuals
and they prey on the gullibility of that
particular individual so our Nigerian
frauds or the lotteries that we win on a
regular basis of hundreds of million
dollars uh those messages the emails
that we receive they are all phishing
emails where uh they're basically
prone to victimize the user and then Rob
them of money or install some malware
or do some other malicious activity if
you want to enhance encryption about
data that you have stored on your
devices or on your or that is accessed
by your software or being transmitted by
your software use encryption encrypt
your data whether it is at rest whether
it is in motion or whether it is at use
thus reducing data leakage and data loss
possibilities and finally in the
foremost secure your DNS DNS is the
domain name server which is utilized by
computers to resolve domain names to IP
addresses
if a DNS poisoning attack is possible
where your DNS settings have been
modified by an attacker and you're
redirected to a malicious DNS server
that server is going to redirect you to
another malicious application which may
have a malware or a malicious software
as a payload also you don't want people
to know your DNS servers and the queries
that you're making so you want to use
secure DNS or DNS over https to encrypt
your DNS queries as well
so in a nutshell if you follow these
eight steps your devices your computers
your applications are going to be as
secure as possible the next question
discuss security related aspects between
C C plus plus and Java now this is an
open-ended question it depends on which
level you're giving an interview on but
you're looking at it from a fresher's
perspective or a less experienced
perspective and thus these are some of
the aspects that we want to look at and
the comparisons between C C plus plus
and Java so the five aspects that we are
looking at are Pointers core
translations storage allocation
inheritance
and overall security uh based on C C
plus plus n Java so when we say pointers
we are looking at how we are going to uh
we are using pointers and uh stacks and
heaps to point to functions and how we
exit those functions and how those
functions are then recalled into the
next function so C supports pointers it
is most secure C plus plus also supports
Point pointers but it is a little bit
less secure than C Java it is not
supported tarot access is given to
memory allocation and thus it is the
least secure as far as pointers are
concerned when we look at code
translations
see is able to compile but it is not
secure same with C C plus plus but in
Java it is an interpreted language and
it is abstracted and secured in storage
allocation in cvu's malloc and Kellogg
memory allocation uh Which is less
secure because it does not have internal
checks on verifying what memory is
allocated and the user input that is
being compiled or that is being input to
that memory right thus this can allow
buffer overflow errors uh to creep in
because of the uh non-verification of
the input data so it is the least secure
in C C plus plus it uses new and delete
options and is comparatively secure but
Java uses a garbage collector and thus
is the most secure as well as storage
allocation is concerned
when we talk about inheritance
the most secure is CC plus plus C has no
inheritance so it's not secure in C plus
plus it is supported
thus it is the most secure whereas in
Java there is multineritance that is not
supported and thus is comparatively
secure overall the most secure out of
all these based on these five aspects is
Java
the least accuracy
and the mid level is C plus plus moving
on to question 13 what are the different
sources of malware now malware stands
for malicious software right malware is
basically a software that poses as a
legitimate software but has a payload of
atrogen virus spyware keylogger or sub
Malaysia software that is going to have
a negative impact on security of your
particular device
so the question here is what are the
different sources of malware we want to
identify the most common sources through
which malware infect end user devices in
today's world and you can start with
pop-up ads so most of the websites if
you're visiting untrusted sites if
you're being redirected to sites that
you don't know about there will be a lot
of pop-ups coming your way where it says
you're the one millionth visitor to this
site please click here to download your
gift
or it will say uh congratulations on
winning a particular product for
visiting this page and so on so forth
there are some instances where you can
see a banner which is flashing at you on
top of the page and says that there are
eight uh infections that have been
identified on your computer click here
to download an antivirus to clean the
infections so all of these pop-ups
are there as a social engineering attack
as a phishing attack to make gullible
people click on those links and download
those malwares now the software that is
posing as a security software itself can
be a malicious software which is going
to install a Trojan or a virus or a bot
on your machine compromising the
security of that machine
the second is removable media USBS and
humans have a fascination with USB so if
you find a USB lying around it's a free
USB you get excited about it and you
want to take it home you want to plug it
into a machine and see what's on the USB
worst case scenario you format it and
you've got a free USB to utilize higher
the capacity the better but that is one
of the most easiest way people
use malware to uh to be deployed on
unsuspecting users if there is a USB
lying around why would why would
somebody want to forget a USB it's most
likely planted over there as a social
engineering attack so that a gullible
person is going to pick it up plug it
into their device if the device is not
secured enough
it is going to install the malware right
then documents and executable files this
is where your viruses and all those
Creeps in so let's say you're surfing on
the internet you're looking for a
software uh and you find the software on
a particular website you do not verify
the trustworthiness of that site and you
just download and install that software
now that software could be malware as
well thus if you're surfing on the
internet you're downloading files from
different locations you have to research
the website you have to research the
source to ensure that it is trustworthy
and only then are you going to download
and execute those files thus internet
downloads as well and when we say
internet downloads it's not just
untrustworthy sites we go to torrents we
go to uh the dark web or the Deep Web
and we are searching for other softwares
especially those who are researching
security right we always want we are
always on the lookout of new softwares
and we're always on those forums which
may not be so much trustworthy and we
just download those files can start
installing them that is a very bad
scenario right so you have to be very
careful what you are downloading from
the internet your antiviruses your uh
anti-fishing mechanisms you have hit
intelligence mechanisms uh have those uh
mechanisms installed and you want to
verify where your downloads are coming
from then your network connections if it
is a P2P connection it is a local area
network connection or a metropolitan
area network you have to verify whom
which devices are connected to your
machines and you have to validate those
connections before you want to trust
those devices and before you connect to
them
if you're on a public Wi-Fi you probably
don't want to connect to a public Wi-Fi
in the first place
then comes email attachments
there are so many attachments that come
across in today's world most of them in
a zip format or a RAR format uh
some of them come as document files
where there are macros hidden within
them macros are scripts that are
recognized by Microsoft Office files
right and then finally there are these
vanishes advertisements that we find
online right Let It Be Facebook let it
be WhatsApp let it be uh
any social media platform that you go or
even your search engines their job is to
display ads their job is not to verify
whether the ad is legit or not it is for
us as consumers to be careful and
validate that ad and verify whether it
is a genuine ad or not so just don't
start clicking on any of the ad trusting
uh the platform that you're on be be
sure that you are investigating that ad
so these are the most common
sources of malware and the end user
will always get infected by one of these
mechanisms moving on to question 14
how does email work now this is a very
uh
can be a complex question but we have to
keep it as simple as possible and we
have to identify that there are two
servers where both of them either using
SMTP where which is the simple message
transfer protocol where in this scenario
John
wants to send an email thus they've got
an email client installed on their
machine which is connected to the mail
Exchange Server which has a DNS server
which Maps the routing and which maps
The Exchange Server and inboxes so when
John composes that message and clicks on
send John should be connected to a Mail
Exchange Server where the email is sent
through that particular person's inbox
so so John's inbox will then uh be
validated and that email will then be
sent through the DNS server uh through
the internet and will be received by the
recipient mail server so at this point
in time John also requires the
recipient's email address so in this
case this is Jack so Jack at
something.com would be uh the email
address so while John is composing the
two field will have Jack's email address
the from field will have John's email
address the subject field will have
whatever they want to convey as a
message the message body will have the
message itself and then when John clicks
on send it will go to Direction server
the extension server will then validate
the Inbox and identify where that inbox
is located for Jack and then to the
internet it will be sent to the email to
the mail server of Jack the mail server
will then identify the proper
that that email is to be sent to and it
will store that email in that particular
inbox when Jack opens their computer and
accesses their inbox this email from
John will be already waiting for them
and they can respond to it the same way
John had sent that email if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
skillup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
moving on to question 15 what are the
types of threads a company can face
right and this is where your threat
modeling comes into the picture so
you're looking at softwares you're
looking at operating systems and the
company comes and asks you uh what are
the threats that are most likely that a
company will face so on a broader scale
the threats that a company will always
face would be classified as natural
threats man-made threads technical
threats and a supply system threat so a
natural threat would be an act of God
which is outside the control of human
beings could be storms or any natural
occurrences like volcanoes
thunderstorms flooding earthquakes fire
and so on so forth so anything that is
natural so it depends on the geographic
location that you're in and what kind of
climate that area faces and you need to
identify the immediate threats
and prepare for them so if it is
flooding that you're looking at and you
want to look at an office uh and the
possibility of the office getting
flooded is real you probably want to uh
take office at a higher lower
so that the threat of flooding is
minimized
for fire we always have a fire drill
where we practice our fire mechanism so
that we can evacuate all humans as soon
as possible and then worry about the
technicalities of it under any
circumstances under any threats humans
will always have the first priority and
then everything else comes in
man-made threats are where man
themselves are a problem so strikes
lockouts hackers theft uh War rioting
all of those are man-made threads uh
which we ourselves cannot be in control
of but we need to plan for them and we
need to have a business continuity plan
or a disaster if you plan for any of
these threads that have been identified
then come the technical threads
technical could be software bugs
operating system bugs application bugs
that uh that come with the applications
that we have or a hardware failure where
server crashes or hard disk crashes
maybe uh the processor stops working the
motherboard stops working Ram gets
corrupted uh
any of the technical aspects
a stopping uh stop functioning does
creating a break in the business can
come under technical right so uh
anything to do with computers
let's say a server feeling or a patch
that is not installed on a particular
software those would come under
technical threads and then the supply
system the supply system are your
environmental threats which depend on
your supply chain field failures what is
the supply chain for office to function
there are a lot of dependencies that
office goes through right there are a
lot of other vendors that suppose that
support and provide critical
infrastructure non-critical
infrastructure for the office to
function for first and foremost
electricity
without electricity nothing is going to
be powered on and you're not going to be
able to function so if there is an
electricity service provider and if
there's an electric outage that's that
comes under Supply system
so that's a supply chain failure where
the vendor that provides electricity to
you has failed in providing that
particular service and now you need a
business continuity or a disaster
recovery plan so you probably have an
inverter or you already have a power
generator plant that is going to
generate your own power and Supply to
your system
right there could be short circuits
because of fluctuation in the
electricity uh maybe the internet
service provider fails and your internet
caches so you have a backup line for the
internet from a different vendor right
and so on so forth maybe your Hardware
vendors who are supplying you servers
desktops laptops and whatnot they fail
because they feel they are facing a
strike or they go bankrupt and suddenly
you can no longer purchase Hardware from
your vendor because they no longer are
in business so that's a supply chain
failure
so any of these Systems Failing would
also come under threats
so under a broad category these are the
first four threads that you need to
identify and then you can elaborate by
providing more scenarios based on the
experiences that you have had towards
each and every of these threads so
natural threat where you may have had
experience where there would have been
let's say a flooding or
any natural disaster which caused a
problem for the continuity of your
particular business so identify each and
every example for each of these threads
and provide that as an example in the
interview
what is black box and white box testing
so when you are testing a software or
you're testing your infrastructure there
are two different tests that you can
conduct the first one is a black box the
second one is a white box in a black box
test there is no knowledge that is
shared with the tester so let's say your
ethical hacker
and you have been awarded a contract by
an organization to test their current
application that they have developed now
they are not going to give you any
information they are not going to tell
you what the application is they just
probably give you an IP address and a
port number where the application is
hosted and now you have to find in your
own queries and try to figure out what
the application is try to gather
information see what uh what information
can be gathered in the first place and
based on that you're going to figure out
your way identifying vulnerabilities and
see if any of those vulnerabilities can
lead to insecurity incident so without
any knowledge zero knowledge of the ID
infrastructure or the source code that's
a black box attack or a black box test a
white box test on the other hand is
where full knowledge of the IIT
infrastructure or the source code is
shared so the ethical hacker has
complete knowledge and based on the
knowledge they are then going to test
out the system to see if there are any
flaws that they can identify right so
why would these two audits be important
because the first one a black box audit
emulates the attack of a Outsider a
external hacker sitting outside the
organization trying to figure their way
in whereas a white box attack can
emulate the attack of an Insider so a
disconnected employee within that
organization misusing their access
controls or the access rights to make uh
unvalidated profits right so somebody's
corrupt who has been bribed who wants to
sell out company Secrets base so they
are going to try to find out
vulnerabilities try to steal data and
try to sell it on the uh gray market
right so a white box would emulate uh
internal attack a black box would
emulate an external attack moving on to
question 17 what is use case testing now
use case testing is a functional test
and it is also a black box test
right what is a functional test it tests
the functionality of a particular
software once it has been created
why is it a black box test because the
user doesn't know what the functionality
is they just want to find out each and
every scenario and try to see what that
scenario generates as a response they
are not sure whether that is the
appropriate response that should be
generated or not
they're just trying to find out the
response that is going to be generated
after they fire off a query so this
technique is used by testers to get the
test scenarios to exercise the whole
system from start to finish
so let's say it's a login mechanism for
an application right now a user at this
point in time the tester since it's a
black box testing will know that it is a
login mechanism they will not know the
details of what logging mechanisms are
being utilized so they wouldn't know
whether input validation is done they
wouldn't know whether output encoding is
done they wouldn't know how the CGI
calls are being made they would not know
how the queries are handled at the
server side and how the database is
going to treat that particular query so
they have no idea whether SQL injection
attacks are possible and so on so forth
so for them with whatever input they are
going to try to insert for that login
mechanism that's a functional Black Box
test the functionality being whether the
login mechanism works and based on the
type of inputs that are going to put in
whether it creates an unwarranted output
whether they can bypass the mechanism or
they can hack into the system because of
some of the flaws that were left behind
right another example here is a software
made for users to use for documentation
the testers will test all the cases that
the user can do so can the user view a
document can they add new documents can
they edit documents and can they delete
documents so this functionality
will depend upon the access controls
that have been granted to a particular
user so for this particular user the
tester at this point in time they would
not know whether they are an
administrative user or they are a
regular user they'll just try to do all
of these and then write the responses
saying I was able to view I was able to
add I was able to edit and I was able to
delete now the result will be then sent
to a manager the manager will look at
the results and then based on the actual
access controls that were supposed to be
there for this particular user then
we'll try to identify whether this is an
acceptable case or whether there were
any flaws within this case moving on to
question 18
what is static and dynamic testing now
this is again in application testing
static testing is done in an early stage
of development life cycle now software
development life cycles there are
multiple of those what are these life
cycles
there are different stages in which a
application is created
and provide it to the customer so your
first stage would be determining the
scope of the application determining the
hardware requirements for that
application then
creating a flowchart for that
application a functional chart for that
application and then maybe start coding
then an architect comes in tests the
code verifies the code then the testing
phase comes in then the security testing
phase comes in and then the user
acceptance testing comes in but in every
stage at the very earliest of our stage
a static test will always be started
to see whatever code has been developed
whatever scope has been developed
whether that scope is going to be
correct or not this will include
walkthroughs and code review what is a
walk through a walk through is going
through documents that have been
generated and trying to find faults in
the documented Journey that has been
that has been created so far so let's
say somebody has created a workflow or a
flowchart for a program how the
functions are going to be called and how
they're going to be executed so a
walkthrough would be where uh all these
responsible people will walk through
that particular flowchart and find out
any flaws within that and then Rectify
them if there is any code that has
already been written this code will be
reviewed manually and any flaws within
that code would then be identified
static testing will always be 100
accurate in a very short amount of time
because it is immediate uh you have
created it and then the export is going
to test it to see whether everything is
fine or not right it is all about
prevention mechanism so since you're
doing it at the Inception itself if you
find any flaw it gets immediately
repaired so this is about preventing
vulnerabilities from keeping into that
application at a later point in time
whereas Dynamic on the other side is
done at the end of the development life
cycle so you have generated the
application everything is ready now you
want to do Dynamic testing includes
functional and non-functional testing
functional testing is where the
application itself is being tested the
functions to see that all the parameters
that are given to the application are
functioning properly
non-functional testing would be where
security parameters administrative
parameters all of them are being
verified
right this is where your test case
scenarios come in and uh
you're going to test each and every
scenario by generating inputs and
analyzing the output that the
application is going to give you
Dynamic testing is all about cure so
here you're going to identify
vulnerabilities report them to the
management and the management is then
going to figure out a way of patching
those vulnerabilities so that they can
be mitigated moving on to the next
question what are the test levels in
software testing so as far as software
testing is concerned there are four test
levels module testing integration
testing system testing and the final one
is acceptance testing so in the testing
phase of your development life cycle the
first thing is a module test we are
going to check your routines your
subroutines your sub programs procedures
that have been written in a program so
all your functions all your
mechanisms for that application are
going to be tested when you go into
integration testing the software we have
been integrated with multiple softwares
there may be different API calls coming
in maybe a third party software on which
your uh depending upon to supply for
information so all of these integration
of various softwares various apis are
tested to ensure that they are
functioning properly and there are no
flaws errors or mistakes left behind in
the integration of all of these
softwares
then the system testing is where the
entire system so including the hardware
including the software right it starts
from the installation so now the
software is complete we know which
Hardware we are going to support for it
we start by installing the software and
see whether the installation is going to
be completed properly if there are any
errors in the installation process
itself
then once it is installed the
performance of that particular
application the write speeds the read
speeds on the hard disk uh the
transaction speeds that the application
is capable of the network dependencies
that the application may have all of
those would come under system testing
and then the acceptance testing which is
basically a quality assurance exercise
that the application meets the client's
requirements so the client in the first
stage would have given the scope of what
needs to be achieved in the acceptance
testing you're verifying that that scope
has been met and the client requirements
have been met and you can assure the
client about the functionality and the
performance of that particular
application coming to the last question
in this uh software programs what are
the valuable steps to resolve issues
while testing so in the previous
scenarios when we have started testing
now if you find out when you execute a
particular use case
and then you find out of law what would
be the steps that you would utilize to
address those particular flaws in those
tests the first step will always be
record then you're going to report it
and then you're going to introduce a
Control process for it so when you say
record
you're going to create logs
and you're going to try to resolve all
the problems that have happened now when
you say resolve you're not going to
record the application but you are going
to test the system again and again to
ensure that whatever is being recorded
is accurate
and all the logs all the error
mechanisms all the dumps all of those
that have been generated due to this
particular log of up to this particular
error are being captured so that they
can be reported to the higher level
managers so the next step is once you
have eventually have accumulated all
these logs and Records you're going to
report them to the higher level managers
who are then going to investigate it and
go back to the developers trying to
figure out the best way to mitigate
those particular flaws so the report
writing needs also also needs to be
accurate it needs to be to the point it
needs to detail what the problem was it
will document all the steps that they
were that you took all the inputs that
you put in and it will also record all
the errors and it will also record all
the mechanisms that were utilized and
the errors that were actually generated
and that report will be given to the
higher level managers who can then
forward it to the developers who based
on those reports can start their
troubleshooting and then the control
mechanism comes in you're going to
define the issue management process so
this process needs to work in a
particular manner where you are doing a
test you're recording whatever is
happening you're creating a report out
of it you're sending it to the
management the management will then take
those reports study them take it to the
developers the developers will test
based on their criterias they might
interact with the testers at that point
in time to identify particular flaws and
then we might want to record that
application on a develop a patch which
once installed will mitigate that
particular flaw and then it can come
back to the testing phase again where
you can repeat those tests and validate
that the flaw is no longer existed
so these are the three steps that would
be utilized for testing purposes
and that brings us to the first 10
questions on the software platform in
the next video we'll be looking at
operating systems and applications
the first question is on virtual memory
what exactly is virtual memory
for a computer we have two types of
memory we first is the primary memory
which is your random access memory which
is also known as a volatile memory and
the secondary memory is your hard disk
where your data is stored permanently
but for a computer when it has let's say
a 4GB memory or a ram as in this
scenario on your screen it is going to
replicate that and is going to create
another 4GB of virtual memory on the
hard disk and it is going to use it in
tandem along with the ram
so if the ram is insufficient the
processor is going to utilize the 4GB of
the virtual memory that is created on
the hard disk and it is going to swap
data from the ram to the hard disk
this can also be known as a pH file or a
swap file the next question is what are
different scheduling algorithms now the
context for this question is you're
talking about a processor and you are
talking about how processors are going
to be fed to the processor and how the
process is going to treat these
processes so the first is first come
first serve so the process which
requires the CPU first gets the CPU
allocation first now whenever there are
processes that are being run by
different applications they make
requests for some CPU type now in first
come first serve the first service or
the first process that is going to
request some processing time will get
that much allocated to them they will
run through the process first and in the
next and the next and so on so forth
the second one is the shortest job first
this is the process where the shortest
execution time for that process is
calculated and that process is selected
first for the CPU
then there is parity scheduling this
schedule selects the task to work as per
priority so there would be some tasks
that are marked with high priority some
would be normal and some would be low So
based on this high normal or low
priority uh all the processes will be
classified higher priority will be dealt
with uh first then the normal and the
least priority
the fourth option is multiple level
queues where processors are assigned to
a queue based on the specific property
like process priority the size of memory
Etc so it will be classified based on
the attributes given to that particular
process and multiple queues will be
created and then based on the attributes
the processes will be
processed by the CPU
then shortest remaining time the process
will be allocated to the task Which is
closest to its completion so or you look
at it this way the process that will
take the least time to complete its
processing would be chosen first
and then the round robin method where
each process comes in turn gets an equal
share of time so if there are 10
processors each process will be
allocated a certain amount of time after
which the next process will be processed
and so on so forth and it will continue
in a round robin fashion till all the
processes get executed
so in short six different scheduling
algorithms depending on how you uh how
the operating system deals with it
the next question is
what are the steps involved in hacking a
server or a network so this is more of
an ethical hacking question you're
looking at devices and for and the
interviewer asks you uh what kind of
steps are involved what are the
activities that you would do in hacking
a server or a network now there are no
specific steps that you would Define
because every hack is going to be unique
but it has a hack can be classified in
five different steps
which are quite generic right so the
first step will always always be the
recognizance step also known as
information gathering phase also known
as footprinting or fingerprinting
depending on what exactly you're doing
but in this phase
the attacker gathers all the evidence
all the information that is possible
about the targets that they want to
attack so here you're trying to get to
know the victim so you can launch
specific attacks towards them you want
to identify what operating system they
are utilizing what IP addresses Mac
addresses the versions of the operating
systems and applications the patch
levels find out vulnerabilities find out
whatever information is possible find
out the information about the a person
who's using those computers so you can
launch social engineering attacks and so
on so forth so the first step is all
about gathering enough information based
on which you can launch further attacks
once you have that information comes the
second phase which is known as the
scanning phase this is more of a
technical phase so yeah in the first
step you've got your IP addresses domain
names maybe even Network maps and you
have identified which devices are
available now in the scanning phase
you're going to identify live devices
and then you're going to scan them for
open ports processors protocols Services
you're going to identify vulnerabilities
you're going to enumerate them to
identify more information from them
does at this point in time you will have
identified a certain set of
vulnerabilities or a certain set of
security loopholes that you can misuse
once you have identified those
you're going to the next step which is
the gaining access tape in this you are
actually going to execute your attacks
based on the availabilities that you
have found and you are either going to
gain access to that particular system by
installing a Trojan or a destroy the
system by installing a virus or install
a spyware or a key logger whatever you
wanted to achieve so in the gaming
access phase you would have based on the
knowledge that you have gained in the
first and the second phase you are going
to launch your attacks and you're going
to try to gain access to that particular
device
then the next step is where you're going
to maintain that access now that you
have hacked into that device it is not
necessary that you will always be able
to get access to that device suppose you
have cracked the password of that
particular user and the user changes
that password after a few days your
attack is worthless so what you're going
to do here is you're going to maintain
your access
so this is where it is assumed that you
want repeated access to that device and
thus you're going to install a keylogger
or a Trojan or sub mechanism which will
still allow you to get access to that
device without the knowledge or the
authorization of that particular user
and finally the last step is where you
are going to cover Your Tracks so
whatever activity that you have done so
far will have created logs and will have
created information based on which the
victim will come to know that they have
been compromised and may be able to
trace that activity back to you so to
prevent the user or the victim from
realizing that they have been hacked and
to prevent them to discover who has
hacked them you want to cover your
tracks by deleting logs and any
references that point to that particular
activity you're going to hide the files
that you have created so you have
installed it erosion or a key logger
these will create files and directories
you're going to hide them so that they
are not discovered you're going to hide
processes that have been created you're
going to try to hide all the activity
that you have done so that to conceal
the actual attack and preventing the
user from realizing that they have been
compromised so these are the five steps
that will be involved in hacking a
server Network application or any
Computing device you will come across
the next question refers to what are the
various sniffing tools now this is a
network based attack where you're trying
to capture a data package that that have
been transmitted over the network and
then you're going to analyze them to see
if you can capture any sensitive
information like usernames passwords
Bank details or any anything of that
sort now these tools will also depend on
which operating system you're utilizing
for example MSN sniffer would work on
Microsoft operating systems
would be based on Linux and so on so
forth so on the screen you'll see six
different sniffing tools that work on
different operating systems Wireshark is
uh something that is common both on
Windows and Linux
it is used to analyze Network in details
it is the de facto tool that you will
come across in most of your ethical
hacking trainings in most of your
organizations when they want to do data
captures
now data capturing or packet capturing
is not only done by hackers to gather
more information but is also a known
troubleshooting technique used by
administrators and network
administrators to analyze any issues
that may be going on in the network
right so wow the first tool you see on
the screen is Wireshark like we stated
is available for Windows Linux as well
then there is TCP dump which again has
the same capability of Wireshark but is
a command line version whereas Wireshark
also has a GUI a graphical user
interface TCP dump is available on Linux
Amazon sniffer it's a very old tool uh
when we had MSN Messengers MSN Messenger
is no longer there but Microsoft does or
did have a Microsoft message analyzer
Tool uh which they have stopped
development since 2015 but that's
another tool that is specific for
Microsoft operating systems from
Microsoft you are can be installed to
gather more information then you've got
ETA cap which is a tool to launch man in
the middle attacks data capturing and is
is essentially a Linux command line
based tool then D Smith is another
password and network capturing tool
which can help you capture data packets
prominently a Linux 2.
same with heat array
this is a graphical tool which will
allow you to capture data data traffics
and map protocols and identify which IPR
users have been communicating with what
essentially all of the tools have
similar functionality except that some
have addition functionality like logic
and the middle attacks or capturing or
having specific filters that will help
you identify and troubleshoot some
network issues that you may be facing
moving on to the next question what is
an operating system now this is a very
difficult question to answer because uh
we normally when we want to answer this
question we start off with the
functionality of an operating system
right we try to describe what Windows
does or what Linens does or what Mac OS
does and then we are trying to figure
out what an operating system is in the
first place but an operating system
essentially as the slide says is a
software program that provides a
platform for computer hardware to
communicate and operate with the
computer software so it is basically an
enabler for human interaction with the
hardware that you have if you take the
operating system out of the question
it's just some Hardware which cannot
interact with you
but essentially when you have operating
system like Microsoft Windows or Linux
or Mac you're essentially essentially
installing an instruction set on that
particular device which will allow you
to interact
and manipulate the hardware to do
whatever you want that Hardware to do
right essentially when we talk about uh
drivers for your various devices like a
driver for your land card or for your
sound card or for your graphics card
which allows you to tweak these cards
for a functionality right it allows us
input and output functions
uh for example the basic example you
open up Microsoft Office projects like
Microsoft Word or Excel and you get a
GUI on the screen which you can interact
with you got a keyboard and you type on
that keyboard and the computer knows
what you're typing and reflects those
actions on the screen by showcasing it
on that particular Excel file or a word
file so how does the computer know what
to do or what you're exactly intending
to do at this point in time it is all
the operating system that is providing
you all these Services analyzing what
your inputs are and then based uh on the
programming it is going to execute that
and show it to you on the screen right
some of the most common commonly used
operating system are Microsoft Windows
you have them in desktop as well as
server variants Unix Linux again Linux
has desktop and servers you've got Uber
2 in linebacker red hat and so on so
forth and then you've got Mac OS for
Apple related conference the next
question what is the difference between
micro kernel and macro kernel now the
first thing we need to know is what is a
kernel kernel is the
heart of the operating system that
allows that input and output to happen
it allows those drivers to be set up so
that the hardware can interact with the
software and we can then instruct the
software and the hardware both
to function in a particular manner so
there are two types of kernels micro
kernels and a macro kernel micro kernel
is something that we normally use micro
kernels are for operating systems that
use processors directly handled by the
processor the micro kernel is very small
in size uh macro kernel is large because
it basically is an entire image of the
operating system
the execution for a micro kernel is slow
the macro kernel is going to be faster
because it is more evolved there's a lot
of programming involved extendability
micro kernels are easy to extend micro
micro kernels are hard to extend as well
as security is concerned if a macro
kernel crashes it takes everything down
with it the entire operating system is
going to crash but in case of a micro
kernel it is only that particular
process that is going to get affected
micro kernel there is a lot of coding
involved
macro kernel less coding is involved
examples of micro kernels would be
simply an OSS most popularly used on
yesterday earphones Nokia's if you
remember those uh qnx and so on so forth
macro kernels your Linux or vsd
operating systems essentially used macro
kernels
next question what are the different
types of operating systems so as you can
see on the screen
five types of operating systems batched
OS distributed operating systems time
sharing multi-program and real-time what
are batched operating systems the
computer operator places the jobs coming
from input devices into patches so
consider this not from a desktop
perspective but from a server
perspective where these devices are used
by organizations to compute and to
crunch some processors that is going to
make some business sense out of it so
when there are multiple processors
coming in multiple jobs that are going
to be scheduled a batched OS is going to
place these jobs in batches and they're
going to Crunch those based on the
inputs that have been given by these
operators distributed OSS where there
are multiple computers which are
interconnected and are communicating
through networks so in a corporate
environment you don't use one single
computer to do everything you got a Data
Center and the data center will have a
cluster of servers where they are going
to share some resources to one
particular task right so that's where
your distributed OS has come into the
picture
then you have time sharing OSS where you
are renting some time so time sharing
voices minimizes the response time
example in today's world Cloud right uh
you go on to the cloud you have a
virtual service over there you schedule
something you schedule the job over
there it is uh it is executed and for
that time being that operating system
Services your particular request and
provides you that particular job
any application that you see online that
is executed for example Facebook
from a consumer's perspective could be a
time shared experience
then multi-programmed OS the operating
system uses CPU scheduling to separate
jobs so you're scheduling the CPU to
complete certain jobs
in this particular Manner and in real
time OS
the operating system gives maximum time
to critical operations so it identifies
uh the priority of these operations it
knows the high priority items the medium
low priority items and based on that it
is going to execute these critical
operations and get the job done moving
on to the next question what is the
difference between logical address space
and physical address space now when
you're looking at address spaces this is
where applications come into the picture
and when you execute an application it
is going to create a particular address
in the memory where it is going to
create a buffer to store its own
information so that it can be provided
to the processor processed and then can
be returned back to the application as
an output right so as far as definitions
are concerned a logical address is
generated during running of an
application
or a program a physical address is a
physical address or a physical location
on the memory module itself
right
visibility you can view a logical
address because it is programmed into a
computer so if I'm looking at C C plus
plus and I'm using malloc or memory
allocation that's where the logical
address is going to be created where a
buffer is going to be created for that
program and whatever the user input is
going to be it's going to be stored in
that buffer but whereas physical address
is concerned this logical address will
be created on a physical store or a
physical memory module which will have
its own addressing mechanism thus you
you can see the memory module but you
cannot see the specific address on that
particular memory module but as far as a
logical address is concerned by your
programming or your debugging the
application it will show you the logical
address that has been created the start
point and the end point of The Logical
address that has been created for that
particular program it can be shown in a
debugging environment
right
address space logical and physical
address is physical like yeah I just
guess it's the memory module itself you
can access only the physical address on
that particular memory because logical
addresses can be viewed but you cannot
access them physically uh generation uh
The Logical addresses are generated by
the CPU during the processing time
whereas physical addresses are generated
are computed by the memory management
unit or the mmu that you have on your
computers
and as well as logical addresses they
will always be they are variable whereas
the physical address is always going to
be constant looking at the next question
what is the difference between logical
address space and physical address space
so moving on from the previous question
to this
The Logical address is
address created by the CPU for the
processors that need to be addressed and
that need to be stored as a buffer in
the physical memory whereas the physical
memory itself is going to be an address
that is going to be there on the
physical part of that memory which is uh
which is going to be assigned to it by
the mmu well the next question discusses
uh shells so what shells are used in
Linux now what is the Shell Shell is the
command line interface that we utilize
on a Linux machine so the terminal
window as we call it is a shell
and there are different variations of a
shell based on what Linus operating
systems you are using the desktop
operating systems that you use or the
server operating systems and real in
today's world that you're going to use
normally will always have a bash shell
which is the first shell that you see on
the screen known as a bone again shell
it is a default for larynx distribution
so as far as end consumers regular
consumers are concerned it is always
going to be a bash shell a bone again
shell that you're going to utilize for
scripting and to execute regular
commands
but when it comes to high level
programming or it comes to
specialization tasks then you got the
rest of these uh shells that you can
utilize for example the ksh known as a
conch shell is used for high level
programming which supports associative
arrays and built-in operations the CSH
or the C shell
has different functionality like
spelling Corrections and drop controls
the zsh or the Z shell
provides unique features like file
generation startup files and fish
friendly interactive shell which
provides features like Auto suggestions
and configuration so all of these have
different functionalities depending on
what usage that you have for that
particular shell the most common shell
like yesterday did is the bash shell
that you'll always come across in your
desktop Linus operating systems then
looking at the next question what are
the process States in Linux now what is
a process process is basically a service
that is running
for a particular application for that
application to function right this
process is going to direct user input to
the processor process it get that output
back to the application execute it and
then show it onto the graphical user
interface for the user so in Linux there
are five states for a process first is
the reduce phase now in ready in this
state the process is created and it is
ready to run so it is waiting uh it is
waiting for input it's ready uh the
application is executed the running is
when the process is being executed
itself blocked or weight is when user
input is being looked upon so it's
waiting for user input so that it can do
the processing completed or terminated
it has completed its execution or was
terminated by the operating system for
some reason or the other so this is
where things have uh the processing has
been completed
and then lasted state is zombie where
the process is terminated but the
process table still holds the
information maybe it is waiting for the
kill request before it gets terminated
so these are the five states for a Linux
process to be in and that brings us to
the 10 questions in the operating system
and application space in the next video
we'll be looking at 10 more questions on
cyber attacks interview questions based
on cyber attacks
let's start off with the first one the
first question is what is SQL injection
SQL stands for structured query language
which is a language that is used by most
of your databases or your relational
databases the variations of your
database would be MySQL Microsoft SQL
Oracle SQL
you'll have IBM databases all of these
databases utilize the structured query
languages to interact with the
applications now all of these databases
have their own syntax so you'll have to
study most of these databases based on
which applications and which databases
you want to provide security for
but as the name suggests SQL injection
vulnerability or a structured query
language injection vulnerability is
where a user can maliciously inject a
SQL input
or a SQL statement in a query and
send it to the database and evoke a
response response out of it
so this vulnerability is not
specifically to the database it uh the
vulnerability lies more in the
application in the coding of that
application so when the application
receives a query which it needs to be
forwarded to the SQL database we need to
configure at the application Level of
what queries are allowed and what
queries are not allowed so there are
different various aspects
of how to manage a SQL injection
vulnerability but the basic flaw lies in
the application where
invalidated input is accepted and sent
forward to the database where the
database might confuse it into an
executable statement and thus create a
response that was not warranted there
are various types of SQL injections as
shown on the screen in band circuit
injection where you can look at an error
based or a union based injection a blind
SQL injection where it is either Boolean
based or a time-based attack and then an
out-of-bound SQL injection
essentially you're looking at databases
and you're looking at application
security however you want to encourage
secure coding practices so in
unvalidated input is mitigated
the next question is what is spoofing
now in spoofing you're basically
assuming the identity of another person
so here the attacker pretends to be some
other person or an organization and
sends you an email that appears to be a
legitimate email it looks almost genuine
it has been constructed to replicate
what a genuine email would have been
and it is very difficult to spot a fake
one there are different ways to identify
whether an email is genuine or not
but that's for a different video moving
on to the next question what is a
distributed denial of service attack or
a DDOS attack now generally a denial of
service attack is an attack where
legitimate users are prevented access to
the resources that they legitimately can
access right so for example if it is a
bandwidth based attack the attacker
consumes the bandwidth of the network in
such a way that there is no more
bandwidth left for legitimate users to
access the network
now a single device may not be able to
generate that much amount of traffic to
consume the bandwidth of a huge server
thus the attacker will construct a
botnet and through that botnet they will
launch a distributed denial of service
attack
to the Target victim right so a botnet
there are two terms that you want to
look at over here the first term is a
bot and the second one being the botnet
itself bot is a software that was
installed on a victims machine allows
the hacker to send remote commands to
that machine that will make it to
generate some activity
once we have enough machines on which
such Bots have been implemented the
collection of these machines would be
known as a botnet so an attacker would
then instruct this entire apartment to
start generating data traffic to be to
be sent to the targeted Network or to
the targeted server which will then bog
down the server thus crashing it and
preventing users from accessing that
particular resource the next question is
how to avoid ARP poisoning or ARP now
first let's understand what ARP is ARP
stands for address resolution protocol
which is a protocol used by computers to
communicate over the network once your
computer boots up
it starts our Discovery process of
identifying its neighbors so if I'm in a
particular subnet my machine will
proactively send out ARP requests and
address resolution protocol to find out
which other machines are within the same
network and which are live once it sends
out a query a live machine will respond
to that query along with its Mac address
this information is dense stored in what
is known as a ARP table or an ARP table
on the machine's cache
so whenever my machine now wants to send
out a packet to this particular machine
it will go to the ARP table it will
identify the IP address and the
associated Mac address it will print
that onto the data packet as a
destination
IP and destination Mac and send that
packet across the switch the switch will
then identify the MAC address send the
packet to the relevant machine that is
connected to that particular switch
now to confuse this switch into sending
it to a different machine so our
poisoning attack is created this attack
is generally launched to
create a man in the middle attack now to
prevent this R poisoning from happening
in the first place there are three
different aspects that we can utilize
first we can use packet filtering which
will filter out and block packets that
are the same Source address data so you
have identified some malicious IP
addresses and you want to block out some
IP addresses so you're using a packet
filter firewall where you have
constructed the firewall to filter out
certain packets
originating from particular range of IP
addresses this firewall and this
technique will then block those kind of
packets coming in
second keeping away from trust
relationships organizations will develop
protocols that do not depend on trust
relationships and thus you want to keep
this protocol away from there once you
have created a trust relationship
these machines should not be sending out
ARP requests to other machines in the
first place since the trust relationship
has been defined and these machines know
whom to communicate with such kind of
protocols should then be disabled
or you can use ARB spoofing software so
there are some there are softwares out
there that will look for ARP spoofing
and prevent that from happening in the
first place so if somebody has sent out
a spoofed ARP packet
that packet will be picked up by this
software and it will be mitigated of
network visualizers like glass wire
antiviruses like so force uh they have
inbuilt capabilities of identifying our
apps moving attacks and mitigate them in
the first place in the next question we
are going to discuss what is ransomware
now ransomware is a type of malware that
blocks victims to access personal files
and demands Ransom to regain access
there are three categories before we go
into the categories let's just revisit
what ransomware is let's start with the
word malware malware is a malicious
software that poses as a legitimate
software but has a payload that will
have a security impact on your machine
so in this instance viruses Trojans all
of these can be classified under malware
so can Ransom which but Trojan is a
software that will give you a backdoor
access to a to a particular device a
virus will do some destructive activity
on that device or ransomware will
basically encrypt the data of that
particular user from on that particular
machine thus rendering that my that data
inaccessible to the users themselves
and in turn will demand a ransom to
provide access to that particular data
so the three types of ransomware is the
first one is square wear which uses
social engineering to cause anxiety or
the perception of a threat to manipulate
users into buying unwanted software so
this sprays on the gullibility of humans
where you can see a pop-up appearing on
your screen which can scare you into
believing that you may have been
attacked or there is a virus on your
machine and then instructs you to
download a particular software to
mitigate that particular virus now
the malware will be in this software
that you will be downloading and then a
ransomware will be installed and your
data will be encrypted
screen lockers uh we're locking uses
computers by preventing them from
logging in and displaying an official
looking message you will see a screen
saver once you boot up which prevents
you from accessing the login page so it
will not allow you to log into your own
machine but it will give you a warning
that your data has been encrypted and
you need to connect to a particular
email address and send bit send Bitcoins
over there to get a decryption key to
access your own data and in the
encrypting ransomware displays a message
demanding payment in the return for the
private asymmetry key which is needed to
decrypt the symmetric keys for encrypted
file so once your files have been
encrypted you might just have a blank
screen in front of you where you'll
receive a warning message where it
instructs you to pay up a ransom in
Bitcoins or in some cryptocurrency to
some particular digital e-wallet which
is not traceable and once you make that
payment they will send you the
decryption key and then you can access
your data if getting your learnings
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit skillup by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
then talk I'm talking about the next
question what is the difference between
an active and a passive Cyber attack now
when we talk about cyber attacks Cyber
attack is a activity that is caused by a
malicious user who wants to try to get
access or do some security incidents
on the victim's devices so there are two
ways that can happen it's either in an
active manner or a passive manner in an
active manner the Intruder attempts to
disrupt a Network's normalcy modifies
data and tries to alter the system's
resources so this is more active where
the attacker will proactively try to
destroy the network so that
Communications fail or they might try to
modify the data where uh we're using a
ransom where they can encrypt it or they
might delete that data using a virus or
steal the data using and Trojan or they
might even alter the data so that it is
no longer trustworthy whereas in a
passive attack the Intruder intercepts
data traveling through a network here
the into the eavesdrop but does not
modify the message so they're just
listening in they're just observing what
is going on they are not manipulating
the data they are not stealing anything
it's just that they are monitoring the
activity that's going on then the next
question what is a social engineering
attack now social engineering attack is
a people-based attack the victim here is
the Human by itself the vulnerability
also lies in the human it may be
executed through a computer but end of
the difficult abilities of the human so
it is the art of manipulating people so
that they end up giving up confidential
information
now we always read in the papers where
somebody got manipulated their passwords
got hacked and somebody's life savings
got wiped out right because they shared
the OTP with someone or they shared of
the password with someone now creating a
scenario where these people will fall
prey to this attack and share this kind
of personal information to unknown
people that is where the social
engineering attack comes in
creating that scenario which will ensure
that these people give out this
confidential information now there are
three categories in this attack the
first one is a phishing attack second is
a spear phishing attack and a third is a
railing attack now phishing attack is
basically a generic attack
it is targeted To The World At Large
whoever Falls prey to that attack will
be a victim
whereas a spear phishing attack is a
targeted attack towards a specific
individual or a group of individuals or
towards an organization so there is a
lot more research that goes into
spearfishing where you analyze the
victim you try to figure out what their
volumities are and your tailor make or
you customize the attack
to that particular vulnerability once
you have that attack you launch it
against those people those people
will then fall prey to this attack and a
wailing attack is where you're attacking
top level Executives so the sea level
Executives of an organization
politicians movie stars wealthy and
powerful people so any of these people
when they're attacked it will be known
as a wailing attack
next question what is man in the middle
attack now this is something that we are
touched base when we talked about ARP
where the ARP poisoning attack needs to
be executed to leverage a man in the
middle attack now in the man in the
middle attack the attacker attacking
computer takes the IP address of the
client unaware of this the server
continues to communicate with the
attacker now if you remember in a
previous question we have also talked
about spoofing so in this scenario uh
attacker has spoofed their IP address to
replicate themselves as a genuine client
and now with that spoofing in mind they
might either throw our poisoning attack
or just because of the spoofed IP
address become a man in the middle that
means that they are now eavesdropping on
the conversation between the actual
client and the server by imposing
themselves as a server in this scenario
the attacker is now a go between between
the client and the server and can
eavesdrop and can copy the data if they
want they can modify the data as well so
as you can see on the screen the
attacker becomes man in the middle which
means that they are now eavesdropping on
the conversation that is happening
between the client and the server the
next question
who are black ad hackers and Whitehead
hackers the main thing is the
differentiation between a black hat
hacker and a wildcat hacker now a
blackhead hackers are skilled
individuals
who illegally hack into a system the
motive behind such an attack is mostly
for monetary gain these individuals are
known also known as security crackers
now if you look at your criminal hackers
those who have malicious intent those
who do hacking for the intent of
personal gain or for the matter of
disruption the main thing that black hat
hackers lack
is authorization they are not authorized
to do the activity that they are about
to do and they're going to get
unauthorized access to devices or to
data which is going to cause losses to
the organization involved
whereas on the other side a whitehead
hacker or also known as ethical hackers
these are the individuals who discover
vulnerabilities in a computer network
and they help the organizations mitigate
these vulnerabilities they help the
organizations defend themselves from
black hat hackers so the main difference
between these two types of hackers a
black hat and a white hat is the intent
and the authorization so black hat
hackers will have malicious intent they
will try to personally gain from that
attack
from by finding your vulnerabilities
they also will not have authorization to
conduct whatever activity they are doing
whereas on the other side Whitehead
hackers will be hired by organizations
they will provide authorization for
certain activity that the Whitehead
hacker can do to find out those
vulnerabilities once those
vulnerabilities have been found found
out by the white hat hacker they will
reported to the management and guide
them in implementing security controls
to mitigate those vulnerabilities the
main difference between a blackhead and
a white hat is the authorization and the
intent the next question what are
honeypots
now honeypots are a very interesting
device that can be introduced in a
network uh these basically are decoy
servers that are implemented in a
network to attract the attention of
attacker
it is there to lure an attacker uh into
uh attacking that particular device thus
creating a security blanket blanket for
the rest of the devices
so if an attacker has been able to
bypass a firewall and is now trying to
scan a particular Network when they Scan
they will come across various devices
that are there in the network they will
then proceed to do a vulnerability scan
on these devices the Honeypot at that
point in time will provide us and
approve as an attraction to these
attackers because it will
demonstrate some vulnerabilities to the
hacker which will divert their attention
so these vulnerabilities are simulated
on these devices these actually do not
exist but the moment the attacker then
starts interacting with the Honeypot the
Honeypot will identify that as a
malicious traffic and will warm the warn
the administrator about a possible
attack that is going on the
administrator will then investigate
through the Honeypot of what activities
going on and then reconfigure the
security controls to block the attacker
or mitigate the attack itself right so
it is more of a decoy server that will
showcase or simulate some
vulnerabilities to an attacker thus to
lure them and Safeguard the rest of the
network these are the 10 questions for
cyber security in the next video we will
be talking about cryptography the first
question Define cryptography encryption
and decryption now cryptography is used
by Security Professionals to scramble
data
into non-readable format which is used
in securing that information
so it involves converting data from a
readable format into a non-readable
format and then reversing it back to
readable format again
for example the word computer is now
scrambled into looking like an
unreadable format now if you look at
this word that it has been scrambled
into it would be very difficult
for a human to figure out
what the actual world was now in this
scenario we have taken an algorithm
where we have made a shift of the
alphabet where we have added two
alphabets the current one so C plus 2
becomes e
o plus 2 becomes q m plus 2 becomes o so
we have done a shift of 2 and thus the
key over here for this algorithm is the
alphabet plus two so any person who
figures that out will be able to
unscramble this and convert this back
into readable text
the fact of scrambling a readable text
Data into something that is unreadable
by using a particular key is What
cryptography is all about
now as we discussed the decryption again
is replacing the alphabet and taking it
further back by two characters so e
minus 2 becomes c q minus 2 becomes o o
minus 2 becomes M and so on so forth so
anybody who knows this key uh the shift
key
anybody will able to decrypt this
particular character so this depends on
the user if I want to utilize alphabet
plus five then the spacing the shifting
of that character will be the fifth
character from that particular character
and so on so forth
the next question what is the difference
between ciphertext and clear text
ciphertext refers to the text which is
encrypted and totally undesirable
the message received after decryption is
known as clear text this text is
comprehensible so the word computer is
clear text that means that it has not
been treated to any cryptographic
measures it does what it is intended to
be however if the moment we encrypted
that means we scramble it into
unreadable text by using any of the
algorithms that we'll be looking at
that text is known as a cipher text
and without the key this becomes
unreadable
the clear text as discussed is the plain
word that we have utilized we are using
the English language in this instance so
the plain word computer is the clear
text once we add the encryption layer to
it
we get the cipher text to it
moving on to the next question what is a
block Cipher this refers to the method
of encrypting the plain message block by
block the plain message is broken down
into fixed size blocks and then
encrypted now a block Cipher is normally
used for data that is stored so a data
that is stored on a hard disk and we
want to encrypt that data that is known
as block encryption or a block Cipher so
a block Cipher is an algorithm that will
allow you to encrypt data that is stored
onto a hard disk so in this example
we've got plain text which is 64 bits in
size and we have added a layer of
encryption to it so plain text plus the
key that we have studied in the previous
questions and then The Scrambled data
out of it which is unreadable and thus
encrypted then the next question what is
public key infrastructure now the public
key infrastructure is a set of policies
which secures the communication between
a server and a client it uses two
cryptographic keys public and private so
the infrastructure itself is a set of
policies people procedures and
techniques which are standardized in
nature and are globally accepted which
allow us to use digital certificates to
encrypt data and decrypt the data at the
other end we use a symmetric encryption
over here which means that we are used
two keys one is a public key to encrypt
and the private key to decrypt
the other part of your encryption is a
symmetric encryption where the same key
is used to encrypt and the same key is
used to decrypt
now in a public key infrastructure
like I said we have standardized that so
in the standardizing part of it these
are the various players that have been
defined in the public key infrastructure
the first is this user or the sender in
the scenario the one who requires this
digital signature to digitally sign a
particular transaction or a
communication a registration Authority
with whom they are going to register for
that particular key the certification
Authority who issues that key the
verification Authority who validates the
key itself and the recipient who is
going to be the other party of that
particular transaction so how is this
utilized
a sender or the user who requires this
digital signature will request or apply
for a digital signature with the
registration Authority the registration
Authority would validate the genuinity
of the user so they might do some uh
identity verification or uh proof of
residence or something like that once
they have identified the person and they
have validated the information table
then send the request to the
certification Authority stating that the
sender has been validated and we can and
the certification Authority can issue
the digital certificate to the
particular user
they will send the public key to the
sender which will be utilized by the
sender for further transactions so when
the sender is going to sign some data
and uh wants to send it across to the
recipe and they will use the public key
to sign it and send it across the
recipient will then validate with the
verification authority to see if the
data the sign data is correct or not now
why
the certification Authority sends the
public key to the sender the
certification Authority updates the
private key with the verification
Authority so whatever is signed by the
sender received by the recipient and
they want to validate it they will send
it back to the verification Authority
the verification Authority will validate
using the private key once the private
key is validated
it will then send the OK signal back to
the recipient thus allowing the
validation of that particular
transaction
if the signature is tampered with or is
not the very fiction Authority is not
able to validate the signature it will
then send a denial message back to the
recipient and the transaction will not
go through so the pki enables trusted
digital identities for people so the pki
grants secure access to digital
resources based on the infrastructure
that has been created and the core of
the pki is a certification Authority
which ensures that the trustworthiness
of the Digital Data is ensured so going
back to the previous slide
these are the key players that have been
standardized in the public key
infrastructure the certification
Authority is the authority that issues
the digital certificates the validation
Authority is the one who validates that
digital certificate moving on what is
RSA
RSA is one of the first public key
crypto systems that is used for secure
data transmission it stands for ravesh
Shamir and Edelman now these are the
three people who have created this
algorithm rather West atishamir and
Leonard Edelman who are the inventors of
this technique it is a asymmetric
cryptography algorithm which works on
both public and private Keys hence the
encryption key is public and the
decryption key is kept private now as we
have discussed earlier symmetric and
asymmetric cryptography symmetric
cryptography is where the same key is
used to encrypt and decrypt whereas a
symmetric cryptography is where there
are two keys to encrypt and decrypt the
algorithm what are the few alternatives
to our essay now RSA is an algorithm
that is used for encryption there are a
lot of other algorithms that can be
utilized to alter or do scramble data
depending on your requirements so in the
previous question we have studied and we
have talked about what RSA is it stands
for uh
three creators of that particular
algorithm but there are a lot of
alternatives to this algorithm depending
on how secure you want that data to be
and some of them are listed here on your
screen Duo security OCTA Google
Authenticator and last cost LastPass is
a password manager
so is Duo security Google authenticate
is something that we all utilize it is
an application that we can download and
store on our mobile devices and we can
set that up to authenticate ourselves
with certain portals so it issues a
unique ID to us which once utilized will
allow us access to those particular
portals OCTA is an identity manager
where you have created different digital
identities and you have assigned them
certain permissions and based on your
authentication mechanisms OCTA will
allow or disallow access to those
different applications or different
portals as you have configured it so all
four
or authorization authentication
mechanisms which can be used as
alternatives to RSA if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
skillup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
next question what are the prime
objectives of modern cryptography and
this is a very important question
because we've we've so far looked at
what cryptography is and what public key
infrastructure is but what is the
achievement out of it why are we
utilizing it and what do we want to gain
out of it so the main and the prime
objectives of modern cryptography are as
follows uh mentioned on your screen the
first one is confidentiality the second
one is non-repudiation third one is
authenticity and the fourth one is
integrity
now if I go back to the first one
confidentiality that is where I want to
keep data confidential that means it
will only be visible to the authorized
users right so here I have created a
list of people who have deemed as
authorized users and have created a
digital identity to them and have given
access controls to those people now that
is how confidentiality is insured so
when we want to keep data confidential
we create a list of users who we are
going to allow access to certain
resources and we are going to Define
what access controls are to be utilized
what access are allowed whether they've
got an administrative access or user
level access and only those authorized
users are going to be able to access
these resources that is how we maintain
confidentiality
the next one is non-repudiation
non-reputation is the prevention of
denial of having been a part of that
particular transaction so in the public
key infrastructure that we discussed
where a digital signature was utilized
to sign a particular transaction and
then sent to the recipient the sender
would not be able to deny of having
originated the transaction because it
was using their
digital certificate thus non-repidation
comes in the picture uh one more example
that we can have here is on our mobile
phones when we use SMS short messaging
service and we send a message to uh to
another person the person when they
receive a message the number is
validated by the service operator
and thus the sender cannot deny having
sent that message the sender at the same
time can have a delivery report sent to
them that the message was delivered to
the inbox of the recipient and thus if
the recipient denies having received
that message the delivery report becomes
proof of having that message being
delivered to their inbox thus both the
parties cannot deny of have a of being a
part of that particular transaction
then comes the part of authenticity
now in confidentiality we have created a
digital identity assigned it to a
particular person
and we have given them digital
signatures where they cannot deny having
being a part of that transaction but
authenticity is the part where they try
to prove that they are who they claim to
be so if I am claiming a digital
identity
I have to prove that I am that person
who I'm Who I'm trying to claim to be
and an example to that is when we go to
our gmail.com websites it first asks us
what is our username our username is
normally our email address which
identifies the account that we are
trying to access
right so this account is confidential
because it is only authorized for a
particular person
and once they identify themselves by
identifying the email address that's
when the authentication part comes into
the picture where it asks for the
password
now it has never ever happened that we
just go on to gmail.com type in a
password and then it figures out which
account we are talking about so the
first step is always called the
confidentiality part where we identify
which account we are talking about and
then we try to authenticate as the owner
of that particular account by providing
the appropriate password to that account
if both of these match only then do we
get access to that account and we are
able to make uh whatever transactions we
want to make now when we are making
those transactions non-repidation comes
into the place where all our activities
also being logged so we have identified
our account we have authenticated
ourselves by providing the password so
the proof is there that it is us who are
trying to access it and then whatever
activity we do send an email receive an
email delete something attach something
all of those activities are logged and
stored as proof of what actions have
been done so tomorrow if we deny having
sent an email gmail can still prove to
us through those logs that though that
that activity was done by us
and the fourth part is integrity which
ensures that the data received and sent
and sent by the sender and received by
the recipient has not been modified
while in motion
so the Integrity part is the
trustworthiness of that data that the
data has not been modified by any hacker
or any other entity and is still
trustworthy so these are the four Prime
objectives of modern cryptography once I
have scrambled that data
using
my Public's signature it is only my
private signature that is going to
decrypt it right
using these mechanisms I will be able to
achieve all these four aspects of
cryptography and security next question
what is safer now c4 stands for secure
and fast encryption routine which is
also a block Cipher as we have discussed
previously block Cipher is a cipher that
is used to encrypt data that is stored
so it has a 64-bit block size and byte
oriented algorithm
uh safer's encryption and decryption
procedures are highly secure this
technology is widely used in
applications like digital payment cards
so when you are using uh
a digital payment gateway to make
transactions so you have you have gone
on to an online portal you want to
purchase a particular item and then it
takes you to another
payment Gateway where you have to fill
in your credit card information
sensitive information like your uh
expiry dates CVV information and then
the OTP or the password that you have
created for your particular account now
all of these need to be secured or
highly secured based on PCI DSS which is
the payment card industry data security
standard so these standards ensure that
certain Protocols are utilized to attain
that level of security safer is one of
those block ciphers that is used under
the digital payment Gateway
infrastructure next question how does
the public infrastructure public key
infrastructure work
now we have already discussed this in
the previous diagrams we have identified
the key players the certification
Authority the registration Authority the
end user who requires the digital
certificate the validation Authority
who's going to validate it and then the
recipe and the end user with whom the
transaction is going to be conducted so
the first point here is the request for
the digital certificate is sent to the
registration Authority they validate it
and then they okay to the certification
Authority who then process the request
and the digital certificate is issued to
the person who has requested it so when
the person wants to conduct that
transaction they use that digital
certificate to sign that transaction
with the end user the end user validates
that with the validation Authority and
once validated the transaction goes
through and now the last question what
is the Blowfish algorithm it is a 64-bit
symmetric encryption algorithm so this
is an algorithm that uses the same key
to encrypt and the same key to decrypt
the same secret Keys used to encrypt and
decrypt the messages here the operations
are based on exclusive ORS and additions
to the on 32-bit words the key has a
maximum length of 448 bits now this is a
little bit technical uh you might not
want to go this technical in a in an
interview question you just need to
identify what the algorithm is used for
so whether it is a symmetric algorithm
which means it uses the same key or a
symmetric algorithm where it uses a
public key to encrypt and a private key
to decrypt uh does the Blowfish
algorithm is just one more algorithm
which uses symmetric encryption to
encrypt and decrypt data algorithms that
we have seen RSA and others that we have
discussed as well as the interview
questions are concerned what we need to
remember is which algorithms are
symmetric which algorithms are
asymmetric what do symmetric algorithms
do and what do unsymmetric uh symmetric
algorithms do and we also look at block
ciphers and stream ciphers block size
refers are utilized to encrypt data that
is stored stationary data retype rest
and stream ciphers are utilized for data
in motion while they are being streamed
so SSL and TLS is another algorithm that
comes into the picture when you're
looking at streaming data if you are
looking to dive deep into the world of
cyber security then become an expert
with postgraduate program and cyber
security so hurry up and enroll now get
the complete course details in the
description box if you are looking to
have a smart entry in this field then
simply learn offers a six months program
Caltech cyber security bootcamp find the
complete course details from the link in
the description box and pin command here
we wrap up this full course stay tuned
with simply learn for more such videos
If you like this video subscribe to
Simply learn and hit the Bell icon to
never miss any updates from us
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign